Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat.
Hey, hey, hey.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Hey, heat. Hey, heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Hey, Heat.
Hey, hey, hey.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat.
Hey. Hey. Hey.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Heat. Heat.
Hey,
hey,
hey.
In my nightm
everybody day everybody night.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
You're my
Heat. Heat.
Heat up here.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Good day and welcome to the Riftbound
regional qualifiers Sydney 2026.
My name is Logan and that is Rashy and
together we will be taking you through
some of the best Riftbound that we here
in Australia have to offer.
>> It's been absolutely wonderful, Logan,
seeing all the amazing players. We got
to see all 40 legends represented here
in the Sydney regional qualifiers and
it's been fantastic to see all the
different play styles and of course all
the wonderful amazing pilots as well.
>> We have so many skilled pilots on
display here at the regional qualifiers.
Rice, you are so so right. And so many
undefeated players as well. We have some
serious conversion rates that we get to
talk about a little bit later that I'm
very excited for. And Pastry Times
prediction might be coming true.
>> I mean, not just Pastry Times. I also
have an undefeated legend as well. Don't
count me out just yet. Um because I'm
very excited to see what's going to
happen in day two. This is of course
championship Sunday and this is where
things get real dicey.
>> Yeah, really glad we got to see a lot of
different legends there yesterday. But
as you say, today is day two. Today is
Championship Sunday where we have five
rounds of Swiss before that top cut to
eight in the single elimination. We had
a long day yesterday starting at 10 a.m.
AEST Australian Eastern Standard Time
and eight rounds of Swiss. It was a kind
of a 12-hour day for everyone involved
today. 10:00 a.m. start once more and
hopefully maybe I would like to say 10
hours today, but maybe more like that
112 again.
>> Give me more riff
that 10 12 hour plus grind.
>> But everyone is here for a reason,
Logan. Of course, it's the prizing. And
if you make it to day two, like so many
of our players have, you have so much to
work for.
>> I'm really glad that the prizing has
improved so significantly. Top 128, you
are rewarded with that playmat. 64 the
playmat, 40 prize wall tickets, so they
start to get those medal cards from that
prize wall. Regional championship
invite, future RQ competitor passes, and
it's just up from there, Ricey.
>> Exactly. So yeah, I think everybody is
wanting of course minimum top 64 to get
that regionable regional championship
invite. It's uh very much the next
progression of these regional qualifiers
and everybody is obvious obviously also
eyeing that champion prize. Who doesn't
want to come first? Yeah, look, that
champion prize, that Poppy Defender of
the Meek, alt art, playmat, regional
invite, future RQ competitor pass, 40
prize wall tickets, and $6,000
US in prize money. That's what everyone
is fighting for here today, Ry.
>> Indeed. But let's have a look at who has
made it today to who is fighting for
that prize. Well, we have, as you
mentioned earlier, quite a few players
that are undefeated. Five of them, in
fact. Let's let's look at these amazing
names. The top eight undefeated, a
couple of draws amongst them there. CTCG
Daniel on that Leblanc deceiver as Patri
time predicted, but as you predicted,
prismaticism
on that Annie Darkchild still able to
work his way through to that top three
undefeated even in the new unleash meta.
>> Look, I don't want to count you and step
out just yet because Diana is there on
Diwali. Seven wins, one tie. So maybe
your prediction is still in the uh
contention, but let's also now look at
the meta game breakdown. This is where I
mean you mentioned at the opening you're
really excited to have a look at uh how
the actual day is going to be
progressing.
>> Yeah, so many phenomenal players here.
We can't go past all of them obviously
because we do have these meta breakdowns
and as you can see at the tippity top
I'm sure knowers know Master Yi has 24
legends 24 players that have made it
through to day two which is that sort of
12% share of the meta but following
closely behind is Aurelia
>> indeed and we see how many there's 21
total but we saw how many Aurelas were
in that top 10 Ireelia seems to be quite
a strong con like consideration for
being a really wellplayed legend in
general, but also of course with those
pilots that are using Ireelia, it's
going to be quite exciting to see how
the day progresses. I'm keeping my eyes
out on those Ireelas.
>> Yeah, Aurelia does have one of the
highest conversion rates here as well
from day one to day two at 26.6%. So,
really nice to see that. But it's field
rounded out with Leblanc, Diana, Vex,
Civa, Fiora, and Poppy. Seven Poppies
with a 4% meta share have made it
through to day two here. Very impressive
showing. Very impressive. I want to take
a moment as well to to see how many like
in our heads perfectly calculate how
many of these are potentially Aurora
decks as well. There's a lot of talk
about Aurora before this regional
started and people were worried about
how strong Aurora is going to be. But
looking at this, maybe not even that um
scary.
>> Yeah, the thing with Civ Fiora and Poppy
that could be 23 potential Aurora decks.
Masti with a 24 though, we don't know
the mix of mid-range versus Aurora. So,
the Aurora representation could actually
be a little bit higher than 23. However,
the Auroras are overwhelmed by the rest
of the legends.
>> Well, Riftbound is an amazing amazing
place to be, an amazing game as well,
and has amazing communities. You get
joining up here and seeing everybody
talking, playing together, having fun.
The smiles on the face has been
absolutely fantastic.
>> Yeah. And that's what we see. We're here
amongst the crowd and every single one
of these people is smiling, laughing,
having a good time. The vibes feel good.
The energy is high. We've all had a good
night's rest and we're ready for this
championship Sunday of Ripbound here at
the regional qualifier in Sydney. Rice
here,
>> indeed. It's been wonderful here. It is
wonderful here at the championship
Sunday. But if you guys also want to get
involved, of course, you can get
involved with your Nexus Knights and
some of the skirmishes. I have a
wonderful story to tell about my Nexus
Knights. Tell me.
>> So, one of my first times going, this is
my second time ever playing Riftbound. I
rocked up with no dice cuz I didn't have
any dice and I had to borrow dice from
everyone around me. And uh I kind of got
my uh
my hands handed to me. And after I lost
quite spectacularly, I ended up my
proponent actually gave me a set of dice
as well. and was like, "Welcome to TCGs.
The community of Riftbound is absolutely
amazing and everyone can experience this
at your nexus nights and summoner
skirmishes."
>> Yeah. Summoner skirmishes being that
next level higher OPL event. That's
where you take your practice, your decks
that you've been competing with and you
really put it up against the best of
your local geographics there because
once you win that summoner skirmish, you
do get that buy which you can then apply
to your round one here at the regional
qualifier, making your journey to that
day two a little bit easier. But I love
those Nexus Night stories. There are so
many of them, Risey, and it speaks to
the quality of the community.
>> Indeed. And I mean, going back to those
those round one buys, as you said,
they're very important. We had a 12-hour
day yesterday, but if you had that round
one by that, that would have reduced it
to 10 and a half hours potentially. Yum.
Yum. Which would have been great. A
little bit of a sleep in or maybe just
composing yourself is really important.
>> Yeah. A lot of people were still working
out their deck texts as well. Well,
obviously the submission cut off at
11:59, but if you have that extra time,
there's a little less stress, a little
less pressure. So, those buys that you
can earn from your summoner skirmishes
come in clutch. Very, very valuable. But
someone that didn't actually have a buy
coming into this one, as we heard a
little earlier, was Prismat on that
Annie. He has gone 8 and zero the hard
way. No buy. He's won every single game
so far.
>> And I'm feeling pretty confident in my
predictions, Logan, that Annie is the
one that I personally predicted. I will
admit the main reason I did predict that
Annie is of course because of Prismat I
thought he would coming from such a
grand win previously in the previous
regional qualifier. He's primed and
ready to pilot Annie to victory.
>> Yeah, but Pastry Times predictions also
proving very very strong. That hook
Leblanc piloted by CTCG Daniel there is
proving its worth. 8 and zero as well.
Steph and I we obviously predicted that
Diana we thought she'd be pretty strong
seeing pilots like Allen's EQ on that
one. Currently though, 70 and one draw
with Dwali who we actually got to see on
the featured matchups yesterday against
that Leona.
>> Yeah, it was really fun seeing that
featured matchup and I'm excited to see
more featured matchups of course
throughout Championship Sunday. We've
got so many games to go through. Another
eight rounds. We got five rounds of
Swiss and then of course that top cart.
>> I'm really looking forward to this top
cut. That's the pointy end of the
championship Sunday Rasi where we get to
see the best of the best. They've been
grinding out for two one and a half days
to get to this place. The mental
exhaustion will be kicking in, but we
have to get through five more rounds
before we even get to that top cut of
eight.
>> No, I totally understand you, Logan. And
we don't want to keep you waiting any
longer. Let's hand it off to the classes
for their prediction uh update as well.
>> Thank you very much, Ricey and Logan. My
name is Pat. Joining me once again is
Steph Panicasio. Eight rounds of Swiss
yesterday.
>> Big day. relatively big day and perhaps
a bigger day upon us here. Five more
rounds of Swiss, three rounds of top
eight, and one more regional qualifier
champion. How you feeling about Diana?
>> Look, I still feel reasonably confident.
She's still in contention. She may not
necessarily be right at the top of the
list, but I see there is a lot of
potential. Obviously, we did see quite a
lot of Leblanc yesterday, and you must
be feeling pretty happy with yours, but
who's to say? There's still time.
There's a whole day ahead of us.
>> There is. I think I got very lucky. Uh
Diana, just looking at the metag game, I
don't think has done maybe as well as we
expected. But I do also think the
skilled Diana pilots will continue to be
near the top of the standings. I mean,
when there's a player like Allan running
around on a legend like Diana, hard to
think that she's not going to do too
badly. If we have a look at the metag
game ourselves, cuz it's been
interesting. Yeah, Aurelia converting
well. I mean, Aurelia hasn't always
converted well, but I think as far as uh
decks that people know quite well, that
are very comfortable with that has been
developed for quite a long time in
Spirit Forge because we had, of course,
an entire set to play. That doesn't
surprise me. Leblanc actually, I think
that's kind of expected conversion wise
given how many Leblancs were in the
field, but obviously not that many. And
I think Diana probably underperforming a
bit. What's really absent from this list
though is Misfortune was I think the
fifth or sixth most played deck. There
was at least 50 copies going uh starting
day one and she's not on this graphic.
So there's seven or less of them on day
two and they're all Aurora decks.
>> Look, there is still potentially plenty
of Aurora representation here, whether
that's with Civer or Poppy had a huge
Aurora rep today. Master Y maybe as
well. I don't know how many of them
would have necessarily converted to
today, but there is still a potential.
The other thing that I'm really really
stoked to see here is how well Vex has
converted. Obviously, Vex Apathetic was
one of the big cards of yesterday, we
saw it quite a lot. And seeing that
there are still 10 in contention, I
think that's pretty exciting, actually.
>> I think between the two kind of new
Chaos Unleash legends in Vex and Diana,
very curious to think how the how well
they'll do. I think everyone kind of
expects Diana to do well because skilled
players are playing her and those
players are generally saying they think
the deck is quite good. Generally, when
talented TCG players think something is
good, they're often right, even though
we are early into the lifespan of this
set. Vex definitely more of an unknown
quantity, but certainly the presence of
her champion unit was very heavy
yesterday. So, you have to feel like
there's probably a Vex list out there
that is going to be near the top tables
and perhaps even through to the top
eight once we're here once we're done at
the end of the day. But 10 of I believe
also 50 copies coming through. It's
actually a pretty nice conversion rate
given how wide the metag game is.
>> I think realistically, if I was to make
an educated guess there, as much as only
10 Vex leading it off, I reckon Vex
apathetic. Oh, countless.
>> Yes. Oh, yeah. They're probably one of
the most played units in the field.
Might might actually be one of the most
played uh cards in the field. Like, we
think about cards we expect to see a lot
of. We expect to see a lot of Dazzling
Aurora. Don't know how many exact copies
of that card are out there, but uh and
we did have a look at some cards based
on their card type, but Exathetic is
probably like I mean, think about how
many different chaos decks there are. I
think almost all of them. I mean,
there's some decks we haven't even seen
like Prismaticism and Back on Annie. I
don't know what the deck looks like
updated. uh for this metag game. I don't
know if he changed any cards at all. He
had a week. Uh I don't know what the
Aurelia decks are doing these days. I
think we haven't seen that many Aurelia
decks on stream yet. Even though we've
had a couple of them in our backup
feature, haven't seen that many Aurelia
deck list. And that's a legend that I
think has a lot of different ways you
can potentially build it, especially for
a metag game. We're expecting very big
monsters to be one of the things you
have to deal with. So, lots of
questions, but it does feel like Chaos
is yet again the undercurrent of another
another regional qualifier.
>> Absolutely. I do think as well it's been
interesting to see how many unusual
bruise there have been. There have been
some builds that I definitely wouldn't
have expected. Yesterday we saw that Vex
build that had so much Aurelia presence
as well. And also as we said Vex being
present in everything has been really
really surprising. So it's it's been a
little unconventional. I think
>> I think one of the knockon effects is
that Fury's kind of gotten a lot of
splash damage with how much vexathetic
there is. Think about how good uh Rengar
was in Spirit forge for prismaticism
Annie specifically. That's a very good
ambush unit. Unleashed has a ton more
ambush units. We've seen a bunch of them
in different decks. I've seen way more
VI peacekeeper than I expected in a
bunch of different order decks because
it's just a good solid ambush unit with
a nice ability. So, I felt like Fury's
big identity was getting all these
cheaper ambush units and when everyone
is playing Vexpathetic and they're kind
of just slamming it on turn two in most
games,
>> yeah, your deck kind of feels as good
>> very very quickly.
>> So, I'm curious to see kind of how the
meta game shakes out at the end of it
all. But I know we have players on stage
getting ready. I don't know how close
they are to getting ready, but I know
the match up should be a fun one. If you
want to see an undefeated Leblanc, that
is what we're going to bring you in our
first feature match.
>> I'm very excited to see the this one
specifically. Obviously, the Leblancs
that we've seen, there have been a lot
of different builds, but this one I feel
like you're going to be particularly
excited for.
>> I certainly am. It is Beta Leblanc. So,
spoiler alert, the Challenger boys
already showed the deck list on uh on
stream. So, we'll have a quick squeeze,
shall we? As uh look at some predictions
because uh like I said, we've done we've
done okay, I think, as far as
predictions go. So, in terms of MVPs, I
still think that realistically, I'm not
way off. I think
>> I think you're very close, actually.
>> I'm pretty close. I think we has been
such a versatile unit. And honestly,
when it comes to those Diana decks that
are performing, you can really see how
well that's being utilized, especially
because it is so adaptable to the
situation.
>> I think other mind decks probably want
to use this unit as well. I think if it
wasn't for Vex, we would be talking more
about Hay as maybe the big new unit from
this set. Uh for me obviously here the
resurrection more of a pet card but I
did expect more chaos decks to want to
play slower and get more value. Haven't
seen this card too much in these decks
but ash focus definitely for the
successful order list in this metag game
specifically because it is so good
against Aurora. I think the order list
that are succeeding have two or three
copies of Ash Focus somewhere in their
48.
>> Speaking of Aurora, we do obviously have
Elder Dragon there as one of Logan's
picks as well which has seen a lot of
play in the Aurora decks. It is such a
dominating presence. I'm not surprised
to see that this is one of the MVPs for
our little crew here.
>> Yep. And Ricey just nailing it
basically. Yep. So, two good chaos
cards. Turns out in pretty much all of
the decks that want to play these
colors, even Aurora decks are playing
these cards as well, I think, in some of
them. So, uh pretty good. Not bad. Not
bad for a bunch of Aussies guessing in
brand new meta that's been out for 9
days or whatever since. Uh
>> yeah. So, no big deal.
>> Yeah, it's fine. We're doing all right.
>> Uh I will say again, Aurora not doing
all that hot. I am curious to see of the
Aurora decks that are going to be close
or in top eight. What what builds did
they decide to go for? I said this
yesterday. Aurora to me is a deck that
benefits a lot from your deck building
choices before an event. The game plan
is somewhat linear when you when you
when you draw well. And obviously when
you play a deck like that, you want to
draw well as often as possible. It's one
of the the great things of any TCG is uh
even no matter how skilled you are as a
player, you also do need to get a little
bit lucky to have a good tournament
typically. Um, but you can, you know,
make some choices to try and curb some
of the potential variants to try and
keep games in a streamlined fashion. So,
is it triple elder, single baron like we
saw on stream? Is it something like, I
don't know, a bunch of dead blooms and
minds splitters like we've seen in days
gone by. We're going to answer those
questions at some point perhaps later in
the day, but we do have our feature
match players just sitting down and uh I
do know on the right, of course,
challenger at TCD's Daniel is over there
playing the undefeated Leblanc deck. Uh,
the best performance for that archetype
in the field so far. on the left. Not
too sure who his opponent is, but I do
know what they're on. They're on
Aurelia.
>> Aurelia. We're seeing for I think one of
the first times on the feature desk, but
I'm very excited to see how this matchup
does come down to it. Obviously, as you
said, the Leblanc deck is undefeated,
and I think it's going to be interesting
to see how it differs. A lot of the
builds have really focused in hard on
those death nail triggers. Obviously,
with baited hook, there is a little bit
more unconventional approach there as
well. Yeah, one of the nice things about
baited hook is that uh you do like it
does force you to
>> kill the unit to get the effect of the
hook. So if your deck already cares
about death nails, well, you can kind of
get value on either side, right? If you
get value when the unit you hook goes
out, you get some value. Then you get
hook value when you find a unit off the
top of your deck with hook. So it did
naturally make sense like as someone
that's played a lot of different
archetypes with this card and just
generally enjoys the strategy at a macro
level. When I saw Leblanc, I was like,
"Oh, this is probably going to be the
best hook deck if the hook build is even
good." I didn't think that the Hookfield
was going to be the best Lebanon build.
I thought the deck had enough value,
enough juice kind of built into it
naturally that you didn't need to play
hook in order to kind of unlock the deck
fully. And maybe I'm just wrong because
so far this version of the deck is doing
very very well. But we'll explain when
we get a little bit more into the deck
list once we have that on stream. there
is a lot of uh a lot of good value kind
of built into something you already want
to do and generally in card games if uh
you want to do something and you're
rewarded for doing the thing you already
want to do tends to be a pretty good
kind of layering of strategy.
>> Absolutely. I'm also very excited to see
how this Aurelia ability goes because we
haven't really seen a lot of how the
unleash set has impacted on those decks.
I don't know what is coming in, what is
coming out in a lot of these higher
performing decks, but here we go. where
we can have a quick look. A lot of
expected things here. We do see all of
the charms, defies, ong guards that we
would normally see. A lot of ride the
wind, but is there anything here that
really stands out to you?
>> Yeah, the the absence of something is
standing out to me here for killers as a
rally list. There is a vex in this deck.
>> There is a not the Vex we expected.
>> Not Vex apathetic.
>> Vex cheerless, which does make sense. I
know a lot of rallies were experimenting
with this, especially in their boards.
Uh, it's exceptionally good in the
mirror because you end up with having so
many battles in showdowns at reaction
speed or at action speed as you trade
pumps back and forth, especially with
counters. So, uh, Vexilus is really good
at making all your spells cheaper and
making all your opponent spells
expensive in a showdown. So, typically
if it's a battle of cards and resources,
which is kind of where you're going to
be jostling once you do move in with
something like Aurelia or a Stellicorn,
uh, Vex Chills does make a lot of sense.
So I think if you expect Aurelia to be a
decent portion of the field. I think
having one Vex chills in your main feels
pretty reasonable. Looks like we are
going back to sneaky deck hand is kind
of the card of choice. This was
something we saw from pretty successful
Aurelia builds in Atlanta. Just saying
that you know what I kind of just want
to go back to deckhand. Try and get two
points early and then use Aurelia to
kind of win two points a turn for the
rest of the game once I have enough
resources built up. either that or a
Stellon cuz you can make Selicon
shockingly big and the cards it gives
you are so overwhelming that even if
it's not as big as Aelia it tends to not
matter cuz you have enough of an
overwhelming advantage.
>> Yeah, I think the only other thing
that's worth noting here is we do have
that abandoned hall as one of the
battlefields. We did see quite a little
bit of success for that one because it
does choose Aurelia.
>> Yes, this is an interaction that will
certainly come up in this game. We'll
explain it kind of when we have the
battlefield on the field. But Aurelia
basically cares about being chosen. When
you choose her, she gets bigger. An
abandoned hall. Believe it or not, it's
not just a when you play spell pumps
stop trigger. You also have to choose a
unit. So, that one is real nice.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Looks like the players are on some dice.
Again, these should be two undefeated
players. Uh we didn't have too many
overnight, but certainly are continuing
to see who is going to be undefeated at
the end of it all. As we have a look at
Disden's deck here from CTCG, that is of
course Challenger TCG. Three of them
flew over from the States to play in
this event and all three of them are X1
or better. Daniel actually played his
teammate Colin in the last round and
stayed undefeated among the three. But I
know Villionaire, the other player
that's here on Volibear Aurora, is still
X and one in pursuit of yet another
Volibear best off. And
>> there are those three baited hooks that
we were talking about earlier. Very,
very good to see you. Oh, you look so
stoked at the fact that they are here.
Obviously, we have a couple of other
staples of that. We've got the ruined
Rex in there. We've got Thousand Tailed
Watcher is good to see as well. And
Carus, you know, all the standards.
Yeah, we'll talk about hook chains kind
of when we get there. But the weird way
to think about baited hook, I guess I'll
read it actually cuz I don't know how
many people are familiar with the card.
Uh it might be familiar to other cards
you've seen in perhaps other TCGs. This
one is a three energy gear. You pay one
energy, you pay an auto power, and you
kill a friendly unit. When you do that,
look at the top five cards of your main
deck. You may play a unit from among
them that has might up to one more than
the killed unit, ignoring its cost, and
recycle the rest. So basically, you're
doing doing a little bit of counting. If
you hook a two, you find a three. If you
hook a three, you find a four. Hook a
four, you find a five, etc., etc. And
the big one for this deck with all the
unleashed jungle monsters is when you
hook a six, you find a seven. And the
sevens are nasty.
>> Absolutely right. It really comes down
to a kind of calculated risk assessment
there because you are getting rid of
some things. But with Leblanc, it's
slightly less of an issue.
>> Yeah, with all the death nails, right?
Whether it's a reflection cuz remember
this looks at might, it doesn't look at
cost. So reflections are still token
units with might. So you can hook them,
keep your original unit, still get the
death nail with often attached to it.
and move on from there. That's why cards
like watchful sentry, this two energy
one might unit are getting played just
because it says when I die draw a card.
If you have Karthus in play, which of
course basically every Lebong deck is
playing three cardes, uh you get even
more value. A Starring going to be the
first battlefield here as just going to
move on over for a point. Tie Turner the
first two drop not the best unit here
for Aelia, but Aurelia is not the
fastest deck. Typically wanting to again
deploy your champion unit and then build
up from there with either that or a
Stellicorn. So a slow start isn't
typically not isn't too atypical for
Aurelia, but basically every deck with a
bunch of shoe drops is going to want to
do this. And already the value train is
rolling. This is just the regular
Leblanc stuff, right?
>> Yes, absolutely. And yeah, you're right.
There is an expectation that there would
be a couple of developmental turns for
Aurelia so that she can establish that
stronghold. But it is also interesting
to see we have the Rockfall path and
Starring up here today as well.
>> Oh, my brain just figured out why they
have Starring. So, Windswept Hill is
actually a card we saw in Leblanc that
uh we did see yesterday and that one was
pretty good cuz when you're ready
reflection tokens move onto that
battlefield, they get ganking. So, they
can move over and grab you another
point. What happened here with Starring
is actually a very similar thing. The
first time a player plays a non-token
unit here each turn, they may move
another unit they control here to its
base. And what happened is Black Rose
Dignitary reinforced that battlefield.
The ready reflection token got moved
back to base and then could move on over
kind of pseudo ganking if you will over
to the other battlefield to get two
points. So, we're going to use two units
because uh disciplined Tide Turner is
rolling into the Star Spring. But, uh
two points very swiftly and a bunch of
death not triggers here. You're going to
channel a rune and draw a card after
discarding a card to make a copy of
something that you already want to die.
Like again, this is without beta hook.
You can see the value trend that Leblanc
wants to be pushing turn after turn.
>> Absolutely. The tempo that is
established is so important in these
types of decks where you can really just
get the ball rolling early, make sure
you're getting those early points and
really establishing for the late game as
And I guess I should have figured it out
earlier because Starring is actually the
most played battlefield at this event.
It's 20% of the battlefields in this
tournament on day one. And I guess I
should have figured that the most played
deck is probably playing this the most
played battlefield.
>> Absolutely.
>> All right. Lonely Porro little Aellia
activation
because uh it is choosing. That's kind
of a fun little interaction. Going to
move on over and kind of do the same
thing. This is something that Starbring
again is symmetrical so your opponent
can uh do tricks as well. And Leblanc
may have ready reflections, but if
there's one legend that's good at
readying units, my goodness, it has to
be Aurelia.
>> Absolutely right.
>> All right, two more runes. Channeled up,
draw a card. Did lose the unit, but did
get the card. It was a reflection of
watchful sentry, so didn't uh didn't
manage to defend the battlefield. Wasn't
going to be able to score anyway as both
players end up at two points. But ruined
Rex,
>> nice little six drop channeled pretty
early thanks to those extra runes from
Black Rose Dignitary. going to mean that
uh pretty big unit here and a pretty
good death nail as well to try and use.
This is another six that this deck can
hit from hook off of fives, but also
this is a six that has a good death nail
and again the sevens are really where
the money is for this particular baited
hook build.
>> And how early would you be expecting to
get that baited hook out there?
>> You would want to play it, you could
have played it uh
last turn potentially uh depending on
what your hand texture was. I think
developing Rex makes a bit more sense
here because one of the things you do
want to try and do with hook is
>> move in with your use your unit's might
or use your unit in some way before you
hook it away. If you just play a unit
and hook it, the value is still decent
because in some cases you're you know
maybe playing a Gallo which is a very
cheap six might unit and getting
something that costs seven that uh
getting a seven might unit that costs a
lot more energy and power. Like if you
get an Articon for a Gallo, the resource
difference you manage to kind of cheat
in that space is really nice. But
generally, you want to like use your
unit first and then hook it. So I think
developing a unit like Rex, which lets
you set up, even if there was a hook in
Daniel Sand, I think trying to win one
of these battlefields, maybe even make a
reflection with Leblanc, cuz again,
there's always value to be gained when
you're conquering or holding with
Leblanc. And then you can decide which
one do I want to do. Do I want to hook
the reflection unit and have that find
my unit, which is kind of, you know, not
exactly free cuz it costs you a card
when you discard, but
>> uh generally whenever you need one and
you have a unit that you can reasonably
use, you can.
>> So I think if this Rex lives and there
is a hook, I would expect it next turn.
But the other thing about Baited Hook,
and this is true of decks that have
>> some sort of combo element to them,
sometimes you just don't have your card.
Sometimes you don't have your Aurora.
The difference between Dazzling Aurora
and Beta Hook though is that Beta Hook
decks are just very normal decks most of
the time and then they kind of
supercharge when you find Beta Hook.
>> Exactly. It's It's not reliant entirely
on the Beta Hook to make everything
work. Obviously in a deck like Leblanc
as well because you have all of those
death nail triggers because you have all
of those reflections. You're still
getting a lot of value especially in the
early game being able to set up that
tempo and then coming in with those big
heavy hitters.
>> Exactly. And I think this is one of the
reasons why Leblanc is maybe the why I
thought it would be the best baited hook
deck we'd ever seen. I think Darius is
the other one because baited hook Darius
>> it worked into Darius's game plan very
well of wanting to play units very
quickly and then you can cheat a bunch
of units that really no other domain
other than Fury has access to. Like if
you when you pop a two to find Draven
Show and it's a six for some reason.
It's like that feels like a very good
value trade for you. But there's not
that many units that kind of like cheat
on costs in most of the domain. But
Leblanc is just such a good deck
valuewise when you play a normal game of
Riftbound using the text written on your
cards
>> that Beta Hook just gives you another
angle to go even bigger and try and go
over the top of the other decks. I think
it creates like a a state where you can
really overpower your opponent. Whereas
we've seen some of the Leblanc decks,
they do a lot of really cool things, but
they're kind of doing things at like a
let's call a reasonable pace, right?
Unless you have Karthus. Sometimes this
deck
>> with Karthus or not, especially with
Karthus, you do completely unreasonable
things. And I think that's one of the
reasons why this version has seen a bit
more success than maybe the other
Leblanc decks we've seen on screen.
>> It's absolutely very scalable compared
to some of the other builds. I think if
nothing else, what we are seeing here
and the fact that this has gone
undefeated, it is just really spreading
the good word of baited hook, which I'm
sure you're very pleased by.
>> So, I am very pleased by it. I mean, I
already own some, so I guess I'm not uh
too worried if everyone starts to take
notice. I am curious cuz there is a
judge call.
>> Not sure exactly what the question is,
but I believe Aurelia is the Aurelia
player, excuse me, is away from the
table asking the judge a question. So,
it probably has a question maybe about
an interaction of a card in their hand.
Obviously, you don't want to give
information to your opponent uh when
you're at the table uh when the
information isn't public. So, just
wanting to ask that question in private
absolutely something you're able to do.
So, again, if you're at a TCG event,
you're not sure, call a Dodge, put your
hand up. That's what they're there for.
They do excellent work at our events
here all across the world. Oh, and no
back. The other thing I was going to say
is I know Colin, who is playing set, one
of Daniel's teammates, uh, did also do
quite well at the pre-Q. He was playing
Leblanc. Now, I'm really curious which
Leblanc deck he was playing.
>> Interesting. I don't actually know
whether he was playing or not. But I
wouldn't be surprised if he was playing
the team's Leblanc deck and just kind of
I don't know, giving it a go, seeing if
maybe he wanted to switch away from set
for a tournament. Well, I do recall
having a conversation late on the Friday
where he was a little unsure as to where
he was going to go with it, but landing
on set makes a lot of sense. He's seen a
lot of success with it.
>> Certainly has. There four points now to
Koya, our Aurelia player. Did manage to
make pretty good use of that Starring
and Aurelia's ability to reset some
things up.
>> There's also that Guardian Angel out
there now as well.
>> Looking good. not usually the uh the
hero you want to protect but sometimes
the hero you uh you have
>> good old lonely para ruined Rex's kind
of an issue assuming it dies which
>> will happen
>> it will
>> most likely uh
>> eventually
>> cuz sacrifice is an option if hook is an
option uh even as even just a reflection
unit is kind of annoying it's going to
go away eventually
>> so I do like backing off here again is a
a deck that does often play off of the
battlefields cuz she's so so good at
readying and moving
>> with things like boots of swiftness. But
uh I feel like we're in for a big turn
on the Leblanc side. At least that's
what I'd be hoping for if I was in that
seat.
>> Oh, absolutely. And
>> oh god.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> Oh no.
>> That's usually the start of the end
times.
>> When you see Carus off to Starring we
go. Trying to get the points first.
Again, you want to make use of your
units before you hook them whenever you
can. And Starcross going to prove to be
the big answer here. But which do we
bounce? Is going to be Ruined Rex. keep
that point off and keep that very scary
death off the table.
>> Absolutely.
>> Sacrifice is a reaction, I will note.
So, if there's one here, it's going to
be a pretty big blow out of the star
cross, but hook is very slow. So, if
that was the plan for Distant, that
one's not going to work out all that
well. And I do see a hook in the hand,
but I don't see a sacrifice. So, back it
goes.
>> Not yet. It is good to see also, we were
talking earlier about the unleash cards
that would be coming into an Aurelia
deck. It's good to see Starcross in
there and making good use of it as well.
Yeah, it's interesting cuz I think it is
not as good as Rebuke was at winning you
combats and uh Aurelia doesn't
necessarily have that many units that
she wants to be returning to hand. But I
think especially the presence of cards
like Elder Dragon,
>> wanting to bounce that before the damage
happens, I think is a reason why a lot
of these decks have shifted away. Even
Aurelia not making necessarily the best
use out of it is more than happy to kind
of lose a little bit to gain a lot in
some of those matchups. as a glass
mixologist. This is a uh a mainstay of
the beta hook list. I believe uh this
list is on the full three of them. So no
spectral matrons here, which is kind of
the the middling or the more mid-range
the more the smaller reanimator kind of
unit. This one on death now uh does get
some units back as long as they're cheap
enough. There's plenty of cheap units in
the bin and of course combining with Kus
means that you get a lot of value. I
think this is something even the regular
Leon decks are looking to do as well.
>> Absolutely. Aurelia Fervent kind of the
terror of the seas as it were or the
plains I don't know but wherever she
wherever in Ionia she is
>> Aurelia hails from she has been uh
pretty much terrorizing people since
spirit forged and over she goes to the
star spring which as we've noted could
be tricky lonely power going to do the
work on rockfall path instead so two
more points that is up to six I believe
>> for cya so uh going to have to do
something that starcross certainly put a
stop to some of the plans here alongside
that carus. Looks like we're going to
hide a card. I think everyone knows
that's a tie turner given that unit was
returned to hand from Starcross. But
just cuz you know it's there doesn't
make it any easier sometimes.
>> Plus with the way that the game moves
sometimes it is easy to forget. Not so
much with higher level players that we
are seeing today. But you never know,
especially on decks that you are still
only maybe a week, two weeks into.
>> Yeah, it's interesting because obviously
Leblanc is a very new deck, right? an
unleash legender who's I think players
are still figuring out how to build
them. I think even this deck isn't
necessarily the best version of it, but
uh there's a lot of different ways to
approach a death nail heavy value engine
that Leblanc kind of presents to you.
Aurelia obviously has adapted for the
new meta, but is much more established.
So, I imagine Leblanc has significantly
more practice in general in this matchup
than Aelia would the other way.
Although, if you are testing for this
event, I think you probably did expect
Leblanc to be quite the presence. Maybe
not this version in particular, but even
though there's some fancy stuff
happening, a lot of the like core things
that this Lebong deck is doing are what
kind of all the Lebanon decks want to be
doing. So, uh clearly Cuya has a plan
for this matchup. And generally, you're
just trying to put enough pressure on
that, uh the value train can't get out
of control because if you ever really
lose like a lot of
>> if you ever lose the plot, let's say, it
gets bad very quickly.
>> Yes. Look, that tempo can scale out of
control very very quickly. So getting
that interruption early can make a big
difference and having that star frost
definitely made some early changes to
some strategies.
>> Yeah, feel like it kind of stopped
momentum that was potentially building
again. You see Carthus, you expect uh
the siren start blaring but no death
nail trig sacrifice again would have
been very good in that spot. So glass
mixologist instead rolling up into the
star spring and you might think why
because Aurelia is chilling there. We
know this is something else there. We do
know it's a two might tie turn which is
actually I believe revealed now get
popped over. So obviously five might
running into I don't know like sevenish
before Aurelia has anything else to say
about it. Doesn't feel all that good but
might just be fishing for the mixologist
triggers here cuz there are at least two
units you'll be relatively happy to get
back and trading with one of these might
feel okay. Just try and pair down the
board a little bit. Look, I mean, in a
deck like Leblanc where you do have
those death nail triggers, sometimes the
value is in just making those swaps
there.
>> Yeah, you did tell me like how how you
getting those triggers and sometimes you
do it like a natural. You just get
>> just throw them in there, make it
happen.
>> Ooh, by peacekeeper. This has been an
absolute house for these decks. Ambush
on on attack, stun a unit, and uh good
little Aelia is going to get stunned.
Doesn't have to pay deflect. Don't
forget uh because that is a choice you
are making. You are targeting a unit
with an ability. So, uh the the price
must be paid, but uh a worthwhile one
here as Aurelia is no longer going to
deal damage in combat. Vi is going to
contribute her five might to that. And
all of a sudden, that's a very simple
combat
>> for this deck to win.
>> We did see that soaring scout in hand as
well.
>> It's a fun one. Another little death you
can get back. I see baited hook. I see
Black Rose Dignitary.
>> Might be time for some fireworks.
Dignitary going back again. Still
resolving the Leblanc trigger. This is
one of the reasons you you chase points
so aggressively as Leblanc is the value
you get from discarding a card and
making reflection is just so immense.
And there's another five. Oh no,
something really
>> gross might be about to happen.
>> Actually, not enough energy
to hook right now. You need four total.
Three for the gear and then one in a
power. So it might just be developing
hook and passing is going to be placed
near the tables. We can just barely see
>> but no extra resources voiding. So just
going to play it and pass. Hope you
don't have any main deck gear removal.
Off you go.
>> An investment. And this is something
that sometimes happen like generally you
don't want to play a hook and not use it
because your opponent removes it. You
did nothing with your card.
>> But investing the three energy now it
only cost you one energy one power which
is basically one rune to activate it
after that. That is a significantly
better rate than the four you pay, let's
say, when you first use the hook. So, if
it does go unscathed, given that the
board is already quite tricky for Aelia
to navigate, it is a worthwhile risk
just running it out there.
>> Absolutely. Taking the gamble that there
isn't that gear hate is, you know, it's
a risk, but obviously it's it's paid off
this time around.
>> So, Aurelia in this spot, I mean, again,
generally good at fighting kind of on
the chain as it were, right, with with
pumps, with counters, but
>> uh not so easy at this point. That five
peacekeeper really put an end to all the
fun that Aurelia was trying to have. And
generally when Aurelia loses her
champion unit. I mean they often play
more than one. Now I actually don't
recall how many are in this deck but
usually the first one you play from your
champion zone is the one you try and
protect for the entire game. Protect the
princess as it's been dubbed.
>> Exactly.
>> Uh when the princess uh ends up in the
graveyard.
>> Not so hot. Not ideal.
>> Not ideal. Not really a great place for
her to be. And again, Aurelia can still
pump her units to pretty big numbers,
but there's 15 might just vibing. And
again, even if you do end up moving in,
Iselia did get saved by it must have
been a G
>> the guardian angel, was it?
>> I think so.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes, there was a G.
>> I do see another in hand there as well.
>> Can't see the bin right now, but I
imagine there's one on top of it.
>> Mhm.
>> But still a lot of M even for Aurelia to
contend with. Again, she can get very
large, but without abandoned hall, it
might be tricky with cards in hand to
get that pick. That is a lot of unit
gunking up this hand. This is something
that does happen to Aurelia sometimes as
well. In the same way that sometimes the
Aurora and the hook decks don't draw
their namesake gear. Sometimes Aurelia
draws not the right mix, right? You want
enough units to do the thing you need to
do with them, and then you want a lot of
ways to make those units bigger.
>> Yes.
>> But units don't help you do that.
>> Exactly. And I'm sure against some decks
it will probably not be quite so
dramatic, but on Sunday against a deck
like this, you really want to be hoping
for the best every single time you pick
up a card.
>> It's a pretty important turn as well.
Just feels like the again was at six
points was threatening to to maybe
double conquer and try and win.
Obviously, this is why there's such a a
fortified battlefield on one side of the
map, just to just to make sure that
nothing bad happens. Cuz I think if
Leblanc is able to reawaken and have a
kind of a turn after not too much
happens on the other side, I think the I
think you're going to see the things
this deck can really do cuz everything
is kind of in place. You have baited
hook, you have a Karthus, you have a
bunch of different units with death
nails you can utilize. And uh some very
silly things might happen on the next
turn. And it's Aelia's job to try and
figure out, can I stop that by just
ending the game and winning? Cuz that is
usually one of the best ways to stop
your opponent from doing things they
want to do is just taking the game away
from them. Very Yeah,
>> in League of Legends we say death is the
hardest form of CC. It doesn't quite
work the same way in Riftbound, but
>> you can uh you can infer how that might
play out in a TC.
>> Teleorn herder.
Guardian Angel.
Aurelia is going to have to run in and I
think just chop things down to size, but
I don't think there's a lot for Aurelia
to do
>> right now. I believe that Lonely Power
did score a point for holding. So, if
there is a way to crack through on this
other battlefield, which is very
immense, that will be enough to win this
game.
>> But you're going to have to get to 15
with just an Aurelia. Yeah, look at this
point it's going to be very very
difficult to rack up those numbers that
much.
>> You get calculated risk here
>> from Din just saying I don't think you
really have anything. I don't think you
can get through this.
>> Can also mixologist can also replay
units to the same battlefield. So fun
stuff happens every now and then. So
Karth is going to trigger twice.
Mixologist does go away. It was a
temporary reflection and we have two
units we get back cuz death nail is
going to happen more than once and it is
going to be two black rose dingitaries.
can be played.
That means two battlefields sometimes.
And one is going to go over to the
Starring and that's going to trigger
Starring as well.
>> Mhm.
>> And all of a sudden, you can see why
maybe this battlefield is something that
is uh quite potent in this meta game.
>> Absolutely.
>> This is happening in the beginning
phase, by the way, if anyone uh thought
wasn't complicated enough already.
>> And the other one's going to get
reinforced there as well.
>> You did say this could potentially be a
very big interesting turn.
>> Reflection going to happen as well. One
of the nice things about Leblanc is uh
you get to put units you potentially
want to revive with cards like
Mixologist into your bin when you make
reflections.
>> And I believe that's another mixologist.
Certainly it is that five representing
the might value.
>> It does feel like one of the most
cyclical recursion decks at the moment.
>> Yeah, it's uh it's just Yeah, the amount
of times you see the same three energy
unit from time to time is uh
silly. I mean, very very evocative of
Leblanc, right? Makes a bunch of uh very
deceptive. Makes a bunch of mirror
images of herself.
>> Exactly. Right.
>> I see a hardest dragon. That's a fun
one. Usually one you want to get off of
baited hook, but sometimes you just play
it for eight and kill a unit and often
that's good enough as lonely Porro think
going to meet a very untimely demise.
Not a fair fight as VIP piece keeper
rumbles in for a stun and a punch.
>> Porro at least going to draw a card,
>> but uh things should be okay. And I from
memory serves I think it's now six
points to seven after those two points
get gained by Daniel. So can we deal
with Aelia is the other question. Is
does a Vega have to do it twice if you
do it at all?
>> Plus there's that deflect cost as well.
>> It feels a little bad sometimes to have
to pay uh pay the price but every now
and then you just got to do it.
>> Mhm.
I
>> think at least threatening Aurelia by
taking off the G makes some sense here.
So baited hook.
>> There we go. Ooh, by peacekeeper going
to be the one to bite the dust. Looking
for a six as a hus dragon. It's a pretty
good hit.
>> Oh, there's two actually.
>> Can only take one unfortunately.
>> Yes, but pretty good catch.
>> Yeah, I imagine harness dragon is going
to be the pick here. It is just going to
knock off the G unfortunately, but uh
better than nothing as they say. And uh
thanks to a recent rules change, you can
actually uh reinforce the same
battlefield you're hooking at cuz the
unit as the uh ability is resolving is
still technically controlling that
battlefield. So if he does want to play
the dragon and reinforce to where the V
is, that is a thing you can do. But
instead decides that, you know, I'm a
point away from losing. I'm just going
to try and make one battlefield as hard
as possible to get through.
>> It's very reasonable. And that
battlefield is looking absolutely
stacked at this point. Yeah, seven
points on Aelia side, but looks like
only five right now for Don, but
actually going to take out the
Stellicorn. Deciding if the G on the
Aelia, not really interested in trying
to pick a fight with it. Just again, I
don't think can get this big. I mean, if
it didn't happen last turn, you have to
think it's probably not happening this
turn.
>> Probably not.
>> And with Stilicorn unavailable to draw
you a bunch of extra cards, your
opponents kind of capped what you saw
them use last turn. And again, they
weren't able to crack, you know, 15
might. So now 20 plus feels like a
challenge they likely cannot overcome.
So I think a good read there in general
from Leblanc just saying that the
situation we're in means that I just
don't want to give you extra cards.
That's probably the way I lose this game
is ruined Rex going to reinforce once
more as Kus just vibes in the backline.
>> That Star all these death nails better.
Yeah, Starring's been a house.
>> Absolutely. And it is looking very very
full over there as well.
>> Crowded little spot.
>> It's been very fun to see the baited
hook in action. I will I will give you
that. It's It's good to see something
with such value coming in.
>> It's not even its full power. This card
gets hidden. We know that's a hidden
blade
>> and perhaps Cya suspects it is that as
well. There's not that many different
hidden cards in these domains.
They're going to draw a card. And again,
had a bunch of units last time we
looked. There's a charm. I believe I saw
on a Defiant Dance I also spotted. That
is usually the thing that gets uh gets
the deck rolling. But Aurelia is going
to take a card draw from a point. And if
Aurelia can find a way to capture the
other very stacked battlefield, that
will be a win here for Curya.
Victor Swiftness. Good start.
>> Yes.
>> No way to get over to the Starring
without them. So going to have to try.
Don't know how uh likely it is to
succeed, but you can kind of do the math
face up in a way. M
>> uh you have to accommodate for some of
the death nails cuz again mixologist can
have units replayed to the same
battlefield
>> and there's a couple units in there.
They're pretty small only I think two
>> that mixologist can possibly get and
there are two mixologists. So uh there
won't be that many units reinforcing.
They'll be quite small cuz they're only
one might units. It's the kind of early
two energy units that we saw in the
early part of the game. But even just
running the numbers alone that is what
12 + 4 is 16 + 10 is 26 in a hidden
card.
Yeah. Look, uh,
>> doesn't feel easy.
>> It doesn't feel easy at all.
>> I mean, I guess I can do the math while
we're waiting cuz it's four, five right
now for Aurelia. 67 for the boots with
the plus two. Don't look at me like
that. Would be chosen once. That would
be eight. Would ready from her legend
ability for nine.
>> Divine dance is typically plus five on
average.
>> What's that? 14. That's good, but it's
not enough.
>> Not enough by still a reasonably large
margin. Is
>> there a there is a chance? Is there a
charm?
>> Is there a charm? No.
>> No, there isn't.
>> I see something that looks suspicious.
Defy. That's what it is.
>> Yeah, you've got two Defies there.
>> Defy. Defy. Stellicorn, which is going
to get replayed. And I guess just saying
I don't have to win this turn.
>> Mhm.
>> Going to actually ready up the
Stellicorn here and go moving for a
card. Did
>> did ready Aurelia. Everyone just making
sure that costs are paid.
>> Mhm.
>> And Stokin just is going to draw a card
and threaten to hold maybe
at the rockfall path.
>> Look, I mean, at this point, it is
feeling like a much less ominous option,
but we shall see.
>> So, there's also a Leblanc trigger when
you hold, and I have a feeling ruined
Rex is going to ruin someone's day cuz
uh if you didn't know what that one
does, it's a it's a big common. I think
maybe built more for limited uh as a six
drop, but it does uh on death deal four
damage to a unit anywhere wherever they
are. Oh, harness dragon as well. Oh, I
fully forgot about that.
>> Mhm. And with the carus trigger as well,
not just for it'll be
>> from memory. Reflections do not get play
triggers.
Yes, I become a copy of something when I
play, I don't get the card's play
effect. That's one of the reasons
Leblanc is the way she is
>> is because you only get death nails. So,
you can't actually get a harness dragon
uh killer unit trigger when you make a
copy of it. So, instead going to maybe
look to make a copy of something else.
Starring also triggering
as
mixologist dying moved a soaring scout
into the spring. So, that moved the
harness dragon back. Now, we're copying
something. We're going to copy ruined
Rex.
>> Yep.
>> And uh that is four instances of four
damage potentially if both Rexes go
down. But each one is deal four damage
twice cuz of Carus.
>> Mhm.
>> Aurelia and Silicon are relatively big.
I don't think they're big enough.
>> Look, it it does feel like the Aurelia
side is looking a little worse for wear
at this point. The
>> Oh my goodness.
>> Now it's three every time Ruin Rex goes
down.
>> And to be fair, like distance only at
six points. You're not going to lose,
>> but probably not going to win.
>> Yeah. Look, I think the cool thing about
this is regardless of the fact that the
baited hook is there. I think even if it
wasn't at this point, there is still
such value in what LeBlanc is just doing
anyway.
>> Yeah, right now it's just for this. I I
want to kill a unit.
>> It's just to kill a unit. You get some
extra value. It's fun, but it's mostly
just for the the the text where the unit
goes bye-bye.
>> Absolutely.
>> You haven't hit anything.
>> Gonna get a Gallo. That's ruined
actually.
>> Nope. Oh, there's a rift.
>> Rift Herald. There we go.
>> This is a fun one. This is one of the
like uh this is one of the big hits in
this deck. It's actually three copies of
this card in this Leblanc list. So
clearly leaning into the power of this
big seven might unit when I when it
moves to a battlefield you look at your
cards and you you can get a unit if you
find one. So it's kind of like when you
move draw a card which is pretty good
piece of text
>> and then when it dies you just put
something from your hand into play.
>> Sometimes another rift ignoring the
cost. Some it's a hunter dragon
sometimes it's a rift sometimes it's
anacon.
>> Lots of fun stuff to be had here.
Definitely one of the more interesting
death nail uh big boys from unleash.
>> Yeah. So it looks like harness dragon
rolled on in. Basically just uh traded
with the earlier lost the GA and then
Carus going on take a battle is the only
ready unit left and we didn't see it uh
exactly on the table but uh three rip
ruined Rex, excuse me. Uh cuz there's
both of them. Three Ruined Rex deathnail
triggers dealt enough damage to kill
Aurelia and Selicon. And now it's seven
points to seven. One player has to get
through, I don't know, 15ish points of
might and one is only a play with a
bunch of units in their hand as we know.
>> Yeah, look, it's not looking great, but
at this point, you just have to
congratulate Leblanc there for very
decisive and very effective play.
>> Yeah, you can kind of see like how much
value this deck can kind of acrewue as
it gets bigger. That is going to be game
one over to Dist and a very clean look
at this deck and what it does. Again,
it's not trying to you're not trying to
hit the high roll, right? So, there's
been hook list in the past where you try
and slam a five as fast as you can and
then hook for harness dragon as early as
possible. That's not this list. This
list is just using the hook as an
additional value piece to go even
bigger. But the core of the deck that
we've seen in Leblanc, right, the
carpasses, the death nails, that stuff,
that's what this deck wants to be doing.
>> Absolutely. It will be very interesting
to see what gets sideboarded in for
this. As you said earlier, it's it's
very different to your dazzling auroras
because there is still strategy around
whether you don't get the baited hook or
not. doesn't pin everything on that. So,
how would you approach trying to work
around a hook given that you are the
resident hook fan?
>> I'm trying to think. It's so it's funny
cuz we obviously don't play the we don't
show the players sideboard on stream
just kind of as a general thing
especially in the Swiss one deck lists
are not known. Uh obviously the
challenger boys uh wanted to advertise
>> their creation. So if you want this list
is only there on Twitter. That's
confidence
>> in in the glory. And that is that that
is confidence to know that uh everyone's
going to know at this point what you're
on and you just said, "You know what?
Fine. You can find out. Have a see if
you like what I have here."
>> Uh and I just in my head I don't think
there's anything in the sideboard that
jumps out to me immediately. What I
guess I'd be worried about is like some
extra gear removal if my hand is really
reliant on hook. But again, I think the
thing that's really cool about this deck
is it just isn't reliant on that card.
It is simply a card that makes the deck.
>> It like turbocharges the deck when you
get it, but you don't need it to do what
happened there. Now, I don't know if you
have enough consistent ways to trigger
death nail without it. And we do know
sacrifice times three is in the list,
but there's no call the weeks, right?
That's another way to kind of get a
death nail while also getting another
unit. Pretty good against Aurora.
Uh, and one of the reasons I think
people have been interested in order as
a domain for this event in particular. I
mean, there is also hidden blade.
>> Hidden blade, that's a fun one.
Sometimes you just hit your own unit,
draw a couple cards. I've hidden bladed
my unsung hero many times.
>> Will be interesting to see which
battlefields are out in play this time
around. I wouldn't be surprised if we do
see that abandoned hall come in just so
that there is that choosing.
>> Yeah, I'm curious if I guess they are
going first this game. So I think it
makes sense when you're kind of on the
tempo lead that you will want to go to I
think what is maybe your best
battlefield in abandoned hall.
>> I think just thinking about the match up
in general at a macro level. I do think
that you can't let Leblanc drag the game
out like that.
>> Uh obviously like didn't get that much
choice with how the how things lined up
and I think both players navigated as
well as they could. I think Leblanc just
kind of turned the corner at a critical
turn and managed to stop the the
bleeding stop from getting the final
point. But I think uh at your best
battlefield on the play, I do think
Aurelia should try and win before that
happens again, before Carus gets in the
mix too much. And there are things like
charm, right, that can affect backline
units to uh try and break those things
up. But
>> typically these kind of decks when they
get enough resources can do everything
kind of in one turn, right?
>> Play Arthus, have your Rex, hook it, pop
it, make another thing, take the
battlefields like a lot will happen at
one time and typically it's hard to to
stop that once you get overwhelmed. So
the trick is to just put enough pressure
on your opponent that they can't build
the perfect little combination.
>> And uh the more you can deny points
going from the blanc because her legend
ability does trigger on conquer or hold,
the better off you're going to feel. So
I think I expect Aelia to be very
aggressive with trying to keep control
of these battlefields because if the
block can't get the first score, it's
very hard to actually utilize your value
train.
>> Absolutely. And I do think that in the
last one, we did see a little bit of,
you know, trying to to make it work
despite not having those cards necessary
for the first couple of turns there. You
really want to establish that hold as
soon as possible so that you can start
building.
>> Yeah, I think some little things stuck
out to me there as well. Like with
Aurelia, with Ruin Rex's death trigger,
I think actually choosing the Stellicorn
was really smart. Just knowing that in
that position,
>> the other cards you draw are going to be
way scarier to me. Even though Aurelia
is the single best unit in the deck,
it's it's the whole deck, not just the
legend and the chosen champion, but in
many ways, this is a deck that cares
maybe more than any other about its
chosen champion.
>> But aspirin's climb on the other side. I
like this a lot.
>> No abandoned hall target.
>> Maybe deciding that
abandoned hall is best save for the
final game. Black rose dignitary coming
down. This is kind of like soaring scout
with uh a little more might cost a
little more, little bigger on offense as
well. notably uh does have assault one.
So if you get into a combat,
>> you can actually you will actually
contribute some might to hook as well,
but you must actually be assaulting,
which means units must be there for you
to hit. You don't just get it if you
roll into an open showdown. So is
sometimes bigger than it looks, which is
nice. Titoner is going to go ahead and
grab the Tagon Speak. And in general, I
do like this is another battle that I do
like on going first for Aurelia. That's
because
>> as soon as you grab it, uh you just hold
up spells for the rest of the game.
>> Yes. Yes. And that is a very powerful
thing for a deck that always wants to be
holding up an on guard, a discipline, a
defiant dance. So we even saw actually
in Atlanta bunch of sneaky deck hands.
So when you're on the play for Tagon, so
on the draw for Ton Speak going second,
you can take the peak and then do the
same thing and kind of get the point
tempo and never let it go. Is actually
we're going to gank on over and get two
points out of the deal. So very nice
start here for Aurelia.
>> Much much faster. Absolutely. We did get
a little sneaky peak of the hand there.
I think there's a little parro there.
Yes,
>> little lonely power. Little discipline.
Little guardian angel. Three cards I spy
but unfortunately can't hold both as
Gallo going to hit the bin. Make a copy
of Black Rose Dignitary. That one is
ready. No shenanigans with ganking or
Starring this time. So uh that
reflection isn't going anywhere but uh
we'll at least uh get an extra bit of
ramp happening as a channelneled rune
will get exhausted once that temporary
unit goes away. And just setting up here
Carus already
>> making the value train very present
readying two runes and saying yoga, what
do you got?
>> Mhm.
I think Deceiver has definitely been far
and away the most popular Leblanc option
>> for this tournament for sure.
>> Yeah, this is uh this deck is so sweet.
Again, just like I I'm curious to see
what the makeup of the list is like.
This is really nice by the way. Finding
a charm
>> able to take out the cartus. I mean,
>> even just like
>> face up on the table with channel two
runes,
>> uh which was a pretty good death nail to
get. Titan are actually going to get
involved even more. And I think this is
kind of how the tempo has to go.
>> Going to look to crash through all these
units. 2 3 4 five might versus six. Tie
is going to win a very nice melee.
>> And even though the deathn will happen,
Carthus wasn't there.
>> A much more aggressive start building
way earlier for Cya.
>> This is kind of the thing. You have to
kind of pick the pieces apart before
things get out of hand.
>> Definitely.
>> So should be four points I believe on
Curious side. Two on the first turn
thanks to those boots ganking. two on
this turn thanks to the same thing. And
Ruin Rex kind of going to get the train
going again alongside Watchful Sentry. I
like that Disney is continuing to deploy
units. One of the nice things about this
deck is there's so many little units
that channel runes for you that you can
actually afford to play your more
expensive six might six drops kind of
earlier than you'd expect from other
decks without putting yourself too far
behind in resources. Cuz again, one of
the things that is true about this deck,
it is extremely resource dense. Like
very greedy how how much energy it needs
to operate.
>> All right. And we can say yes, there was
that lonely parro in hand.
>> Adapatron, not a bad one against the old
beta hook.
>> Good against Aurora as well. Been a very
popular choice for quite a while.
>> Yes,
>> five points it looks like. Had my math a
little wrong cuz of holding for this
turn. And of course go to six now.
>> And this is kind of uh commonly the
doomsday scenario up against Aurelia.
>> Could even see Aelia maybe be deployed
here. Don't know if we have enough to
also play G. going to play Lonely Porro
instead to reinforce
>> and maybe just pass it on back and say
this could be enough in the face of Ruin
Rex. I'm not sure that is true, but
making an effort here to try and put the
point pressure on before Leavant can
really get set up here.
>> Also be feeling so much more comfortable
with making some of those choices
without that Carus there to double those
triggers as well.
>> Yeah, playing G but not equipping. So, I
think trying to set up for a big Aurelia
turn next turn. Aelia does cost five. G
equips basically for
>> a power, but it doesn't cost you
>> uh energy, so you can leave a couple
runes up to play more spells. That will
mean there will be two runes available
as Watchful Sentry
awakens alongside Rex. And Rex is going
to go ahead and make a reflection of
itself, I believe, off to the peak.
Discards another Rex and uh is starting
to get some value here.
It can turn around very very quickly
just because of the tempo of those
Leblanc decks.
>> He's only six points. So don't have to
don't have to necessarily
stop the other battlefield from scoring
by holding. Although not a comfortable
spot to be in with your opponent seven,
especially with again kind of the
impending Aurelia next turn threatening
to score the other battlefield. You can
also score both. Uh there is a boots of
swiftness also just on the board.
>> Uh
>> second Rex. So there is some stuff to
navigate here, but Rex the second the
long fragmented as well. Nice little
value piece from your champion zone.
Makes a lot of sense in a deck that is
trying to acrue value pretty steadily
and not a bad baited hook target either.
Although there aren't that many fours in
this list you're trying to crack for. So
we are going to go to seven here. Cura
if he can find a way to score that very
dense battlefield once again with triple
ruined Rex at it will be able to take
this game and push us to game number
three. Oh no, it's an Aspirin's Climb
game. I'm so wrong.
Foiled again by Aspirin's Climb.
>> So, actually, I changed my mind. I think
this is a really rough position for
Aurelia cuz Ruin Rex is going to be uh
charmed on over, but going to deal six
to everything. And I guess that means
the death nail doesn't do anything. But
>> you traded three of your cards for one
of theirs. W
>> not necessarily the value you're looking
for against the very valueoriented deck
and again aspirants climb meaning the
game is a single point out of reach than
it would normally be means that Disney I
think has actually bought enough time to
turn the corner once again.
>> Mhm.
With both of these undefeated so far
it's got to be rough to be in that
position. This Leblanc deck just looks
so good. Again, even without the hooks,
just I haven't seen the rest of the
Leblanc, so I don't know how many like
two drops these decks are playing, but
that seems pretty important as far as
like the early turns going. I don't know
how many Black Rose dignitaries people
are playing. But that card, despite
seeing seeming a little silly as a three
energy unit and kind of like a, you
know, slightly upgraded version of of
Soaring Scout, I think that feels like a
very important card in this deck.
Clearly a very wellthoughtout build from
the challenge of TCD Labs, which is not
surprising at all given their pedigree.
And now two points to seven, but we're
climbing. And Aurelia is just starting
to fall woefully behind in card
advantage, which is kind of the thing
that LeBlanc does.
>> Yeah.
>> And even Silicon Silicon is not going to
live on this board ever.
>> It is a very precarious position here.
I was just just thinking even more. We
haven't even seen a sacrifice yet, by
the way, but this is a card that I think
order was very happy to receive in
unleashed. And
>> as particularly as a reaction spell,
>> there's going to like usually we don't
think about
>> with the exception, I guess, Star Cross.
Now, as well, we don't typically think
of cards like hidden blade as cards you
have to worry about at reaction speed,
right? Cuz it's an action and it has to
be at a battlefield.
>> Um, but even something like vengeance,
which is a slow spell, right, that can
kill any unit, harness dragon, a unit
that can kill any unit. We don't
typically worry about getting our units
taken out at reaction speed, but with
sacrifice and ruin wrecked, you actually
do have to worry about that.
>> There is Aurelia coming out after all.
>> Like if Aurelia, if they go to equip and
sacrifice happens on this ruin wreck,
I'm going to lose my mind.
>> All right,
>> cycling.
So, moving to equip and ready Aurelia
with the legend ability.
>> That does have to happen cuz it happens
when you choose. There is no sacrifice
cuz that would have been instantly
killed on side. Although I guess
more complex than I think but Aelia is
going to roll on. We'll we'll think
about it later.
>> Again, the game is getting uh quite
saucy as Ruined Rex is going to deal six
>> and deal four. That's 10 total. G is
going to pop
>> and I think Dist's going to say, "Yeah,
sure. That's fine with me. You want to
do it again? I got another one."
did kill the uh the real one, which
makes some sense given that you probably
going to go back in for the temporary
one, but if you don't, at least you
can't they can't make another one.
>> Absolutely.
>> There are still three in the deck in
total, though. So,
>> yep,
>> very likely to see more.
>> Wouldn't have expected a six energy
common from the set to be one of the
allstars, but does kind of make sense
when you consider what Leblanc wants to
do. Boots are going to be equipped and
uh that legend is not ready cuz a
conquer did not happen. So can't even go
back in even if she wanted to.
>> So instead, we're just going to deal
four damage and it's going to have to be
enough for now. Deflect has to get paid
if that happens as well, though.
>> I believe you have to pick.
>> Interesting.
No. Okay. Just thumbing through the
graveyard.
>> Yeah,
>> I think uh didn't deal the death nail.
Interestingly, I didn't know you could
elect to not do that. We see ruined Rex
on screen. It says deal four to an enemy
unit on death now.
>> Obviously the four is not enough to take
out the six that Aurelia currently is.
But dealing four and losing a rune
doesn't feel all that good. Don't know
if it'll matter, but I believe Disney
would have been required to pick a legal
target there.
>> Watchful sentry though. Going to move on
over to the Tagon Speak. Get another
point. Worry about it later as Leblanc
trigger is going to happen again. You
have to think. Nope. Moving straight
along. Doesn't want anything to do with
that. going to be VI peacekeeper
instead. Played to base and there's
baited hook
>> who's getting hooked.
>> Goodbye VI. Going straight for a six
here. Looking for harness dragon. There
are three of them in the deck. Mirror
image, dignitary, sacrifice, watchful
sentry. That is a whiff.
>> That's rough.
>> And this is this is the variance that
happens when you play baited hook. You
only get to look at five cards. Your
odds are often very good. You know your
ratios when you build the deck, but
sometimes you miss. And this is a miss.
Look, as I was saying earlier, having
played a little bit of Aurora, I can
sympathize with the feeling of just not
getting the thing that you want.
>> Yeah, unlike Aurora, sometimes you draw
your thing and still don't get what you
wanted. At least with Aurora, you get
the thing that you wanted.
>> But, uh, Aurora cost three times as much
in terms of energy cost. So, perhaps it
is a reasonable understanding there is,
uh, offered to cut the recycle cards,
decided, nope, I'm good.
>> And, uh, at seven points in a nine-point
game with Aurelia ready to go. Uh, I do
have to remind everyone that whiff is
pretty bad. Like threatening to win the
game on Aelia's side now. Kind of went
from a position that felt so
overwhelming that there was nothing to
do to I think Aelia is just going to win
easily.
>> Yeah, look at this point. It's just
chalk and cheese from the last goound.
>> Think the math checks out already. So,
is there a hidden blade here? That's not
a hidden blade.
>> Nope.
>> That could be. Now, again, Leblanc does
get a card draw. Not the beginning
phase. You don't get two, but you do get
one. So, if that isn't a hidden blade
that's been drawn up, this is going to
easily win combat against two might and
that's going to be game number three.
>> That will do it.
>> Going to get the W. I thought that game
was done.
>> I mean, look, a really, really tough
hook there. It It's rough to say when
that happens, but ultimately, I think
that really was the turning point there.
Aelia just couldn't really have made it
quite as easily without having that be a
whiff. Yeah, I mean it looks the line
looks a little silly when you spend all
this energy on Vi just to immediately
>> kill it without any extra value, but can
kind of see why you had to do it. You
know, VI VI peacekeepers trigger only
works when she's attacking and if Aelia
is coming in, even though you can
ambush, you don't really get the stun,
so it's not going to help you. So
instead, swung for the fences. Odds
would have been good there to hit a
harness dragon and uh
>> take out the Aurelia, but did not work
out. So, instead we play a third game,
which I'm kind of excited about given
how sweet these decks are.
>> Yeah, sometimes them's the brakes. And
as we said before, it does mean that we
will now see that abandoned hall come
into play.
>> Yes, I think uh Afron's climb was in a
really good spot there
>> for uh for Leblanc. And uh having that
climb game slip away might feel a little
bad. I guess you were going second
anyway, so now you're back going first
in this third game on a pretty good
battlefield. So, doesn't feel too bad,
but you can kind of see why people have
been liking climb when going second, cuz
it kind of gives you the opportunity to
potentially steal the game when you
start behind, right?
>> That extra point made a world of
difference in that game. And this is
also why we see Arena's greatest often
uh
>> sometimes to just counter the extra
point that Aspiron's Climb is making the
game go to.
>> Yeah, it was interesting seeing the meta
breakdown from yesterday with those two
both making a reasonably decent showing.
I think it was about 18 19%.
>> It was the second and third battlefield
after Starring. So, uh haven't seen too
much of them, but you can kind of see
when they when they deployed in their
spots. Uh they're quite good. In fact,
early would have loved to have it in
that game, but don't think it's in the
list here for Cy. Still players are
counting up their decks, shuffling up
for game number three. And deep breath
again, maybe to remind everyone, not
only do we have a lot of rounds to play
today before Tope, but these two
players, they are still some of the only
undefeateds left in the room and they
would like to stay that way.
>> Absolutely. And coming to game three, it
does make a little bit of extra
pressure. Obviously, they are both very,
very good pilots for their decks, but
there is that necessity of a mental
reset as you come into it because
there's just so much going on. They've
already played a full day coming into it
with a little bit of extra pressure.
Even if you're used to it, it's still
quite a lot.
>> Yep. So, the prismaticism push-ups in
Atlanta to see just deep breaths in the
feature match area in general.
>> Hey, however you need to center
yourself.
>> Exactly.
>> You got to do it.
>> Little mental reset, little Wooa, and a
little game three is what we're going to
get here to kick up the feature match.
This has been a very intricate back and
forth. You can kind of see again that
Aelia wants to get ahead and stay ahead
before Leblanc can turn the corner and
Leblanc wants to make the grossest
looking board possible
using all of those death nails to just
build up an advantage too large to
overcome. So, who's going to win game
number three? Let's find out in just a
moment. Leblanc going first at Windswept
Hill and Abandon Hall as predicted
>> or Aurelia.
>> Oh, we've chased champions as well.
>> Interesting. So, off to Leblanc
everywhere at once as our chosen
champion.
>> So, this one is it's interesting cuz
this one it fits kind of the mid-range
Leblanc build way more, right? If we
start making copies of this, if you can
keep them at a battlefield, you will not
stop making copies of this. And I think
something I noticed with Starring that
was really valuable was that
>> Leblanc was able to consistently
pressure the other battlefield when
making reflections on hold. That didn't
happen in the last game because of
Aspirin's Clam. Even though clam did
create some room for that game to maybe
be one. Windswep windswept Hill does
basically the same thing for Leblanc. In
fact, it's arguably more efficient than
Susman because you don't need another
unit. So all of a sudden Aurelia goes
from kind of saying I can pretty easily
get to one battlefield and maybe hold
the other one to like oh I'm in danger
every single time you make a reflection
now.
>> Absolutely. That tie turner coming
straight in.
>> Yeah. Onto the hall but uh just kind of
developing here for Aelia. This is again
very common and uh slammed the chosen
champion on turn four. This is also a
four energy no power champion unit.
Leona has access to two very good units
in her champ zone. So off to the hill.
Star cross is going to be the answer
here.
>> Yep.
>> And these colors do not have ways to
really fight on the chain. So this is
just going to happen.
>> Yep.
>> You can see why would have made a
reflection ganked over to the hall and
taken out the tide turner. So Starcross
protects all that from happening. hugely
slows down the momentum and even stops
the point from being scored as well.
>> Very understandable as to why it has
been one of the most commonly used
spells over the course of the weekend so
far. One of the most interesting ones
from Unleashed to be in so many decks.
>> Gothus. Yep. Pretty good follow up here
on six. Carthus recycling one and
playing Black Rose Dignitary. So setting
up again kind of the the MO of Leblanc
is to find a way to get a point so you
can get some reflection value and then
have something else to do with it. And
Kardus usually means all the things you
want to do just get enhanced.
>> If you're gonna do it, do it twice. Why
not?
>> Yeah, exactly. You already want to do
it, might as well do it again. The
reason Kartus has gotten so much more
attention ever since Leblanc was
spoiled.
>> Little Origins card, kind of a seed for
future sets. And clearly, I think this
is one of the payoffs that the devs had
intended. But a Telecom with Guardian
Angel starting to move on a battlefield
that has ganking should be
>> warning bells for everyone that's ever
played against Aurelia.
And there's the charm as well.
>> Very nicely timed. Already knows what's
happening. Just Yep. This is the one,
right? You don't want this other one.
>> No, don't want it. That's fine. Guess
not.
>> It's one of the things that I love about
being here on the Sunday is that there
are very decisive plays and everybody is
very, very good at reading what is going
on. They are all so familiar with their
decks. As we said, these are both
undefeated decks. So, being able to read
what's happening and go, "Yeah, you're
going to do this, aren't you?" Yep.
Okay, cool. Let's go. I think playing
appropriately quickly as well cuz not
that much time left in around 11 minutes
left.
>> Plenty of time to finish game number
three. But have to think that Don maybe
didn't expect to have to play one as B
going to come in and keep the piece once
again.
>> So her are going to lose that beautiful
guardian angel, but is going to live to
fight another day.
>> Leblanc value though is going to
continue to acrew and again with that
ganking granted by Windswept Hill. There
is just so much value to be gained. This
is kind of how Leblanc gets to break the
the points in a way that's in her favor
cuz you always want to take one
battlefield, right? Cuz you get value
from a reflection. This lets you pretty
freely ensure that you get both. And
there's a very big difference to getting
two points a turn than getting one.
>> Absolutely. Having both conquer and hold
be the trigger for it is really really
effective.
>> Yeah, it could have been either in
Levanc I think would have been pretty
good. So clearly a legend that uh
>> got a lot of love in development maybe
we can say
>> as just considering the discard here
tend to want to get something you can
get back with mixologist or something
that is a little too clunky to cast
>> labon everyone at once going to fulfill
kind of more of the latter condition
than the former making a copy of is that
black rose or vi is going to be a copy
of vi the one's the biggest unit
actually
>> interesting
>> establishing a very large presence more
than anything else
>> bit more on the value side of things
this go around just trying present the
most might possible
and one more to come. It's soaring scout
reinforcing and maybe doesn't want to
grab the other point. Yeah, just wants
to keep this teleorn at bay. So stacking
might on the bottom battlefield instead
13 presented with that reflection.
>> I mean we did see in game one that it
does add up very very quickly once
you've been able to get all of them on
there. It makes a dominant presence that
even Aurelia at her best would struggle
with.
>> Yeah. So going to let Stellon kind of
have the other battlefield for free in
essence, but which is a little dangerous
cuz Stellon is when mobile is very
dangerous.
>> But I think valuing
>> just holding on,
trying to keep out Aurelia from getting
her points rather than prioritizing
getting your own, I suppose, is the
consideration. M
>> and certainly while Aurelia is good at
making units very big uh at some point
the numbers will not add up for her
right like especially when it's not
Aurelia Ferbit uh that you're making
bigger. Silicon can get big but it just
cannot get as big as Aelia can.
>> It also doesn't get the advantage that
Aurelia does from abandoned hall.
>> Right. Exactly. You do get a little bit
but you get not nearly the double dip
that Aelia gets which is sad cuz we
might not get to talk about it.
>> Yeah.
>> We had it we had it prepared since
Friday. getting so excited.
>> All right. Well, a lot of considerations
here for our player Koya. Two points to
one. So, feeling okay. But again, you
just feel like the more turns you give
Leblanc, the worse it tends to feel. And
you're a little offkilter as far as
point tempo goes. So, after the hall,
that's going to be a card draw and a
point. No uh no fuss there with Leblanc
having no runes awakened.
>> Very straightforward.
>> Ride the wind. Rebuke. I saw a star
cross in that hand. I don't see too many
pumps. I think I saw a discipline,
but a single pump is usually not enough
to get the job done. I think maybe Tide
Turner is that card I can barely make
out.
>> Oh, it's hard to
>> second from the right
>> possibly.
>> But two cards on the table. Just trying
to figure out what to follow up here.
Not really enough resources to deploy
Aurelius safely. So, I think it is going
to be a game where Stell's going to have
to do a lot of the heavy lifting.
>> Oh, discipline.
Okay, so making a play
to maybe just move again. Draws a card.
It gets bigger thanks to abandoned hall.
>> There's that defy there. There is seeant
dance. Oh, defiant dance.
>> So this is going to shrink the vi
sticorn's going to ready. I assume
abandoned hall kind of farming extra
might actually all Aurelia. So now
that's a nine might stellorn herder all
of a sudden.
>> Not bad.
>> Five piece keeper is a little smaller.
So it's 11 might I believe on the bottom
battlefield as Tide Turner going to swap
them in.
>> Aurelia still needs to be used here.
Ston hood is not ready. I might remind
you all
>> but uh that recycle is going to be
enough as Aurelia does use Tide Turner's
shoes to ready the Stellorn. A move is
going to draw a card. Ready is going to
happen and we're going to move back in.
>> Very nice. Huge amount of cards and a
massive amount of damage dealt to this
battlefield.
>> 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 plays nine. but not
enough to actually do it all, but enough
to clear at least all the units that
aren't temporary. And that feels like a
pretty good amount of damage done.
Sometimes feels bad to sacrifice your
Stellorn given how good that unit is,
but I think that is actually a very good
use of all those resources.
>> Absolutely. Especially because if you
are building up to eventually having
Aurelia as your main focus rather than
building up Stellorn for the big event,
like it makes a lot of sense to try and
negate the fact that they were building
up that battlefield once more like they
did in game one. So the other thing to
consider, I mean, Tai is still around
scoring points. So that actually is kind
of nice, but recycling a bunch of runes
there, which is something Aurelia has to
do to have her kind of biggest turn, and
that was a relatively,
>> you know, mid plus size turn,
>> uh,
>> is going to mean that redeploying Aelia
or deploying Aurelia Fven at all is
going to be kind of hard. I mean, the
rune disadvantage is is pretty massive
if you look at the pile of runes over on
one side versus the three on Curious
side. And that does make me worry only
because
>> that's more time being given over to the
Leblanc, which is a deck that does want
time in this matchup. Whereas Aelia
again tends to want to kind of get that
tempo and keep it. Is Thousand Tail
Watch are going to make an appearance.
This is another one you can hook every
now and then. That is enough runes for
acceleration. And that tie turner is
going to very badly lose this combat.
>> Ooh.
>> Ah, Leblanc. Yeah,
>> never forget. It's never just one point.
>> Yep, that'll do it.
>> Make a reflection. Discard a unit you
might get back later like Leblanc
fragmented.
>> Yes, Leblanc there as well.
>> Make a ready unit. And that ready unit
has ganking thanks to being at the
helix. So off we go. Goodbye tie turn.
And all of a sudden the points are even.
>> A very very decisive move there. Being
able to get both really turns the tide.
>> I think at some point Curry just felt
like I have to deal with all these units
at this battlefield. I have to stop
Leblanc from triggering. Right. does
trigger on hold which temporary units
cannot do. So used a lot to kind of
bring the game back to even all of a
sudden it feels like one watcher kind of
has meant enough of a tempo loss that
I'm a little concerned for's ability to
catch back up in this game cuz
>> the game plan has been get ahead and
stay ahead and now you're I'm behind I
have to get back ahead is oh my
goodness.
>> Oh wow.
>> Sacrifice finally showing its power here
before the temporary trigger does mean
the unit goes away. Just sacrifice it
instead for a rune and two cards. Why
not?
>> Do you like drawing two cards for one
energy?
>> Oh, I wouldn't say no.
>> I certainly do.
>> Yeah.
>> Baited hook as well in that hand. Glass
solid cart. Something bad is about to
happen.
>> Yeah. Suddenly that rune disparity
really really feeling very oppressive.
>> Okay,
>> there is a star cross which can break up
some reflection combos but card that's
going to get discarded here. Make
another thousand tail watcher.
So, it's mostly just for the points, I
have to imagine.
>> Going to go over point number five.
>> Makes sense.
>> Still seven might sitting at that
battlefield as well. Not bad as far as
uh presence out of sight goes. And
there's baited hook.
>> Baited hook.
>> There's no eights, but maybe just for
fun, we'll do it. Goodbye. Seven. Hello,
harness dragon. I see a Rex. I see a
Rift Herald.
>> Banger. Banger alert.
>> That'll do.
>> Oh, ruined Rex.
>> Yeah,
>> always taking the good cards instead of
the fun cards.
I mean, look at this.
>> Oh, no. No, no, no. He's got another
one.
>> Yes. I was just about to say a fun card
would be to to rock another hook. And
here we are with it out here.
>> Yeah. So, hook happens first. And
there's just no runes available for to
do anything. I really usually pretty
good at making her one bigger at least,
which all you need to dodge the death
nail. But four damage is done. And
that's going to be G.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> Piston goes to nine and zero with baited
hook lanc.
What an incredible game. I am so
impressed by how this baited hook did
come into play at the end of there.
Having the two to finish off really
showcases how the card really can change
everything. Look, the Aurelia player at
that point in time, obviously with that
few runes, it was always going to be a
difficult position, but goodness me.
>> Yeah, I think found himself behind, had
to make a play to try and equalize the
game and then opened the door for
Leblanc to do Leblanc stuff. And that is
the Leblanc stuff.
>> Yikes.
Look, it's easy to see why that deck has
been performing very well so far this
weekend.
>> I think uh very preient of you to be
like, "Oh, like
>> how do you kill your death units?" And
we actually just had like the most
boring mode of baited hook at the end of
that game, which is pay four
>> energy and a power to sacrifice a unit.
>> That was the only part of that text you
needed.
>> That's all you need to do sometimes. And
clearly it worked. Yeah, it did do more,
but like I guess the first one did more
cuz it actually found the ruin rex that
could kill the Aurelia, but the second
one was basically sacrifice that cost
four times as much energy.
>> It didn't draw you a card.
>> Look, it's still a little bit more
satisfying than just kind of running
into a wall, you know?
>> I mean, I can kind of see what the
challenger boys have been cooking up.
That deck looked nasty in that game.
>> I Yeah, look, I I love Leblanc, but I
would not want to be coming up against
that deck personally. I very interesting
to see a chosen champion change as well.
I'm curious what matchups Den wants to
do that. I guess we have an interview
coming up. So, if our other talent can
hear me, perhaps you ask about when you
change the chosen champion. I'm trying
to talk extra loudly cuz I see somebody
moving up for an interview. Perhaps
we'll ask about the chosen champion.
Logan,
>> that would be great. Look, I think it's
very interesting. I don't think we've
seen it on the feature desk at this
point. A chosen champion change.
>> We've seen one for Ari, I believe. I
think changed to green yesterday. We've
seen a little bit of Leblanc everywhere
at once. In fact, the mid-range Leblanc
decks tend to have been favoring that as
their chosen champion cuz like we didn't
see it in this game, but we've seen it
before like once you start the
reflection train, you just keep your
temporary units forever as long as
they're at the same battlefield. And all
of a sudden, I mean, you saw what
happened. There's like 15 might hanging
out in the battlefield pretty commonly.
If you just make like I don't know four
copies of Leblanc everywhere at once and
you have like 16 might permanently and
even more units to add, like it gets
gets pretty gross pretty quickly.
Definitely a very dominating presence on
the board there.
>> So, don't know how the other lads are
doing, but Challenger TCG again only
sent three players. I mean, it's a long
way from home. It
>> is a very long to a city that's a long
flight no matter where you're coming
from. I I came from LA, which is one of
the closest cities you can travel from.
>> It's still very far.
>> So, only three of them, but they're all
again, they're all in contention for top
eight still coming into this round. And
I mean, Don is poised to make top eight
with his deck at this point.
>> Absolutely. I think I would be the
feeling very confident at this point
coming out of that. Look, I think
realistically, regardless of how far
you've traveled, obviously a lot of
people are contending with jet lag to a
degree, but the decks that are going
well are really just thriving at this
point and it's nice to be able to see
them going so well. Kicking off the day
for Sunday here.
>> Yeah, shout out to Al Zu who keeps
tweeting about his horrible sleep
deprivation is going through this event.
I mean, it is it can be brutal jet lag.
I mean,
>> we talk about the US being far from
Sydney. My goodness, Europe is a very
long way away. Have you ever done that
pie, by the way?
>> Oh my gosh, yes, I have a couple of
times. And look, I'm very blessed that I
can sleep on a plane anywhere. Being
5'2, it makes it very easy to just kind
of squeeze in there. But I do not envy
it. It is a rough flight, but it is
worth it to be here because Sydney is
wonderful, and I'm really glad to see so
many international people coming and
having a very, very fun time here, being
able to explore a little bit, if not,
you know, having a a little bit of a a
break every so often.
>> Yep. I had heard a lot of fun about the
extracurriculars that were happening,
but we have an interview ready. I'd love
to hear more about this Leblanc cook.
Logan, what do you got for me?
>> Thank you so much. Pastry time for that
fantastic cast. I am joined by our 900
undefeated Leblanc CTC Daniel.
>> Hey, how's it going?
>> Not as good as you, mate. How does it
feel?
>> Oh, I mean, it's great. I mean, I
haven't had any of these RQs an
undefeated streak on day one. Um, so
being able to go 9-0, you know, I need
to win a few more rounds and then I can
draw one and I'm locked for top cut.
It's it's a great feeling to have.
>> You're definitely on track to get to
that top eight for the end of the day
after the obviously first round of five.
You've made it through the first one.
You got four more to go. But Patriot
Time had a question. Walk us through the
decision of sideboarding that chosen
champion.
>> Yeah, so the main reason to use the four
cost chosen Leblanc is for the windswept
Hill game. Uh, going first, you have
exactly four runes to play on turn two.
She is just able to put out more might
uh every single turn for the over the
course of the game than any other uh
combination of cards in the game because
of the leader ability. I can make
duplicate copies that say they have
temporary but she protects herself. So
on turn two I'm playing four might. Next
turn I have eight might in the
battlefield for free and then the next
turn it becomes 12 and 16 and so on.
It's very hard for most decks in the
game to deal with that. So anytime I'm
going first with Hill, I'm trying to
sight it in.
>> Yeah. It's that overwhelming might that
you're presenting that presents that
challenge for your opponents to come in
towards.
>> Exactly. And if I can ask, what inspired
you to jump onto Leblanc in the first
place?
>> My teammate Colin Kaiser. Uh he was he
was guaranteed to write a Leblanc guide
for this season, but he wasn't sure on
which version he wanted to play. I was
not so I was not a fan of like the
weaknesses of the original list, but he
said, "I've got to try them all, so let
me try Baited Hook." Uh it looked kind
of like inconsistent and weird and it
didn't look too good, but then we played
it and we refined it a little bit and it
started getting really really good. And
so essentially the choice was either
he's going to play it, I'm going to play
it, or both of us are playing it at this
event. So,
>> and it ended up being you today.
>> It ended up being me. And unfortunately,
I had to knock him down into the losers
bracket on uh the last round of
yesterday. So, not not a great way to
end the day, but
>> yeah. No, we see it on socials. You guys
have obviously got that relationship,
that banter being team. You guys
practice into one another. You make
these decisions that hopefully benefit
you both as much as possible to get into
that day two position and hopefully that
top eight. Yeah, we're both still
gunning for it.
>> Abs. I I believe you.
>> And uh you've been in Australia a few
days now. How do you feel about it? Do
you have any thoughts? Have you enjoyed
any local things?
>> Uh so we did a day of tourism. We got to
go see the zoo. That was nice.
>> Tanga zoo. Very good.
>> Um yeah, it was really nice. Um the jet
lag kind of killed us for a day. So it
was really just the one day where we got
to do touristy stuff. Didn't get to see
the bridge. Didn't get to see the opera
house yet. Maybe before I go, depending
on how things look, but it's it's uh I
got a morning flight. So,
>> you'll probably see it when you fly out.
>> You'll probably see it when you fly out.
You You go over the harbor anyway. You
see the house, you see the bridge. It's
It is beautiful. But if I can ask you
this,
>> without giving away too much, what would
be a matchup you might be most concerned
about heading into, you know, the last
few rounds of day two here.
>> So, the vulnerability of this Leblanc
deck, I'd say it's really, it has to be
two very specific things. You need to
have an early aggressive curve. you're
able to score points quickly and then
you need the very specific interaction
of Gust and Starcross. Those cards are
very good into Leblanc the way that her
reflection trigger works. So, I would
say it needs to be both those things
coming into me. One or the other doesn't
do it. Um, if they're a slower deck, but
they still have the interaction, I'll
just overwhelm them eventually. If
they're an aggro deck, but they don't
have those specific tools, I'm just
going to eventually find a time where I
can lock up a battlefield and then every
single turn that goes by, I get more
value than they do.
>> Yeah. Okay. And is that why the
inspiration behind that sort of aspirin
climb as well to extend that length of
the game as you say increase your value
over the course?
>> Yes. So in set two we uh a friend of
ours um Andrew Dval, he came up with
Aspirin's Climb for Draven because
Draven as the game goes every single
turn you're acrewing a few more cards.
Obviously not every deck can do that. So
the longer the game goes the more time
you have to build value, the more time
you have to find a spot to flip the game
in your favor. And we're using the same
strategy with this Leblanc deck.
Anything that's aggressive, we're going
second. So, we're behind essentially a
point every single turn. We want to play
the aspirin's climb. Just give us one
extra turn to fight back. Well, thank
you so much for those insights, Daniel.
That is fantastic. And congratulations
one more time on being 90 here at the
top of day two. And that'll be all from
us here on the lounge. Thank you so much
for watching. We'll be right back after
this break.
Welcome to Riftbond Basics featuring the
ground rules. Riftbond is a trading card
game based on the League of Legends
universe in which the aim is to score
eight victory points across two
different battlefields. Points are
scored by moving your own units onto one
of the battlefields and conquering it or
by holding it for more than one turn.
The different car types in Riftbound are
units, gears, and spells. To play these,
you must pay an energy cost, which is
shown in the top left corner of the
card, as well as a power cost. Energy is
obtained by exhausting runes. These come
from the 12 card rune deck from which
the top two cards are played for free at
the beginning of each turn. If you
exhaust your runes to pay energy, you
must also pay a power cost for some
cards. To do this, you simply place one
of your runes bearing the symbol shown
on the card under your rune deck. You
can also use runes that are already
exhausted for this.
The domains of the runes and the cards
you play in your main and sight deck are
determined by your legend. Units that
you play enter the board exhausted. This
means they cannot move until they are
readyed at the start of the next turn.
Just like all other exhausted cards on
your side, you initially play your units
and gears into your base. There they are
protected from combat. Gears can't get
into combat. If you already control a
battlefield, you also have the option to
play your units directly from your hand
onto it. This is where your units might
comes into play. This is the number
shown on the top right hand corner of
the units. Might represents both the
attack power and the defensive stat of
your units. If a player moves units into
an already occupied battlefield, combat
stunts. Here, spells with action and
reaction speed can be activated to deal
damage or modify might. When combat
occurs and no player wishes to activate
any more spells or abilities, the total
might of all units is added together and
distributed amongst the opposing units.
Players may decide for themselves which
opposing unit they wish to damage. Once
combat is over, any damage is healed by
units that were involved and did not
die. The game ends when a player reaches
eight victory points, though this is not
quite so easy to achieve. Whilst every
other point simply requires conquering a
battlefield to earn the eighth point,
you must either have held a battlefield
for one round or you score two points in
the same round. Now you've got all the
information you need to know to start
enjoying a game of Riftbound.
We're here at the Riftbound Regional
Qualifiers in Sydney 2026 and we're
going to take you for a tour of the
showgrounds. Let's go.
So, the first step on our journey to the
Sydney Showgrounds is here. This is the
badge collection where you will start
your riftbound journey in Sydney 2026.
Make sure you get all of your promo
cards and your playmats.
Enough you've got your badges. Don't
forget to get your merch. Here we have a
full merch wall as well as statues,
playmats, and more for your riffbound
enjoyment.
So, you've got your badge, you've found
your way past the merch wall, and you
are inside the showgrounds. Now, don't
forget to come to registration where the
friendly and helpful staff will make
sure you are signed up for all of the
events that you want to play.
So, now that you've registered, you'll
be wanting to earn tickets for the prize
wall. Don't forget, there are some
unique prizes you can earn here, which
include the metal prize wall tickets,
but we also have some oversized
battlefields, as well as the Riftbound
regional qualifier, Sydney pin.
But it's not all about competitive
events here at the Riftbound Regional
Qualifiers in Sydney. We also have some
free play areas where you and some
friends can just get together and play
some games. We also have cosplayers
roaming the halls to bring the magic of
League of Legends and Riftbound to life
here today. And we also have some
creator activations where you'll find
some content creators putting forward
their best content for you to enjoy.
For your competitive viewing pleasure,
if you're knocked out early or side
events were your jam, we also have a
schedule where you can come and enjoy
the competitive scene here with the big
screen and the chairs behind me as well.
It's a viewing platform for everyone to
enjoy. And if you've forgotten any cards
you need for your decks at the regional
Riftbound qualifiers in Sydney, the
vendors have you sorted. With more than
six different vendors, they'll have you
covered, including signed overn.
A new addition at the Riftbound Regional
Qualifier Sydney is the signature wall.
Don't forget to get down here and check
it out and maybe sign it just like I
have.
At the Riftbound Regional Qualifier
Sydney 2026, you'll also find side
events. We have a little something for
everyone from 2v2s, trios, sealed, and
preconstructed fights. You'll find it
all here in the side event area. Here at
the Riftbound Regional Qualifiers in
Sydney, we even have the featured
tables. This is where we will see the
best of the best Riftbound players in
the world come together to fight it out
for the regional championship. And on to
Worlds. And here we find ourselves at
the main event. This is where all of the
action happens. These players will be
fighting for best of cards. They'll be
vying for the second day gameplay and to
hit those featured tables. But more
importantly, they've come here to win it
all. And for all of you hungry gamers,
do not forget we also have three food
trucks parked out the back, including
some of our personal favorites, the
pizza. Make sure you check that out on
your breaks between games.
So, that's the Riftbound regional
qualifiers for Sydney 2026. You've seen
it all. You've got the tour. If you're
not here, then where the bloody hell are
you?
>> Welcome back to the regional qualifier,
Sydney. We have just witnessed round
nine and we are so excited to watch
round 10. But before that, let's talk a
little bit more, Logan, about round
nine.
>> I love talking and I love talking about
that round nine. What an absolute banger
of a matchup there. CTCG Daniel against
Cuoya. And Cuya, you have a fun fact
about him.
>> Yeah, Cuoya came from New Zealand. So,
our brother is just across the ocean,
across the dip, whatever you want to
call it, the river even. And it's
fantastic to have, of course, so many OC
representation in New Zealand coming
over and competing quite heavily. They
had a 10K tournament as well not long
ago. And Ky came in the top 16, but uh
apparently that was around where the
bands happened, so he had to play with a
different deck. But here he's really
shown up now. Though he did lose that
round, so he's now 8-1.
>> He is 8 and one, but it is still an
admiral spot to be in. And as you say,
that 10k over in New Zealand was a
fantastic showing. But that's the power
of having the RQ here in Sydney, as you
said before. It's the first in the
Southern Hemisphere. So we have all
kinds of international guests, New
Zealand, Southeast Asia, China, and the
like. We even have people from as far
from America and Europe down here
competing to become the regional
champion.
>> Yes. So many different cultures, so many
different nationalities are coming here
in Sydney. It really shows how, I guess,
worldwide and how beloved Riftbound is
for everyone in the world. We all love
Riftbound and we all enjoy it. And when
we come together to enjoy our hobby or
enjoy our sport as well, we all come
very excited to share our craft and our
skills.
>> Excitement is the name of the game and
that is what we are seeing out here in
the crowds. As we've said before, it's
great to sort of be amongst it. We get
these breaks where we actually go walk
in the main event and we see everyone
playing and the energy and the spirits
are just in good vibes especially with
that now improved prizing there's even
more to compete for more to fight for
here Nomi and that uh 90 Leblanc I
expect we'll see that one again
>> 100% yeah that 90 Leblanc I think we'll
be seeing more Leblancs in general uh
just how many of them of course entered
the entire tournament in the first place
and how many have made day two I did uh
walk around during the previous game,
having a look at the players in the uh
on their tables playing away. And it's
been fantastic to see um not only just
like my own local game store friends, I
just like having a little little sneaky
peek. How we going? How are things? I
mean, not talking to them.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> But being able to see how they're going
and cheering them on because it's great
a great community and as you said,
Leblanc's choir comment, but also I'm
checking out all the the other legends
that are still in the game.
>> Yeah, the Ye, the Aurelas, the Diana.
Such strong showings from these legends.
A couple from the new set Unleash here
as well. But as you say, it's so
fantastic to be able to walk around and
see people that you recognize that
you're, you know, that you know yourself
personally. And uh with so many familiar
faces, there's something here for
everyone with our side events, our main
events, the ondemand events. Even if you
drop out at any time, you can just jump
into another game. It's constant
riftbound here. Yeah, you can you can
never have too much rift bound and
that's what we have here at the regional
qualif qualifier Sydney. Unfortunately,
it's only like three days of course with
day zero on Friday. But as you said, if
uh even if you unfortunately don't make
day two of the main event, so much more
riftbound to be had in those side events
and of course those prize tickets.
Everybody loves those prize tickets cuz
then you can turn in those prize tickets
for those metal cards.
>> Yeah, the medals. And you've got to
remember, Unleash is the last chance at
getting those origin metals before they
are phased out, never to be available
again here, which is why they're flying
off the walls. That Ahri, that MF, they
were some of the first to go. They're
Origins Legends.
>> Which which of those metal cards from
Origins would you be most interested in
getting? I'm kind of Lux. I feel like
Lux is so pretty, but then I kind of
like Teemo as well.
>> Yeah, look, I'm a big big fan of Leona.
I play Leona a lot in League of Legends.
So for me, obviously I can't compete and
get the tickets, but my wife is out
there right now scuffling in the 2v2s.
She's at 26 tickets, another 14, and
she's going to lock in either Civer for
herself or that Leona for me.
>> Yeah, it depends whether or not she
wants to get that Civer for herself or
not. Like, do I go for the C? I mean,
Civer is wonderful as well. Of course
though, it really depends what is left
available because there are limited
stock of these uh metal cards. So, you
really got to try and grind as fast as
you can and get those metals because I
mean they're so pretty. I got to hold
one and it's like
>> and they're heavy. They feel worth it.
They're weighty. You're like, "Oh my
gosh, I don't want to drop this cuz I'll
leave a dent in the tiles, you know?"
Like, they're fantastic.
>> Yeah. I love the prizes as well in
general. Like you can also turn in your
tickets for many other things as well.
>> Yeah. booster boxes. You can get
individual boosters. I'm fairly certain
you can convert your tickets into the
statues as well. They brought a full
plethora of those statues. So, there's
always something worth fighting for,
which is why those changes to that top
64 prizing matters so importantly. Now,
they're going to be rewarded with those
40 prize wall tickets as well, and
they'll be able to pick up a medal for
themselves from what's left over.
>> From what's left over?
>> Yeah, I mean, I mean, that is the truth.
>> Talk realistically here.
>> You have to be realistic. Yes, those 14
prize tickets will be able to get them
that uh that one of those metal cards.
>> Yep. The coveted medals.
>> Yes. But here we are. Round 10 of this
regional qualifier. Sydney, we can see
our featured match here. I'm really
excited for this one. Logan,
>> who is it?
>> Prismat.
>> Yeah.
>> And do you know who my prediction is for
coming first?
>> Annie.
>> Annie, which in brackets Annie brackets
Prismat. So he is going to be versing
Minju here. Uh one of the mas we were
talking about mas slightly earlier.
There's quite a few uh masis in this
event and it's exciting to see um more
masteries. I was a master player back in
Origin. So this is kind of like how do I
become better?
>> Yeah. Well, Y is the second most
converted champ legend here from day one
over to day two. So a very strong
showing. And we take a quick look at the
deck tech on offer here. Love to see
that ruin runner still highly
represented. This is the mid-range
build. There is no Aurora happening
here. So, Vilemore obviously that new
unleash tech able to sort of minimize
those combats that you'll have to fight
out. And on the defense, that will be a
10 might unit. So, when you swing into
it, if your might is less than it, you
can't deal that combat damage. That
Rengar trophy hunter with that
doublesided ambush here too. Sneaky
piece of tech. you do love to see it,
but I'm a big fan of the white flame
protector. It's back.
>> It is back. I mean, there was a unit
that got released with unleash somewhat
similar, but the white flame protector
kind of does the job a bit better. On
play, you can give eight might to
another unit this turn, which means you
can protect with the white flame
protector your units that are already in
play. The punch burst as well, I think,
is super duper strong. It only costs one
uh one energy. It does cost two power,
but that one energy means if you only
have one rune up, you can still play it
providing you have those two um body
runes.
>> It will force Prismat to play around one
energy up. You are absolutely correct.
Not so fast. A fantastic counter running
that triple defy, that triple charm,
which is so so standard in these calm
decks as well as one of your favorites,
that triple discipline there, right?
>> But for protection, Za's hourglass is in
this deck. And we take a look at those
battlefields. The arena's greatest for
that fast-paced game. Volmore's lair. So
units can't move off of that one. And
Starring, a new favorite rising.
>> Yeah, these battlefields really dictate
how of course Masi wants to play. And it
really supports that play style as well.
As you mentioned, arena's greatest will
make things quite fast. But Bahamour's
Lair, I think he's been a staple since
Origins in Masi play style because of
the fact that you can't move units from
here to base. And Mari, like in League
of Legends, loves ganking.
>> Yeah. And absolutely. And something that
will help that as well is this Starring,
this new unleash battlefield. The first
time a player plays a non-token unit
here each turn, they may move another
unit they control here to its base. And
because that move effect is replaced,
it's going to enter that base ready and
you'll be able to move on to the other
battlefield, creating that kind of
unexpected combat showdown you may not
be ready for here. So, I really do like
this matchup. I do like these
battlefields that we're seeing in MU's
Master Yi list. Yeah, as you mentioned,
that that battlefield is really useful
because Master Y generally only wants
one unit on a battlefield at a time,
especially with that proven grounds
master. But this is Prismat's
uh deck list of course running the Annie
that he is so well known for.
>> Yeah, Annie. He's decided that Annie is
still very very strong and it's worth
running here in RQ Sydney up against the
new challenges. LeBlne up against Diana
and we take a quick look and see if
there is many unleashed changes that Vex
apathetic coming through abandoned
Starcross. I really love Starcross. I
think you called that as one of the meta
sort of changing cards here. Grim
Apothecary a welcome surprise.
>> Yeah, I mean of course uh if you
remember the the cards we submitted to
be the most metading. I did think
Starcross and Vex were some of the most
metading cards and it really shows how
strong Chaos is. And we can also see
though of course Annie is not just
Chaos, it is also uh Fury which is why
that grim apothecary is a really
interesting pick. Yeah, also taking a
quick squeeze at those battlefields here
that we can't forget those seat of
power. When you conquer here, draw one
for each other battlefield you or allies
control. We saw this yesterday as well,
right? I see they wanted to conquer that
horns forge before going in on that seat
of power to get maximum card draw. We
all love it. We all know it. The arena's
greatest, giving that extra victory
point over at the beginning of each
player's turn one. And we've seen it
before. Zorn Warren. It's going to be
able to discard one and draw one
whenever you conquer here.
>> Very plays into that uh chaos play style
where you want to try and curate your
hand as much as possible and make your
hand be as I'm kind of saying the same
thing but as strong as you can and get
make sure you get the right cards to
verse the particular opponent you are
versing.
>> Yeah. But it's definitely not without
his combat tricks. That cleave that long
sword at react speed equip as well. And
we've got the ambushing Rengar there, I
believe, too. That superstar from Spirit
Forge that actually got Prismat over the
line with this Annie into that Draven
and uh that grim apothecary as you
highlighted. Also having that ambush
mechanic and when you play me, you may
return a friendly unit at a battlefield
to its owner's hand. So, it's another
way to save your units if you think that
that showdown will not go your way.
>> Yeah. And having that onplay ability
once more with so many uh these other
ambusher units as well, it'll mean you
can return it and then ambush again. So
you could do that with of course Renga,
with Inferna, and maybe with another
Grimma carry.
>> Yeah. But we are in for a real treat
here. For those of you who don't know,
Prismat has been on a hell of a run,
just climbing every single regional
qualifier that he's appeared in until he
actually won the most recent regional
qualifier in Atlanta on that Annie,
which has clearly inspired the choice
of, you know, predicting Annie to take
this one. And there's a lot of really
great adaptations here. Kaiser Survivor
though still such a fantastic staple in
these fury domained decks here, Ricey.
But Ferris 4Runner not to be left
behind. So much value in that body. It
just goes from six might to two three
mites for still a total of six.
>> Yeah, these are I would say one of I
want to say the staple, but such strong
cards of Fury Kaiser Survivor. We've
seen her so many times since Origins. Of
course, when Kaiser conquers, she gets
to draw one and can come in accelerated
as well. Such an aggressive aggressive
card.
>> Yeah, but you have to play it at the
right time. Yes, it's good for card
draw, but there's no use sacrificing
Kaiser Survivor for absolutely no net
gain. You want to be conquering. You
want to be drawing and hopefully be able
to repeat that. You'll be able to pull
that off with that grim apothecary.
You'll be able to pull that off with
that star cross as well, saving Kaiser
Survivor. I dare say
Kaiser in set one only wanted to run
one. Kaiser's found more value in fury
decks that aren't Kaiser than his own
legend here. Yeah, I find that kind of
funny, but it really is an impressive
display of how I want to say versatile
Riftbound is like it it shows how many
different options there are for each
legend. Um, and even if you're playing
in a particular domain, it doesn't mean
you have to play all the most strongest
cards of that domain. It really is about
more your play style, how your legend
wants to play as well.
>> Yeah, they definitely don't synergize
with each other just cuz they have the
same name. And that's one of those
things that we're talking about in
Riftbound, the diversity of champions
and legends that we get to see, the
different builds, which are just so
interesting. I was having a chat a
little bit earlier. Just because two
decks are in the same domain, it does
not mean we're going to get the same
builds. More often than not, they're
still 50 60 75% different across those
two decks.
>> I mean, one really good example is
Master Year. He has two extremely
different but still viable play styles.
A mid-range and the Aurora Yi. I looking
at the deck though, this is of course a
mid-rangey that we are watching. So
every even within legends who are of
course the same domain and even the same
legend ability, we have so much variety.
And I do love that you mentioned Yi as
well being the first legend to actually
have two unique legend cards in
Riftbound having those two unique
signature spells as well. Now, Yei can
still only have a maximum of three
signature spells. So, can distribute
that between the first and that new
alpha strike here. But the game's a foot
here, right?
>> It is. We're here in game one of round
10. We're watching Prismat, the previous
winner of Atlanta regional qualifiers
versus Minu Master Yi representative.
>> Yeah, Master Yi finding themselves at 8
and one into Prismat on that 8 and one
as well. So, a bit of a slog ahead of
them. However, Prisma has decided to
start on that seat of power. When you
conquer here, draw one for each other
battlefield you control as well. And
Starring there for Mu on that master.
Yay. As we do see those legends and
surely is that is that the best of
Annie? I can't quite tell from here.
It's it's still not as um flexy though,
I want to say, as that 9.5 graded that
we saw yesterday, Razie. That 9.5 graded
was a pretty big flex, but I remember
seeing I think Prisma had two bests on
display before. So, I mean, we don't see
three here, but you know, maybe he'll
have he'll have four if he could
potentially go for the fourth one today,
right?
>> That's it. Prismat on the play though.
Inferno dropped into that base. And I
did see a flash in his hand. So, he
already has options.
>> That flash is very strong, of course.
Uh, and it's one of the cards that uh
we're giving out as a promo now for
Riftbound. Lots of flashes to go around.
One of the most used uh spells and
abilities in League of Legends as well.
So, it's good to see here in Riftbound.
Now, next turn, we have of course
Prismatic thinking what to do. There's
Flash. Move up to two friendly units to
base. A bit of a a spell that you can
use to save your units.
>> Yeah, reaction speed and only two
energy. Absolutely massive. Lonely Porro
play there by Mu. Turn of play back over
to Prismat as he considers his options
here. does have that Kaiser Survivor in
hand, but he's toying with Inferno.
>> He is in fact thinking about maybe
taking it to Star Spring, try and get
that first conquer point on the board,
but lots of options. It is Chaos of
course where you have so many abilities
to use and uh very curious to see
whether or not he is going to go for
that Starring or maybe he's going to
bring something else out first. Nope, it
will be Starring.
>> Yeah, going in for that Starring. The
first time a player plays a non-token
unit here each turn, they may move
another unit they control here to its
base. So, this speaks to why you want to
move to it first while you have all of
your runes up. So, they have the option
to play that unit to return inferno back
to base. And that's what's going to
happen. Getting Vex apathetic onto that
battlefield now. I see.
>> Yeah. And as you mentioned, the first
time you play non-token, they may have
it. And so, well, Inferno is back in
base, back and safe, and that Vex is on
that battlefield. We know how scary Vex
Apathetic is on a battlefield cuz when
she is there, every unit that Mu is
going to be playing will enter in
stunned. So that scuttle crab is
stunned. But out the lonely power onto
seed of power.
>> Yeah, it's good to get on the board
here. It looks like that might resolve
unless there's a gust in Prismat's hand
and he decides to go for it. That stall
porro coming down and it's happened.
Lonely Porro will conquer that second
battlefield there. that seat of power.
So they will be on one victory point a
piece here.
>> But just to that Vex, there's so much
value in that Vex apathetic here. Icy,
it's only four energy, no power for a
four might body with deflect. So already
pretty decent, but having that when an
opponent plays a unit while I'm at about
stun it. Well, I mean, we just saw this
happen once more where Vex, who was
ready, can get pulled back because of
the Kaiser, goes in now on to City of
Power to Contest, will actually get that
conquer point as well, but we'll have to
sacrifice the Vex in return.
>> Yeah, Vex apathetic taken out there,
that lonely pour of two with that Y
passive with that plus two on the
defense. So, it was a four might trade
into one another. What would usually not
work here in Ye a powerful two my unit
becomes that four. So a great trade
there and arguably Vexpathetic the
number one priority target here
>> number one priority but right now maybe
it's also potentially Kaiser as well who
is quite strong and has a few abilities
of themselves but of course Mari loves
to be on a battlefield and defending
with that plus two when he's defending
alone. He has to try and consider what
he wants to do here. It's going to bring
out the Ruin Runner. Uh, a really strong
unit because he it cannot be targeted by
abilities.
>> Yeah, we also got to see a sneak peek at
his hand. He has three Ruin Runners. A
full play set. Six energy, five might. I
can't be chosen by enemy spells and
abilities. So, that is going to protect
it from things like that star cross.
Unfortunately, obviously being too big
for that gust, but even if it could, it
would not be able to target it. So
that's a great amount of protection
there that ruin
a couple of options that Prismata
survivor is sitting on that Starring on
the northern battlefield and Prismat in
control already up to five points.
>> Yeah, being able to control both
battlefields means now that he's holding
gains an extra two now sitting on five.
Looks pretty strong and with Kaiser
there as well. I mean, kind of likes to
conquer a lot to get that extra draw.
It's kind of sitting and holding. Maybe
Prismat wants to try and conquer and get
those benefits back. Yeah, we do see
though Prismat's list is very heavily
leaning into the ambush mechanic. He
does have another Noxus hopeful there as
that traveling merchant. It does go down
onto that seat of power and he will take
that inferno back after moving the Noxus
Hopeful forward onto the Starring. He's
just shoring up these battlefields right
now. Ricey, he's knows that this master
Y, he's a competent player. He's got to
have some responses to clear Prismat
off.
>> I mean, Mu is eight and one, so he has
to be competent definitely to be in this
round 10 at such a wonderful score as
well. But out comes another scuttle crab
and three units on the board for Mi just
trying to build up, develop his base to
go in quite strong. Having a look at his
uh units again, he's got quite a few, as
you mentioned, those ruin runners. But
what else does he want to play here? I
would almost think a great play here
would be to send in that ready scuttle
crab into one of those battlefields just
to get the information on Prismat's hand
so he knows what he has to play into. We
see that Win has some answers. He's got
a not so fast. He's got a defy so he
could know the timing of when he needs
to play those if he gets that free
information. He does have what appears
to be approximately six runes up at the
moment. So still a lot of options.
Probably doesn't want to play out
another ruin runner right now. having
one on the battlefield is still quite
the threat that Prismat is going to have
to work around here.
>> He I think he is doing what you were
thinking considering that scuttle crab
because on death now you get to choose
your opponents and make them force them
to reveal their hands. You also get an
experience as well. Master doesn't mind
experience especially we can look at
that chosen champion. Yeah, that
champion unit, Master Yi Tempered, has
that level six and that level 11 XP buff
there. One of those new ones from
Unleashed. And if we do take a quick
look, level six, I have deflect and
ganking, so there's no level 11.
Correction to myself there, but he also
has Hunt, so he can generate his own XP.
And he does it. That scuttle crab goes
in and he's going to get that
information out of Prismat.
>> Prismat only has three cards, but those
are some strong cards. We see that
starcross, we see that flash, we see
that grim apothecary as well. So now Mu
has all that information. Of course,
Starcross can return both one of
Frismat's friendly units to their own
hands and one of Mu's to his hand. Of
course, as mentioned before, Ruin Runner
cannot be targeted, but that Stalwood
Pearl can, and so can that scrap. Yeah,
and like we were saying, those small
units can get real big when it's Yi that
passive. The two might on the defense as
Thor Porro. I thought we were seeing Mu
go into this battlefield, the seat of
power here on that south side. And he's
committed.
>> He is committed. He's going in with both
Starlord Pro. He doesn't of course get
that shield benefit cuz he's not a
defender. So sitting at two might only,
but that ruin runner is a bit more
mighty. Prismat does have that grimacar.
You saw it goes in with that ambush to
back up his uh back up his seat of
power.
>> Yeah. And also has that when you play
me, you may return a friendly unit out
of battlefield to its owner's hand. But
that is may that is an optional. He did
not elect to do that. He just dumped
that extra might onto that battlefield
to force Mu to trade and lose out here.
>> M I think was expecting that. I think
that might be why he was hesitating as
well and is going to be playing his ruin
runner to think forward to the next
turn. But with this Prismat, if he's
holding and he is, he's going to go to
seven points.
>> That's it. Prismat though he knows the
hands. Mu knows what is in Prismat's
hand here and uh we draw one off the
top. Prismat on that seven points
holding both battlefields absolutely in
the commanding position right now. Rise.
>> Yeah. Only needs to hold one battlefield
and he will take the game in his next
turn. So, he's very much on the on the
cusp of victory. He is of course
considering what do we play here cuz he
has lots of runes up and as Annie does
of course operate with that legend. He
can get those two runes back up after
the end of the turn.
>> Yeah, ready two runes in your end step.
I think he just moved the traveling
merchant to discard that cleave and I
think he actually just picked up another
cleave. That inferno does go in. If it
resolves, if he's allowed to conquer
there, he will be able to draw that one.
>> Exactly. And it looks like he can draw
and discard once as you were saying. And
out comes the Annie, the champion chosen
stubborn is in play and going to be
playing on seed of power. And when you
play Annie, you can return a spell from
your trash to your hand.
>> Yeah, he actually fetched out that
cleave that he discarded just moments
before. So now we know Prismat has two
cleaves in hand. That is that assault
three allstar from Origins that was so
popular in those Kaiser decks. Action
give a unit assault three this turn and
it only costs one energy.
>> One energy. So if Prismat does get
forced off those battlefields, he can
easily come in with that extra three
might as assault and only costing one.
But of course it's Mu's turn. Let's see
what he does.
>> Well, that's the thing, right? There's
eight runes up here for Prismat. He We
know he's built a lot of ambush into his
deck. However, we don't have full
information, full insight into his hand.
He could have that that red Rengar that
was so famous in the back end of Spirit
Forge that he used to take down his
opposition so effectively and then apply
that cleave.
>> We'll have to wait and see.
>> Of course, Mu is also trying to figure
out what he needs to play as well. It's
going to be quite difficult here with
only two units in his base, two ready
units. He has a lot of spells. We can
see discipline we can see not so fast,
but it's going to be hard considering
how strong Prismat's base con
battlefields currently are.
>> Yeah, I mean Mu only at one victory
point. Prismat victory points. This is
Prismat's game to lose right now. He is
in the driver's seat. He has all of the
points. He has that board presence. He
has those runes up. Mu is considering
all of his options.
He's going in with both the scuttle crab
potentially. Sorry. Going in with both
the scuttle crab and the runer.
Just one. Just both of them. He's still
thinking about it. I'm not sure either
what the best play is. You could, as you
said earlier, put the scuttle crab in.
Have a look at Prismat's hand. Um Oh,
he's going for it.
>> He is going in with just the Ruin Runner
onto Starring.
>> Yeah, holds the focus. Cast that
discipline plus two might onto Ruin
Runner. Gets that card draw here as
well. Digging for some answers, some
extra options. into the face of Prismat
>> does get the draw as well. Oh, Prismat
is not going to be I mean he doesn't
have defire but defying any. What was I?
I didn't see it.
>> It was a Rengar trophy hunter.
>> That's going to be big. He has Mi has a
lot of rings up. He could bring that out
with that ambush as well. Rengar trophy
hunter has ambush as well and can be
played through a battlefield with our
enemy units. He's pretty strong. And out
it comes. immediately slams that down
onto that star spring in the top side,
forcing Prismat to answer with Star
Cross. And we know Starcross, what it
does, of course, it returns both a
friendly unit of prismats into hand and
one of Mus. It obviously cannot target
that ruin runner cuz it cannot be
targeted by abilities or spells, but
that Rengar may have to go back to hand
again. We do know though Mu has options,
has the runes up, has the defy, has that
not so fast here as well. This could be
the make orb break moment for Mu to be
able to push Prismat off here, force him
to commit a lot of resources and slow
that tempo down of this fast and
aggressive Prismat any build. However,
still holding that seat of power here
too. Yeah, MJI needs to get both of
these battlefields considering if
Prismat holds the next round, he will
hit that eight points and take this game
one.
>> It's a good position to be in if you're
Prismat under the pump if you're MU. But
this is such a strong play
that Ruin Runner currently presenting
seven might.
>> There comes the defy, but we're talking
about it. Is this the spell that MJI
wants to defy? And it is. He keeps his
Rengar on the battlefield on that star
spring.
>> Stopping the star cross in my opinion is
the right play here. Absolutely. Rengar
with the six might. Ruin Runner with the
seven for a total combined 13 might from
the side of Mu into that Noxus Opal on
four that Kaisa on four. So the might
total on Mus absolutely clears Prismat's
battlefield here.
Prismat wondering what he can do. He
still has that flash available to him,
>> but Mu knows it.
>> Yeah. Uh one flash, two cleaves. The
cleaves obviously aren't useful here cuz
he is the defender. He is not the
attack. It won't give that plus two
three assault, but that flash is the
only card he could really play.
>> It is his option to save his units on
that battlefield if that's what he
wants. And there he goes. He's happy to
concede that one. Let those two units
trade out and die. Give that point over
to Minju and keep that flash in reserve.
>> I mean, maybe Prisman is thinking he has
those cleaves. If I need to go in, I can
just pump up my units and go back in for
the conquers and use maybe the flash to
save seat of power, but out comes that
first mate and he's able now to bring
back that unit. Yeah, using that
Starring battlefield to be able to
return that Rengar and then Rengar goes
in onto that seat of power as well. So,
a really strong impactful turn here from
Mu gets that conquer for the Starring
able to return that Rengar trophy hunter
and uh Prismat though Annie is
definitely more of a conquer style of
deck rather than a hold and Prismat
knows that better than any of us as he
infernes cleaves back onto the Starring
here. Back onto Starring. Prisman going
for that conquer. Get that card draw
because he's sitting on seven. Needs to
of course I mean to win here he needs to
conquer both battlefields to get to that
eight. So he's looking at his card draw.
He did play that stack deck. So looking
at the top three and be able to choose
one of those cards to keep in their
hand. There of course is that Rangar
there and a hidden card. I think I
remember seeing a Zas earlier in Mu's
hand. So that's my bet. It might be a Z.
I do think that Minju has those two ZA
hourglasses in that deck. So there is
every possibility, every chance that
he's hit at least one of those which
could give him some nice protection as
we are there. It is the Za's hourglass
as you predicted that information going
over there.
We do see that the Annie, the traveling
merchant and the Rengar are on that seat
of power.
>> I think that's game though.
>> I think that's Prismat taking the game.
>> It is. is I mean Prismat able to claim
that final battlefield giving himself
that eight points. Game one does go to
Prismat and that means we're going over
to a game two.
>> Yeah, game two should be very exciting.
I that game one was so fast from
Prismat. He got to that 5-1 threshold
immediately and then was at 7 and one
and I believe Minju conquered that
Starring so was on at least that two
conquered that seat of power so three.
So I think it was an 83 finish there in
that game one here but I don't think Mju
got to showcase the best of what this
mid-range has to offer here. I think he
needs to be able to build a little bit
more board presence as we do get a sneak
peek at some of those notes. These notes
you are allowed to bring with you to the
table. They are your sideboard
information. These notes must be
pre-prepared and that is the only
information you're allowed to bring on
those written notes as well.
>> Feels like an exam.
>> Yeah, it does. Right. But it's an open
book exam with what you've pre-prepared
for those sideboards. He'll doubtlessly
be checking those references going,
"What can I sideboard to win better, to
win harder here for this game two of
this best of three match between Prismat
and Mu?"
>> I also want to maybe think maybe put
myself in Prismat's shoes a bit as well.
He'd also have to be considering what Mu
is also going to be sideboarding as
well. It's a bit of a metag game
situation because of course Mu also has
access to his sideboard and maybe Minju
he was going to be choosing to go first.
I mean, Masi loves being a defender,
loves being on those battlefields, and
going first, especially if that two drop
uh unit will be able to get yourself as
quickly as you can onto that board.
>> One thing that I really do like here
though, Rice, is the potential for both
of these players to run an arena's
greatest here in game two. If they both
opt for that, that could be one of the
fastest games of Ripbound we've had the
pleasure of seeing. However, Minju,
sorry, Prismat does still have that
other battlefield here as well. We do
take a look and it has the Zorn Warren
for that. When you conquer here, discard
one, draw one. So, it'll be interesting
to see which way they decide to go after
they do their sideboarding check against
their opponent and what battlefield they
opt for here.
>> I mean, battlefields are uh really
important. They have a few battlefields.
Of course, they have two choices now and
now that they've used their Star Spring
and uh Arena's No, the Arena's greatest
is one of the options that could go.
They use Starring um earlier. So,
potentially looking for of course the
best battlefields here for game two.
>> Yeah. So, definitely the battlefield
selection here will be very important.
If they do run into a double arena's
greatest, which could be possible,
that's going to heavily favor that Annie
deck there. It's such a fast-paced, high
aggro deck, but it will be interesting
to see, like we've said, what sideboard
tech they're going to produce. They're
obviously considering their options
here.
>> Master Yi, I think he needs to play play
build something a little bit faster to
be able to respond what Prisma wants to
present.
>> That's kind of what I was thinking as
well. Or maybe he wants to make sure he
has enough uh two drop units in hand to
ensure he has that turn one play to try
and get on that board as fast as he can
because Annie plays also very aggro.
Wants to be on board quickly too but
wants to get on board quicker for that
defending bonus.
>> Yes, definitely Master Yi wants to get
on those boards defend with those two
might from that passive legend ability
here. But I really do like that
championed adaptation here, that master
y tempered as well, getting that level
six because he has that hold too. He's
also able to build his own XP. That's
that new card from unleashed, right?
Hunt two when I conquer and hold gain
two XP. Level six, I have deflect and
ganking. So he becomes a four might
deflect ganking unit here. So very
versatile, very mobile champion unit to
be able to play alongside. And when it
defends alone, it also goes up to six
might.
>> Uh yeah, exactly. This pretty cheap card
only costing four uh energy is
essentially a six might unit. And when
at level six has so many extra
abilities, it it feels like a little bit
of a a powerful um unit to to play and
it it can if it's in your um champion
unit, you can play it at really any
time.
>> Yeah, if you think about it too, Vex
apathetic obviously being four energy,
four might deflect with the stun
mechanic there. And we look at this four
energy, four might hunt two, level six
deflect and ganking. So off the rip,
it's not as powerful, but as it levels
up overwhelms, you know, unit to unit.
However, Vex has more of an impact on
the game state, whereas Nasier is
definitely much more of an individual
powerful unit.
>> So, we will see, I believe, these two
contest because Vex Apathetic is in
Prismat's deck here, too.
>> Yep.
>> And uh they're just having a good time.
They're all laugh. They're all smiles.
I definitely think it's like I I wish I
had this unit. It could have helped me a
bit more.
>> Hitting triple ruin runners there.
Probably not what you wanted to see that
early in the game there as well because
that takes up other card slots if that
makes sense, right? You'd probably
rather have like another Defy or another
not so fast to be able to answer the
spell slinging that Prismat wants to do.
However, we saw how heavily Prismat has
overloaded into that ambush mechanic and
you cannot counter a unit. No, you
cannot counter a unit. I mean, the not
so fast is not bad at countering maybe
elder dragon's ability when they're
played, but not something like ambush is
not the same.
>> Yeah, definitely not so fast countering
those sort of spells and abilities. Uh,
it is a good answer into the elder
dragon, not a good answer into units
because here in Ripbound, you can't
actually counter a unit, right? Those
units, they will enter, they will get to
do their play mechanic
>> unless you've got stark frost. So I
guess they play and then you can
immediately turn return it back to to
hands. But that of course is not
Master's hand. That is Annie. Annie
running to Starross in their main deck.
I don't know if he's got any in his
sideboard, but that is still something
that of course this Masi has to
consider.
>> Yeah, look, I know you said that the
Star Cross and the Vex Apathetic are
sort of meta changes. And I know I put
Elder Dragon and Vex Apathetic, but I
absolutely agree with that Starcross.
It's a favorite of mine. It's in my
personal Diana deck as well. I know,
right? Shadow.
>> Like I said, master, you was my first my
first legend. So, I'm just looking like
I don't like that star cross. I don't
like that Vex. But here we are. Game
two.
>> We're having a look at what they're
looking at for the cards. I don't think
they're playing just yet, but
>> we do get some insights here as well, R.
So, we get to see some of the
battlefields that have been chosen here.
We see that Zorn Warren and the arena's
greatest. So, we're not going to get
that double arena's greatest match up
here. It was like a 50/50 chance. I know
someone in chat, smarter maths than me,
will be able to correct that one. But,
uh, we're going to have a moderately
decent pace game with the arena's
greatest. The beginning of each player's
first turn, you get one victory point.
And that Zorn Warren, you're able to
move, discard one, draw one. So, that's
really going to help out Grismat's game
plan of cycling through and getting the
cards he needs to answer what Minju
wants to provide against him. Yeah, lots
of options there of course over with
that discard draw one and of course he's
also running other cards that do the
same like the traveling merchant. So
Prismat is going to be able to curate
his hand pretty well. Looking at his
hand at the moment is still only for the
mulligan but that might be in the
process of mulliganing right now. Has
that long sword and two of them.
>> Yeah, that long sword is a fantastic
piece of equipment that actually came
out in spirit forge. has that quick
react. So, it's a reaction speed
equipped there. But we do spy as
sabotage, which is fantastic tech to be
able to rip apart the hand of your
opponent. Obviously, hitting those
nonunit cards. Yes.
>> So, able to get gear, able to get
spells,
>> able to get that long sword.
>> Absolutely. Can get that long sword,
too. Able to remove those star costs,
which are becoming so so important here
in this new unleash meta.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I mean Star Quest if if uh
Mu decides to play that ambush that a
Renga ambush, he can just get completely
stared back into their hand and well,
Ren's not a cheap unit to play it. It
costs so much. So that's kind of
nullifying potentially, especially if
it's in the early rounds that entire
turn,
>> right? You are five energy, one power
for that Rengar trophy hunter, that
powerful unit, that expensive unit. So
yes, it's return to hand, but it's
extremely unlikely you'll be able to
play it again immediately. We also see
that those punch firsts are in this
Master Yi deck here, which could
definitely do enough damage to go over
the top of any offering that Prisma has
on the battlefields. But I'm looking for
that white flame protector. I want to
see that Origins Allstar again just
because I have that nostalgia with it.
That eight energy two power gives
another unit eight might this turn. But
Ricey, we're on the play.
>> We are. And Mji does have that two drop
unit in base. Good hand from him so far.
And out comes the traveling merchant
from Prisma. They both have that turn
one play. And now of course it's once
again Meni's turn. That's Star War is
ready could go in for that conquer.
>> It is so so important to get these turn
one plays here in the top end of these
regional qualifiers. You don't want to
be caught lacking. You don't want to
start to fall behind. So these turn one
plays so so important. Now, each of them
have had their first turn. So, that
arena's greatest will be triggering.
They will both have that one victory
point a piece, which I think is what's
actually being represented here by these
dice at the moment. And we do see that
individual XP tracker, which matters to
this master Y tempered down there when
he hits that level six, Ricey.
>> Yeah, level six. He becomes a little bit
of a monster. Out goes a Saw. On to the
arena's greatest going to be answering
with Is that a Reno already?
That's a That's the red Rengar. So
that's not Rengar trophy hunter. That is
the spirit forged Rengar. The one that
actually ended up winning the Atlanta
regional qualifiers for Prismat. We do
take a quick look here. It is Rengar
pouncing. So it was actually ambushed
before it was made ambush. Reaction I
can be played to a battlefield. You're
attacking and assault. So it comes down
as a five might unit on the attack but
right now just in base.
>> Yeah. I mean cuz if he goes in with that
ambush he won't actually have that plus
too cuz he will be there before with the
reaction speed and so he is going in
base going in for that assault for the
next turn. Um and also it's still
actually Mu's turn and out comes Amasi.
He was considering for a little bit but
will be playing that to base. Now it's
Prisma turn. All the runes are up. Four,
five runes because of four runes because
of the Rengar being recycled earlier.
And now what is he going to play? He has
this assault Renga.
>> Yeah, the assault to Rengar I can be
played to a battlefield you're
attacking. So whenever that ambush
occurs, it can be played to that
battlefield when you are attacking. That
assault will be in play for a total of
five might. However, it's currently in
that base and Prismat considering his
options currently has those four runes
open. could push Orengar in for five
might, but you have to remember that
SWAT Porro is four might on the defense.
That said, Mu will have no answers
available right now. No runes are ready.
>> No runes are ready. Four runes in the
hands of Prismat and these really strong
units. There goes the Traveling Mage.
Discard. Draw one. Thinking about which
one he wants to discard. Of course, it's
actually going to be a Kaiser. And he is
going to draw another Kaiser.
Love to see it.
>> Oh, that allstar unit. But the thing is
he can also play Annies again and he
does it again because of the Zorn Warren
trick here too when he conquers.
>> Well, now he's down two Kaisers in his
deck. He likely has another one in there
somewhere, but it's going to be the long
sword going to be equipped onto that
ranga. Remember, plus two on assault and
that long sword gives that ranga quite a
big strong might. And that stole a lot
of power even with that plus one on
shield and that plus two on defending
with a Y a five might unit is going to
get taken out.
>> Yeah, absolutely overwhelmed there.
Seven might presented from that Rengar
as you so correctly called the shield
plus the two from Y being that five
might presenting on that storewall
porro. It just wasn't enough for Rengar
on its own.
>> Sabotage gets played and so Prismat's
hand is going to be shown. Doesn't have
many units in hand. Uh doesn't have many
cards in hand. And in fact, I think
they're both units. So sabotage can't
actually force a discard.
>> Yep, that is a you call that like a a
moderate sabotage, right? You get that
information from your opponents, but you
don't actually get to rip any spells out
of hand here because as there was no
nonunit cards in Prismat's hands, no
gear, no spells, so minimal value.
>> I see a charm in the hand of Mu if he
wants to use that. I also see that
Rengar. There's a lot of options here
for Minju to try and take these
battlefields back. He has of course Masi
in his base ready to go in.
>> Yeah, Master ready on base is always a
good thing. We're just taking a look at
that inferno, making sure we understand
the rules around that one. That is a new
card here with unleashed has that sort
of ambush. We'll just take a quick look
as the players consider their options.
Inferna, ambush, assault two. So it's a
two energy with one might that can be
played at reaction speed and become a
three might on the attack here. So it
can be quite the surprising little jab
in the side. That little extra boost of
might to take you over the top here. The
Mu considering his options does have a
full hand of runes up and a few cards. I
say full hand of runes. Do I say like a
full hoorde of runes cuz they're they're
ready.
>> Yeah, they are ready. One, two, three,
four, five.
>> Quick counting. and master. We'll be
talking about this master. It is ready
and bait. It can go either of these
battlefields. But of course, you got to
remember Prismat has two runes up right
now. So, he's actually more wanting to
go for the squishier uh unit, that
traveling merchant. In he goes four
might to two might. Prismat is happy to
just lose that battlefield, lose
control, and give it over to Mingu.
>> We do see the judge update here with the
dice on the top of screen. So both
players three victory points a piece and
Mu I think that was the right call. It
was the right timing. It was the right
call. He knew Prismat only had units in
hand. We did see that Ferris 4Runner as
well. So minimal options to respond now
with that conquer from that Yi and that
hunt two has gone up to two experience
which we do see on that XP tracker as
that scuttle crab gets the base.
>> Scuttle crab comes out. But of course
when you play scuttle crab you get that
card draw in hand. And of course we all
love scuttle crab. Well I love scuttle
crab. Maybe not everybody loves scuttle
crab but I love scottle crab.
>> Scuttle crabs in my earlier. I slammed
three into a.
>> Okay. So we're on the same side here.
And so when scuttle crab does die
unfortunately with only zeromite but
with the plus two of master he's
defending he could be a bit defense.
That's the one.
>> Yep. He will when he dies he will be
able to reveal the opponent's hand once
more. But we already know what's in
Prismat's hand. But now there is
something different.
>> What does a chunky scuttle crab look
like?
>> Like is it bigger and bigger and bigger?
>> Yeah. Like takes up some more space.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Does it give more vision though?
>> Yeah, in my mind he does. I'll give him
everything. I'll give him everything.
>> I would die for Scott.
>> I mean, not literally.
>> Literally.
>> I will give you vision. But we do see
that scuttle crab as you called. And
then the turn is given over to Prismat
who's considering his options here.
Prismat holds to four victory points.
Has reached that halfway point. Could
potentially win in two turns.
>> However, I just don't think the options
are available to him right now. Taking a
little peek at the hand.
>> Ooh, something expensive. It's Annie
herself does get played and going to be
played to the battlefield. The northern
battlefield of course. Arena's greatest
to back up that Renga. I mean, I don't
think Prisman is scared of the Scott,
but he's still scared of Mu. Yeah,
because unfortunately getting no value
out of that Annie either for four
energy, one power. When you play me,
return a spell from your trash. He had
no spells to return from his trash here.
So that is I have to play a body because
I've just got no spells to grab. You
hate to see that sort of relatively
inefficient use of these abilities on
these champion cards.
>> It does hurt a little bit. And now it's
back to Mu's turn. He does get that
point for holding and also the two
experience as well. only two more
experience away from Master Year
becoming level six becoming deflected
and ganking which does give of course Mu
a couple more options to approach the
arena's greatest from multiple angles.
>> Yeah, once that deflect comes online
it's going to make sure that star cross
that Prismat will likely hit becomes a
three energy two power. a little bit
more punishing becomes less of an
option, but the Annie Legend is still
comfortable with that. Able to ready
those two runes at the end of goes in.
>> Goes in. I mean, it's a Zeromite unit.
Of course, he's just going to go for the
combat damage and reveal the hand. We
still see that Ferris Forerunner and uh
>> open the cards up, Prismat. We need to
see.
>> Is that two more infernas? They're two
enemies.
>> Does look like the Infernaction?
Yep, that's two more infernas. He's only
got units in hand right now, Ricey. He's
got no tricks up his sleeve in terms of
spells.
>> That doesn't feel great for an Annie. Uh
with of course Chaos having so many
possible spells to use. Like we
mentioned the star so many times, he's
just only drawn
uh units. I'm looking at the board, he
has not played any spells. Literally
every single one he has drawn for this
game has been units.
>> Yeah, right now this game state is
definitely Master Yi favored. That
mid-range aggro is happy that the Annie
is not able to sort of build this
insurmountable lead in this early game.
Prismat though doing well. They are four
victory points a piece. But I almost
have to think that we're reaching that
pivotal moment where Annie starts to
fall off and this Master Yi starts to
build up and become too strong.
>> Is that a hidden card? I don't know. I
don't remember seeing a but no, it's a
charm. He is going to be charming one of
those units over to Master Yi who will
have the defender plus two bonus and it
is going to be the Annie. Uh he knows
that Prisma has no spells. He has no
answers to this. I mean maybe he could
do something though.
>> I mean Prismac considering his options
but I really do think this one's a
foregone conclusion here. Annie not even
strong enough to fight that master Y
even without the Y. There's the inferna
play.
>> That was what I was thinking. Is he
going to be playing that inferna onto
that ba that battlefield with that
ambush ability and uh also has that plus
two as an assault as an attacker because
he was in that attacking position. But
out comes Rengar as of course his own
ambush.
>> Yeah, Rengar trophy hunter presents on
the battlefield. Clears out the other
Rengar. That must feel like how would
that go? Like hi Rengar. Hi Rengar.
Goodbye Rengar. There's just too much
Rengar on these battlefields right now,
Ricey. But great turn of play there
coming out of Mu goes up to five victory
points to Prismat's four. Prismat on the
play here considering the options open
to him. Equips that long sword.
>> Of course, the other Inferna that was I
believe in base is now in play. And out
comes another Ranga. Um, and so this is
quite a strong attack coming out from
Prismat, of course, with the assault
options, you know, plus two from Renga
pouncing and of course with the Inferno
as well, who also has assault plus two.
This Renga, the other Renga on Arena's
greatest is looking a little weaker.
>> Yeah, defending though gets that plus
two might. So is currently eight might
here for Mu's Rengar trophy hunter. I
don't know how many more times I can say
Rengar here, but that Rengar pouncing
obviously contributing a total of five
might. that long sword with plus two for
seven and that inferna being at least
the one plus its assault that is a
minimum of eight might. So they will be
trading here that Rengar trophy hunter
will go down unless there is something
that Mu is able to do. They're mathing
it out.
>> Yeah, that that Rengar trophy hunter
will be taken out. I think quick math
it's was 10 to eight. You're shaking
your head. You agree with me? And so
with that Inferna is of course the one
that is going to be left behind. It
makes sense. as she doesn't have a salt
when she is defending.
>> That's the one. Inferno is right there
ready to be taken out. However, Mu Oh,
another Rengar trophy Ricey. Another
one. I mean, why not? Why wouldn't you?
You have the runes up. You have the
ability to And you had one in hand. And
of course, that Inferno who is now
defending has nothing to can have
nothing to really defend against. We
knew Prismat didn't have any spells.
This is not a spell. It's a Feroh.
Ferris a 4erunner. We've seen this one
before um in his hand and he's going to
pay it immediately.
>> Yeah. Ferris 4runner and Allstar from
Spirit Forge. It's that mech that all
troublesome mech. Six uh six energy, one
power for six might and death nail play
two three might mech unit tokens to your
base. So it's effectively 12 might
across the cost of that six energy, one
power. an extremely high value unit here
that uh Prismat has played to his base
right now.
>> Yeah, when that unit goes in if if he he
is quite mighty know in in and of
himself six might and of course trophy
hunter with the plus two from Mazi is a
little bit stronger. So he won't be able
to get that death now just from this
situation alone. But we don't know what
Prisma's final card in hand is.
>> Yeah, absolutely. That long sword though
with that plus two might he could
definitely trade into that Rengar trophy
hunter clearing him off that
battlefield. But he has to do something.
Prismat currently at five victory
points. Mu currently at seven. So Mu,
he's happy with the state of the game
right now because Prismat is just not
finding these spells. He needs to be
able to play more effectively into Mu's
mid-range E here. I don't know how
Prismat is feeling, but I watching this
and having no spells in hand, it just
feels like your hands are really tied.
So, judging though by the chances of how
many units have already been played and
already been in the trash, I am betting
that one card that we don't know is a
spell.
>> Yeah, he has to start hitting these
spells soon. Absolutely. You can see his
trash there. That is all units. The more
units you see in trash, that means the
more spells there are to be pulled from
that deck. as the players they are
considering their options here.
>> Yeah, I mean
>> taking a look at his hand. A lot of
defies.
>> He's on seven points right now according
to the green dice at the top which means
if he conquers Zorn Warren
Am I massing this right?
>> Well, for now we need to make sure we
know whose turn it is.
>> True.
>> We did see Prismat play that Ferris
4Runner, right? We do see that Mu
currently looking at his cards
considering his options. Yeah, that
rango was played though on Prismat's f
um turn. So I think with all the runes
up, he's considering what do I do here?
How do I get that other battlefield?
>> Yeah, look like them. I'm thinking about
it. Prismat taking a look at that one
card in hand.
>> It could be anything. We don't even know
what that is.
>> Yeah, he's not giving us any
information, Prismat.
>> Yeah,
>> of course not giving any information to
Minja either.
>> I know. I mean, let's talk about it.
We've seen a couple of Kaisers
discarded,
>> so there's less chance of that.
>> We've seen a lot of inferners. They're
gone. All gone.
>> All gone. Could be a Vex apathetic.
>> Could be. We've only seen I think one
forunner, so there could be two more if
he didn't sideboard it.
>> That's it. That's it. But this is
something that Prismat was doing as well
in Atlanta, right? He's okay to slow
down and take his time and consider his
options in front of him.
>> Yeah,
>> he likes to think these things through.
See the lines before him. See his
options. See his outs. Can he discard
and draw? M
>> can he send a ferris for a runner in?
Obviously not this turn. It is exhausted
but he has to do something now because
Mu on those seven victory points very
very close to taking this game.
>> Very close indeed. I mean Prisma did win
that first game. This is a best of
three. If Mu does win this it's going to
be even one and so we could get a game
three right now. But of course, Presman
wants to win here. And now he's trying
to think about how he's going to be able
to do this. And Mu wants to stay in this
series.
>> Absolutely. Mu needs to win to take it
to that game three to give himself a
chance. Prismat already having that game
one. If he wins here, it's a two-0 clean
sweep.
>> I love this dual cam.
>> See both their um points of views, how
they how they're thinking, how in the
zone they are. I want to say how
stressed they are, but they don't quite
look stressed or anything like that.
They're just in the zone.
>> These these definitely aren't stressed
faces. These are I'm a professional TCG
player faces and I am thinking about
every single possible option here.
You've got to think about it like chess.
You've got to think 20, 30 moves ahead.
Not that I think these games have that
many moves,
>> but you get the point. You've got to
have a lot of foresight, a lot of
forethought. If I do this, what then?
It's almost like a program, right? If
this, then that.
>> Yep. Yep.
>> And so that's the options in front of
us. as we do take a moment to appreciate
the board game, right? Obviously, this
mastery has been able to play a bit and
is the ruin runner goes in,
>> brings back that Renga as well. And so,
Renga is going to be ready to go in as
well. But that ruin runner is on the
arena's greatest. And remember, we
assume that there is a spell in
Prisman's hand because judging by how
many units he's played, there is likely
a hand a spell in there. And Ruana can't
be targeted.
>> Yeah. So, while we were deliberating,
that was Minju's turn. So, he was
actually considering all of his options.
As we've said, he's played that Ruin
Runner onto the arena's greatest and has
withdrawn that Rengar trophy hunter. So,
now the play is over to Prismat. So, Mu
seven victory points. Ruin Runner
holding Rengar trophy hunter able to
conquer if needs be. Prismat on the
five. One of them he drew was a Kaiser.
It was another unit. Of course, Kaiser
does manage to conquer and we'll get
that card draw as well. And we see a
stacked deck. Is that what he's
>> trigger first? Of course. Of course. I
discard and is another unit. But out
comes
>> the equip going in first forunner with
that long sword has plus two. But don't
forget punch first exists is going to
buff up that rune runner by quite a lot.
He is digging with that stacked deck and
I believe yes he said that is game.
>> It is one.
>> Yep. They wrap it up one a piece here. A
great sort of marathon if you will from
Minju taking this game with eight
victory points over Prismat. Currently
one game a piece in this round 10 best
of three matchup here at the ripound
regional qualifiers Sydney 2026. Ricey,
it's getting tense. It's real exciting.
>> These are two of the best players we
have in this building right now. 8 and
one each. The Mari versus the Annie. And
now they are 1 here in the series.
Whoever wins this of course will be 9
and one. Whoever loses will be 8 and2.
So I'm very excited to see what happens
now in this final game. Of course
Battlefields they've only got one choice
left.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Those battlefields are
Vile Moors Lair and the arena's
greatest. So we are ready for another
quick one because they're each going to
get a victory point at the top of their
first turn. And that Vile Moors Lair
units cannot move off of this
battlefield. So you do love to see it.
There's going to be that control here as
we do see the players starting to
shuffle up. Valmore's lair reads units
can't move from here to base
>> and Annie loves her flashes which is
move up to two friendly units to base
but with Volmore it you can't do that.
>> It will be very very prohibitive. Uh,
Val Moors is always a good choice
against more mobile decks and we do know
that those will be both of those
battlefields as both players considering
their options, consulting their
sideboard tech guides.
>> You just have to think Prismat didn't
hit any spells until the end there. He
hit that stack deck. He got
>> even when he looked at the stack deck,
he couldn't find what he needed. I It
was just felt like Prismat had very
little options. Yeah, he just had no
answers into what Mu's master Y wanted
to do. I mean, if he was able to find,
for example, that abandon right then,
right there, he could have forced Mu to
have to recast that, sacrificing another
two runes, like recycling those for that
power cost. So, that could have
definitely been the game winner, but
unfortunately, he went digging. He was
unable to find it. And again, MU takes
game two. So, we are on even footing.
It's match point here between both of
these 8 and1 players and our previous
regional qualifying winner from Atlanta
here, Prismat.
>> It is very exciting. I did expect Annie
did expect Prismat to be here in the
upper I want to say upper bracket the
upper levels of this regional qualifier
but this that game was so tense as you
as we would keep saying he had no
options to play and this game three of
course with Prismat losing he has to
choose whether or not he wants to go
first or second he gets to choose of
course relook at that sideboard consider
what options he has and how he wants to
verse this Mi
>> yeah Look, Master Mid-range is such a
powerful and popular choice here. Has
fantastic representation at the regional
qualifiers and uh it's being piloted so
effectively by so many people too, which
you love to see, right? Because we all
have our favorite legends.
>> We do.
>> Master E, fantastic jungler.
>> He is
>> unleashed all about junglers.
>> It is
>> representing even if it is the old
Master E legend.
We ignoring the uh the names of the
moment. We are getting our overlays back
shortly, but right now we are of course
with that arena's greatest with that
VMO's lair and out comes that first
turn. We see a Kaiser in hand, but it is
going to be that inferno that is played
of course using a two after Annie
finishes the turn, gets a two back.
>> Yeah, readies those two runes so has the
options but unfortunately both the fury
so that locks out any chaos options.
Stor played there for Mu on his turn
one. It's great to have options.
>> In goes that Inferno. Going to be able
to conquer that arena's greatest and
still has four runes up. What does he
want to play? Yeah, he has options. I I
did see that Kaiser trying to see what
else is in his hands. Quite a few of
them. Look like there were four might or
less. A four full cost or less.
>> I do see that there is one of those
Rengar pouncings in hand. That three
energy one power is the tell here.
However, Prisma with that conquer does
go to two victory points. Plays an
inferno. plays enough to hopeful.
>> Good play.
>> Amazing play coming through. Being able
to bring out quite a quite a heavy uh
mighty unit coming out. Of course, hope
nexus hope noises hopeful is only two
when playing second the second card on
that turn. So that's two a four might
unit for just two. Out comes the Sovo
going to be able to conquer Valor's
Lair. And that little too cost unit is
now presenting as a defender in a
defending position as F might.
>> Yeah, the the little porro that could
here I see love to see it. It's a staple
in these Y decks and as you said that
Noxus Opal two energy for four might is
so much value because of that Legion
mechanic.
>> You get the effect if you played another
card this turn which Prisma had done
with that inferna. Sabo committed
>> sabotage early once more. gets to see
the entire hand. Maybe this time Prisma
will have something that's not a unit.
>> There's only one. It is going to be the
long sword gets recycled. We know though
of course there's a Ferros, a
fourrunnana, and a Kaiser in his hand.
Two units to consider for potentially
the next turns.
>> Yeah, that Ferris and that Kaiser are
both very strong units though. So that's
good information to have for Mu having
that intel on what Prismat will be able
to play. Critically though, he has no
ambush units. So right now there will be
no surprises coming out of Prismat. Mu
will be able to play comfortably knowing
that Ferris 4runner and Kis are the only
options available to Prismat at the
moment.
>> He I mean considering though we have to
consider maybe there's something else
he'll top deck but yet currently looking
like he could go and try and contest
that hopeful and that inferno in the
next couple of turns as right now he's
considering playing Mari tempered.
>> Yep. Master Y tempered. The brand new
unleashed ye champion unit at level six
with hunt two gets deflect and ganking
is played.
>> It is in fact played and of course it is
exhausted and base. It won't be able to
contest that arena's greatest just yet.
But let's see if Prismat was able to top
deck something really exciting.
outcomes. Six runes and an exhausted is
going to be that first four hunter going
to be played onto the arena's greatest.
Inferno is going to be brought back
though, of course.
>> Yeah, Inferno is definitely fantastic at
conquering. Absolutely terrible at
holding and Prismat knows that he that's
all he's done for this turn and he's
passed it back over to Mu. Currently,
both players at three victory points a
piece. For the viewers at home, you can
see the score at the top of your screen.
That green dice representing Mu, that
purple dice representing Prismat.
>> Building that base up. We see Lonely
Pyro and Star Pro now in the base being
played. But of course, we've got to keep
our eye out on that master temp, but he
is ready. He could go in to uh start a
showdown on that arena's greatest. Of
course, you have to consider the
abilities. So the spells looks like
stack deck was going to be played but is
defied.
>> That's like a high value defy here,
right? Because he knows Prismat doesn't
have any spells or at least very very
few and does not want to let Prismat dig
to try and find any possible answers. So
now it's about Mu controlling Prismat's
game plan. He knows he had the Ferris.
The Ferris has been played. He knows he
has the Kaiser. So there's only one
other option available to Prismat. He
cannot let him get any more spells here
to play the game that he wants.
>> Well, Prisman has exhausted all of his
runes and is considering and will be
playing I believe that sneaky deck hand
and that Kaiser
>> that is an overzealous fan and that is a
Kaiser survivor played to the Reena's
greatest here as well. Really shoring up
this battlefield trying to present so
much might that is just not an option
for Mu. But Mu, that's where he thrives.
That's that mid-range Yi. It has the
punch first. It has the vomals. It can
move in and prevent that might being
attributed back onto the Y. On that sort
of defensive side here,
>> we can see a couple of spells in the
hands of Minja. We see that on guard. We
see that defy, a second defy. So maybe
that's why he wasn't too scared about
using it. Goes in with that lonely
power. Remember when Lonely Po dies
alone, he gets to draw one. Goes in with
that uh
discip was it a discipline as well? Um
and on guard I believe and so that was
able to take out that Kaiser.
>> Yeah, really well done there. Kaiser is
such a high value unit. You definitely
want to remove that one. But I do want
to point out that Vilemore has not yet
been seen. We we cannot see it in that
hand. But if Vmore does become present,
that is an eight energy, two power,
eight might drop with ambush. So you can
use it on the attack here. Enemy units
here with less might than me don't deal
combat damage. So could absolutely shut
down any sort of defense that Prismat
might want to put up when he decides to
go in.
>> Yeah, Valor is definitely a good unit to
close out with. One of the uh strong
units to end with, but as you said, not
in the hand right now. And in the hand
in the base right now is of course that
Masi tempered is that Star War. He does
have Valmo's lair uh conquered and
occupied right now, but he is kind of
behind in Temple Con for points right
now from this hold. So, if he wants to
try and win this game, he has to go for
that arena's conquer. Arena's
>> like greatest arena points.
>> This isn't working. That's my name.
>> We're saying conquer and arena's
greatest so many times.
>> I know. I know.
>> We had arena's greatest last game, but
look look at how shiny these tall pores
are. Not only are they superstar units
in this deck, but they're looking
squeaky clean. They're looking Mickey
Mouse.
>> I love I know I say I love the scutter
crab pearls. Oh, the pearls. I just love
every single one of them. I don't know
anyone who doesn't like pears, but the
masi wants to maybe potentially back up
his lone his puro,
>> but Valmore's there.
>> You can't bring back.
>> No, no, no. So, Valour's lair units
can't move from here to base. Ye when
he's unlocked at level six will have
ganking will be able to move over. This
could almost be a mental game, right?
Because he's gonna start holding. He's
going to start getting XP if the game
goes long enough. And then if you forget
about it, he's going to be able to gank
across to that battlefield. And Prismat
may be caught unawares.
>> Wait, I think Prismat just played
another stack deck. And out comes
another defy from Mi. Oh, he is being so
mean to Prismat. knows in his hand is
mostly usually I think he's only got one
card in hand at the moment and I don't
remember if this is still that unit we
saw earlier or not maybe it's a spell
but not many options
>> yeah we know the kaiser and ferris
4runner has been played so we don't
suddenly the traveling merchant has been
played but this is Mu's game plan he is
controlling Prismat out of this one
defying those stack decks is so so
critical because it just does not let
Prismat dig for those cards with no
answers there's nothing he can do.
>> He has no hand right now. Absolutely no
cards whatsoever. He does have a lot of
units. He has those two inverters. He
has that overzealous fan and he has that
traveling merchant. So, he has something
here to potentially go in with the next
turn. But of course, it is Mu right now.
Out comes another lonely parro costing
only two of course, but is exhausted in
base.
>> Yeah, absolutely. That lonely parro for
the two leaves those six runes up.
Prismat finds himself on six victory
points right here, right now. However,
Minju close behind on that five and will
definitely be comfortable with a unit
kind of tradeoff here being able to
fight might for might presuming he has
some of those tricks. We do know Prisma
unless he's just top deck something to
save himself. Doesn't have those tricks
available. Doesn't have those tricks
present. That said, he knows two defiers
have been used. So whatever he does, if
he hits it, it can't be
>> outing merch. Doesn't need to discard
one cuz he has no cards, but he gets
that draw. Now I don't think he looked
at it just yet as he's now going in to
try and conquer that Valor's lair.
>> Yep. Two inferners there with that extra
assault, that overzealous fan going in.
Discipline.
>> Discipline comes out. Of course, it's
going to be able to buff give more might
to I think he's choosing master. No, we
don't know yet. Maybe Porro, it's going
to be Porro.
>> Interesting. So, Porro will now be two,
three, five cuz it's not defending
alone.
>> Out comes the star cross. He did top
deck something pretty useful. Of course,
it's going to be that star cross. Not
sure who he's going to star cross just
yet. He is going to be star crossing the
pearl, it looks like, because that pearl
with that plus one as a defender is
actually sitting at five might.
That's the one more might than the Yei.
So bounces that has bounced his Kaiser
from the arena's greatest as well. We do
see two spells in Trash.
Mari is now alone. So he's now at six
might, but still less than the back off
is coming out. Going to be backing off I
believe the inferno cuz with that plus
two he's going to be a three might unit
and also gets that card draw played from
hand. You get that extra card draw and
still has ruins up. Could still keep
going. I think MJI might have more
spells in hand.
>> He did draw into a ruin runner.
>> Oh,
>> so the other card needs to be the spell.
We're working at the math cuz the
inferners are each three might on the
attack.
>> And of course, that inferno was stunned.
And as the attackers, you do bounce back
onto the base. And so it looks like
master temp is still holding on to
Valmore lair. And uh well, Prismatic is
not going to be able to
potentially get it just yet. I think
maybe
>> he has played that Annie though. And
with that Annie, he was able to get that
star cross back out.
>> It looks like he's played the star
cross.
>> We're waiting to see if Miju has a
response here.
We're talking to the judge just to see
how that turn of play occurred. But both
of these players know they must win this
one. They don't want to go to that eight
and two. They want to move up to that 9
and1 position here. Scuttle crab also
and it looks like a charm potentially in
the hand of Mu.
>> Charms could be useful here. Don't
forget I don't actually know what
experience that Master Yi Temper is at.
I
>> currently zero
>> zero still.
No, now on four. Okay. Now on four from
the holding two now two. Yep. Prisma
make it from the hold just then goes in
with that lonely power. gets another
card draw. Is able to trade that
traveling merchant out though power is
available to go in but of course they're
both on six right now and we have more
vision.
>> Yeah, we do love the victory points. We
see that hold come through for ye
tempered. The victory points currently
showing for at five currently showing at
six for Prismat. So he's ahead on
victory points but I would argue he's
behind on tempo. M
>> he's definitely
top decking his answers right now
because of those all critical defies
onto both of the stack decks. The
Prismat was able to finally draw.
>> Yeah.
>> So Mu just stifling Prismat out of this
one slowly turn for turn hoping to build
this XP for Master Yi Tempered
and possibly gank over to that arena's
greatest.
>> Six victory points a piece. Thank you
for confirming
>> two XP on that tracker and still poor
sitting in base.
>> Just to confirm as well, Meni does not
have two wins. That is a one that now
has been corrected. Um they're both
currently one win a game in this best of
three. So they are fighting here for
this last game. They're currently six a
piece too. They're both two conquers or
well not conquers cuz one of them's
already conquered each. Two points away
from winning this game. It's very much
feels pretty even and also very tense.
>> Right. You are very very tense as you
called out as the graphics are now
updated too. Both have won one game a
piece in this best of three matchup.
This is the all critical third game.
It's tied up. Six victory points a
piece.
Prismats
in base two on the greatest arena. The
arena's greatest. The greatest arena
could be the arena's greatest. It could
be
>> two units for Mui tempered up on VM's
lair and store porro in his base.
>> Doing some calculations wondering can
prize Matt win on his turn. Do we need
to buff up a a battlefield and bring
Masi back for the conquer? It's there's
so many options here for Mi has to do
that. Matt has to consider what cards
does he have? I mean he knows exactly
that the uh starcross is in the hand of
Prismat um and made top deck something
really really special.
>> Yeah, as you say starcross in the hand
returned with that Annie played a turn
before. However, Mu does have that
Trinity Force 2 the four energy equipped
gear when I hold score one point and
plus two might. That could be quite the
challenge, but I don't think now's the
time to play Scuttle Crab. He doesn't
need to get much information out of
Prisma.
>> I mean,
>> and there it is. He thinks a lot better
than I do.
>> He's going to do that. And he's going to
actually equip the Trinity Force. You
are mentioning it. Um,
>> has something to say though.
>> So, Scuttle played for two.
>> Trinity played for four.
>> He's like, I might react to that. Don't
forget I do have that
>> star cross.
>> Star cross.
>> You are right. So, Trinity Force is a
very, very powerful gear, a very
powerful equipment. As you mentioned,
when I hold, score one point. So, if
that master holds his next turn, he'll
get to eight from that hold.
>> Showed the discard, showed the charm,
forces the starross out.
>> I don't remember seeing it defy.
>> Yeah. So, Mu played that charm
>> and in response, Prismat played the
starross.
>> Yeah.
>> Bouncing that Annie, bouncing that Y.
And with that, Yei is not on Valour's
lair anymore, but Trinity Force is in
base. It can be equipped again. Salo is
going to go on there. And he is going to
choose to equip that Trinity Force. He
is going for that win. He's going for
that hold, that stall wart polo hold.
>> Has there ever been a mightier stalwart
porro as that Valor's layer will be
shored up with that first mate as well?
>> First mate when he gets played, he can
ready another unit. He could ready that
scuttle crab if he wanted to.
>> Turn of play is already back with
Prismat.
>> Okay,
>> Prismat has readied all of his runes.
Has inferna traveling merchant ferris
4runner noxious hopeful to play with.
It'll be difficult to see how he's
getting that Ferris 4Runner and Noxus
hopeful off of that battlefield. I think
he wants to leave them there. Defend on
that one.
He has that Annie in hand.
>> Goes in with that inferno. Remember plus
two assault when they're attacking. So
that's a three might unit.
And now Prisma is on turn zero. Goes in
as well. That that was a nine might
versus a five might. We don't know what
Prismat top decked there.
>> It does look like that's a stack deck as
well as that Annie Duck child as they do
trade the Inferno into the first mate.
>> There's that Starburst
>> and that is game.
>> GG's. There it is. Prismatic
game. Game three in this best of three
matchup. Prismaticism wins 21 here at
the regional qualifier. Sydney Icy,
>> he does take that game. He gets onto
that seven from holding and manages to
conquer Valor's lair as well. That
little stalwart for was not able to hold
the defenses down even with that Trinity
Force. Even with that, he wasn't plus
two because of Master, but all the other
benefits he had with that first mate
there too. It is going to be Pris Mad's
game with of course that powerful star
gloss.
>> Yeah, you do love to see it. Obviously,
people think Annie is a very fast, very
early game deck, but Prisma able to
pilot it so well, so effectively. I dare
say it's almost a mid-range aggro with
those assault, the ambushing units that
he has put into this one with those
combat tricks, with those cleaves and
those long swords, able to trade more
effectively into Yi. This speaks to me
that he's got a really good read on the
meta already. That he understands the
competition that he will be going into
like LeBlanc, like Diana, like the Ye he
has just faced off against and beaten.
Taking himself to 9 and one now, righty.
>> Yeah, Prismat is sitting on 9 and1 and
I'm pretty happy about that just because
of my predictions. I predicted that
Annie is going to be the top legend and
I'm just one step close to that. But we
didn't get to see your Diana in this
match up. So maybe your Diana is also
doing quite well.
>> Yeah, I'm absolutely barracking for that
Diana. But there's, you know, some honor
to be had in getting the correct
prediction, but so far, I mean, we're
all still in the running. LeBlanc on the
up, Ye on the up, and Annie also on that
up. Yet to see the Diana today. However,
that was a phenomenal three games out of
Mu and Prismat here competing to make it
to that top cut of eight at the end of
these five rounds here on day two. 91 is
a good score to go for that top card.
Top eight of course generally you don't
want to drop more than one or two games
and 9 and one still pretty good. Of
course there are so many more rounds to
go in this Swiss stage. Yeah, but fear
not X and 2 does not knock you out of
the running for that top cut of eight
here. So MU still in with a chance and
has to be proud of how he played there
for sure. absolutely cleaned up in that
game two. Obviously, Prismat taking that
first win, Mu getting that second. So,
it was very back and forth. We did get
to see what that mid-range Master Y deck
wants to do here and it's what's so
representative of the Yees here in the
regionals in Sydney.
>> Yeah, so many Y are present as well as
the Blancs, as well as Aurelius um and
there's so many ALS currently in that uh
top of the the leaderboard right now.
But let's hear what Prismat has to say.
We have an interview ready. Let's take
it away.
>> Oh my goodness. What a incredible game.
How are you feeling now that you've
taken a second a beat to to settle in?
That was very tense. How are you at?
>> Yeah, I I starting the day with a loss
round nine. Then it's always like having
to bounce back from that is tough. And
then um the my opponent was playing
pretty slowly. I was having some issues
with that overall. And I I was the one
having to point it out, not the judge of
the table, which was a bit frustrating
as well. Uh I made a small misplay game
two. My opponent did give away some
information where um he sacrificed a
scuttle crab before he made his play and
he said, "Oh, I should have gone for the
risky play first." And I should at that
point have read that his hand was a
Rengar with no pump spells. So then when
he charmed my Annie in, I should not
have played the Inferno on offense to
trade with his E. I should have saved it
to trade with his Rengar on defense. Um
what ended up happening then is because
I'm down on point tempo now, I can't
develop my 4Runner. If id saved the
inferno to defend against the ringer and
trade, I go to five points to his four
because he doesn't get the conquer and
then I get the forerunner out and the
game's un losable from there. Um, so
that was there was that and then I
played a little bit too quickly at the
end when he charmed my Annie in. I
should have starcrossed anything other
than my Annie and then that would have
been a better play.
>> Yeah, look it's anything can happen in
the midst of a game. It's very very easy
to get swept up in things. Were you
expecting to have a little bit more of
that issue against Master? Obviously you
did say you dropped against an Ireelia
earlier today. How was your approach to
these decks?
>> It's actually my first time playing
against Master E this matchup bas pretty
much at all. Uh I think the matchup
should be quite favorable for me
overall. Um I think especially when I go
first, it's probably just un losable. Um
even though that last game did get a bit
close, but that was uh some pretty weak
draws that showed up on my end. I think
if at any point I can just break his
battlefield that he's holding on Vile
Mosaw, I just win instantly. And
unfortunately that just wasn't possible
for most of the game. So he got to
develop and just cycle through his cards
for a while. Um, but even going second,
I think like I have the Rengar plus unit
turn one and it in game two if he
doesn't have a Stalwarp or as a turn one
play, I just walk over him, don't need
to develop the long sword and I can get
4Runner out a turn earlier and again the
game's just un loseable. So I I think it
should be a very good matchup for me
overall.
>> So what were you more concerned about in
terms of opponents that you might be
facing up over the rest of the day?
>> Um,
let's see. Probably want to avoid
Leblanc.
>> Yeah,
>> ideally I don't know how Daniel's doing.
He was undefeated last I checked. I
don't know if he won or lost this round,
>> but that that's an annoying matchup. Um
I don't have as many Gusts in my deck as
I'd like to have for that matchup,
though. I think the cards that I've
chosen have worked out well overall. Um
and ideally, I'd like to avoid Aurora.
I'd hate to lose a run to that deck,
even though I think my matchup against
it is favorable overall.
>> That's fair enough. Speaking of your
deck, you have made a couple of changes
with the release of Unleashed. We did
see that Starcross coming in clutch a
couple of times there. And you also have
the Vex Apathetic, which is really just
a crowd favorite this weekend as well.
What were the thought processes behind
putting those into the deck?
>> Yeah, so
the it's a lot of card upgrades overall.
Uh the the Rex size are gone now,
replaced by Grim Apothecary and the Vex
Apathetics. And then Starcross is just a
huge upgrade over Rebuke. The fact that
I can loop it with Annie, um gives me a
lot of endame situations that become
basically unusable where I can bounce
their one big unit every single turn and
just keep them off the board. happens
against Leblanc happens against Aurora.
Uh, and then Inferno is amazing. Just a
insane two drop even even on defense.
She could have mattered a lot if I had
used her better. Um, but then just being
a three might and then works very well
with flash. Uh, just yeah, a lot of
really good cards for Annie this set.
>> Absolutely. So, now that you've finished
up here, you're going to have a mental
reset and going into the rest of the
weekend. How do you do that? What is
your mental reset for something like
this?
>> M
>> probably just eat something. I'm going
to save the be push-ups, but maybe I do
some push-ups. Might might need it after
that.
>> Was a little bit stressed as we were
hitting time at the end.
>> Yeah. Look, I mean, the push-ups I feel
like are kind of a staple at this point.
You're going to be expected to do maybe
at least one or two over the course of
the rest of the day, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I should I should do some
right now on camera.
>> You want to go?
>> All right, let's go. This
>> work. Where do I go?
>> All right.
right here.
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 Oh my gosh. 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 19 20 Oh my goodness.
Nicely done. Look. Thank you.
>> All I've got to say to that is if that
isn't a mental reset, I don't know what
is.
>> Yeah. Got to put the energy somewhere.
>> Yes. All right. Well, we'll throw back
to our wonderful desk and uh hopefully
they've recovered from a very tense
match as well. And good luck with the
rest of your day.
>> Thank you.
>> How inspiring. I love hearing what
Prisman has to say. But I love how he in
like values that that mental reset and
20 push-ups. I can't even do one. I was
very impressed.
>> Fun fact about those push-ups. the story
that's actually been developing since
Atlanta Regionals where he needed that
reset and he went out and did some
push-ups, came back and won the next
game as well. And he's already in a
winning position, but has the power of
the push-ups. God, who knows what we'll
see, but we'll be right back after this
break for round 11 of the original
qualifier. Sydney,
>> hello rift bonders. Are you wondering
how the game developed with Unleashed?
Let me give you a little introduction.
The calm domain has reinvented its
defensive capabilities. With powerful
pump spells and counter spells, calm
decks were already good at contesting
their battlefields, but with unleashed,
holding the fields becomes a whole lot
stronger. A standout example for this is
back off. Three energy, no power. This
card on action speed stuns a unit and
draws a card if played from hand.
Incredible. But leaving three runes open
isn't always an option. Luckily, you can
also hide this card if your runes are
exhausted or you want to keep them open
for another card. Fury, on the other
hand, brings plenty of new ways to
assert pressure onto your opponent.
Every jungler's dream is coming true
with smite, finding a new way to remove
units. It simply deals three damage to a
unit at a battlefield for two energy and
one power. While those stats are not too
impressive, the unit will also be
banished when it would die. This takes
powerful death nail effects out of the
equation and can also remove follow-up
if your opponent relies on resources
from their trash like Fiora worthy that
can't be played through spectral matron
anymore. Order has been known for its
hard removal and kill spells. Now, what
if I told you that you can remove your
opponent's hand as well? Ash Focus gives
you full information about your
opponent's hand and lets you banish a
card of choice for five energy and one
power. They will get it back as soon as
they hold a battlefield. But with full
information in one card less in the
opponent's hand, it's now on you to not
let that happen. Chaos has been
chaotically bouncing cards left and
right, pushing them front and center.
And now you will also be able to reach
the opponent's units in base. Starcross
reaction speed removal is revolutionary,
especially when it hits the base as
well. For three energy and one power,
you can return a friendly and an
opposing unit back to the owner's hand.
While this can give you an incredible
advantage with play effects, it also
disturbs your opponent. It slows them
down massively and can sometimes deny
powerful effects like Elder Drankren's
passive kill ability. While this domain
has already been good at controlling the
opponent's units, the mind is now
finally greater than the sword. The mind
domain receives a fantastic gear removal
card. Turn to Dust will turn any gear
into a temporary problem for two energy
and no power cost. While it does not
immediately help you remove units that
are boosted by equipment gear, you can
easily take care of seals, dazzling
aurora, or other great gear that stands
in your way. Now, what's scarier than
body units that are standing on your
opponent's side of the field just
waiting to overwhelm you with their
physical prowess? The ones you didn't
see coming.
Ringa Trophy Hunter has to be on your
opponent's mind at all times. Every time
your opponent feels secure about the B
states, the Apex Predator could be
played on a battlefield where they have
units for five energy and one power,
either as an ambush or reaction speed to
support your other attacking or
defending units, or as a lonely attacker
straight from hand with its powerful six
smite. What cards do you think are going
to see the most play? And which domain
do you like the most after Unleashed?
Show us at your next tournament.
Have you been feeling moody lately? Are
you also tired of conquering for your
points all the time? Do you not want to
play a normie deck like the others? Then
we got the deck just for you. Vex
Gloomist appears in Unleashed, a legend
that massively profits from holding
battlefields. Stop your opponent from
ambushing or accelerating consistently
as early as turn two with Vex Apathetic
as your chosen champion unit. Tell your
opponents to back off by stunning their
units when they try to conquer. Player
shadow ready into battlefields to
immediately use its ability on the
opposing turn. Vex can rely on so many
different defensive tools that the calm
and chaos domain already have. Use
guardian angel and zona's hourglass to
protect your units from dying. Not so
fast and defy to counter opposing spells
and deny their tempo. But also new
defensive cards can be found in unleash
like existential dread or the mutated
mouser. But in the shadow isles, a
monster lurks supporting Vex, giving her
near unlimited defensive and offensive
possibilities. Enter Vimmore. The spider
god has ambush, meaning it can be played
offensive and defensively with this
powerful eight mighty jumps into a
battlefield that you are attacking and
crushes any unit smaller than it without
taking a single hit. If your opponents
doesn't manage to push it out of a
battlefield, an additional draw for
holding is a free bonus. With these
cards in your deck, you're going to be
able to keep all the others away from
your battlefields. Keep holding,
Riftbounders.
>> We are here at the Riftbound regional
qualifiers in Sydney. I'm here with Matt
and Nick. How are you feeling about the
weekend so far?
>> Oh, amazing.
>> Are you actually uh I honestly I lost a
little bit of hope today playing a bit
of Leblanc, but then I think going into
a couple of side events playing Vex, I
feel a lot more confident. So I think
tomorrow we'll be running probably the
Vex going into it.
>> Interesting. And what about you? Who are
you running?
>> I'm running Ahri.
>> Interesting. Have you got much
experience playing Ahri?
>> Yes.
>> He is a He is a very He loves Ahri
always. Back home it's nothing but Ahri,
so I can vouch for him. He's very good.
So all the other Ahri players out there,
watch out. We might have our best of for
the weekend.
>> Interesting. Those are those are
confident words. Are you feeling as
confident as he's making you out to be?
>> Yeah. Well, I named my deck the best of
already. So, if I don't get best of, my
deck list would be inaccurate. So,
>> we shall see. We'll see how it f unfolds
in the next couple of days. And, uh,
good luck.
We are here at the Riftbound Regional
Qualifiers in Sydney. I am joined by
Courtney. How is your weekend looking
ahead? Very busy, but I'm super excited.
I'm actually hosting trivia on all three
days of the week and I've got a bunch of
packs and prizes to give out. I'm very
excited to see the community and hope
they can answer all of my really tricky
questions. Ooh. How How tricky are we
talking? Like like 10 out of 10 tricky.
10 out of 10. All right. Picture this.
I've zoomed in on a picture of Kha'Zix
who is a bug. Could you tell me that it
is Kha'Zix? I feel like I I could
probably do it. I feel reasonably
confident.
I I don't believe you. I'll see you at
trivia. Okay, I will try. I will I will
be there and I will do my best.
>> We are here down at the Riftbound
Regional Qualifiers in Sydney. I am
joined by Morgan. How is your weekend
looking so far?
>> Wonderful so far. Um I'm amazed by the
turnout and we just found out that
there's 1600 plus players for main event
tomorrow.
>> Are you competing? Are you excited?
>> I am indeed. I'm going for best of Vex,
but we'll see how we go. And you're
feeling confident?
>> As confident as I can be.
>> Well, that's something. I And have you
have you been practicing? Have you been
running it a lot in the leadup?
>> Uh, a lot of online practice, but then
flipping and flopping on my list the
last couple of days practicing with
these two.
>> I feel like you're not alone with that.
A lot of people kind of analyzing, oh,
what should I be running? What should I
do? Especially because of the release of
Unleash so recently.
>> So many variables around.
>> And have you changed things because of
any unleash card? Uh, couple of changes,
but funnily enough, most of the changes
are pulling in Origins cards.
>> Interesting. So, we'll see how that goes
for you over the coming days. Fingers
crossed and good luck.
>> Thank you so much. Yeah,
>> we are midway through Sunday here at the
Sydney Regional Qualifiers. It has been
such an exciting day packed with really,
really thrilling features.
The ultimate rarity Baron Nasher has UV
light reactive ink. In the darkness of
the pit, only the Baron's teeth and eyes
glow, ready to consume. May the Baron
spawn in your next pack and unleash the
power of the void.
Hello and welcome back to coverage of
regional qualifier Sydney. We are
starting to get to the pointy end of the
Swiss round, Steph. Oh,
>> absolutely. Look, I have just had to
deal with watching the push-ups and that
reveal. Oh my goodness.
>> Yeah, that is a that's a very nice
looking card.
>> It's stunning. The UV. Very, very cool.
>> Very nice. Yeah. I didn't even know that
was a thing.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh also, weirdly, I feel like not as
rare as it seems because that's all I
ever see on social media that people
have opened. That may be some uh
confirmation bias at work.
>> Must be nice. I certainly haven't seen
one yet.
>> Yep. That's how I am at. But thankfully,
I do get to see a lot of other great
refound cards here on the coverage.
Round 10, if I recall correctly. Yep.
Eight. Yep. That's where we are.
>> Mhm. Mhm.
>> Five rounds of Swiss today after the
eight we had yesterday. And then of
course top eight. So, eight rounds just
like yesterday with a couple changes.
And we are three rounds away from
figuring out who is in our top eight.
And I have to suspect some of the
players are getting awfully close to
drawing in.
>> I think so. Look, at this point in the
day, it kind of does make sense that
that would be the case. But I'm very
intrigued to see because we've seen a
couple of players get a little bit more
tense over the past couple of rounds.
>> It is a very, very grueling weekend and
you have to have that endurance. So
whether or not you're able to manage,
who's to say?
>> Yeah, certainly the two things I think
players are generally thinking about is
one, just don't lose. That's pretty easy
way to win a tournament. Never lose you.
Yeah, it's pretty good. Other than that,
looking towards top eight, X and one
probably the record you feel very
comfortable on. uh x and 2, x, x1 and
one. That's where things get a little
interesting and that depends on things
that I genuinely cannot do math for and
get sorted out by some giant robot uh
later down the track when top eight
actually rolls around.
>> Well, I've been relying on you for all
of my mathematics.
This is uh it's putting me in a position
of strife here, but I'll trust that uh
the people who need to know, they know.
>> Yeah, certainly uh the uh the standings
robot and the judging stuff will be able
to figure that all out. But certainly
again uh the philosophy should just be
just win. Although I will say there is
more than just top eight to play for.
Obviously making top 64 gets a lot of
lot of different stuff. Get a playmat,
get some prize world cards, get a
qualification to the regional
championship. As a reminder, this is a
regional qualifier. This is a tournament
that qualifies for something else. It's
kind of hard to remember because it
feels like this is the peak right now of
Rift, which it will not be once regional
championships do roll around. So at
least want to get top 64. That's kind of
the the big goal for everyone here. But
also the best I'll plant. I don't know
exactly where some of them are up to,
but I I'm pretty confident there's at
least a couple players that rocked up
today as the only person on their
legend. So, they're going to have a
great day just free rolling the rest of
the tournament. Other than that though,
there's a lot to play for still with
winning some of those legends because uh
there are only so many. There's in fact
only one of each for this event. And I
imagine there's a few copies squeezed in
today too where you're going to be
fighting it out literally to the last
round. Even if you can't make top eight,
you want to have the best record. Well,
I mean, there was a representation of
pretty much every single champion over
the course of the weekend, and that is
wild.
>> Crazy, every legend, every champion.
>> Oh, yeah. I know there was more than one
Leona that made day two. So, went from a
deck that had made day two once to now
multiple players are fighting on day two
to win that best of. And as a reminder,
this season is the last time you can get
uh best of legend prizing for Origins
and Proving Grounds. There's going to be
16 legends rotated out of the pool. All
the Garen enjoyers don't have very many
events left.
>> Yeah, look, I think there are a few Ahri
hopefuls there as well.
>> Oh yes,
>> Ari definitely been a hot one. We'll see
though what happens in our 10th round.
What do we want to see? We've seen a lot
of things. We've asked for many things
and we have pretty much received all the
things we've asked for. But especially
this deep into the tournament. Kind of
curious what to expect. I feel like a
>> maybe not that much Aurora, but maybe
someone sneaking in. I think probably
should expect a lot of rounds of Aurelia
at this point.
>> Yes. Look, I think we'll probably see a
lot of Aurelia. I think what would be
really cool given that it seems to be
the theme of the weekend is to see a Vex
deck make it through. I don't know where
they're at at the moment, whether or not
that's realistic or how they're
tracking, but if that was the case, that
would be very cool.
>> Yeah, I think Vex and Diana, who we
haven't seen, I guess we've seen a
decent amount of Diana at this point,
but seems like someone that isn't
lurking quite towards the top tables.
Don't know how Allen's doing right now.
Don't know how been doing. two prominent
players on that archetype that were
doing very well in day one, but we just
saw Prismaticism almost lose his second
match of the tournament. So, for a
player that has not missed an RQ, I
believe uh since going to them, that
would be an impressive thing to lose
this late into the tournament.
>> Look, I still have a little bit of hope
that my Diana prediction might still
ring true.
>> It's it's doing all right.
>> It's possible. Although your position as
a Leblanc predictor, I think that's
probably a little bit uh more realistic
at the moment just based on how we've
seen those decks play out, but it is
still very possible that I might be
right.
>> Yeah, it turns out predicting the most
played deck in the field uh means that
sometimes you just get lucky, which I
think is what happened to be perfectly
honest. Uh as soon as we have a round
for you though, we'll queue it up cuz
I'm very excited to see what our round
10 brings us here. Two more rounds after
that and then top eight will begin after
round 12. Usually gets interesting. So
there's a couple things to maybe think
about. We talked about best of some
rounds you may get that are actually
just fight for best of, right? If
there's a player that you know,
especially if there's a mirror for one,
which the records might not be good
enough to make top eight, but there's
some prizes on the line that might be a
little bit more fun than say just the
top eight that is at stake. So we're
going to have a look at our standings.
This is where we are right now at the
end of round 10. There are only two
undefeated players left. That is
Ghostaster Driver. If that name is
familiar to you, that is the top four
Victor from Bolognia. Not playing Victor
this time around. winning on Aurelia and
of course we saw them on stream already
challenges TCG's
Daniel is on Leblanc Deceiver but not
just any Leblanc it is baited hook
Leblanc
>> Mhm. Look, before I put my prediction
in, there was a tiny little part of me
that was like maybe this is Aurelia's
time. Maybe this is the time that we see
it come up on top. And now seeing that
there are more than a couple there,
maybe I was wrong. Maybe I should have
gone with my gut.
>> Well, I mean the other thing you maybe
want to look at is that there is an X1
Diana player that's not named Alan EQ.
Uh there are more than one X1 Vexes in
this field.
>> Love to see that.
>> There's even an Azir. Still a deck that
seems to be pretty potent. And the rally
we actually saw on stream lose to
Leblanc in the feature still winning.
Only that one round uh kind of
>> as a blemish on the record.
>> Not to mention that Ezreal there as
well.
>> I have a funny feel. Well, actually I'm
curious where we want to go cuz the you
could just say, you know what, let's
just take the two undefeated players.
There's only two left at this point. see
who's going to stay undefeated cuz if
you go they going to get paired
obviously at this point cuz you do get
paired in Swiss based on record and when
there's only two of you it's very easy
for the system to figure out that you
should be paired against each other even
I can figure that out.
>> So have a look at the most played decks
here on day two. So remember we started
with many many many players registering
many different decks on day one and the
field has shrunk as expected with Miy
Aelia and Leblanc being our top three
decks. So, still our top three decks
from day one, but
>> the uh conversions have been different.
Being the most represented deck and
converting the worst of those three.
>> Yeah, look, seeing that top list there,
it is very interesting to see Aurelia be
one of the more dominating names that
we're have up there. Leblanc being up
the top. I mean, look, with 16 people
here, but I imagine probably only one or
two maybe running baited hook.
>> Yeah, I mean, there was what, 80
Leblancs, I think, to start day one. It
was the most played deck by far. I think
79 if I recall correctly. M so uh
obviously not converting all that well
because tends to happen to the most
represented deck is often not of let's
say a wide range of players like pick up
the deck and sometimes uh generally the
more skilled players do move on but
still plenty of representation. I will
say just looking at the standings that
we just saw thinking about this day two
conversion rate I don't know how many ye
are going to be in strike edition of the
top eight. It seems like that deck,
while a very good deck for the field
generally and quite a popular deck for
lots of different reasons, maybe not a
deck that's thriving that much in this
exact meta game.
>> Yeah, look, I mean, having 24 people at
this point in time and not really seeing
a lot of it up here at the feature desk,
I think realistically we can say almost
for certain that it will be a case of
being Aurelia, Diana, Leblanc, all kind
of oscillating around that top bit until
we get to the crunchy end. So, we get to
talk about the fun thing we always
mention every single time we have an
argu. Is it a reelious time yet?
>> Look, I I don't know. Maybe I should
have gone with my gut instinct. Maybe I
was going to be right. Look, with three
in that top round, look, I think there's
a possibility. There's a possibility. I
I don't know. I changed my answer for a
reason. I I did have a little bit of
hesitation there, but she's performing
really well and there is a lot at stake.
So, I still think that Diana has
probably more of a chance just because
there have been some really skilled
pilots, but as we said, I didn't see
Alan on that list. Uh, and there was
only the one Diana on that list. Three
Aurelia. Law of numbers, there is a lot
of probability there. And if I turn out
to be wrong, and it is Sydney bringing
the Aurelia time, honestly, I'm okay
with that.
>> Yeah. Uh for everyone that doesn't know,
Aurelia has pretty consistently been one
of the top decks uh in any regional
qualifies
tend to leak through. So not a deck that
always converts that well, especially
given how many copies of the deck are
typically in the field from memory
coming into day one. It was the second
most represented deck in this field. Uh
but lurking around the top eight maybe
getting a few copies in there. Has not
won in the west. Has won finally a
regional open in China. But uh even that
deck which was also very popular over
there was not particularly good at
winning.
>> So uh still waiting for its first
champion in some ways. Curious to see if
Aelia's time is maybe this time cuz that
was a deck I honestly thought might see
less play. I just didn't know with all
the new legends, especially with a bunch
of new cards being added how that would
kind of work out. But perhaps proving
that she's still a very resilient, very
powerful deck even as the format changes
around We're going to buy ourselves some
time as we are getting our next round
underway. It is time for everyone's
least favorite game.
>> Well, our least favorite game.
Production's favorite game perhaps.
We're going to get some flavor text once
again. We went one for three last time.
We'll see how we can do this time around
as production. Well, the flavor text I
know you love to watch us.
>> We can try. We can do this.
>> Is a leaf's only purpose to fall. That's
that flavor text I can tell you is an
in-game line from Yasawo. That is one of
Yasaw's lines. I mean,
>> but which saw?
>> Oh, I don't know.
>> I
>> What do you reckon?
>> Wind Rider versus
I'm going to say
>> that it would have been Wind Rider.
>> I think it's the green one. I think it's
>> six energy, two calm power. Yaso. I
think it's Yasawo, but it might be
something Yaso adjacent, which makes me
worry. But we're going to go with
Yasawo. Yaso Ramosus, I think, is the
name of that one. What do we got? Let's
do it.
>> All right.
>> Yes.
>> Uh, spoiler alert. This is my main in
league. So, I do know his voice lines
quite well.
>> Yeah, you're kind of obligated on that
one.
>> Thanks, production for throwing me a
softball. Maybe now I do like this game.
It's now become my uh a game I am simply
neutral about. All right. They called my
crew scurvy dogs, and I took that
personally. Ah,
>> well, that's going to be a pike, right?
Isn't it?
>> I think.
>> No. Wait.
>> Who's Which pirate has a crew?
Yeah, but which
>> spoiler alert, one of them isn't in the
game.
>> Yeah,
>> so Gangplank kind of the pirate everyone
thinks about. Uh not in the game.
There's no champion unit for Gangplank
anywhere. There is another pirate that
uh is pretty good at those Aurora decks,
but I have a feeling that this is what
it is. Cuz I'm pretty sure this is one
of her lines.
>> Is it
>> Misfortune?
>> Is it Misfortune?
>> I think this is Misfortune. Now, which
Misfortune?
>> I don't think Oh, it is not the one I
run.
>> Oh, who do you think? You think it's
Pike? Well, now I don't.
Oh, I'm less confident now. Uh, look.
Brazen Buccaneer. There you go. We're
both wrong.
>> The guy with the oranges. Oh, tells why
there's all the oranges. Get scurvy.
>> Should have been able to figure that
out.
>> Scurvy is one of my irrational fears.
Have I ever told you that?
>> No.
>> Yeah.
>> Now the world knows.
>> It's just I don't know if it ever
happens to me, it's going to be the
worst day.
>> All right. Well, we didn't get brazen
Buccaneer. One person's treasure is
another one's trash. I'm pretty sure
that's treasure trove.
>> Surely.
>> Is that treasure trove?
>> Is that too obvious?
>> Does the cast have a special?
>> Is it too obvious?
>> Is it?
>> Could be.
>> Are you giving us extra time because
we're wrong?
>> It's not cemetery attendant. Oh,
>> boo.
>> Ah, makes sense.
>> That is actually that is actually much
more sensible. We didn't think about it.
We didn't think like what is the what is
the card trying to convey?
>> M what is the message?
>> Yeah, just I just lined up the word
treasure with the other card that has
treasure in it and sent.
>> Yeah, the trash really should have given
us a hint there.
>> They could have told us it was like a a
playable card that people are running a
lot of. That would have helped me. Boo.
I actually have no idea what
are the ghosts.
>> I mean, are we talking sprites? Not
really.
>> Oh, it could be a sprite. I don't think
it's bewitching sprite.
Is it like oh like sprite find
>> it could be it is a little you know a
few words bit spooky
>> I know that one of the vex cards is just
ew which I love
>> is it shadow
>> m maybe
>> is it
>> could be sprites though
>> could be
>> I guess
>> I'm with you that I think it I'm I'm I'm
here on vex I'm
>> think it might be might be vex
>> which vex
>> well I don't think it's apathetic
>> it could be cheerless
>> cheerless maybe let's go with cheerless
Oh, this card's banned.
>> Oh, no.
>> Ah, well, all I know should be illegal
is that
>> show a banned card.
>> We need to brush up on our flavor text
>> clearly.
>> But we did not get completely defeated
thanks to you. So, still production,
we've got one up on you.
>> All right. Don't Oh, no. You already saw
the code. I was like I was going to do
another one.
>> Oh, you were going to do another one.
>> Yeah, but
>> no.
>> Send it.
>> I'm ready.
>> You're just trying to Okay, look.
>> What else we going to do? Oh, we're
chilling. We're waiting for the round to
pit.
>> This is a classic of card game
tournaments, by the way.
>> Every now and then, I mean, look, I
don't know if you've ever moved like a
few thousand people in a hall to the
exact right table they need to be at to
play their opponent in the card game
tournament, but
>> all right. If smashing doesn't work,
just keep smashing.
>> Smashing.
>> That's very vicoded.
>> Yes.
>> But I feel like we've been burned
before. H. But maybe this is the double
bluff and we actually should go exactly
what we think. Gut instinct wise.
>> Nar's not in the game. That's kind of
where else I would go. Someone would say
something like this. I don't think N
knows English. So
>> it's
>> which vi then cuz there's many vies.
>> Yeah. Look, it doesn't really narrow it
down that much.
>> Peacekeeper. There's the original one
which I don't think it's the original
one from Origins. And there's the other
Fury one from Unleashed.
>> It's not on Punch first, is it?
>> Oh, it could be on Punch first. I think
it I like it.
>> Blind first.
>> I like that a lot.
>> Maybe
>> the tension.
>> Oh, the anticipation.
>> Cut it with a fist.
>> A fist. A big punching fist.
>> Hopefully, I'm trying to manifest the
right answer.
>> Whoa. It was a knock card.
>> There you go.
>> Dang it. This is hard.
>> That's fair. Yeah. Look, I I feel really
confident with punch first for a second
there, but you
>> either way.
>> We're starting to get into the territory
of less less played cards. I feel like
>> one last one.
>> All right, I'm going to really
>> Now I feel I'm getting tricked cuz now
I'm going to be thinking of like every
random Origins card that's never been
played on stream and it's going to be
something really obvious. All right, as
long as these 37 things go right, it'll
work every time. Okay, that is a that is
someone hex techie.
I have to feel like that is a pilto
person. So that could be him. That could
be Jace.
>> I feel like Jace wouldn't say this.
>> No, it feels more Himemer coded.
>> This could just be the dinger.
>> I should know this by the way. This is
one of my favorite champions.
>> Well, then
>> this is my original favorite champion.
>> You got us in the right area with Yaso.
Are you happy to go with Homer? So
there's Hexte anomaly. That could be
this card as well. M
>> that feels well look I feel like because
they've been going with like walop and
all of the uh maybe lesser common ones
now.
>> All right I'm going to I'm going to
steer away from my gut of high say hex
technolon which is the gear that makes a
bunch of power. It's in mind. I that
might have been the real name but I'm
pretty sure that's close.
I'm going to be I'm going to about to
get burnt. Whatever is about to appear
on the appear on the screen is going to
haunt me forever.
Oh.
>> Oh, there. Well, no, that makes sense
flavor-wise. Makes
>> sense. Yeah, not sure. New to it.
>> Was a built over card. I was in the
right zone,
>> but I should have thought no one as
practiced as Himerdinger
>> would be that concerned about the thing
not working. We already know it works.
>> There's a wave.
>> Hello.
>> Not waving at us, by the way. But
>> no, but I'll take the wave as though
we're crowd.
>> That's great. Love that.
>> Philly involved.
>> Love a bit of riffbound. very excited to
see what we have in store here.
>> I will say sometimes I like knowing what
the matchup is ahead of time,
>> but often I like getting thrown in the
deep. I don't know what that says about
me, but
>> look, I feel like on Sunday I'm I'm down
to be surprised,
>> you know, could be. Uh
>> hopefully by hopefully by top eight we
don't get surprised. Hopefully we know
by then.
>> That I feel like is fair enough. But
right now I like being in the suspense.
>> I like it too. That is an unbelievable
tattoo, by the way.
>> Oh, very cool.
>> Players are chilling. Judges are getting
things involved. And I can just barely
not make out the legend.
>> I saw the very top of oop.
>> Is that Vex?
>> It does look a little
>> You see a little pop of green. That is
Aurelia.
>> Yes.
>> So, one of the one of those champions, I
guarantee it is Aurelia. Last time I
guaranteed something I saw on
Battlefield, by the way, I was wrong. It
was not.
>> Not this time. This time for sure. looks
so much like Vex.
>> All right, I think it's Vexerelia, which
if that is true, this match up's really
exciting.
>> Yes,
>> cuz we had Yasawo, who was a good time.
>> Loved him dearly, but uh
>> not the best perhaps we can say. Uh very
fun, but perhaps not the uh not the most
represented at the top regional
qualifier level, I think, is the nicest
way I can put it.
>> That's that's reasonable, I And then
Aurelia came along and Aurelia was uh oh
boy real good and Vex the same domains
but a very different legend. We are into
round number 11. Did I say 10 before?
Don't worry about that.
>> Maverick Jack on the left on Vex Glumis
versus Phantom Diver on Aurelia Blade
Dancer. And who's going first? Cuz that
feels pretty important in this matchup.
>> And we've got the Zom Warren there. And
what have we got there? We got the Raven
Blue Conservatory.
>> All right, Vex going first. Feels pretty
good to win the die roll here.
>> Do you have a two
>> stack deck? Oh, it's actually Aurelia's
Warren. That's interesting.
>> Very interesting. Well, we we have seen
a little bit of crossover over the past
couple of days.
>> That's true.
>> So, maybe there will be a little bit of
a not not quite a mirror obviously, but
maybe there will be some cards in common
here.
>> Okay, so Maverick Jack, I spite a few
cards in hand. I can see the the stack
deck as a charm gets taken there. Uh
this is definitely kind of more in the
vein of let's call it traditional. I
don't know if we could say this. Legend
came out like a week ago, but like kind
of the the the more stock hold Vex lists
trying to use things like Sona
>> from set one to uh stick on battlefields
and then just try and keep them as long
as you can cuz obviously Vex Gloomis
wants you to hold so you can exhaust her
and draw a card every single turn and
get that grow the God Willow value uh no
matter what the battlefield is. So
Lonely Por up against nothing right now.
Feels pretty good for the power. A fight
that it can probably win.
>> Up against nothing.
>> Up against nothing. But
>> is it doable? But I imagine once players
start getting on battlefields, we're
going to have kind of two very different
philosophies. And Vexpathetic straight
from the champ zone.
>> Absolutely. The card of the weekend
almost by how much we have seen it both
on the feature desk but also across a
lot of the decks on the floor today.
>> I think it's impressive how format
shaping
>> Vex has been. I think so many of the new
ambush cards which are very sweet
>> uh have kind of been Stonewall by Vex.
One of the reasons it's such a popular
not just deck but a popular as you noted
champion unit played in just about every
fact I wouldn't be surprised if Aelia
had one or two copies lurking in the
main lonely power though did score point
number one and Stellacorn Herder
>> in some ways heralds the beginning of
the end whenever you play against Aelia
>> and yes I know it's turn two but trust
me this card is a nuisance to say the
very least.
>> That being said in the hand there of
Maverick Jack what have we got? Can we
sneak a little peek? It did seem like
there was a star cross there.
>> Shadow Sona
>> and a defined dance off the top. That is
a brutal draw off the conservatory.
>> Four to two, but passing on back. Phanto
says, "Yeah, I'll take my card instead.
My defant dance can be used for
something else." And Vex very good
against a lot of the mobility that
Aurelia does want to use when an
opponent plays a unit while I'm at a
battlefield, which currently Vex
apathetic is. Stun it and they can't
move it this turn. So only when the
unit's
>> uh played. So if the unit's already
there, like the Stellon for example,
ride the wind and will still work.
>> So
>> it also has that deflect there. So it's
going to cost a little extra to deal
with as well.
>> Yeah. Turns off of uh sorry, turns off a
lot of the like really big turn stuff
that Aia can do. Turns off kind of going
from nothing to something. But things
that already established and Aurelia
does tend to develop her units before
using them because uh turns out her
units are a little bit expensive. like
four for the telepelia.
You do tend to have a turn off deploying
them before you move on in. So Vex will
stop some of the things but not all of
the things. This isn't like uh
>> isn't as big of a hammer as it is
against many decks actually which is one
of the reasons I think Fury has maybe
not had such a good time. Is Shadow
>> going to get deployed?
>> I think that might be the first time
we've seen Shadow at the desk.
>> We did not see Shadow earlier on the
Future Material. So we can give that one
a read as well. This one is a weird one
when you read it for the first time.
This is a signature unit. This is Vex's
signature unit
>> and it has an action ability which is
not usual
>> for uh for units.
>> The card reads, "If you play me to a
battlefield, I enter ready."
>> That's what happened.
>> And we have one and I can't quite see.
Can you see that?
>> One and a exhausted.
>> One and a power exhausted. And you can
stun an enemy unit attacking there.
>> Yeah. So, it's a weird one cuz typically
uh when you exhaust a exhaust something
to use this ability, most of those
things are at kind of regular or slow
speed. This one's an action, which is
not as good as a reaction obviously, but
does mean that you can stun units kind
of at will as they move on in. Kind of
makes single units a much less
attractive option for running into a
battlefield. So, uh right now between
Vex and Shadow and Shadow does also
three might for what it's worth. Will
still contribute that to the combat as
well. Feels pretty tough to break this
particular battlefield. So I think
Stellin might be going the other
direction once we get there cuz I think
Maverick Jack is considering what else
he might want to do. There is an Ozel
fan in hand. I can see not enough for
the Sona unfortunately. That would be
really good in this spot. They're just a
little short on runes there.
>> All right, Shadow going back. Actually
retreats in. There's a charm in the
silicon in. This is a very critical
moment if you can find it. But there is
the defy.
>> Oh, there it is.
>> Countering that charm protecting their
unit and hard bargain.
>> Hard bargain. Oh, well baited there.
>> Oh goodness. Sometimes I mean Vex does
have access to defy as well, but had the
answer and Stellicorn runs in does draw
a card notably for Phantom Diver still,
but unfortunately the Stellon is not
going to live to see the light of next
turn and that is bad news for Aurelia.
>> Mhm.
Look, we've seen in previous games that
as soon as it starts getting a little
bit more disrupted in that building
developmental phase, it does make it a
lot trickier to contend with some of
these decks.
>> Yeah, Aurelia, again, a deck that also
tends to, you know, deploy something
like Aas or Guardian Angel before
committing their units to the board,
>> often have a way to protect them. kind
of figured that against kind of just
charm as really the only way for VC to
proactively move a unit into a
battlefield where it could maybe perish
in combat. Felt like the fight was safe
enough, but had the answer. Maverick
Jack very heads up to try and pick that
fight in that spot.
>> And curious to see Shadow actually move
back,
>> but I guess just actually values it as a
unit right now. It is still a unit that
can take Battlefields and hold points as
now it's two to one. Stack Deck once
again is going to have a look at the top
three cards and Maverick Jack's going to
take a peek. I do spy a flash in hand
though for van diver. So this teleon
should be significantly more protected
from any future charms.
>> And there is another one in hand. I see
it just barely at the top of the screen.
>> There was a star cross there I think as
well. And obviously we do know that
there is the defiant dance.
>> Yeah, lots of good pumps in Phanto's
hand. Spide on guard as well. The these
decks do obviously they're in the same
domains. They do share some DNA in terms
of uh key cards they play. Both kind of
play a mix of things like hard bargain
and defy. I think most of the Vex lists
have at least discipline but not usually
onguard. So uh they will have some
overlap in terms of tools but obviously
only Aurelia gets to wield defiant dance
which I guess thank goodness that card
is
>> unbelievable as the zone war is going to
trigger after shadow goes ahead to claim
a little bit of extra territory. Point
number three card goes into the bin and
one extra goes into hand and it did spy
another charm. So I think we're going to
get a redux of the last thing we just
saw. Also of note, Ravenloom
Conservatory will trigger when this
charm moves into Vex. Apathetic. So
Teleorn moves on back in. Don't forget
your trigger. Draws a card thanks to
Stacorn. Trigger Raven Bloom
Conservatory cuz you are technically
defending even though you forced your
opponent into combat.
>> Finds a defy and I think that is bad
news for Phantom Diver. Looking at all
these spells that can potentially save
the Celicon and none of them are going
to work.
>> Not so much there. The only thing they
could have is on guard plus defy and
going to commit the on guard. So it
probably has the defy cuz you know the
other defy is face up
and looks like just kind of have to have
to commit it. You're priced in.
>> Yeah,
>> make him have it.
>> There it is.
>> There's one.
>> Oh, defiant dance. Oh, that is the other
option actually. Nice little bait
>> using the bigger spell. Using the sorry
using the smaller spell to bait out the
bigger one. And they do you just
mentioned to buy a dead ride the wind.
>> Interesting. I
>> think thought something else was going
to happen there, but Ride the Wind
instead going to save the Vex.
>> Mhm.
>> So, Stellorn will get to take the
battlefield. Oh, shadow moving in.
That's so sick. Now it stuns the
Stellorn add three might to the
battlefield. And that is slick.
>> I love that so much. This is why I have
been so excited to see Vex this weekend.
Oh my goodness. recycled a boatload of
runes to get there, but
>> still doing it all against Silicon
Herder. Silicon was a five. Vex was a
two versus the five on the other side,
but it didn't deal damage. That silicon
is absolutely dead. Did not have enough
might to live through the combat.
>> Goodness me,
>> all of a sudden
>> not expecting that.
>> Yeah, I thought I sped two energy chaos
spell and I thought it might be another
hard bargain, but that was even better.
But even with the ride the wind, I I my
gut instinct there was that they were
going to down.
>> This is why I let them play the games,
not me.
>> Yes,
>> checks the hidden card. Usually a back
off as Aelia Ferman gets committed,
>> but the point race is starting to get a
little bit dicey. four points to one
right now as Aurelia pretty far behind
on tempo but can catch up
>> and yeah and again with all the runes
being recycled.
>> Definitely an advantage for Aurelia
going into the next fight which is very
good news for Fervent and I have to
assume it running out of charms at this
point. Also can't even play one cuz
didn't actually flip over a calm rune.
>> Oh, are we going to
a little sneaky peek perhaps?
>> Oh, is that Evelyn?
I think that's Evelyn.
>> Star cross to flash. Another defiant
dance there.
>> It's funny that I said that. Uh couldn't
charm. And then the other charm is just
>> Evelyn. So, no big deal. I
>> think that's what it is. Just making
sure that it works out. There's Mousa.
>> Flip one over.
>> Out a little tank.
>> Yep.
>> When you flip me face up on your turn,
char basically is what this says. So you
have to hide it for a turn and have it
survive the turn cycle. But really nice
little addition to the hidden package. A
card that you get paid off for later.
Usually hidden cards pay off immediately
on your opponent's turn. This one only
pays off on your turn, but pays off
pretty big.
>> Mhm. It also has backline there as well.
Signed combat damage last.
>> Oh, alongside that tank. Kind of a lot
of uh lot of force choices here for Port
Aurelia.
>> Very much so.
>> Cool. Raven Bloom trigger as well. I
think we're Yep. remembering. Flip it
over. That's not a spell. That's a pair
of boots.
>> Would have liked that one by the looks
on the looks on the face, but still
trying to win this combat.
>> I mean, they they look like they're in
pretty good shape.
>> I see another Defiant dance.
>> Yes, there was a few things in hand from
last we checked.
>> Little might calculation as the shield
does make the mouse bigger. It's
currently a three. So, one base, shield,
two, and tank is good for three might
total. So 3 6 10 12 might versus Aelia's
four currently.
>> I mean we've seen it get pretty big so
>> we shall see
>> kind of know everything that it could
be. It can only really be defiant dance
and that is typically the short the
heristic of that is plus five.
>> Yeah I don't think it's going to Yeah.
>> Plus two minus two and plus one for
choosing Aelia and that is not a big
enough number to get past 12. So picks
up a unit and has to lose yet another
one to effectively three charms in a
row.
>> Mhm.
>> And only enough to take out the little
cat. Oh, still a very powerful presence
here.
>> Could have used Shadow there as well to
stun and make that combat even less
interesting, but decided that recycling
wasn't worth it.
>> Ma was good enough to get the job done.
And Shadow's going to retreat.
>> And this Vex deck is looking real nice
right now.
>> Did have to scale down on the runes to
be able to get to this point, but
there's an overzealous fan coming out
there
>> and just a base. Could have reinforced
for Vex, but decides that
>> safe enough. But I think one of the
things that's good about keeping the
board clear as a Vex player is that when
Vex Apathetic is on a battlefield,
>> you are just not scared of what your
opponent can do because no matter what,
the unit they play, even with Aurelia,
who's very good at readying units and
charging them into battlefields, doesn't
do anything cuz the unit stunned and
can't move.
>> It's such a very effective tactic here.
Honestly, this is one of the reasons
like I keep saying that Vex Apathetic,
I'm just such a huge fan. We've got the
Tide Turner coming out as well.
>> Yep. Tide turn
>> and the Swift. I hope we don't see an
oopsie.
>> Oh.
>> Oh no.
>> Okay.
>> I'm scared.
I mean,
>> seeing star cross. There's a flash in
hand for sure. There's the defiant
dance.
>> Don't actually know if Vex is a trigger
or not.
>> Oh no.
>> Now zero my unit.
>> Okay,
>> I am reading Vex. Right. Right. Let me
I'm going to read this again. I just
want to make sure I'm fully
understanding what's about to happen.
I'm pretty sure Vex says when I'm at a
battlefield, which Vex apathetic
certainly is at.
>> Mhm.
>> When you play a unit, stun it. It cannot
move this turn.
>> Yep. That is all the text. Stun units
don't deal combat damage by the way.
>> So, we can go conquers on warrants. That
is something actually that uh although
it can't we'd have to move, but is this
a can't move?
>> Yeah, they can't move at this point.
>> Can't even use a regulation move.
>> Mhm.
Yep, there's pointing it out.
>> So, doesn't lose the unit thankfully,
but just has to pass it back. I mean,
not so bad equipping a tie turner there,
but
>> obviously not exactly how we drew it up,
having to recycle an extra rune thanks
to Aurelia.
>> And did they not just ready it before or
>> Oh, they ready the tie turner.
>> Oh, yes.
>> But they had to use Aelia to do it. The
problem is just can't move and doesn't
deal damage.
>> Look, it it is what it is at that point.
Yeah, Vex Gloomis triggers draws a card
and looking to go from five to six
pretty swiftly here. Can move a fan into
that Zorn Warren. Get a bit of filtering
there with the draw discard.
>> Seeing that charm in hand though for
Phantom Diver.
>> Yeah. So,
interesting.
>> So far behind in points.
>> Starcross, Sona, exit potential dread,
boots of swiftness, and
oh, purple Ka'ix. Chaos Kaix.
>> Interesting.
>> That one's really good if your
opponent's units are alone. Whenever I
attack or defend, if an enemy unit is
alone here, give me plus two this turn
and gain two XP. The XP doesn't matter,
at least in this deck, but uh Kha'Zix's
mutating horror. Pretty sweet one.
>> It can also be played as a reaction
because it has ambush.
>> Does have ambush. Sometimes, you know,
it's funny cuz the keywords are often
like the smallest bit. I do this remind
text especially on the new cards but
every now and then you just look at a
card you read the text like oh that's
pretty cool and then you read again
>> and you're like oh
>> you're like oh that has tank that has
shield that has deflect oh that one has
ambush
>> absolutely
>> all righty well
>> much less scary to be playing ambush on
that side of the table I think rather
than on the Aurelia side there's fan
coming in
>> right
>> protecting that battlefield's also
captured there's
>> little song to be sung four runes to be
readied That's fair. We were down on the
rune count on that side.
>> That's one of the reasons I think these
decks are so excited to play with Sona
is that you do want to leave up your
interaction to try and defend your
battlefields when you're looking to hold
them.
>> And Sona gives you a pretty good
discount.
>> Resource generation is really really
vital especially at this point in the
game.
>> Think in all many card games people will
people say such things.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh does hold true in Riftbound as well.
Little Sona harmonious. Another card
from Origins that's kind of uh gotten a
big boost thanks to Vex existing as
Overzel going to get pushed away here. I
think this is one of the rarely seen
charm off a battlefield.
>> Doesn't want to have to deal with this
incoming trigger.
>> Interesting.
>> Charm resolves or are defies in Vex's
deck that we've at least seen. though
not not there or not used as Tide Turner
at four power currently with those pair
of shoes looking maybe to break up the
Vexpathetic finally
and put an end to her reign of terror
>> seeing there the on guard
>> flash star cross I think sneaky deck
hand is lost yeah it doesn't matter what
it is and too far behind has to break
both battlefields to not has to break at
least one to not lose
>> the hold does good is good for six to
eight and that is enough
very
fashion.
>> It was efficient more than anything
else. It had a very very clear early
presence. It held it and obviously
having that stun can be so effective.
>> Yeah, a lot of really cool tricks. I
think the the first instinct with Shadow
is kind of like, oh, this is like
another thing I add to Battlefields to
just like help me hold, right?
>> Kind of get a not a free stun, but like
a a stun every turn for a minimal cost.
and Eve seeing Shadow like enter ready
then move back and then actually do some
like normal unit stuff moving around and
capturing that ride the wind to ensure
the stun could happen again and also
adding might to that battlefield. Lots
of like tricksiness which is very common
for these domains but I haven't really
seen it manifest in a hold strategy like
it has for Vex which is I think why it's
such an exciting deck for me as an
Origins Ahri player. I look at Vex I'm
like oh I feel like Vex is doing all the
things I wanted Ahri to do in Origins.
>> Yeah, I can see that. It's very
interesting having not seen the deck
lists to figure out whether something
was or wasn't already in the main deck
after this sideboarding. Had a little
sneaky peek there. I saw I think I saw a
fizz maybe.
>> Love a fizz.
>> A good fizz. Even Aelia started to pick
up fizz as well.
>> Some of the lists we've seen. Turns out
just one of the better cards.
>> Absolutely.
>> In those domains.
>> So players are boarding. Little chitchat
with the table judge.
>> Could be about anything. Could be about
breakfast. It was a while ago at this
point.
>> Probably lunch then.
>> Probably lunch.
>> Yeah,
>> definitely remember to grab lunch if
you're out in the tournament hall.
>> There we go. And hydrate. Hydrate as
much as possible.
>> Excellent example set for everyone at
home.
>> Again, we said it yesterday. We'll say
it a lot again today. Days are long
tournament hall.
>> It is as much a physical game as it is a
mental game sometimes when you are doing
these longer days.
>> And certainly round 11
13 rounds of Swiss Alto together. 8 + 5
is 13. So two, this is three rounds
until top eight happens. And especially
getting towards those later rounds,
round 12, round 13. Again, looking at X
and one is kind of the obvious way to
get yourself into top eight. There's
only two undefeated left, so they're not
going to stay undefeated for long. In
fact, after this round, there will be
only be one.
>> One will be left.
>> So, uh, both of these players in this
particular seat,
>> winning is pretty important here.
top. It's not impossible to make top at
X and it's much harder, especially at
this stage in the tournament. If you
lose in like if you go X2 at round 12,
round 13
>> depending on the rest of the standings.
It's a little more possible. Although
>> at this point though,
>> the tournament's so big, it's also tough
to like
>> Yes,
>> you definitely don't want to be beholden
to uh whatever mythical tiebreaker math
happens to happen
>> uh behind the scenes. By behind the
scenes, I mean done by the computer cuz
it does all the work. But so you'd
rather just again just win forehead is
generally the moving forward.
>> So uh this is not a win and in in the
strictest sense but certainly a win and
get awfully close to top eight.
>> Absolutely. And you're right. We have
had a huge showing here at Sydney. I
believe we started with 1,600 people.
>> Yep.
>> So the fact that we're here already on
the Sunday, it's a huge testament to
these players, but there is still a
little ways to go and I I feel the
hunger from everyone still remaining.
>> Yeah. I'm not even sure actually don't
even know how many players we entered
day two with. It was not very many.
>> I think the cutoff was pretty brutal.
>> Mhm.
>> Given the size of the tournament. Uh, as
a reminder, our top 128 players get a
very fancy new Vex Gloomist playment
that I'm very jealous of.
>> Yes, I'm so jealous of that.
>> I have to feel like any of the Vex
players in the room that are still
playing for top eight this late into the
tournament can at least say, you know
what, I think I got myself a fancy new
playman to update my deck going into the
next event. But obviously you come in
wanting to do a little bit better than
that. Top 64 gets you a qualification
for the regional championship. That is
certainly a good starting point, but top
eight is where everyone really wants to
be by the end of today. And
unfortunately uh for the numbers don't
lie. Uh there's only eight players
allowed into top eight. That's why it's
named that way.
>> Kind of how it works. There's really no
way around that actually.
>> There is there's no way around it.
>> It is top eight.
>> We've never let nine players into the
top eight.
>> All right. So side loading, shuffling,
pleasantries, all being exchanged
between players. Little card on the
screen that looked very good in that
game. Don't know how many copies of that
card people are running, but when you
consider cards to run in your hidden
package. We saw a lot of edge of knights
in Spirit for kind of a one-off
>> where it's just like, you know what,
sometimes I want you to not know what
exactly what this is. Even if it's
mostly this card, sometimes I want to
make you think about playing around
another card. And I think Evelyn is so
cool because it is a hidden card that
punishes your opponent for doing the
thing you typically do against hidden
cards, which is if you can't play around
them, you just ignore them cuz you don't
face check them, nothing bad can happen.
Except with Evelyn now something can
>> Evelyn.
>> Well, yeah, exactly. And sometimes when
you don't know it's an Evelyn or a I
don't know, we're not fight anymore. Uh
Ed knight. Sure. Or a
>> what?
>> A back off.
>> Back off. There you go.
>> Should have thought of that one. M
>> very different cards and
>> very very different energies there.
>> Very different energies.
>> Uh one art is significantly stronger
than the other on those two. Even though
both of the pictures are beautiful and I
am of course referring to Back Off. One
of the best pie art in the set.
>> So great.
>> I do wonder what the flavor text is on
that one actually.
>> Should we look it up?
>> Yeah, why not?
>> All right, let's find out. All right,
chat. Put your put your answers.
>> Oh, that's the one. That's the one.
That's the Ew.
Oh, I got it mixed up. This is so great.
You know what? My favorite flavor text,
maybe my favorite art.
>> It's really good flavor text. Hopefully
the other talent aren't in the room
listening and they can get delivered
that one for the upcoming guess the
flavor text segment
>> and we'll see if they are keeping track.
>> Sneaky hint paying attention.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Well, trying to think what
Aurelia
might I mean I was going to say might
want to change. I think honestly just
kind of got like it happens sometimes.
you're going second, your opponent
triple charms you and kills all your
sweet units. And even though you have
defenses, that none of them won't care
cuz your opponent has the answer. Like
that is the matchup in some ways, right?
>> Uh there's aggressive charms are really
the only way for Vex to
>> like proactively remove units. Again,
very defensive deck that wants to sit on
battlefields and hold them. So typically
units in the backline are somewhat safe,
which is good for Aurelia cuz she wants
to protect them and then use them later
when she's got all her resources at her
disposal. So, I think you can feel
relatively confident that's not going to
happen that way
again.
>> Well, look, I mean, it is one of those
things where you can be doing everything
right and still your opponents will have
the answer every single time. Whether
that can happen two times in a row in
this rapid succession, look, it would be
very cool. It would be very interesting
to see that happen. But I also really
want this Aurelia player to be able to
flex and see a little bit more of the
deck. I'm I'm keen to see what's
sideboarding. A lot of the Aurelia
decks, I imagine, probably have some uh
a little bit of Vex action a little bit
as well.
>> Yeah, I think so. We've seen a Vex TLS
be pretty good. It's actually be quite
good in this matchup. Uh the Origins,
not the Spirit Forge Vex that Allen's EQ
pretty famously uh performed with in uh
Bolognia in his deck. Uh I said earlier
that that's a card that a lot of earlier
that are playing for the mirror and this
isn't exactly a mirror but there's kind
of some of that same energy where you're
>> as you saw clearly doing a lot of
fighting on the chain in showdown
>> as you trade action windows back and
forth. So
>> if that's in there I could see that
being good. I think in general just like
finding a way to deal with Vex apathetic
feels pretty important for Aurelia. Like
it doesn't sty me all of your game plans
like it might against a deck that are
more heavier on ambush let's say whereas
where Vex really shines. But you can
even tell in that game like trying to
play catchup when you can't actually use
your legends ability to ready a unit and
run in like means that once you fall
behind, if you can't dislodge
Vexpathetic from Battlefield, you just
kind of stay behind the whole game. So
given that you know it's going to happen
basically on turn two every single game,
I think there should be a plan for
dealing with that particular, you know,
whether that's a charm of your own,
whether that's some other balance spell
like a rebuke or starrust. I think
thinking what do I do on that turn when
Vex pathetic comes down. How do I set up
around that is probably something that
everybody needs to think about pretty
heavily cuz
>> you kind of just don't get to play a
portion of your deck.
>> Also worth noting that shadow is in
there as well. So is there there is
another stun effect there. It is a
little bit more costly obviously, but it
is very very possible that you're going
to have to contend with multiple things
there. Even if you are able to manage
the Vex apathetic, there is still a lot
of tech in there that can make things
tricky.
>> Yeah, Shadow feels kind of especially
brutal in this matchup because a lot of
Aelia's thing is making one big unit,
right? One big Stellico and one big
Aurelia fervent is the kind of the
marquee one and uh a single targeted
stun really good at beating exactly one
unit in combat.
>> As we are back in game number two, it is
Targon's peak for Aurelia and it is
abandon hall.
>> Abandoned Hall
something is very good at using
>> so that makes sense but one that is a
little dangerous in this match up and
going especially
>> I'm surprised so clearly Maverick Jack
believes that Hall is a battlefield that
Vex is also very good in cuz I don't
think you would do this otherwise as
Overz fan going to be the first play of
the turn no two drop for Phantom Diver
did spot a sneaky deck hand earlier and
I have a feeling that it's going to find
itself on Targon's peak in just a moment
>> Mhm. For those of you who have not seen
up close, abandoned hall reads, "When a
player plays a spell, they may give a
unit they control here plus one might
this turn." So, I can understand why
you'd want to build up some of those
units there as well. And look, it is a
bit of a risk coming in to an Aurelia
matchup here and playing that. But if
that's if that's what you need to do to
build up your hold, might be worth the
risk. I mean, in general, a lot of the
plan is like create battlefields that
are very challenging to impossible for
your opponent to actually do anything
about. So, if Aelia is getting stunned,
it doesn't really matter how big she is.
She's not going to deal damage in combat
anyway.
>> So, I can kind of see where you feel
like you can maybe mitigate the power it
can give Aurelia.
>> As noted though, Sneaky Decan did do the
thing and gain a point straight to the
Tigan's peak, which of course is an open
battlefield. You may play Sneaky Decan
to open battlefields. Uh the reason to
do this, especially when they have peak,
is that
>> you just get to protect a unit and start
getting points as early as possible,
even going second, although obviously
Phantom Nova went first this game.
>> Just being able to immediately reread
your runes and kind of start the game
earlier than your opponents might
expect. Again, lots of fours and lots of
fives that Aurelia deploys in the
earlier stages before kind of looking to
score points at Battlefields. This one
kind of gets it done early. And
honestly, Sona kind of does the same
thing.
>> Does the same thing. Yeah, that resource
generation once again making sure that
you're up on your runes.
>> Fun. Very minor thing that could have
happened. Oh, actually there's no shadow
there. Never mind. There was a stack
deck over there. Maverick Jack could
have actually played that as well.
Actually didn't quite get the full value
out of Sona there. Only readying three
runes at the end of turn instead of
four. But nothing worth playing which I
don't think going to be too upset about
as guardian angel
>> going to find its way down here. I see a
Stellicorn or two in hand. Then I see a
very beautiful lonely porro as Stellorn
is going to get equipped and passed.
>> No answer this time.
>> No ready either. Didn't want to move it
for a card draw. Wants to save it for
later. But does value the protection
that guardian angel grants that unit.
>> Getting that Vex trigger there.
>> Feels so good to draw an extra card
every turn.
>> It does. Oh, love a little card draw.
>> I love card draw so much.
>> All righty. What's next? Using those
runes makes sense. Is gonna give you a
rebate at the end of this turn anyway.
>> Two points a piece.
>> What are we going to use them on is the
question. Oh, nope.
>> I lied.
>> That's a pathetic. Does cost four.
>> Mhm.
>> Not to sound like a broken record here
on the cast desk, but is a unit we've
seen a lot of this
>> weekend.
>> And I'm thrilled for it. Honestly,
>> it's real good. Uh
>> it does feel a little uh in congruous to
say I'm thrilled for apathetic, but I am
and I'll accept it.
>> Just having a peek right now. Is that a
factory recall?
If if that is what that card is, then I
am concerned for how much rift I have
bought.
But I see a hard bargain. I see a hidden
card. Didn't spot what it was, but
Vexopathetic is actually going to base
this time around.
And then some more considerations here.
Maverick track just puzzles it out.
>> There is already that presence at the
abandoned hall with the overzealous fan
and Sona there. So
>> yeah, it's a tough one to break.
>> Curious to see Vex kind of playing
defense, playing at home, but I think
>> valuing Vex's actual might value in this
instance as a potential challenger
>> for the bottom battlefield instead of
its effect on this upcoming turn.
>> So card drawn here, Gust in hand. That
is a very good answer for Overzalis fan.
Yes, very much so.
>> Got to be careful. Sometimes doesn't
work out the way you want it to. If the
unit gets a little bit bigger than you
may expect, say, I don't know, maybe
with a discipline.
>> Pretty common card played in calm.
>> There is that defiant dance in hand as
well. Just got a little glimpse.
>> We challenging or are we are we are we
scared? Cuz Steelorn wants to draw
cards, right? So, moving to a
battlefield, we've already scored. Not
the best, but not the worst cuz the
cards are very valuable.
>> That is true. Obviously, if you can uh
do some damage, maybe claim the hall for
yourself. Start digging in and
protecting there. That's going to feel a
bit better. There is a hidden card for
it.
>> Four. Draw a card. There's another charm
actually in hand. Little shake at the
head. Don't know if you caught that from
Phantom Diver.
>> Perhaps not the trick they were looking
for.
And five currently playing six might.
There's an Overzel fan trigger being
considered now by Maverick Jack. Do have
to use it as a defend.
>> It's always interesting seeing those
kind of little tells. I I have no poker
face, so I'm terrible at bluffing. You
can absolutely tell if I've drawn
something good every single time. Are
you inscrable or are you, you know, a
little see-through? I
>> think it depends. Sometimes I would say
like 60% of the time.
>> Pretty good. 40% fall to pieces
immediately. Defiant dance going to try
and win this fight. Make it very unfair.
We assume assume they have passed on
Overzel's fan.
>> Mhm.
>> The fan is staying for the fight. There
is still that hidden card to contend
with though.
>> Yeah, could have been players reaction
with a fan trigger on the chain as well,
but deciding that's not what we wanted
to do.
>> Not much,
>> but they have by there.
>> All right, so Defiant Dance going to be
turned off as Gust going to get
committed here.
>> Looks like it. Yeah,
>> Gust, your fan
trying to win this fight again. It's
four for four right now. Defy dance is
not going to be resolving.
>> Mhm. Unless there's another Defiant
hanging around, but uh it doesn't have
it. So, Gust Defiant Dance
going to
>> Oh, abandon hole. There we go.
>> Oh, of course.
>> It looks like both players have to
choose. So, Sun So getting bigger and
Stell getting bigger. Gust uh did
resolve. The Diviant Dance actually
won't get to give the hall buff if I
recall correctly.
So it's currently five playing five but
the guardian angel makes this feel like
a reasonable exchange for Stellon
Herder.
>> Definitely a much safer position. It
will be interesting to see because there
obviously is that Vex at the base there.
I don't think I would move it, but ah
>> not necessarily
thrilled to have to trade and still have
the guardian angel, you know, do its
thing.
>> Yeah, I have a feeling both players have
a bit more.
>> I think just considering
>> something in the tank.
>> H I don't know, folks. I don't know what
to tell you. Pretty good bit of kit
against Zir. It's kind of where we
started seeing this card
>> get a bit more play, but quite good
against Aurelia for the kind of a
similar reason. When you
>> move the gear from uh hand at action
speed, even though they get to replay it
again, you turn off the thing that is
protecting their unit and that is worth
its weight despite the tempo loss. Well,
it's a tempo positive thing, but
eventually they'll get it back. You just
hope that he eventually basically never
comes. Hm. Tempo neutral then. Maybe.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah.
>> Tempoish.
>> Tempo.
Jason.
>> Jason.
>> All right. So, looks like we're in
Maverick Jack's action window. So, Bad
is happy to trade. Existential red going
to be the card committed though. That is
a good old stun. Not repeated. So, not
going to be returning the unit to hand,
which kind of makes sense. I think
wanting to win the fight and actually
try and at least remove the GA from the
silicon. Maybe have dreams of uh of
bouncing the GA as well and killing the
silicon for good.
>> Stun an attacking enemy unit. If it's
already stunned, return it to its
owner's hand instead. Is the text of
existential dread has repeat does cost
you two extra energy to get it repeated.
So, three energy and a single chaos
power to do the whole thing. It's just
one and a stun though in this spot which
is pretty good for our purple thonk as
they've taken to calling it. Abandoned
hall once again making Sona bigger.
>> And now Sona winning the fight very
cleanly. And Maverick I think is trying
to bait
>> his opponent into using more cuz if they
I guess no never mind. You actually get
an actual window again. Well, if you
want to recall, you get an actual window
back. That's what I was worried about.
But
>> onus back on your opponent. So, you
still have the opportunity to recall
this GA and take this teleorn out for
good if that's what you want to do.
>> But if your opponent passes, you can
just say pass and let the GA go the
natural way. Hold on to your
battlefield. And yep, decides that
that's good enough.
>> Yeah,
>> I'll take my combat win. I'll take your
GA and I'll move your Stellicorn back to
base. Not an actual move though, just a
recall. Doesn't get to draw a card.
>> I think actually, yes, exhaust me and
recall me is the text on Guardian Angel
as a charm.
>> Charm
>> is going to happen here. I think trying
to charm Sona off the battlefield to
take out the hidden card.
>> Maybe
>> doesn't happen that often, but it's fun
when it does.
Can't move your own. You don't have to
move an enemy unit with charm.
>> Evelyn Evelyn again.
>> Evelyn, of course, does not work when
it's not your turn.
>> But hold on to the battlefield. We'll
get the point. We'll hopefully get the
card draw off of Vex Gloomist.
>> But uh I can see the vision
>> there for Maverick Jack. Cannot hold on
to it.
>> Art on the lonely poro there.
>> That is It's very pretty.
>> It's so pretty. makes me concerned
as Vex Gloom is going to draw a card.
Three points to three, I believe.
>> Mhm.
>> Should be the score as Maverick Jack
awakens and considers their options.
>> Yeah, looking at that lonely parro, it
is definitely uh threatening the old
bank account.
>> Love how happy all the other P in the
foreground are.
>> Oh, his little sad face.
>> If I died alone,
>> draw one.
Oh,
>> all right. Couple cards in hand. Spied
most of them at a glance, but Maverick
Jack pulls them back.
Mutated mouse overzealous fan.
Discipline. Factory recall. Hard
bargain. And one more in the grip. It is
a Kha'Zix.
Mutated horror. We learned this one just
a game ago.
>> We absolutely did.
>> So going to go from base to the peak.
>> It's peak.
>> It's peak
>> as Vex. Four points to three. should be
the score.
>> Mhm.
>> And what to do with the rest of the
runes? Sona is going to give you a
refund on four of those. So, probably
want to spend a couple.
>> Can we see in hand there? Oh,
>> should be Mouser plus fan here. It looks
like seems like a pretty good use of the
resource.
>> Yeah, there we go.
>> Stacking that top battlefield. Deciding
that the abandoned hall is where the
stand is going to be made. Leaving Sona
on her lonesome down at Targon's Peak.
Look, again, I'm not surprised that that
is the case given that abandoned hall
does have a lot of that benefit for
Aurelia as well. You might as well make
a stand somewhere that is more
advantageous to have them not be on.
>> And I kind of like this pacing from
Maverick Jack in terms of when do I move
Vex to a battlefield. I think kind of
step one is like when it feels a bit
safer.
>> Yes.
>> But also when it feels a bit more
relevant, right? I think Aurelia Fervent
has kind of been the unit literally
looming over this game from the champ
zone and seven runes is a lot. That is
something where Aurelia can do a lot
more work.
>> Absolutely. It is interesting to have
not seen her land just yet, but there's
been a lot to have to contend with.
>> Exactly. Been a lot of a lot of stuff
going on.
>> So Aurelia not going to be able to be
readied or moved. Well, can ready. It
doesn't do very much. Not going to be
able to deal damage or be moved this
turn if she gets played. So kind of have
to contend with the units you brought to
the party to begin with. And one of them
is a Stellicorn Herder. That's usually
good for
>> solid establish quite a lot. There's
that charm.
>> Charming something off the battlefield.
Looks like it pointed to mutated Mousa.
>> Well, it does have the tank. It makes
sense that you'd want to be able to
make some more decisions.
>> Yep. Mouser goes back. Might be running
in the lonely por here to try and
basically force the fan.
>> Mhm.
One way or another, it's going to go
down indeed. Lonely Parro charges on in
to its demise, but to an end that is
potentially worthwhile for Aurelia.
>> Mhm. Look, I'll do a lot of things to
draw a card. And if it means sending in
that lonely for its inevitable demise,
sometimes you just got to do it.
>> Yep. Even if it's that beautiful,
sometimes it must go.
>> Mhm.
>> Little decision here for Maverick Jack
whether or not to use the fan or not.
basically, do I care about my opponent
having this unit later versus them
having the card now? Decides that the
unit later is a uh worthwhile
>> thing. So does pop the Oh, never mind.
Trades.
>> I got uh jaded
>> by that little exchange.
>> Interesting.
>> But as expected, the Lonely Poor runs in
and takes out the fan.
>> And of course, the fan deals only the
only damage it can. Well, the rest of
the units deal the damage they can. And
uh the Lonely Porro does perish. Boots
of swiftness now committed.
We are equipping Celicorn getting
bigger, stronger, faster, better, all
all the above as Dehand rolls on in with
the Celicorn Roricard. Thank you.
>> And arguably more stylish with some
fancy boots.
>> Very stylish.
>> Mhm.
>> Sona also in danger. I will say that
ganking and that Aelia.
>> Mhm.
>> Legend ability
>> seven there in that showdown.
>> Ooh, a classic as they say.
>> Mhm. draws a card from the silicons and
not so fast. There's a factory recall
that is targeting something that you
own.
>> Trying to bounce those boots.
>> Yeah.
>> Turn off the two power to might that's
been given over. There's not so fast.
>> That's not so fast.
>> There's our bargain as well.
>> Oh,
>> there we go.
>> Yep.
>> Just make sure we didn't have to repeat
it, I think. But, uh, all's well that
ends well. Once again, another attempt
at protecting units being foiled by
these pesky counter spells that these
domains wield. Vexpathetic going to get
bigger as well.
>> And of course, with the not so fast not
resolving thanks to that hard bargain,
it is two different abandoned hall
triggers going to make Vexpathetic even
bigger.
>> Would not be mad at that.
>> Now five plays eight. Not a fight that
uh Silicon Herder and Dehand are going
to win. Yeah, look, losing out that
Stellorn would not get. There we go.
>> Wow. Phantom Divers, here's the writing
on the wall. Gives it over to the Vex.
Just too much of a stronghold on that
battlefield. You can kind of see how
problematic Vex Apathetic is for this
Aurelia deck.
>> Truly, it is a standout card this
weekend for a reason. It has really,
really well matched up to a lot of
different champions at this point.
Aurelia just not enough to come up this
time around. But it'll be interesting to
see if uh we see some Vexes in the other
Aelia decks.
>> I I'm just that's such an interesting
matchup because I never thought really
much about how this matchup would play
out, but seeing it on camera at least in
those two games,
>> it looks kind of miserable for Aelia at
times. Aelia is very very good at
breaking battlefields, but
>> when Vex put digs her heels into a
battlefield, she does not let go.
>> I really like the use of Evelyn in this
as well.
incredibly good. It's nice to, as you
said, do a little bit of a bait by
having her hidden and not necessarily
what you'd conventionally expect. Making
it work.
>> Yeah, we saw kind of the rise of charm
through the end of spirit forges.
Basically, every com deck started to
realize, wait a second, this is one of
my best ways to remove units in effect.
And in a deck where you want to be
sitting in battlefields anyway, you have
all manner of stuns and pumps to play
with.
>> Makes a lot of sense to see not only the
charms in the deck, but some Evelyn as
well. It is so great to be seeing a Vex
with such a smooth engine.
>> Yeah. In striking distance.
>> Very possible.
>> 10 and one with two rounds to play of
the Swiss. That is
>> maybe one win away from drawing in.
>> Solid solid attempt. You'd be feeling
pretty confident. Obviously the next
couple of rounds they're going to be a
little bit more tense for you. The
pressure can definitely escalate and you
want to go in with a good head space.
But it does look like they have a pretty
good mindset right now. Who wouldn't
after a win like that?
>> They got some mates in the crowd like
that. Yeah, good win. It's all good.
>> Things are going great.
>> Well, they gave a wave at the start of
the match. So now you can celebrate and
we will hopefully hear a little bit from
them soon as well. But I am very very
excited to have seen this matchup. I I
think given that I did have that little
bit of a wobble on my prediction, this
is making me feel a little bit more
confident there that maybe I did make
the right call in switching off Aurelia.
But there are still others to contend
with.
>> Yeah, a lot of Aelia in the field. Lot
of Aurelia in the top of the standings.
So, a lot to play for still, but Vex
potentially one of the decks that we'll
be seeing in our final rounds of the
day. Really interesting to think again
what mix of legends are we going to get
three sets of riftbound now origins
spirit force and unleash and unleash
obviously the talk of the town
>> given uh it was only released a moment
ago it felt like
>> but uh always cool to see new legend
succeeding in a new format.
>> Yeah I mean look the the fact that we
have seen such success from Leblanc as
well it will be interesting to see a Vex
versus Leblanc if there is a baited hook
involved. I don't know if they would
have come up against that kind of build
before, but you never know what it'll be
at the tail end of the day.
>> So, it was interesting actually. I think
when we interviewed Dizden on the lounge
>> Mhm.
>> was ask you know what matchups we
considering when you're building this
deck and I think originally he said that
when they started playing it felt like
Aurelia was horrible
>> and then they played more and more and
kind of
>> played the match up a bit and kind of
tuned the deck and actually felt like
you know what this feels all right.
>> Yeah. And I have to feel if your Aurelia
match up starting to feel all right that
perhaps your Vex match up doesn't feel
so bad either.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Well, looks like we have an
interview lining on up. We'll get there
when we get there, folks. Don't you
worry. But, uh, we wanted Vex and we got
Vex. So, what are we going to ask for
next?
>> Ooh.
I mean, if we're manifesting, I I would
like to see Diana. I think I want to see
if my prediction is going to be, you
know, realistic or not. And I haven't
seen one here. Obviously, we have seen a
few at the desk already, but I'd like to
get up close and personal. I think
>> not exactly sure where I want to go next
cuz I' already got Faded Hook on stream
today to kick off. But I will say as we
kind of move towards the last few rounds
and and think about top eight, I do
think we're poised to have maybe the
most diverse RQ top eight we've ever
seen in terms of different numbers of
legends represented. Already the metag
game for a number of different reasons
is extremely diverse, but I think even
the decks that succeed by the end of it
are going to be we've had six different
arbound.
>> It would be fantastic. As we said
earlier at the top, I mean there has
been so much diversity over the course
of this weekend. Every single legend was
represented. That's wild.
>> And of course, the race for the best of
still very much in the hunt for a number
of players. Obviously, if you win the
event, you also win the best of.
Congratulations, you did the thing. But
if you're just a single copy at the end
of the day, whether it's top eight or
very near the end of the Swiss, that's
also good enough. So, I'm very curious
what the race is like. But for now,
we'll hold those thoughts because we are
going down to Profound Rice with for an
interview with our winner.
>> Thank you so much, Pastry. I am here
with the winner, of course, Maverick
Jack, but also including his son as
well. Would you like to introduce your
son?
>> Oh, yeah. This is Noah.
>> Say hi.
>> Nice to meet you.
>> So, I hear you both play Riftbound. And
tell me about the legends you've been
playing so far in Riftbound.
>> Uh, I've been playing a lot of Vex,
Leblanc, and Pike for the set three. Um,
what decks have you been playing?
>> Um, Teemo, Vex, and Leblanc mostly.
>> Yeah. And how are you finding Vex?
Obviously, Vex is one of the new
unleashed legends in Riftbound. And you
both play Vex, and we just saw Vex kind
of dominate against us, Ireelia.
>> Well, it's a funny story. So my son
borrowed the VEX deck I think Thursday
off a like a local player. He did very
well. And then my son was playing I was
like damn that Vex deck looks pretty
good. Like it was like I was watching
his game performing well. And then last
night um sorry on Friday my Pike deck
didn't go very well. And I was like I
don't know what to play and I said to my
son are you playing Leblanc or Vex? Cuz
he'd played a lot of Leblanc. And he's
like I'm going to go with Leblanc. I'm
like all right I'm going to use your Vex
deck. cuz um a friend went 5-0 in the
pre- tournament on Friday and we just
changed to uh Heath's deck. Heath, shout
out to Heath. So his list, he helped and
gave me some kind of notes kind of what
he he'd been playing Vex hardcore so he
kind of knew and gave me the gist and I
just been on the fly with it cuz um
yeah, I I haven't played Vex before this
week and this is my first tournament
with Vex. So
>> yeah. So I have a question then for
Noah. How do you feel now that your dad
has taken your Vex deck and now is
currently sitting at was it 91? Uh 10-1.
>> 10-1. Now, so how do you feel about
that?
>> At least he won and not someone else.
>> Um did you enter the competition as well
in the main event? How did you go?
>> Um for day one, yes, but not for day
two, sadly.
>> Well, you've got your dad here now to
keep cheering on. And uh I want to al
also ask you, so you're from Queensland,
but I also was chatting to you earlier.
Um what happened recently in Queensland
for yourself?
>> Oh yeah, we just relocated there. My son
just started high school, so it's been
really good. We're a part of helping out
car shop, so that's been that we opened
that last month, so that's been a bit of
chaos, but it's uh I'm enjoying it,
though. The hard part is uh it makes it
very hard to travel. Uh cuz yeah, we
need more stuff so we can stay open
while while we go play.
>> Do you want to shout out the card shop
or?
>> Uh yeah, it's it's card den. So yeah, we
rep that.
>> Nice.
>> I need some merch. I need to I need to
get organized and get some merch.
>> I mean, you aren't representing your
card shop very well currently in the
regional qualifier Sydney here. I also
have another question for the both of
you. I love having both of you up here.
I think it's a fantastic show of how
Rift Battle is for all ages and of
course is really fun to play. Do you
guys play by yourselves at home,
practice and build and uh plan things
together?
>> You guys,
>> yeah, we do that. Um just learning how
to play and designing new decks, see how
it fills them out.
>> Well, that that sounds wonderful. Being
able to play games with your family and
of course with your friends, I think
it's such a fantastic thing to do. And
in rift bound it's very much possible
you know opening packs together getting
excited over the game and everything
like that. I also want to talk about
some of the plays you made in that game.
I think one of the most standout plays I
gased from the backstage and I think the
casters also go as well. The ride the
wind and shadow combo was so fun to
watch. We loved it. Chat loved it.
Everyone loved it.
>> Yeah. I kind of So that was my first
time actually versing Aurelia with the
deck. So, but thankfully I played a lot
of Aurelia in set two, so I kind of knew
the gist of it. Uh, yeah, I was excited.
That's why we run two ride the winds. It
also combos well with Fizz.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh, I think one thing that was really
cool, I don't know if anyone really
knows, but game three, I didn't factory
recall his GA. Uh, I saved it and then
that closed out the game too, waiting
for that boots of swiftness because of
the the swing with the Yeah.
>> Well, your game was absolutely fantastic
to watch. It was an absolute joy. Thank
you so much both of you, Maverick and
Noah for joining us here on the
interview. Let's turn it back to the
casters.
>> I did notice actually that you didn't do
that. Uh just kind of felt like in that
spot you uh didn't really didn't really
mind that you were just already getting
a combat win of sorts with the unit
already being stunned.
>> Look, take the combat win. Absolutely.
>> And the other thing is it wasn't game
three, man. It was game two. You two
owed that man. I don't know if you know
that, but uh
>> wild
>> pretty uh rapidly approaching and not
only being a great dad, but uh perhaps
top eight competitor here at regional
qualifier Sydney.
>> We shall see. Queensland and Mario
Sydney RQ. We'll see as we have two
players here on our backup feature match
both X and X1 and one. Interesting. So,
records are starting to get a little bit
spicy. It is Kane on the left playing
Aurelia. Very confusing,
>> but SD Lovely Snow who eagleeyed viewers
may remember from a very, very, very
long time ago. But fun fact friends,
that man used to be a professional
jungler in League of Legends of a team
called Frenetic a very long time ago.
That was some of the first League of
Legends games I ever commentated in my
life.
>> Wow. So, you're coming full circle now.
Really?
>> Full circle. Full full circle.
>> Full circle. We're going full circle.
>> Full circle. Bit of a circus sometimes
here on this battlefield cuz there an
awful lot of units chilling as we're a
win up here for our Aurelia player. And
that Vexpathetic perhaps doing work
against the old sand soldiers. Very good
against Arise in particular.
>> Well, as I said, Vex in an Aurelia deck,
you're seeing it more and more. You see
chaos, you expect apathy. Apparently,
there's abandoned hall currently being
contested. There are a lot of dice on
the field. I have to imagine that is
some might counting.
>> Also good to see that scuttle crab
there. We've been seeing a lot of
scuttle crab today. I believe it was the
third most popular unit, which is very,
very surprising, but I love the crab
personally.
>> Everyone loves Seymour. Certainly been
uh showing up all weekend long here. So,
it looks like we're just resolving this
combat. I guess we'll have a look. All
right. What's going on here?
>> Trying to figure out whose adaptron that
is. I guess it has to be Aurelius cuz
there's a boots of swiftness under it.
>> That would make sense.
>> That card is illegal in here.
>> So, Defiant Dance perhaps going to turn
the tides here cuz it's 5 6 7 8 9 plus
three with that BF sword. It is 12 power
plus the VI. So, Defiant Dance going to
try and equalize things. I believe the
stunned unit is the Adaptron,
>> but I don't exactly know. But plus two
for Vex, minus two.
for
>> VI and plus one more from the hall.
>> Little plus five action of your own.
>> A little bit of mathematics here.
>> Build your own Aurelia whenever you're
at abandoned hall. And then if you are
just I don't know go off.
>> Yeah.
>> What about if we did it again?
>> Is that abandoned in hand?
>> Yep. Abandoned. But that one is uh not
going to be
>> not going to be relevant. But the
defiant dance there.
>> Yeah, dancing. So,
>> and then a little shake of the head
there for a lovely snow
>> on team
>> there with a smile.
>> Team stack deck, I believe that's what
the ST represents. Pretty sweet
sweatshirt as well.
>> Caught it in the hall as I was walking
around.
>> But, uh,
>> collide over there.
>> Look, it's part of my job, I suppose, is
to read things at a rapid pace. Seven
might for Vi
>> and I think Vi must be the unit that
isn't stunned because uh, looks like Vi
is doing all the work in this combat
with Adaptron kind of pushed off to the
side.
chooses uh goes again.
>> Vex,
>> that is Vex. Adaptron goes bye-bye. And
Vex is going to
>> win the rest of the combat. It looks
like
>> cuz Vex is too big to be taken out after
all those all all that dancing.
>> All of the dancing. I can't imagine Vex
doing much of a dance. Just a very uh
reluctant one, maybe.
>> Yes. M
>> every now and then for those familiar
with League of Legends launches herself
about a screen and a half away.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh so you know she got that going for
her but uh
>> in this instance I think just uh
defiantly sitting on the battlefield
>> and uh getting more points five to five
now between these two as Vax Apathetic
is problematic.
>> Mhm.
>> Again generally when Azir is in spots
where they're behind you're looking to
play Arise get a bunch of sand soldiers
ready them and move them in. And that
does not work when Vex Apathetic is on a
battlefield.
>> Absolutely. And it does look like they
only have the sword as well equipment
wise.
>> Yeah, good enough to make it a five,
which would be enough to beat Vex
perhaps. But the ganking happens.
>> Mhm.
>> Point number six now. And it's six man
at the battlefield. Here's chilling at
the seed of power grabbing a card. Oh my
goodness. To find the third.
>> If the head shook for the first two, I
can't imagine what's going to happen for
the last one.
>> One, two, three, four.
Aia coming out.
>> And there's one card, one rune left
available. What could it possibly be?
>> What could that be?
>> What could it possibly be? We're ready.
We're channeling. We are getting got it
seems like on the Azia side.
>> Mhm.
>> Appreciate the yaps per minute, but
unfortunately that does not score points
in games of Riftbound.
genuinely struggling to think of
possible outs here. Threatening to hold
two
>> for the win here from six to eight.
There is no aspirants climb to trick me
this time.
>> Yeah, it does not look friendly there
for SD. Lovely snow.
>> I guess in theory
a BF sorted sand soldier could win a
combat against Aurelia and prevent you
from losing next turn. M but
>> doesn't really deal with the problem.
Vex is the problem.
>> Vex is definitely the problem there.
>> I've obviously uh we might get to talk
about abandoned hall Aelia finally if it
happens.
>> Let me tell you, but you're used to
doing regular Aelia math at home folks.
>> It gets very irregular with abandoned
hall.
>> I mean you're only thinking about two
cards here. Well, you're thinking about
three things. Ong guard, defiant dance,
or nothing.
>> Yep.
>> Those are the three options. Oh
goodness.
>> Lovely. Snow extends a fist bump and
Kane going to go to 9. One and one
>> in touching distance for top eight.
Don't know how draws are going to shake
out at the end of it all, but three
Defiant dances effectively in a row.
>> Goodness me. Oh, I mean look, it's a
very very decisive way to end this
matchup.
>> And once again, we see the power of Vex.
Apathetic and yet another. Didn't even
have Vex
>> as the legend this time around. didn't
need it as Kane takes a Don't know how
game one went, but that second game
looked rough by the end of it.
>> Yeah, look, you're right though. We get
to hear a little bit more about that
Aurelia abandoned hall interaction
potentially. And
>> you know what? We're here. Let's just
explain it. So, abandon hall. When you
play a spell, choose a unit here, give
it plus one. That is effectively the
text of the card. Now, you might all
remember actually that sounds a lot like
a card called Raven Bloom Student.
You're right. That is very similar text.
The difference is that Raven Bloom
Student, all that text is attached to
the unit itself. So, Raven Bloom Student
just looks at your spells and says,
"Hey, you played a spell. I'm going to
get a little bit bigger this turn."
Abandoned Hall gives you a choice. What
unit would you like to pick to get the
buff?
>> And who loves getting chosen more than
anybody else?
>> It's aia
Fervent loves to be chosen cuz when you
choose Aelia Fervent or when you ready
her, we'll give her a plus one might
this turn. And wouldn't you know it, if
you play, I don't know, a simple ong
guard perhaps with Aelia alone out of
other people. That's usually plus two on
its own. And then we choose Aurelia with
the ong guard. Well, that's plus one
more. So that's plus three. That seems
pretty good. Well, when abandon
triggers, it gives plus one. That's what
it does. It's like Raven Bloom student.
Um, but if you choose Aurelia, which you
did do,
>> you already did adding extra.
>> So that's five.
>> Suddenly getting very, very dominant
there.
>> Again, if we see Aelia, it's going to
come up at some point in this fight.
We'll see what happens in our next round
cuz we're getting awfully close to
crowning some people in our last eight
players. Don't go too far away. After
the break, we'll have more Riftbound.
A key component of playing League of
Legends is gathering XP and leveling up.
Now you can do that in Riftbound 2 with
the newest additions in Unleashed. Every
XP you get will add to your level as a
player and will benefit you in different
forms. So far, three legends have been
released that directly benefit from XP
gain. Kha'Zix Void Reva, Poppy, Keeper
of the Hammer, and Master Yi, Wu Jun
Master. Notice that all of these have
the body domain in common. Master Yi
uses XP passively. With higher level, he
finds stronger passive effects. At level
six, your units are permanently boosted,
and at level 11, your units always enter
ready. Of course, in the main deck, most
masteries will rely on the champion
unit, Master Yi, unstoppable as a win
condition. This one gets cheaper the
more XP you have, and at level 16, it
even becomes unargetable. Combined with
Master Y, Wu Master's ability to enter
ready, he can really swing games.
Kha'Zix and Poppy have the unique
ability to gain XP through their own
legend abilities and otherwise use it
like a resource. While Poppy generates
card advantage by spending XP, Kha'Zix
gains utility by either buffing his
units or moving exhausted units away
from their battlefields back to base.
Since all of these three legends have
the body domain in common, there's a
huge variety of body cards that can get
you the XP you need through the hunt
keyword, for example. Hunt cards grant
you an XP whenever you conquer or hold.
So, winning combats for those decks is
of utmost importance. Cards like Gemand
Hunter, Boracious Gromp, and Master Heat
Tempered can be found in all three
decks, but XP can also be splashed into
other decks. Grim Resolve, for example,
is a strong combat trick that gives the
unit free might on action speed. If the
unit wins a combat, it grants you two
XP. This card might find its way into
other decks as well. Fiora players have
already played around with the
Shepherd's Heirloom, which works like a
Dorance Blade, but does not equip for
power cost, but for XP. There are plenty
of ways to integrate some XP gain into
your decks. So get those level in and
scale into the late game. Riftbounders,
>> we are here at the RQ in Sydney. I am
joined by Prismat, fresh off a win in
Atlanta. How are you feeling about
Sydney?
>> I really enjoy it here. The weather's
been really nice. I like the wildlife
and so far it's been going all right. I
think maybe a bit jet-legged. I think
I'm not playing amazingly. 3 and one so
far in the pre-RQ, but it's all right.
Got to get the losses out of the way
today and then do well in the main event
>> as long as you get them over and done
with now. And you do still have the jet
lag to contend with. So, how recently
did you get in?
>> I got in yesterday morning, so Thursday
morning. Today's Friday, and it it
hasn't been I haven't felt bad, but
gameplay has has felt bad. So,
>> well, there's a whole weekend ahead and
there's plenty to see how it's going.
How are you feeling with everybody here?
>> Oh, it's nice. Yeah, everyone traveling
out from different parts of the world.
Allan coming from Europe. Randy, I mean,
he's kind of living in China at this
point, so it's a bit easier of a trip
for him. Uh, but yeah, seeing everyone
again, and then we'll see each other all
in Vancouver as well.
>> And obviously, we've just had Unleashed
release. How does that change how you're
approaching Sydney compared to how your
decks have been in the past?
>> Uh, honestly, it feels for me similar to
Le where I settled on Annie. I feel like
the deck is good. I know that I'm not
going to have any really bad matchups,
so I can always play my way out of any
match to be able to win. Um, but it's
not like I'm super confident. I think
when I was going into Atlanta, I was
thinking, "Okay, my my deck's the best
deck." And Allan saying, "Yeah, your
deck's still the best deck." And maybe
starting to believe him over time. I
think Diana's also really strong. Um,
but it is really interesting cuz there's
a limit to how much you can prepare for
each matchup. Like you can say, "Okay,
we expect these decks to be the the top
percentage, top meta decks coming in."
Like Aurora is a big one. Um, I think
today there's a lot of Master Yi and
Aurelia, which is a bit surprising
because they don't have very good Aurora
matchups. Um, but, you know, prepare
against the the expected matchups and
then the rest of them you just have to
go on the fly.
>> Well, we will see what happens. Uh,
we'll see whether it comes down to Annie
and Diana. Who knows? Maybe. We'll see
how it goes. We've got a whole weekend
ahead of us. Thank you so much and good
luck.
>> I'm here at the Sydney Riftbound
Regional Qualifier. Right before the
weekend kicks off, I have the one and
only Alan Tiku. Alan, how are you doing
in the preq?
>> Uh, wonderful. Lack of sleep doesn't
stop me from just winning back to back
so far the runs and hopefully it follows
up until tomorrow. So, how you feeling
about your deck? You have changed
legends but not uh domains and we kind
of knew this was coming. How's Diana
treating you?
>> Uh, very good deck is so good. I think
it's like the second best deck in format
right now.
>> What's the best deck then?
>> Ani
better than any player on your team
maybe that we'll be seeing around. most
certainly you will he will swap
eventually to the same domains in
different champion but for this event
there was a bit short of time on the for
the practice because uh we just finished
Atlanta and then we had to travel so and
we had literally one week to practice
and we just stick to what we know uh but
for the next events we'll definitely be
mixing up.
>> How have we been feeling about Unleash?
Obviously set very close to release kind
of with this event. How have you been
feeling about the shifts as set 3 joins
Riftbound?
>> Oh it's amazing. There is such a
widespread meta you get to play around.
so many things against so many things
and like it just diff so many different
play styles. It makes hard with the
current sideboard side to make a deck
that's going to be all around deep
decent into everything. You have to
sacrifice the some matchups. Uh because
how like low on the cards you have in
just the cyber slots.
>> Of course, expecting a pretty diverse
metag game over the weekend. There are
40 legends now and obviously you're
chasing Diana. You went pretty well on
the Ezreal hunt. How's Diana going to go
in this season? Uh, I like I like the
deck to the extent where I think I could
go for four out of four on Diana. We'll
see how it goes on the event. I might
get humbled and the deck might actually
fall apart and like it might run out of
just the value in general. Maybe too
much tempo. We'll see. But, uh, as solid
this set as well, so worst case, it's a
fallback.
>> Best of luck. Have a great tournament.
Thank you so much.
It's so great having a little bit of
insight into what these top players are
thinking. Of course, we just got to hear
from Alan and Prismat in those
interviews. It's been amazing hearing
all the thoughts behind everyone here,
Logan.
>> Yeah, look, one of my favorite things
about these interviews with the winners
of these matches is we get to see their
insights. Sorry. We get to hear their
insights into the decisions of the cards
that they are playing and why they think
they have those values in those decks
that they're building.
>> Yeah. I mean, we just heard from Alan in
that interview. He thinks Diana is the
second best. And what I loved hearing
from him is he thought he thought Annie
was the best deck at the moment. And
that makes me feel pretty good about my
prediction earlier.
>> Yeah, look at that. Ricey, the absolute
number one superstar when it comes to
guessing predictions here, but we take a
quick squeeze at this deck and the
representation as a reminder at the end
of day one. Ry,
>> yeah, this is day one's metag game. We
can see of course Leblanc was the most
chosen legend 88 total is 7% share
Ireelia following somewhat close behind
6% and Masi we've been seeing so many
mas throughout both days.
>> Yeah, one thing that's really really
apparent right now is that Aurelia is
still strong that LeBlanc currently 10
and0 undefeated and Aurelia is out there
10 undefeated as well. So really really
loving that performance from Ghostaster
Driver. Hopefully we do get to see him
on the feature tables. But take another
look at the lower half.
>> This is now day two's meta game. And
interestingly, Master He is now the top.
It wasn't a top in day one, but the
conversion rate on Master is really
strong. 24 total now at 12% share up
from quick quick remembering it was 6%
from day one.
>> Day one. Yeah, definitely a much better
showing. And as you said that conversion
rate really really high for this Master
Yi. A lot of the Master Yi decks that we
are seeing is that mid-range not that
Aurora. So Aurora players, you know,
they're out there. The Civer potential
Fiora potential Poppy. However, you'll
love to see the unleashed legends making
an appearance in this top eight in day
two. I mean, we can't not talk about
Leblanc with all the really fun,
exciting plays that she has and new
mechanics that came through with
Unleashed.
>> Yeah. No, so Leblanc really indexes
heavily into that sort of temporary into
that death nail. Really brought a lot of
origin cards up into relevancy that
Carus as well as a spear forge glass
mixologist. So, one of my favorite
things about that Leblanc deck is all
three sets so far are extremely relevant
in her.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I love the way that the the
copies the reflection token units are
played as well. And you can have so many
copies of really really strong units and
make your deck do whatever you want.
>> Yeah, with four of the top eight being
unleash legends, it just really spreads
that meta share. It proves the diversity
of this game. With 40 legends here in
Rift, with the release of Unleashed,
there is a legend for everyone that
matches and suits your play styles. And
you can see people are jumping on board
these new legends as well and showing
the world just what they can do.
>> I think also one key thing we need to
remember with these legends there is of
course that prize roll and the best of
and with unleashed now origins those
some of those are going to be
disappearing.
>> Yeah. When vendetta releases the next
set after unleash if we're going to look
ahead you will no longer be able to get
those origins or proving grounds metal
cards. So, right now is your best chance
if you're trying to get the medal cards,
the best ofves to get out there, get to
your summoner skirmishes, get those
buyers, and get to a regional qualifier
for your chance to get the Origins and
Proven Grounds medals.
>> Exactly. It is really exciting times at
the moment because everybody is vying
for those best of
going back to those legends. You said
there's a legend for everyone. I want to
maybe ask you what kind of legend in the
future, you know, we both play League of
Legends. Who are you maybe interested in
playing down the track?
>> Look, I'm a support main, so I would
love to play Nautilus, but I'm also
really enjoying the aggressive style of
decks that I'm finding, right? The three
decks that I currently have right now,
Kaiser, Aurelia, and Diana. So, I love
that sort of mid-range aggression, that
targeted removal from Kaiser. So, the
one I'm actually really looking forward
to is Akali coming with
>> Vendetta. That would be pretty exciting.
I think Akali would be quite aggressive
and be able to suit that sort of play
style. I personally am also a support
main. So my my
champions I love playing in League of
Legends is Saraka Pana and I also like
my Leona but I chose not to play Leona
in um in Riftbound but now I'm kind of
regretting it a little bit watching all
these amazing Leona out there. Yeah, we
did get to see L yesterday on Iona into
Diwali with that Zenith blade, that hook
tech that we do love to see here in
Riftbound. And um I love that we're both
support mains which explains how we're
able to support each other here.
>> And that Sarraa absolute beautiful
treatment in Spirit Forge there with
that spirit blossom skin line.
>> She is gorgeous. I have a really sad
story to say.
>> Hit me with it. But you got to cheer us
up at the end.
>> Okay, there was no cheering up at the
end. It's just it's gone from me. But I
went to my first pre- rift in Spirit
Forged and on my first night on that
pre-ift I was opening my cards and the
person next to me opened that card and
they opened that open numbered Soraka
but not Annie. It was the signature
Soraka sitting right next to me and well
he said I'm willing to sell it and I was
like do I do it? Do I do it? Do I do it?
And I hesitated and then I had to move
the next day. So it was a moving truck
and he went to the city and sold that
signature Saraka. So, it's been on my
mind ever since then. Like 3 months.
Wait, I can't do math. In fact, a long
time ago.
>> Yeah. And your story resonates with me
so much because that's my GG Easy Teemo
moment as well. That Nexus Knight promo
card from Origins, the Chase with that
GG easy in the background. I think I I
saw one and someone was like, "Oh, yeah,
you can grab this." And I was like, "Oh,
not for me right now." And now it's
almost out of reach. But these are
beautiful cards that we do see here in
Riftbound. And there are so many amazing
chase cards. And speaking of cards,
maybe we can guess the flavor text of
some of these cards.
>> Okay, let's do it. Production, if you're
ready, let's do some guess the flavor.
We got to see we got to do it earlier
yesterday and it was really fun.
>> How magic and conditioner. Something to
do with hair.
>> How magic magic and conditioner.
>> Oo, I'm thinking
>> I want to say serapene, but serapene is
not a drip down there. I know, but like
she will be in radiance, so it's like,
oh, that works so well for Sarapine.
>> Magic and conditioner. Who has crazy
hair?
>> No, no, no. She does. I don't think she
uses conditioner, though.
>> Yeah, you're right. It's sprites.
>> She was magic. It's just magic.
>> Oh, no conditioner. All right. That's
not Caitlyn. Caitlyn, you know, very
human, obviously. prone to those.
>> One thought I had was
maybe C hair's kind of crazy, but she's
not magic though.
>> Civer mercenary doesn't have that flavor
text.
>> There's also uh the So, there's a purple
and orange. I don't think either of
those. You know what? Full sand. How
magic and conditioner. I know it's not
Jinx. I know it's not Civer.
>> It might be just a normal unit.
>> It could be a common. It could be an
uncommon. Something a little bit lesser
known. You know what? I know it's not
right, but I'm gonna go with Inferno
just for the funsies. It's Inferno. Lock
it in, Eddie.
>> All right, I'm locking it in with you.
It's definitely someone with hair.
>> That's my That's my locker.
>> Unlike me.
>> Yeah.
>> Ultra soft.
>> I love them.
>> I didn't even know Porros could speak.
>> Magic hand conditioner. You love to see
it. That's why it's so soft.
>> It wasn't hair conditioner. It was like
the the softening conditioner that you
kind of use for like
I mean, it could be like dog conditioner
or whatever. Pearl conditioner.
>> Exactly. Exactly. We do have the next
one up, though. I feel like I've Oh,
echo.
>> I guess I like it. No, let's lock in
>> Ah, you were great.
>> No, no, no, no. Let me look into
>> Oh, no. You me.
>> Got you, mate.
>> No, I actually tried playing I don't
think it was this Zillian.
>> Yeah, this is the Zillian. This is the
Oh, it is a Zillian. Yeah.
>> Unleashed. Yeah. that lets you uh do
some copy shenanigans actually.
>> Yeah, I played that on my premise with
um Lilia and I tried to bring out more.
It didn't work out. I lost basically
most of mine, but it was prem. Everybody
was learning.
>> Hey, it was my domain. I was kind.
>> Yeah, there's no way they can hit us at
this distance.
>> Monster harpoon.
>> Ooh,
>> yeah. I'm locking it in. Fury monster
harpoon.
>> Okay. I don't want to You're You're
locked in.
>> I'm locked in. You got to get Yeah. Oh.
I was so expecting it cuz they got such
similar art as well.
>> It's It's red. It is.
>> Yeah. It's fury. I'm getting the
domains. I'm just not getting card.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> All right. Surely another one. We got
this one.
>> I genuinely hope we see Evelyn's cuz
Evelyn's is like fantastic. And I
already know that one. So, it'd be kind
of cheating if I see it and like, "Oh, I
know that one."
>> Yeah.
>> He's Ray is just sleepwalking to an art.
>> You guess
sleepwalking. So, it's probably someone
sleepy. Someone
No, I'm I'm not saying mine cuz then
you're just going to copy me.
>> Oh, someone who's who's unleashed. It's
unleashed.
>> It's unleashed.
>> Is it a common?
>> Uncommon.
>> I've started quizzing myself.
>> Okay.
>> Calm.
>> He almost has something to do with this
in his name.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> All right. I'm looking at Trevor Snooze
Bottom.
>> Oh, of course.
>> That's it. Come on, hit me with bottom.
>> Yes.
You never really been seeing him in the
games today, but I
>> do remember him cuz when I was doing my
pack opening, I would cover things and
try and remember what things were, and I
just
>> doesn't seem to be sticking. But
>> that's stuck with me. That one. Ah, I'm
up one. I feel good.
>> You're up one. I'm still at zero.
>> Hey, but one's good. I don't think the
other power have any.
>> I don't know. 1 Z going into game five
here. Undefeated right now.
>> Oh.
>> Oh. Oh. Um,
that could actually be Civer.
>> No, I I feel like
>> maybe Jinx. It's very Jinx energy.
>> I feel like
>> the jungler.
>> I actually feel like it's more of like
an uncommon or rare card rather than one
of the champion units.
>> I mean, Civer is rare.
>> Okay, fair.
>> Yeah, I'm going to lock in Civer, but I
don't know which one it is, whether it's
mercenary or the other one.
But because I know the name, I'm going
to go super mercenary.
>> I I feel like it's a bit too
places to go, people to gank kind of
type style.
>> And you know what? Super can't be right.
She's an AD in the bot lane.
>> This is a jungle focused set. Ganking is
a jungle mechanic.
>> Maybe it's like Rengar.
>> Doesn't Rengar just go?
>> He's going to ambush from a bush.
>> Places to go, people to gank. It's
definitely not my even though he does
ganking. That's not his style.
>> Got to lock in a guess here. Ricey.
>> Okay, I'm going ring. I don't care
which. There's like so many rangers in
the game. One of them.
>> Oh, I thought I thought it was a common.
>> No, it doesn't help.
>> Water fully from Origins. Got us with
the old school tech there. Look out.
>> When I am buffed, I have ganking.
>> That makes sense to me. It's in the
flavor text. It's in the card mechanics
rice. Today I am the guest, the flavor
tech champion 1 Z. Thank you very much.
>> My card George just contested.
>> Oh god. I thought it too early.
>> You did. Maybe this is mine. This is
mine here.
>> You're still in the game.
>> Are you going to be the one to tell him
he's not scary? Oh,
>> why do I think it's like the N the um
what's the N's ability code where we
like
>> Wallops?
>> No, not Walop.
>> Primal strength.
>> Primal strength. Primal. No, I don't
think it's primal strength. You're going
to be the one to tell him he's not
scary.
>> God, I can see the card art in my head.
>> Oh, you know it.
>> I know the card, but the name just is
escaping.
>> Hey, describe it to me. I'll give you a
half a point if you get it.
>> Are you going to be the one? I feel like
it's Fury.
>> Mhm.
>> Production's probably already laughing
cuz they have they know the card. They
know if I'm wrong or right. They're
like, "Haha, this guy."
>> It's not Fury. It's actually Chaos, you
know.
>> Is it?
>> No, I don't know. You already know it.
Uh, man, are you going to be the one to
tell him it's not scary? Uh, it's not
Evelyn. I know her flavor text off the
top of my head. I love that flavor text.
Uh, it's not Synra. It's not Vex. Cuz
Vex is talking about apathy. Um, Criy. I
don't even I don't even know who to lock
in for this one.
>> Um, well, you got to lock in someone.
Maybe it's not Noturn. I was like scary.
No, it's not. Definitely not Noturn.
>> Yeah. Are you going to be the one to
tell him he's not scary? Oh, it's not um
uh there's that Damascian unit in order,
>> but she gives her life and her legacy.
That's definitely not her cuz the play
is about life and legacy.
>> Um
>> are you going to be the one?
>> Can we get clues? I don't even possible
here.
>> It should be like how you play, you
know, Rift tool online. It should be
like as you say that then show a little
bit more. Show a little bit more and
then you know I like
>> rift. At what percentage do you do you
recognize? You're going to be the one to
tell me it's not scary.
>> I'm going to lock in.
>> Can I just say I don't know. You know
what? I like I'm
>> Oh, okay. Production saying we cannot
I'm going to say I'm just going to say
primal strength. I said it earlier. I
know it's primal strength.
>> It's not primal strength, but I'm going
for it.
>> Locking something in.
>> Oh, you know what? I think it's calm. I
think it's
>> meditating or something.
>> No, no. It's also a y.
>> Okay. Uh, I think she's I forget her
name. I know her art. She's like, uh,
it's not the backy cheer squad. Um, I do
think she's unleashed.
>> The name eludes me. I'm going to look in
Darius just to have the guess. I know
I'm wrong, but I want to see the card.
>> What is the card?
>> You're going to be the one to tell him
he's not scary.
>> A, how cute. It was chaos.
>> It was when I attack. You may pay one to
move an enemy unit here to its base.
Listeners Po, are you going to be the
one to
>> I would never tell him.
>> No, I would never.
>> I would never tell him he's not scary.
But enough of the guess the flavor here.
We're going to throw to a short break
and we'll be right back with the next
game.
Hello Rift Bounders. Are you wondering
how the game developed with Unleashed?
Let me give you a little introduction.
The calm domain has reinvented its
defensive capabilities. With powerful
pump spells and counter spells, calm
decks were already good at contesting
their battlefields, but with unleashed,
holding the fields becomes a whole lot
stronger. A standout example for this is
back off. Three energy, no power. This
card on action speed stuns a unit and
draws a card if played from hand.
Incredible. But leaving three runes open
isn't always an option. Luckily, you can
also hide this card if your runes are
exhausted or you want to keep them open
for another card. Fury, on the other
hand, brings plenty of new ways to
assert pressure onto your opponent.
Every jungler's dream is coming true
with smite, finding a new way to remove
units. It simply deals three damage to a
unit at a battlefield for two energy and
one power. While those stats are not too
impressive, the unit will also be
banished when it would die. This takes
powerful death nail effects out of the
equation and can also remove follow-up
if your opponent relies on resources
from their trash like Fiora worthy that
can't be played through spectral matron
anymore. Order has been known for its
hard removal and kill spells. Now, what
if I told you that you can remove your
opponent's hand as well? Ash Focus gives
you full information about your
opponent's hand and lets you banish a
card of choice for five energy and one
power. They will get it back as soon as
they hold a battlefield. But with full
information in one card less in the
opponent's hand, it's now on you to not
let that happen. Chaos has been
chaotically bouncing cards left and
right, pushing them front and center.
And now you will also be able to reach
the opponent's units in base. Starcross
reaction speed removal is revolutionary,
especially when it hits the base as
well. For three energy and one power,
you can return a friendly and an
opposing unit back to the owner's hands.
While this can give you an incredible
advantage with play effects, it also
disturbs your opponent. It slows them
down massively and can sometimes deny
powerful effects like Elder Drankren's
passive kill ability. While this domain
has already been good at controlling the
opponent's units, the Mind is now
finally greater than the sword. The Mind
domain receives a fantastic gear removal
card. Turn to Dust will turn any gear
into a temporary problem for two energy
and no power cost. While it does not
immediately help you remove units that
are boosted by equipment gear, you can
easily take care of seals, dazzling
aurora, or other great gear that stands
in your way. Now, what's scarier than
body units that are standing on your
opponent's side of the field just
waiting to overwhelm you with their
physical prowess? The ones you didn't
see coming.
Ringa Trophy Hunter has to be on your
opponent's mind at all times. Every time
your opponent feels secure about the bot
states, the Apex Predator could be
played on a battlefield where they have
units for five energy and one power,
either as an ambush or reaction speed to
support your other attacking or
defending units, or as a lonely attacker
straight from hand with its powerful six
smite. What cards do you think are going
to see the most play? And which domain
do you like the most after Unleashed?
show us at their next tournament.
>> We are down here at the Sydney AQ. I am
joined by the incomparable Dave Guskin.
How has it been being in Sydney so far?
>> Uh, good. I arrived yesterday morning.
Uh, it was very long flights and then I
had to work all day, but it's been
really great. All the people are really
friendly. Um, got to go out to a game
store last night. It was really fun.
>> Awesome. And how has the reception been
like in Sydney? Obviously, this is a
huge event. So many people here.
>> Yeah, I heard there's maybe 1,600ish
people in the main event. Very exciting.
Um, yeah, everyone seems really excited.
A lot of high energy around Riftbound,
around Unleash, so really cool to see.
Yeah.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And are you going to
do a little bit of exploring around
Sydney while you are here?
>> I don't know if I have time this trip.
It's kind of a quick turnaround. I'm
here at the event for most of the time,
but um I want to come back. So hopefully
we'll do more events in the future here
and I'll be able to come back. So yeah.
>> And obviously we are so close to just
having Unleash release. How has that
changed the game for you guys at the
moment?
>> Yeah. So, Unleash has been really really
good reception. I think um set over set
there's like more players, there's more
people buying product. It's really
great. Um I think Unleash is a little
bit of a shakeup. You know, there's a
lot of new mechanics. Um we'll see if it
kind of like disrupts the metag game in
significant ways. Um obviously a lot of
power to the Aurora decks. Um some
interesting kind of new builds with XP.
So, we'll see. Yeah, it's kind of
exciting to see.
>> So, with the main event coming tomorrow,
do you have a gut instinct on what we're
likely to see a lot of given the
release? Um, I would guess the most
prevalent deck is are Dazzling Aurora
decks. Um, you know, Elder Dragons,
really, really strong. Um, I think that
there's a lot of interesting kind of
like purple X builds. Um, I think a lot
of interesting Leblanc builds, so I
probably expect those to be uh lots of
people playing them. What what will win,
I don't know. Um, but that's kind of
what I think the field's going to look
like.
>> Awesome. Well, at this point, it is
still anyone's game. We'll see how it
goes, but thank you so much and we'll uh
we'll see what happens.
>> Welcome to Riftbound Basics. This time
we are talking about legends, chosen
champions, and signature spells. The
heart of your deck is your legend. This
determines which domains you are allowed
to play in your deck. Let's take Kaisa,
daughter of the void, as an example.
With her as your legend, you can play
cards from the fury and mind domains and
consequently fury and mind runes. You
also have the option to play a chosen
champion unit, Kaiser Survivor or Kaiser
Evolutionary. At the start of the game,
you can take this unit from your main
deck and place it in the chosen champion
unit zone right next to your legend. You
can play this card from this zone at any
time as if it were a normal card from
your hand. If it dies, it does not
return to the zone, but goes to the
trash. Another important factor in
deciding which legend to play is the
signature card. Even if the domains
match, you can only play this card in
the main deck of the corresponding
legend. For Kaiser, this would be
Atheian Rain, which you couldn't play in
a rumble deck, even though it's also
fury and mind. Which legend do you like
best? And is there one you only play
because their signature spell is so
good? Let us know in the comments.
We are back here about to enter into
round 12 of the regional qualifier.
Sydney, we've had so many games today so
far and of course yesterday as well,
Logan, where we have been seeing the
best of the best, not just in Australia,
but all around the world of players have
been traveling here to Sydney to
compete.
>> Yeah, like you said earlier, QA from New
Zealand. We've got several from China
here, even the esports team EDG. We've
got several Europeans. We've got several
Americans. But most of all, we've got
Aussies to boot. Rossy,
>> we do. Lots and lots of Australians
flying in from Queensland, Melbourne,
locals here in Sydney as well. Even some
from Perth are here as well to compete.
>> Yeah, they've definitely made the
journey. They've gone the distance for
Riftbound's first Southern Hemisphere
regional qualifier here in Sydney for
2026, Ricey. And so far, the games, the
quality level, it's up there. It's
contesting with the best.
>> We are doing so well here and and it's
it's great to see all these
international giants coming down and
playing with I would like to say our
giants of Australia as well. You look
pretty excited. Let's see what this
matchup is going to be.
>> Yeah. So, this is going to be an Aurelia
there for Gaster Driver on the right. Uh
but unfortunately, I don't know what
GT86 is currently using as his legend.
This is an undefeated Aurelia. actually
got out onto the floor and was able to
have a quick chat to him. But he also
topped forward on Victor in Bologna. So
this guy is a quality player and it
looks like Diana Scorn of the Moon is
the opposing legend.
>> Diana versus Ireelia. I mean these are
two giants of a legend as well. These
these legends are considered one of the
best decks currently in the meta. Yeah,
I mean I was saying it obviously I've
predicted Diana, but I fully expect
Aurelia to still be very very strong
here in Unleashed. She actually got some
really powerful battlefield upgrades and
we're seeing it here. Aurelia Blade
Dancer that legend making a deep deep
undefeated run in this champion Sunday
matchup here. Yeah, this legend and of
course as you said those battlefields
they're able to boost and protect the
queen of that is of course the chosen
champion Ireelia or potentially the
Raven Bloom student quite a lot of
options and we always talk about the
abandoned hole and everything as well
who can also keep these uh cards very
strong.
>> Yeah, Raven Bloom student of course
being that mind unable but I think you
were referring to Diana no longer human
also in that chaos domain able to be
buffed up with those spells. I
definitely love the energy. Definitely a
card that you can play around and and
beef up and protect with those spells
like you were saying.
>> Exactly. Which is what GT86 is going to
be playing that Diana and with all those
spells can boost that. Well, Ireelia as
you said is a very strong contender
still in this meta.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Aurelia making deep
deep runs. We've also got Diana here,
which is uh obviously my prediction. And
uh we'll take a look at the matchup in a
minute. There is the Diana deck list of
nice boy. And we do see here some
unleashed tech unleashed that moonfall
that new signature spell that Vex
apathetic and one of your favorites
there Ricey in the bottom left corner.
>> Yeah, that star cross is here as well.
Oh, we got also Vex Cheers and Vex
Apathetic. Both the purple vexes, the
chaos vexes are in this deck. Of course,
that abandoned hole I was talking about
is in play in Diana. You don't not want
to have a bandit hole when you're
playing Diana. Also, Hay is also, I
would say, a staple of a Diana deck.
>> 100%. Hey, Hay. I put the W in the wrong
place. It's a staple. Hey, but one thing
that I'm loving, right, and I'm not a
professional player, but I've got Vex
Apathetics and Vex Chiluses in my Diana
deck. So, I'm like justification
because the pros are running it here as
well. But interesting piece here is that
frigid jewel. That's not something we
get to see too often. Now, we do take a
look at Ghostaster Aurelia deck. still
very much as you said before a protect
the queen build with a small amount of
unleashed upgrades.
>> Yes, exactly. With um Ireelia that is
the queen and you get to choose already
give it plus one and also with that
abandoned hall it can trigger multiple
times buffing and increasing the might
of Aurelia to enormous amounts.
>> Yeah, that abandoned hall obviously when
you play a spell you may pick a unit
here and give it plus one might.
Obviously that Aurelia Ferven is the one
that's going to be sitting there. When
you choose her, she gets the one might.
When you actually buff her, she gets
that might as well. She's already
Aurelia. She's just a monster. We all
know her. We all love her. We saw plenty
of her in Spirit Forge. But Ricey, we're
on the play. We're here in game one of
the best of three matchup of round 12.
>> 110 each. Nice boy driver. We have the
best in the building currently according
to the score line fighting off against
each other. the Diana versus Ireelia as
well. Kind of the the queens of the
current set as well. It is quite
exciting to see. First turn of course is
going to be played by Nice Boy going
first going to be using both of those
range to play that Raven Bloom student.
>> I will be interested to see though if
they play them like the League of
Legends champions. Diana a very very
effective jungler but can also be in
that mid lane to get that early tempo or
ghost driver on that Aurelia in the top
side plays that sort of island style
builds up the deck before sweeping
through the rest of the battlefields and
conquering to victory
>> in goes that Raven Bloom student of
course onto Abandoned Hole because Raven
Raven Bloom student loves spells and so
does abandoned hole easily going to be
able to conquer that ghost drive has
nothing to respond. Yeah, abandon hall.
A great one to sit that Raven Bloom
shooting on. You really want to be able
to pump that Raven Bloom up and over
what it really wants to do. Both of
these decks presenting very pumpheavy
styles here. More spells, more might.
Out comes Diana on nice boy's turn.
Going to be playing that from that
chosen champion unit spot. When a
showdown begins here, you may pay one if
you do predict and then you can reveal
the top card of your main deck if it is
a spell draw. This Diana card is really
good at curating the deck that he that
nice play has hands in hand.
>> Yeah, definitely wants to filter,
definitely wants to control the cards
that this Aurelia player here, sorry,
the Diana player is going to be seeing
next with that sort of the predict
mechanic that we do see on Diana Lunari
with those abandoned halls as well as
the spell pumps. We do get to see a lot
of spell slinging coming out of these
decks as a rele fervent moves in. We did
have ghost driver ghosta driver bringing
in that tie turner onto sunken temple
getting themselves that conquer point.
And now Ireelia fervent is going to be
seated on that temple. And of course
Aurelia gets really buff if you let her
get buffed. Also going to be hiding a
card there at that temple as well.
There's a lot of options of course in um
an Aurelia's deck, but it could be
another tie don could be something else.
>> Something you said there though.
>> Yeah.
>> Aurelia Fervin. Yeah,
>> she's on her throne. She is the queen.
>> She is the queen.
>> That's it. You said she's sat on her
throne. And up top that throne, she
shall remain for now as nice boy on the
play moves in with Diana Lenari
>> goes in with Diana is going to also
exhaust that legend which remember when
you exhaust it does use that uh resource
for themselves and also when Diana
starts a showdown can look and predict
and grab that card.
>> Yeah, great draw there getting stupify
off the top. Ghostaster driver though
will take that publicly available
information and write that down in his
notepad. So he does have that
information on one card in nice boy's
hand. But that's exactly what you want
>> instead of using that stify going for
that star cross and is going to be
targeting the rape and bloom student to
return to hand and going to be targeting
that paying that deflect cost as well.
Very very important to note with Aurelia
Fervent having deflect she's going to
cost one additional power to target and
uh that starross has resolved Raven
Bloom will be pumped as indicated by
Ghost to Driver for sorry return to hand
my mistake he did nice boy indicate
towards Raven Bloom student of Driver
obviously retreated that Aurelia to hand
and made sure the Raven Bloom did too.
>> Out comes August. This hidden card was
edge of nine ridge is a card a gear that
you can on reveal can actually equip it
immediately. But I mean if you're ging
that unit to hand that equipped is going
to equipment is just going to stand in
base.
>> Yeah definitely a great turn of play
there from nice boy going in with Dian
Linari with a full hand of runes able to
remove that Aurelia Fervin able to
remove that tide turner as well. Now
they did both go back to hand of ghost
to driver so he does have the option to
play them again. But if we can get a
peak, there's a ride the wind, there's a
flash, there's a stupify. Nice boy, he's
in a good position to control this game.
Ghostster driver has been set back a
little bit.
>> Nice boy has those two runes up, but
yeah, as you said, Ghost Driver has been
set back. Doesn't have any units
currently in base to coner to con to
start a showdown with Diana. But I mean
there are options of course that go to
driver could go for if he wanted to
potentially ready that Ireelia which is
what I believe is happening right now.
>> Yeah. One thing that I do love about
that Ireelia legend is when you choose
them you can pay that one uh sorry the
rune and get that readied unit up. It is
that second half of the Aurelia Legend
ability and it reads when you conquer
you may pay one to ready me but when you
choose a friendly unit you may exhaust
me and pay one recycled rune to ready
it. which is exactly what they've done.
So, back on the board.
>> Back on the board and was able to win
that showdown. Nice was trying to ride
the win and save that Diana, but was not
able to cuz Driver used that defy and
that pumped up Airelia with the edge of
knight as well. And of course, a plus
two from targeting Aurelia twice there
readying and then also with the edge of
knight had that plus two went in quite
strong.
>> Yeah, definitely had the might to
overcome that. That defy obviously
helpful to keep Aurelia sticky on that
battlefield and that sunken temple
because she'll be mighty when she
conquers. If Ghost of Driver had that
rune available, he could pay the one to
draw that card here as we do see Ghost
Driver. Looks like he's channeled his
two runes, drawn the card, and he's
ready to go here. I feel like that was a
really quick turn. Yeah, go to driver
has ready now wondering how do I want to
potentially hold up on silken temple a
bit more maybe go to abandoned hole he
has obviously these options in his hands
I can't see what he's holding at the
moment I do see that defian dance though
is available to him but that's not what
he's holding
>> the reason it was so quick is nice boy
played that way out and then pass nice
boy doing some really quick clean hand
gestures to indicate yep that's going to
work yep that resolves and so it's
creating this nice cycle between
Ghostaster and nice boy where it's just
quick clean comms and they're able to
play this one out quickly.
>> Love the way that go driver did that. He
brought out that Titan and of course on
play you can exchange a position of uh
with another unit. Ireelia being ready
does go in onto abandoned hole and gets
that conquer point now. Nice boy here on
three points is going in with a when
moves get to draw one discard one. I
don't think he's discarded just yet. So
of course if he discards a spell he gets
to draw another card. If he discards a
gear he gets to ready up two runes. But
maybe in this situation, he wants to
discard a unit and give him plus three
to get him onto eight might.
>> Dare I say definitely wants to discard a
unit here. That Aurelia currently
sitting at 10 might. And Ghost Driver
has two runes available and like you saw
before does have that defined dance.
They've both passed focus. It's back to
nice boy right now.
>> Going to be discarding a very expensive
unit. That is the mind splitter. I I
reckon I don't know how Nismo feels
about losing that mine so that maybe
hopefully getting another one. Maybe has
another one in hand. You never know.
>> He definitely valued that Fizz a bit
more. There's the stupify.
>> Yep. Stupify happens. Going to be minus
one might on the Aelia. Also gets that
card draw as well.
>> Yeah, Aurelia though with the minus one.
Currently 10 minus one will take Aurelia
to nine. Quay currently only eight.
>> So the might being presented is still in
Gaster Driver's favor. However, both
players,
>> no, only Ghostster has runes available.
There's the Defant Dance.
>> Yeah, we did see that Defant Dance was
in the hand of Ghost Driver and as you
said, has those runes available and will
be able to define dance givea even more
might and of course reduce the might of
that Hay.
>> Yeah, not only reducing it by two on the
Hi side, but this is where that
abandoned hall tech comes in so so
strong. When you choose the Aurelia, she
actually gets that plus three might, but
because of the abandoned hall, you give
that might to Aurelia. It's a six might
swing. Four in the favor of Aurelia.
Negative -2 to the detriment of that
way. Just overwhelming with that might
differential there. Nothing nice boy can
do. Had no runes there to respond.
However, Nice Boy now on the play does
have a full sway of runes down there. I
think that is five. We're looking at
three in Chaos 2 in mind. And
considering his options, we do see that
he has that fizz in hand. So, he will be
able to recur from the trash. Currently
possibly not going for that option. Oh,
there it is. There's a fizz.
>> It is the fizz. You were calling it and
going to be looking through that trash
trying to find a good card. And I mean,
ride the wind. It's a try. It's a trude.
It's It's a really good card to use, of
course, to bring a unit up wherever you
want it really. You get to of course
move a unit and uh ready it.
>> Yeah, move a friendly unit and ready it.
So it cannot target that Aurelia which
is a critical piece of information here
for this one. That Fizz on the board,
the ride, the wind was what was picked
up here by that Fizz, which is just so
powerful. You're able to start to loop
those spells. You may play a spell from
your trash with energy cost no more than
three, ignoring its energy cost.
>> You can see, of course, Fizz is ready
and it goes in onto that tie turner.
Three to two. Quick math. The three is
bigger than the two. Nice by wind out on
that conquer goes back into base because
remember ready from right the wind and
is now safe.
>> That's it. Always great to be able to
conquer and return to base. However, not
able to take any benefit from that
sunken temple trigger. Was not mighty at
the time of conquering. And even if it
was, didn't have any runes available to
pay that one energy for the card draw.
Does play a Raven Bloom student though
to end the turn. So he could have
actually gone for it. Wasn't mighty.
goes for the Raven Bloom and just
presents a couple units in that base
there. Ricey,
>> a few cards in hand for Nice. I do see
the uh the stacked deck and the flash
cards that may be useful in the future,
but of course it is Ghost of Driver's
hand right now. Turn and we can't see
his hand at the moment considering a
card trying to look around the corner
trying to see what he's holding.
>> Yeah, he was just having a quick flick
through his trash. There are a few cards
in there. There's a hard bargain in nice
boy's hand. That sneaky deck hand
though,
>> it's a bit annoying when you're versing
a sneaky deck hand because they can play
to an open battlefield. Meaning go to
driver doesn't even have to wait the
next turn for it being ready or try and
spend extra things to ready it up and or
come accelerated. It goes straight to
that open battlefield getting ghost
driver now onto six points. Ireelia also
comes back away from hole keeping that
queen safe. Yeah, go to driver there
reading the next play from nice boy.
Wants to remove Aurelia from the
battlefield protecting her only having
two runes open. Likely shows to nice boy
he just doesn't have the answers in
hand. So would prefer to remove her to
safety. Nice boy moves in.
>> Moves in with that Fizz once again. Fizz
even though it's a small unit three is
still bigger than two. Ghost of Driver
did have two runes up but didn't decide
to do anything to keep sneaky deck hand
alive. Maybe didn't have anything in
hand. And that conquer point goes to
Fizz now sitting at five points. Nice
boy does have that Raven Bloom student
and is not going to go for pattern hole
and is instead going to the sunken
temple.
>> He's going to be de he's doing it. I was
just about to find that Moonfall.
>> I think he's indicated towards Aurelia.
So you'll have to pay that deflect cost.
>> Yep, that is two recycling of the runes
right now. Moonfall, you get to choose a
battlefield where you have units. you
move up to one enemy unit to that
battlefield and give all the enemy units
there minus two this turn. So Ireelia of
course is the target has paid the
deflect cost but it's going to get
defied. It is below the defy limit.
>> Yeah, defy limit for energy and the one
>> bargain
>> potent. There it is. Doesn't have the
ability to respond to it.
>> So Ireelia does go up into that
battlefield is going to be minus two.
And of course Raven student is quite
happy with the spells being used.
>> Has been pumped. We do see Aurelia with
that minus two. A total of four might
presenting whereas Raven Bloom on its
own is four. Fizz with that three as
well. So will win that trade. I think
Ghost of Driver here though decides to
allocate to that Fizz going into the
trash here.
>> Fizz in the trash. But that is Ireelia
out of the game now. Ghost of Driver has
no units currently on the playing field
right now. Has to try and figure out
what do I do here? I mean if they have
another sneaky deck hand can go onto
that abandoned hole but looks like it's
just a discipline going to be of course
disciplining the raven balloon the only
target just for that card draw.
>> Yeah both of these players they are
closing in goes to driver at those six
victory points only needs to get that
sort of double conquest wingcon which
Aurelia is so so capable of but that
Aurelia now in the trash unable to
return to the base right now. Go to
driver is developing his board. Has some
pieces of gear. Nice boy also on six
victory points though. This is a close
one here. Ricey. They are racing to the
finish. Stack deck happen. I believe he
picked up a ride the wind there as well.
Has I think two flashes of ride the wind
looking potentially to go and conquer
that abandoned hole. Actually before
that bringing out another Raven Bloom
student. Go for the double conquer
potentially next turn.
>> That's what they have to build for.
That's what they have to develop for
here. Nice boy positioned well. Yes,
there's some flashes and ride the winds,
but it's minimal aggression. All he
could do at best is pump over the top.
And it looks like they've conceded. Goes
to driver hands this one to nice boy
taking game one of our first here in our
best of three match.
>> 11 and zero. Both of these two players
are nice boy with that Diana is going to
take game one here with of course that
abandoned whole battlefield. I I we can
see of course Ghost of Driver was not
able to take that game out, close it out
because no units in hand. You cannot
conquer without any units. Well, nice
boy had those two units and was easily
going to be able to conquer that next
turn.
>> Yeah, he was definitely presenting those
answers. And I just saw a sticker on the
top of Nice Boy's cap says made in
Canada. So, it makes me wonder if this
gentleman is actually from Canada. We'll
have to find that one out. That is just
another international guest that we have
here present in Riftbound regional
qualifiers Sydney as we're just taking a
quick moment to sideboard
>> coaster driver. We did see obviously
that nice boy though has the vex cheless
and the vex apathetic neither of which
we saw because this aggressive Diana was
just able to get the job done into
Aurelia.
>> I like what nice boy is showing us. We
get to see a side board as well. I mean
>> that's the whole deck.
>> That is the whole deck we are seeing as
well. I mean, we get to see ghost driver
as well. I think we saw an unchecked
power in a sideboard, some chanted dots.
Obviously, you you put a few um gear
removals in your sideboard to deal with
a lot of decks that do like their gear.
>> Yeah. And traditionally, Aurelia always
love those swiftness boots. They love
those guardian angels. So, gear removal
is not uh remiss here. It could find
some value. Typically that gear removal
is indexed very heavily into the
Azutians, Jaxes and Auroras as we do get
that nice little graphic. Nice boy did
take that game one,
>> but I don't know if he values gear
removal that much when he can literally
just out fight Aurelia.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, I mean Diana is able to
present a lot of might in these combats.
Maybe doesn't want to get though that
gear removal, but it does exist. So does
a few other things as well. Looking at
that, that was the unchecked power I was
seeing. What else do you think you'd
want to put into from the sideboard?
>> Yeah, look, unchecked power being seven
energy, two power could absolutely blow
out an Aurelia board. You don't have to
pay that deflect cost either because
it's not targeting her. It's actually
just a sweeper that catches everything.
However, I don't think that's a good
pick. Aurelia is very traditionally only
a one very tall unit, not a wide
multi-unit style of deck here. As the
Battlefields have been placed, it looks
like they are getting ready here for
game two of our best of three matchup in
round 12 at the Riftbound regional
qualifier in Sydney. I think I'm saying
that quite a bit.
>> Yeah, I mean we're pretty excited to
have this uh regional qualifier here
down in Sydney. It's fantastic to see
all these amazing players and we have
had one abandoned hole in the hands of
the Diana. We haven't had the other
abandoned hole from uh Ireelia yet.
>> Yeah, the abandoned hall was on both uh
their main board texts here. We do see
there's also the option of the Raven
Bloom Conservatory and Targon's Peak for
Diana now being up on that game one. And
we do know Targon's pick when you
conquer here ready two runes at the end
of the turn. So that will leave that
Diana in a very advantageous position
able to sort of respond to anything this
Aurelia player might want to bring.
Obviously having those sort of hard
bargains able to counter those options
as well.
>> It's also interesting because both of
these players do have Targon Tarans Peak
in their deck. So we could have a mirror
match of the Tarans Peak Battlefield. I
mean, could also have that um one of the
other options as you said, the Raven
Bloom Conservatory or of course the
abandoned hole, but these two decks,
they have very similar battlefields
because they both love these spells.
>> Yeah, they both love pumping units up
and over their opposing enemies, right?
And so, it's almost like who can have
more pump spells. I think Aurelia is
going to pump harder and faster just
because of that native. And there it is,
the double target matchup.
>> Pretty exciting. Taran's peak. I mean,
we all need to be very aware of what
this battlefield does because no matter
where you're going, it's going to be
triggering what Taran's Peak ability is.
You mentioned it slightly earlier. We
can refresh ourselves again, though,
because Taran's Peak, as you said, when
you conquer here, maybe two runes at the
end of this turn.
>> So, if you conquer both, you'll be able
to ready four runes at the end of the
turn.
>> Nice.
>> It's the Annie legend effect multiplied
here.
>> Multiplied by two.
>> That's it. Lots of spells I'm seeing in
nice boy's hands at the moment. But
first play of course is actually going
to be Diana. Um I mean on his he does go
second of course so he is able to use
that quite quickly and discipline is
going to be used from ghost driver. It
seems like he doesn't have any units in
hand. He's not able to play now on his
second turn.
>> Yeah but getting a guardian angel out
first turn is still good for these
Aurelia decks. However, I think he was
maybe hoping to top deck a play here.
forced to use that discipline early for
that card draw. Still not getting those
answers as you said here. Dino Lunari
does go in, kicks off a non-combat
showdown. Does tap that scorn of the
moon to get that energy to pay for the
predict on Dunari and hits the stupify
again. He did it in game one. Ricey,
>> I'm wondering whether or not he's going
to be using stupify yet. No, he's going
to keep not use all his runes up. He's
going to keep everything up, of course.
No, I lie. Out comes the vex. going to
be quite expensive of course paying that
power cost but is going to keep the two
up because we know that when you conquer
on targets peak at the end of your turn
you may ready up two runes so he has
those two runes up
>> Vex Cheus for those of you who don't
know this is the one from Spirit Forged
we did get to see this one in the hands
of some Ezreal pilots back then Vex
Cheus five energy one power five might
unit while I'm in combat friendly spells
cost one energy and one recycled rune
less to a minimum of one energy and
enemy Enemy spells cost one energy and
one power more. So building quite the
advantageous position here. Nice boy is
>> I have a feeling in as we were saying
this really pump spell heavy decks
between the two of them. This Vex
tierless might do quite a lot of work
for nice boy now going on to go to
driver's turn. He is going to be playing
Ireelia Fervent from that champion unit
spot. Of course paying that five energy.
looking at his runes up though. He still
has one and he's considering what can I
do here to try and maybe contest this
turn. You know, he's just going to go
for the equip.
>> He has equipped that guardian angel
immediately protecting Aurelia Fervent.
It will save her that sort of first
round of fighting that they have upon
them. With only one rune up though for
Ghost of Driver, potentially a Defy,
potentially a Defian dance, but it's I'm
sure it's not something you want to blow
this fast this early. And nice boy, he's
going to force ghost driver into him.
Retreats from that Ton's Peak.
>> He does retreat, but he's not over just
yet. He has now used turn to do to get
rid of that guardian angel. Fantastic
use. I mean, it is only temporary for
now. So if Ghost of Driver goes into a
fight in this turn on nice boy's turn,
it will still trigger, but on Ghost of
Driver's beginning phase, it's going to
turn to dust.
>> There is that frigid jewel as well.
That's that tech we were just pointing
out as we transitioned two energy gear.
When you draw your second card each
turn, give a friendly unit plus two
might this turn. So he's heavily
indexing into this pumping that he wants
to do. wants to outmite
this Aurelia and it's not a strategy we
see too often but he's definitely built
up quite the board for it that Vex Gilus
he's going to punish Ghost to Driver for
when he goes to pump and he's going to
be rewarded nice boy when he goes to
with much much cheaper spells
>> ghost driver goes in to
to conquer targets peak and also going
to be playing discipline here
potentially also for that cadra maybe
maybe wanting to do a showdown but for
now. Going in plus four, getting that
card draw.
>> Yeah, no showdown will occur there. It's
just that non-combat showdown
correction. And uh we do get that card
draw. He conquers that point. He's on
the board. One victory point to
Ghostaster Driver. Two victory points to
nice boy. Right now we do see ghost
driver does have five runes available.
All of them in chaos. Only two calm
runes exhausted.
And it looks like nice boy might be
considering his options here. That's
three ride the winds and two pupifiers.
He has movement for days, right?
>> He definitely has movement for days. He
could do quite a lot with that. And on
the other hand, girls driver trying to
see what he wants to play to. He's
considering
a card of his own. That's only I can
tell. I can tell it's a card.
>> That's what I do when I play at my next
night, too. I can my cards.
>> That's what I was wondering. Is he going
to use that charm? But he could still
force that showdown. I know he has
charms available in his deck. Also being
a calm deck. Out comes that Vex Cheers.
He's choosing to do Vex Cheers. He has
to be very careful because remember when
Vex is in a combat, everything is more
cheaper for nice boy. Everything is more
expensive for Ghost to Driver. Out comes
that ride the wind which is only one
energy.
>> Yeah, because of that serious cost
reduction. So ghost to driver going to
let that one go. doesn't want to have to
pay the increased cost to contest with
that that Aurelia Fervent sitting on
that bottom Targon's peak eight might
right now but a great save from Nice boy
having three ride the winds he was able
to play that easily
>> well ride the win exists in goes the
driver's hand as well and is going to
target Ireelia move Ireelia over of
course that target does buff up that
Ireelia making it even more mighty
tanmite versus five
>> yeah not only the target but also the
ready. That's how she went from an eight
might to that 10 might.
>> Out it comes a rebuke. That was what was
in the hands of Nice Boy. And Rebuke is
such a strong card. I mean, of course,
people do love Starross a little bit
more nowadays, but Rebuke, you cannot
forget about Rebuke.
>> Yeah. And normally that would be so so
punishing, but because of Vex Cheerless,
the Rebuke is just fine. It costs a
little less energy and the same amount
of power. So Nice Boy has to be happy
with that turn of play there. Aurelia
back in the hand of Ghost to Driver who
is forced to redevelop his board while
Nice Boy has protected his quite well.
And of course from that hold now going
on to four points and it's nice boy's
turn. And well it's unfortunate for
Ghost of Driver trying to do something
trying to make things work but the
rebuke I mean at least it's still in the
hand of Ghost of Drive. will be able to
play it again another time. It's not an
attraction. It's not completely out of
the game.
>> Yeah, but it's not something you want to
be doing this late in the game as well.
With five energy to get that Aurelia
back on the base, there's not much that
ghosted driver will be able to do once
it's played. Daniel goes in, triggers
that showdown.
>> And of course, that showdown trigger
does mean nice by guest. So, look at the
first card. Choose whether or not he
wants to reveal it. And of course, we
got to see I believe it was a ride the
wind. Out comes a stupifier getting
another card draw. And don't forget when
you do that card draw, there is that
frigid jewel as well. So doing another
stupify. Frigid jewel. When you draw
your second card each game, give a
friendly unit plus two. And we can see
Diana having that plus two.
>> Yeah, that's right. Each turn when you
draw that second that plus two might. So
Diana Lunari being pumped there with
that additional might. And uh nice boy,
he's in control. He's at five victory
points to Ghostaster Drivers one. Ghost
to Driver. It feels like he's a bit
behind the play here. Having to keep
playing out this Aurelia Fervent again
and again. And this tactic from Nice
Boy, it's working so well. He's just not
letting Aurelia stick to the board. He's
not letting Aurelia fight the ones she
wants to pick.
>> Only thing that Goa Driver can do on
this turn is just replay that Aelia. As
you said, it's not what you want to do
this late into the game. Nice bow now
sitting at six points. All he needs to
do is hold and win or maybe choose to
conquer in the next turn.
>> That was a double hold and it was just a
small little delay in the update there.
Seven victory points here. Nice boy only
needs one more to go 12 and zero. Ghost
driver up against the wall. If he loses
this one, that will be his first loss
here at the regional qualifiers in
Sydney. Look at all of those runes. Look
at how healthy that hand is from Nice
Boy. And he begins his turn.
>> Stifying, getting that card draw, and
now that Titan minus one once more, but
still so many options. We see, of
course, the ride the winds. What else do
we see in there?
>> Double rides.
>> Moon. Yep, Moonfall again. The new
signature spell of Diana Scorn of the
Moon can force that Aurelia into that
combat. If no units are left, there's
nothing Ghostster driver will be able to
do.
>> Frigid Jewel does give the plus two and
choosing it on the Vex right now. It
looks like nice boy wants to maybe bring
it.
>> Yeah, that moon force one of these units
into that Vex. He's going to be choosing
Ireelia
into that Vex. And don't forget have
bags as currently plus two seven might
minimum
>> he might have a divine hand. What can
goaster driver do here if he's not able
to stop this?
>> It's actually going to be that defant
dance as you were saying which gives
Ireelia a lot of might plus three and of
course is going to be defiant dancing
the uh the vex as well.
>> Yeah, importantly he is.
>> Oh, another one.
That's a lot of a lot of might coming
out now too. Now is minus two and
Ireelia is a plus six. And of course
that uh Moonfall still goes through plus
four.
>> Yeah. Importantly here, Ghost of Driver
was actually able to play that before it
was dragged onto the battlefield and
into combat with Vex. So he was able to
pump for the one and the one here. Not
punished by that Vexus. Ride the wind
saves the Vex.
>> Ride the wind does save the Vex. And
girls the driver will get that conquer
as well. Now on to two points. It's kind
of fun when you conquer on your enemy
opponent's turn. I don't know. It's just
like, "Oh, you thought you had
something. Well, I still get this
conquer point now."
>> That's it. Those off-tempo conquers
giving that second victory point to
Ghostaster. Not out of this one yet, but
he does have a whole mountain to climb
here. Ready? He's up that Aurelia going
>> maybe at Taran's Peak he has to climb.
Plus, you're now on three points for Goa
Driver. And it's his turn now. Of
course, if Nice Boy is able to hold the
other targets peak, he will get to eight
on his beginning phase next turn. So,
Ghost Driver has to work really hard to
try and get this unit, these two units
off of that other targets peak.
>> Yeah, you're not wrong. Ghost driver is
up against it. He has to conquer not
only one but two peaks here in this
mirror matched battlefields that we see.
Both of them utilizing them very well,
having those runes up, able to answer
each other's plays, forcing you to
consider all the options. goes to driver
>> going to be playing that silicon herder
onto target's pick and going to be
flashing it and uh because also
targeting a unit can also pay the legend
cost to ready it as well trying to do as
much as they can to get many moves out
of this silicon hoarder and get more
draws.
>> Yeah, Stell herder has definitely been a
favorite in the Aurelia decks. If it's
able to stay on the board and draw a lot
of cards, it means that Aurelia can dig
and find the answers. He has drawn that
one card. He's considering his options.
We can see a hard bargain there. So, he
could potentially counter the next sort
of big play that Nice Boy goes for. Nice
boy does have three runes up, but those
three units of Ghost Driver are going
in. Going to be starting the showdown.
And let's see what's going to happen. of
course moving the silicon herder gets
the draw one more time. So maybe able to
top deck something useful. But Diana has
started a showdown. And with that
showdown Oh, did you see it?
>> Yeah. So he predicted and put it to the
bottom of his deck and he actually top
deck the flash which he put into his
hand and now he's played the ride the
wind.
>> Oh no. That is going to technically
conquer the other battlefield which
means on seven points he gets to draw
again.
>> Yes. So we do see ghost to driver going
in. is going to win the targon's pig on
the bottom side which gets him to four
victory points. A nice boy as you said
draws and there it is. GG's
>> not able to conquer the other tarans pig
once more using all of his ability to
try and get down to the southern peak
and he won't be able to get and return
back to that northern peak. It is of
course going to be the winner that Diana
it's going to be nice boy. Nice boy
takes this round 12 best of three match
200 clean sweeping the previously
undefeated Aurelia of Gaster driver here
Ricey he's got to be feeling good about
that one
>> you can see him he's like wa that was
intense he did it he won he is still
undefeated a 120 Diana
>> I have to believe I did predict this
Diana this is
>> it No, cuz obviously Prismat on and he
is doing fantastically, but we have no
time for accolades. Nice boy is keen.
He's got his bag. He's going to be
packing that up. But congratulations,
Dice Boy. My hopes on Diana's
predictions ride with you. But he just
had the answers every single time.
Ricey, a ghostaster driver on that ALI
was never able to find a good fight
because he just was never there to
fight.
>> Yeah.
not having enough units to go in. Well,
the Diana nice boy was still able to
hold firm on these peaks here in this
game. Able to hold one or two and the
ride the wins shenanigans. I loved them
so much. Move a friendly unit and ready.
And when they're ready, they can even do
more things.
>> Yeah, you took the words right out of my
mouth. I was going to call that one as
the MVP for nice boy. And it even had a
great moment for Ghostster there. But
ride the wind, it found its preferred
player. And that was nice boy here in
this round 12 matchup that I was frankly
humbled to watch. It was phenomenal. And
I'm such a fan of Diana. I'm now going
to slam some ride the wins into my deck.
>> Yeah. I mean, you say you love you said
you love playing on Diana as well. And
you said you were justified by having
was it the Vex Cheers? The Vex and we
can see the Vex Cheers in the play right
now. It was fantastic to watch him be
able to ride that win for cheaper
because of that beex tier list. Lots and
lots of uses coming out on this amazing
deck. And well, right there now right
now it is the strongest Diana deck.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah, absolutely. It could
potentially even be the single strongest
deck here at the RQ so far. I don't have
a read on all of the standings right
now, but we did have that previously
undefeated Hook Leblanc being played by
CTCG Daniel. But this is an undefeated
Diana. I mean, we can't not talk about
the deep, deep run this new unleashed
legend is making.
>> It's very exciting to watch and I'm just
very excited to hear what we just saw
the interview being set up slowly and
hear what he has to say. We can see, of
course, the tech being played today with
that ride, the win, and also all the
other chaos shenanigans. Let's hear from
Nice Boy.
>> Thank you so much, Ricey and Logan. I'm
here with Nice Boy, the only undefeated
player left in the room, which I have to
think means you are locked for top
eight.
>> Uh, I should be. I think tied to last
round, I should be good for top eight.
It was pretty amazing. It's incredible.
>> I flew all the way from Texas, so I was
uh
>> It's crazy to be here. Feels insane.
>> When did you get in?
>> Uh, I got in Friday morning. Friday
morning?
>> Yes. I had no time to prep.
>> Do you play that freak you at all?
>> Uh, no. Uh, I I rested all day.
>> I mean, that makes a lot of sense. How
when did you decide on Diana for the
event?
>> Uh the second Diana was revealed, I saw
her ability. I'm like, I'm playing that
champion. Even if she's bad, which
apparently she isn't, I'm going to play
her.
>> All right. So, how have you found the
deck that you're testing? What kind of
when you started playing, what were you
like, oh, I feel like this might be a
deck.
>> Uh the second I put three Hay in the
deck, I was like, this deck just feels
completely insane. Uh I tried every
single deck you could dream of preparing
for the event, and Diana is the only one
that just felt like truly unfair. where
like I'm doing things that are just so
much better than anything else in the
game.
>> Yeah, is an interesting one cuz I've
seen a lot of chatter about that one. I
think the players are used to their
Stellorn is kind of that unit.
>> Uh so I played Aurelia all of last set
>> and Hay is just Stellorn times a
thousand. It's better in every single
way.
>> All right, so
>> pretty incredible.
>> How are you feeling? How are you feeling
coming in as far as the meta goes?
There's a lot of different decks to
prepare for.
>> Uh I feel really good. Um, I think the
main matchup that's really sketchy is
Ezreal, but luckily I got super l I
played one, I got extremely lucky
against them, so I was able to own them.
And outside of that, I don't think
Ezreals are doing too hot. So, my other
all my other match ups are pretty good.
I felt really good going to top eight.
>> So, looking at this match, I feel like
in game one, there was a pretty
interesting moment where I kind of felt
like Aurelia was doing the thing Aelia
does, and you're obviously an early
player where you're she's at six points,
she's ready, and it's kind of like,
okay, well, kind of hop in, hold on to
these battlefields. is sneaky means
Aelia can actually be played to the back
line and now you're like well I'm going
to now pass the turn to my opponent when
I can't win on points and have Aurelia
conquer two battlefields with boot of
swiftness very easily. Was that turn
kind of scary for you or did you feel
like you could navigate it?
>> Yeah, the whole match was super
stressful. Uh every turn was it just
came down to draws. Uh Ghost Ste is a
good friend of mine. I've known him for
years. Uh extremely good player. Uh I
drew completely insane both games which
is uh what it takes. But it's uh I think
the main mistake people make against
Aurelia is they don't force stuff out
from her.
>> Yeah.
>> So you just kind of have to play cards
and see if she has the answer or not.
Cuz if she doesn't have have the answer,
you win. And if she does, then you try
again next turn. You just keep trying
until eventually they're out of stuff.
>> Yeah. So I'm curious cuz obviously Chaos
has seen a decent amount of
representation kind of throughout
Riftbound's history, especially from
Spirit Forge. Uh defy obviously a spell
that everyone always has in the back of
their mind. Obviously as Dina, you don't
have access to that. How has hard
bargain and maybe abandon for you this
uh this event? Uh, I'm not playing
abandoned, but Hard Bargain has been
incredible. I'm playing the one, and you
just have so much deck filtering and
card draw and everything that times
where you need it, you're always going
to have it, and you normally never need
it more than once. So, it's been really
consistent for me.
>> How have you found Diana's legend
ability? Cuz I feel like that's the
thing where everyone looks at like, "Oh,
free resource every time." Seems kind of
good.
>> So, when I first saw her legend, I
didn't realize it was any kind of
showdown. It doesn't have to be a combat
showdown.
>> So, it just every single turn cycle, you
were getting an extra energy, like no
matter what, always. And it's really
adds up over the course of the game
where you're unls.
>> Yeah. So obviously kind of zooming out
looking pretty good as far as your
position goes almost as surely going to
be making top eight one way or the
other. Obviously we don't know who you
might be playing at this point but
looking at the field especially at the
top tables which I'm sure you'll have
your eye close on. How are you feeling
about your potential matchups kind of in
the run to maybe first?
>> Um I don't know if you won this round
but uh my only loss in Swiss was to
Rico. Uh he's extremely good Aurelia
player which that match was pretty tough
for me. Uh so I'd really like to dodge
him if we also if he also makes the top
eight but uh everywhere else I feel
pretty good.
>> All right well so far so good. Good
luck.
>> Yeah perfect.
>> All right let's head on back to the
casters.
>> Thank you so much Pat. So wonderful to
hear from nice boy. The undefeated Diana
doing such amazing work here at the
riftbound qualifier Sydney. But of
course there is still more riftbound to
watch. Logan, we are going to go into
our second feature match.
>> Yeah, we will find ourselves in game two
here with CTCG Colin. Previously the
best of set at Atlanta RQ into delusion
currently 9 and two on that Master Y Wu
Bladesman. The proving grounds ye
proving his strength once again.
>> Proving his strength Kie on six points
versus Colin K's five. So we know Colin
as of course the set now having winning
winning winning having won that first
game. He does have that advantage here
coming into their second game. We can
see all these buffing shenanigans
happening right now on Valley of Idols
where a showdown is currently taking
place. There is a Rango that Delusion
has there maybe played from ambush,
maybe they're from uh defending. Not
entirely sure just yet, but there is now
a repulse coming out from Delusion.
Yeah, repuls a fantastic answer into any
sort of targeted responses here. It does
resolve, but I do want to point out we
have both fa folk on the bases here as
well. We have that brand new
irresistible fa from unleash looking
fantastic. But this is a big big
showdown. And I will not trip up over
this VI again. When she attacks, she can
stun an enemy unit at the battlefield
here as these players, they've been at
this for a long time now. Nearly more
than a day and a half. Yeah,
>> we're into our fourth round now out of
the five before we go to that top cut.
You know, the mental fatigue settling
in, but they're pros. They've been here
before. They know what to do. Valley of
Idols for Set the Boss. Amateur Recital
for Delusion there. And 5 XP almost at
that 6 XP threshold that will start to
turn on some of those experience
mechanics.
set just VI moved away just to show that
Lucian underneath
>> just a reminder when a player plays a
unit here they may pay one to buff it on
the valley of idols and that may have
been what happened to that vi did get
that buff it's going to be Lucian that
does win out that battle technically
call in with the Lucian and will be able
to stay on that valley of idols now
going in onto the amateur recital
and with that irresistive Hey folk, as
you mentioned, when they go onto a
battlefield, they're able to tempt one
of the enemy units onto that
battlefield. And that means the illusion
now has no units coming in play. That
tasty fire poke is gone.
>> Yeah, Lucian there has been bounced back
to the base. We do see that amateur
recital, right? When you hold here, you
may move a unit at a battlefield to its
base. So Colin, you know, holding that
one, just bringing the Lucian back. I
believe there
we found ourselves in the middle of this
one. So, we're trying to get our heads
around this. They are both at six
victory points, however, and that is a
handful of options for delusion here.
>> But do they have an option to go in with
a unit? Is that a vile? I'm spying at
the end. I'm not entirely sure. We only
see just a little bit. I see a little
bit of green. I see a little bit of
purple. It looks like a really strong
mighty unit. And that might be the
answer that Delusion needs to stay in
this game. And remember, game one went
to Colin K. He's thinking about it. It
does still look like a Vmore to me.
>> That is the eight energy two power that
you were spying in the top left of that
card. That is Vilemore. That new card
from Unleashed. And uh it could turn the
tides, right? Because if you are a unit
with lesser might here, then you don't
deal combat damage. And it has Oh, he's
played it anyway. I was going to say it
has ambush.
>> It has ambush which you can play as a
reactant to a battlefield where you have
units. The issue is there are no units
of delusion on the board. He cannot
ambush but he is going to play first m
to ready and in Valmo goes onto valley
of idols meaning delusion is now on
seven points. He's going to pass the
turnover and hope this Valmore is strong
enough is mighty enough to stop anything
Colin throws here on this potential last
turn. Colin now on seven points as well.
>> Yeah, definitely. As we do get the fist
bump here,
revealing the hidden blade that would
have been able to remove that vile more.
I do believe Colin takes this two in
this round 12 best of three matchup and
moves on up. Congratulations Colin on
that set, proving why he won that best
of set at the RQ in Atlanta.
>> Absolute incredible set. Colin Kay is
known for being the set and here in
Sydney, nothing has changed. He is still
considered, I would say, one of the best
sets in this room. looking to be the
best in this room with his score line
being incredibly high.
>> Yeah, definitely. I do believe there was
a 922 uh situation. So, I believe he's
gone up to 101 12 uh 10 12 10 + 2 is 12.
He's gone to 10 and two now after this
round 12 matchup into that Ye. And we
did get to see a vilemore which I'm
pretty happy with. The art is fantastic,
but it is such a powerful oppressive
unit. But set in order had that hidden
blade was just going to go. Thank you
very much. Conquer and win.
>> Well, we got to see two amazing feature
matches here in round 12, but we do have
another round after this. Let's go to go
to a break while our players get ready
for round 13. Oh, excellent.
>> Welcome to Riftbound Basics featuring
actions and reactions. There are three
different types of spells in Riftbounds.
normal spells, which you can use to
start a chain during your own turn from
a neutral game state. Actions, which can
be used in exactly the same way, but can
also be used in combat to start a chain.
And reactions, which have all the
advantages of the other two, but can
also be used to react to triggered
abilities or spells. Reactions are super
fast and can lead to lots of exciting
interactions as they resolve before all
other spells. For example, if you have a
stupify in your hand and your opponent
activates a spell that really bothers
you, you can use stupify as a reaction
and draw a card before your opponent's
spell is resolved. This might allow you
to draw another reaction that saves you
from their situation, like a defy.
Another exciting example is dealing
damage to a unit with a spell before
combat. If you go into combat with a
unit that's already damaged, you should
make sure you win the fight, otherwise
the units will heal after the combat.
Let's say you have dealt six damage to
your opponent's mind splitter with
falling star and you go into combat
against it with your watchful sentry.
Your opponent might want to activate an
action in response such as grim resolve
to generate extra might and win the
combat. You can still respond to that
with a stupify. You reduce the mind
spplitter's might to six and because it
still has six damage counters on it, it
will die before the grim resolve can
save it. Which one is your favorite
reaction card in Rift Bond? Let us know.
We're here at the Sydney Rip and
original qualifier. I'm Patri. I'm here
with Randy, one of the members of the
legendary team of traveling players that
seems to keep doing pretty well at
Arcus, but although haven't had maybe
the best luck lately.
>> Hey, it's okay. Uh, my friend won last
week. I mean, last week, three weeks
ago. So, that's pretty good already.
Happy about that.
>> So, when did you get in?
>> Uh, got in yesterday morning. Flew in
from Shanghai. So, not too jet lag.
That's a good thing. So, you're not
playing the preq, but you already have a
buy. You've been farming tickets with
your friends. How you feeling about
tomorrow?
>> Uh, I'm feeling pretty good. Pretty
sorted. Uh, bring a spicy deck for
tomorrow. So, we'll see.
>> Said this last time, bring a spicy deck
and uh maybe worked out not how you
intended. Is this uh better than your
last spicy brew?
>> Uh, yeah, it is. It is. It is. It is. It
is.
>> What are you playing domains you've
never registered before at an RQ?
>> Um, I think I registered every single
domain except green so far, like calm.
So, no, I'm not. I I can be, but um I
haven't topped with either in EU or NA.
So, I'll say that.
>> Is it a legend you've played before?
>> I have not played that legend before
either.
>> Is it a new legend?
>> Um, it's not a new legend. It's not a
new legend. It's a set to one. So,
>> how are you feeling about Unleashed in
general, especially given how close it's
been since the release of the set?
>> Uh, I'm feeling pretty good. Been
testing Unleash since before Atlanta was
like uh since it's released in uh I mean
since the spoiler got out. So, I'm
feeling pretty good about that. Um,
we'll see how it goes, but I'm feeling
pretty this weekend is looking pretty
good for for us.
>> And of course, you have lots of
different teammates. You guys usually
register different decks. Is that
happening again?
>> Um, so I have two other friends are who
are on the same deck as I am, but Alan
and Pri are also registering different
decks. So, all three of us are going to
be on different decks. Yeah.
>> What a surprise. All right. Well, good
luck. Hope you have a good tournament.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Have a good
weekend as well.
I'm here at the Sydney RQ with the one
and only Villionaire. You got into
Sydney on Wednesday. How's your trip to
Australia been so far?
>> I'm loving it so far. It's my first time
in Sydney. Um, been having good food. I
like the weather and uh yeah,
everything's upside down, but that's
that's kind of weird, I guess.
>> Did you do anything fun?
>> Uh, yeah, we went to the zoo. Uh, we met
up with Ali Aldrazi, too, so that was
fun. He was just randomly there. Uh, but
yeah, so all the team went to the zoo
and the tranga, I think. I think that's
how you say it. Yeah, that one that was
really cool. One of the best suits I've
ever been to. So, that was sweet. And
other than that, just jamming.
>> So, Challenger TCD has done pretty well
at the regional qualifier level, I would
say. How many of you traveled here for
this event?
>> Uh, it's just three of us this time.
Australia is very far, obviously. Um, so
we've got uh Colin, me, and Daniel.
Obviously, Colin and Daniel, uh, some of
our best performers, and then me, you
know, the best of guy. So, or the Aurora
guy. Yeah.
>> So, what's the plan this event? Are we
going back for best of or we playing
something else? Uh I will be playing
Volibar tomorrow in the main again. Uh I
think he got a lot of really good tools
in set three, not just Elder Dragon. I
actually think uh Rengar 5 is insane for
that deck. So yeah,
>> obviously you played a lot of Aurora.
There's a lot of chatter about Aurora.
How are you feeling about its position
in this metag game?
>> Uh I think it's positioned pretty well.
I do think purple Aurora is a little bit
too all-in still. I think you you have
some really bad matchups because of
that, but obviously when the deck does
what it's supposed to do, can still be
really oppressive, can still crush uh
almost any deck. But I do think like
some of the other decks that play a
little bit better without Aurora like
Poppy, uh, Master Yi, and Volibar are
actually really well positioned.
>> We've had a pretty good tournament so
far, winning some best offs. How you
feeling about your chances this weekend?
>> Uh, I feel like I'm going to take it
home again.
>> Best of luck. Have a good tournament.
>> Thanks, brother.
>> A key component of playing League of
Legends is gathering XP and leveling up.
Now you can do that in Riftbound 2 with
the newest additions in Unleashed. Every
XP you get will add to your level as a
player and will benefit you in different
forms. So far, three legends have been
released that directly benefit from XP
gain. Ka'ix Void Reva, Poppy, Keeper of
the Hammer, and Master Yi Wu Jun Master.
Notice that all of these have the body
domain in common. Master Yi uses XP
passively. With higher level, he finds
stronger passive effects. At level six,
your units are permanently boosted. And
at level 11, your units always enter
ready. Of course, in the main deck, most
masteries will rely on the champion
unit, Master Yi, unstoppable as a win
condition. This one gets cheaper the
more XP you have, and at level 16, it
even becomes unargetable. Combined with
Master Yu Master's ability to enter
ready, he can really swing games.
Kha'Zix and Poppy have the unique
ability to gain XP through their own
legend abilities and otherwise use it
like a resource. While Poppy generates
card advantage by spending XP, Kha'Zix
gains utility by either buffing his
units or moving exhausted units away
from their battlefields back to base.
Since all of these three legends have
the body domain in common, there's a
huge variety of body cards that can get
you the XP you need through the hunt
keyword, for example. Hunt cards grant
you an XP whenever you conquer or hold.
So, winning combats for those decks is
of utmost importance. Cards like Gemand
Hunter, Boracious Gromp, and Master Heat
Tempered can be found in all three
decks, but XP can also be splashed into
other decks. Grim Resolve, for example,
is a strong combat trick that gives a
unit free might on action speed. If the
unit wins a combat, it grants you two
XP. This card might find its way into
other decks as well. Fiora players have
already played around with the
Shepherd's Heirloom, which works like a
Dorance Blade, but does not equip for
power cost, but for XP. There are plenty
of ways to integrate some XP gain into
your decks. So get those level in and
scale into the late game. Riftbounders,
welcome back to regional qualifiers
Sydney. We just got to watch round 12,
but we watched two very, very quick
matches. So we are having a fun match
coming up while we wait for our round 12
players to finish off their games on the
floor. Yeah, look, this is a surprise
show match that we have here for all of
you today. And what a treat it is.
Whilst this won't be a 2v2 match, I hear
rumor, I hear whisper that they are the
production 2v2
champions, Rosie. So, this will be a
match up for the ages.
>> That is so true. We have one of our
amazing production players players team
uh Barrett versus the one and only
pastry time. Players are ready. Let's
enjoy some more Riftbound while we wait
for the main event.
>> Look, I have to imagine that Julian is
going to be playing his hook degeneracy.
He's always been an advocate for baited
hook. He has pastry time. But Barrett,
he's in good spirits. He's going to have
that mental edge. He's already losing it
over the possibilities of stomping. And
there it is, the baited hook.
>> That's why he was laughing. So happy we
got to see the baited hook here on
basically first hand. We are seeing a
Poppy versus a gen matchup.
>> One thing that I do love about that
Poppy, just a small flex that Pastry
Time has to his name is that has been
signed by local Australian content
creator Fasty who is actually here at
the regional qualifier as well taking
part in all of our content creator
activations. But enough about that. Jyn
is on the base. Jin has been played and
out comes that amazing stuff. Shepherd's
loom, I think it's called.
>> Shepherd's aloom.
>> Oh, I did it. Shepherd's aloom, which is
such a unique item where it gives you an
experience when you play it and then it
costs an experience to equip it.
>> That's it. That's it. Ah, we are in for
such a treat here. Right, we've got the
XP tracker online showcasing that new
sort of hunt and XP mechanic that has
come through with Unleashed. We've got
Jyn who is all about the number four and
Ni.
>> Ni comes out to play only playing to
base. Nothing too scary just yet. But
that is a four might unit looming over
the edge right now. But still pastry
time hasn't decided to conquer any point
just yet, any battlefield just yet. But
I mean has some things building up in
the base.
>> Yeah, definitely wants to build those
units. present a lot of might here for
our esteemed Barrett to struggle to
overcome here. Jin though with that sort
of deadly flourish played out is going
to ping a unit for a serious amount of
demage here. I see
>> and going to also use a frigid touch may
not repeat it twice I believe and so
that's pretty exciting. Lots of damage
being dealt and a gold comes out
>> and I hear we have an exclusive access
to player coms roy this could be spicy.
>> Let's listen.
>> What's new? Oh, what's new? Let me
>> read this. What's going on? So, when I
cast a spell of four or greater, I can
banish it if I successfully.
>> When an opponent is telling you what the
card does, that's not a good sign.
>> And I'll draw one.
>> So many fours.
>> So many just like Jin.
>> It is Jin. Four. Four. Four. Four.
>> Hidden blade in.
>> Ooh, that's an excited sound.
>> That's good deck building.
>> Complimenting your opponent.
We need a different
>> uh
>> considering his options. Hidden blade in
hand. Baded look on the base.
>> I don't have an XP. Very sad. Oh no, we
do. That's the whole point.
>> That's why I play the code.
>> Great sportsmanship there. Barrett
reaffirming you have
>> paying costs feels bad, man.
>> It does feel bad.
>> Italy back is absurd.
Which is why elder dragon's so good in
Aurora because you don't have to pay for
the elder dragon.
>> Oh,
>> how comes the n from the trash? Because
of spectrum matron.
>> Let's open the casino.
>> We're going to pitch for a seven. Ripped
Harold off the top. That's the hook.
>> All right. Little hook action.
>> This is the hook degenerous here that
Patry Time advocates for. Barrett's
excited.
>> One, two, three.
>> What's he going to get?
There's another baited hook.
>> Only left. All right. Nah,
>> can accelerate her. I'm trying to think
if it's worth it.
>> It was good to see though. We saw two
seal of unities there. We saw the
>> also a four.
>> You already equipped it.
>> Yeah, I did.
>> I love the show.
>> Oh, this is
>> We're getting some excellent camera
shots here.
>> This movement gets XP. It's not the
same.
>> And they're talking us through the plays
here. Ricey.
>> Yikes. Uh,
>> it's almost like pastry time cast
riftbound.
>> Still be worth it.
>> Honestly, I think so.
>> Barrett, let's deep in the tank
thinking.
>> We'll go here. What options?
>> Out comes acceleration
>> get an XP for moving. All right.
>> Goes in Nyla
>> with one experience. So now P time's on
two.
>> I'll channel.
>> Yep. Conquers goes to one victory point.
Time ahead.
>> Barrett did conquer with that Jin
earlier. Also on the one. Thank you.
Production. But this is a real match
now.
>> Yeah. Barrett Jin Virtuosa murderous
artist currently on the gardens of
becoming.
>> Don't deal with both. Good.
>> This is what we need more of. We need
more player coms. The banter here is
>> chef's kiss.
>> We got to be careful. Sometimes uh
players do say things.
>> Not not as well PR trained as the rest
of us. You could say
>> I do say things and I'll pop the scroll.
>> Don't singularity me big dog.
>> I'll play this.
>> Don't singularity me.
>> Big dog.
>> I mean that's a watcher isn't a
singularity but it is still pretty
strong.
>> It's still a big dog.
>> It is. All right,
>> pause.
>> All right, Jin ganks over. Conquers that
battlefield. Niler goes to the trash.
Barrett,
>> I'm going to
>> up to two for that conquer. Oh, no. He
held. You're right. And then conquers to
three. Yes, my mistake here.
>> Got him, coach.
>> I'll just remove him.
>> Now it's pastry's time turn.
>> Going to be of course drawing raiding up
the runes. I mean, he still has units in
base. Quite a lot of them. Um, love the
baited hook gear. Of course, that is uh
something really fun. He has to kill a
friendly unit to do so. And he gets a
look at the top five cards of his main
deck. We've heard patient time talk
about baited hook time and time again.
>> He is an advocate. We took a selfie
earlier this weekend as well. He had
that baited hook slacked on his forehead
in the background. He loves them so
much.
>> If I were to get past time to sign a
card at this point, I think it might be
that baited hook.
>> I think it have to be baited at the
stage. Well, Ni goes in, does conquer
the Forgotten Library.
>> Actually, no, doesn't conquer. Looks
like it was a trade instead. Um, but
that does get Barrett's card off the
board, but thousand watch is still in
the base for next turn. But baited hook,
the mechanic comes through. Anakin gets
played here and gets played.
>> Worst unit
>> for has to be up to one might more than
the killed unit. So,
>> just when you attack with them, right?
>> Yeah. Seven might
>> a unit there. So they kind of attack
your base.
>> And this is great, right? Reading the
card explains the card. So they're
playing these cards out and then they're
reading them and explaining them so they
can't get it wrong here. I see.
>> Exactly. So out comes out. It's It's
such an expensive card. 10 energy and he
gets to play it. He still has to pay for
the energy cost though. The power,
sorry.
>> Yeah. 10 energy, three power there for
Adakan. But such a strong unit here.
>> So I will thousand
>> moves in. to
>> Oh, no. You don't have to pay the power
cost. I misread that.
>> Ignoring its cost completely.
>> Completely. Usually when they say ignore
its cost, except it's power. This is
unique that you don't
>> ignore it. And goes a thousand watcher
does claim that forgotten library, but
>> you could hook into an elder dragon.
>> Full addition cost.
>> I want to do that.
>> I'm on board the hook degeneracy now.
>> And then you've seen this play.
>> I've seen the light pastry
>> once again. Extremely cringe again. And
then I've got
>> I don't know if I agree if that's
cringe. You just didn't like that one.
>> Pastry.
>> Same card. No.
>> And I generate that gold.
>> Yep.
>> That gold.
>> Look. He's got the professional card
flicking hand going here though.
>> And then I get
>> making sure he can see all of them. Jin.
>> It has vision.
>> Does play Jin.
>> I've already predicted twice and kept it
on top.
And I'm going to go ahead and hide.
>> Hide a card. It's a fury and mind deck.
It could be a few different options, but
it's going to be hiding it.
>> I am in show.
>> He's playing for the audience here. He's
got that card draw, but we heard him say
he wasn't going to do that vision
because he's already predicted the card
on top and he knows it's something he
wants so he's kept it there.
>> Yep. Okay. Makes sense. Makes sense.
>> So,
>> few options in the hands of pastry time
right now. I want to see more beta hawk
shenanigans.
>> Yep. Spectral matron, that hidden blade,
that first mate in hand. Hexte anomaly
for Barrett and Echko who has some real
degeneracy about it. If Patry time wants
to see some degeneracy, wait till that
Echo is played.
>> I suppose we simply find out.
>> Yeah, you got to make them have it.
>> Okay, all that all
>> just like nice boy said, you got to play
into them. You got to force them to have
it.
>> If they don't, great. If they do, you
play again next turn.
>> Dislike it. I will say
>> I don't know if I can abide.
>> What a thought going into this one.
Rice.
>> Lot of back and forth.
>> Lots of back and forth.
>> Past your time. Taking a lot of time to
think about this move right now.
>> Have to do this.
>> He might be forced into a
>> choice. He doesn't like. Is he thinking
about that hidden blade? He is thinking
about the hidden blade.
But does he want to hit and blade
himself or the enemy? I think it is
going to be the enemy is going to be of
believing. Yeah, of course the thousand
tailed watcher got to react to the
consult the pass be able to of course
get that important
draw.
>> Oh that works.
>> And he's drawing a total I believe of
three cards there for that consult the
bar. Come on. Come on. No.
>> That's going to be pretty big for
Barrett to be able to take this game
potentially in the future. We also see
that he has four spells over in the
banish region which remember Jen loves
the number of four. Did I say four? I
meant three. He's three spells over in
the banish region.
>> I wonder if the banished region in
Shadow Isles before
>> cuz that's where souls get banished to
right in League. I think I I trust you.
>> I don't know. I'd have to ask Thresh,
but Thresh isn't in Riftbound yet
either.
>> Not yet. But there is that spectral mag
we saw earlier. I like you're like,
"Let's talk about the game, Logan."
>> Fair call to you as we do see that gem
hand move in and conquer that gardens of
becoming. And we do get a little bit of
a heads up on that gin meticulous killer
with the vision. If you've spent four
energy or more to play a spell this
turn, you may play me for one recycled
mind rune.
>> Yeah,
>> sorry.
>> Oh my god.
>> Oh, good sportsmanship though.
>> Okay,
>> it's it's pay time. Still turn. And he's
going to be returning that gem hand back
into the base to keep it safe.
>> Um, and now out comes Barrett's turn.
Lots of runes available. And of course,
Jin loves doing those large spells. Goes
in to take that top outfield. He's going
to be able to get that conquer point as
well.
>> I'm coming for you.
>> I'm loving how Paris playing for the
camera here. He's got Jin's signature
spell, Cand.
He's got time warp. He's got Hex Anomaly
Echo. A fair few powerhouse cards. or
for
>> of course uh energy there going to be
used and we know if a spell cost four or
more it goes into the banish region and
it's getting to that important four
banished cards amount. Yeah, that's uh
pretty important to Jin Virtuoso. That
brand new legend from Unleashed does
love a good number four here. Icy, we do
see that curtain call coming out. But
Jin Virtuoso reads, "When you play a
spell, if you've spent four energy or
more, you may banish it. Then if there
are four spells banished with me, put
each in its trash. Channel four runes
and draw one." So there is four runes.
Interestingly, you need to note that
those four runes that Barrett is
channeling, they're not exhausted.
They're actually ready, which is really,
really helpful for being able to play
more spells later on. And of course,
curtain call, you can repeat it if you'd
like for one power, one energy, one
power, one energy, one power. And you
can draw one, do a dual unit at a
battlefield, do a three unit at a base,
or give a unit at a battlefield minus
four. So lots of options. Feels kind of
like way in there. You've got lots of
options available, but a bit different.
>> No, stop counting.
>> And then with the five,
>> I'm going to play
>> sprite burst.
>> Yep.
>> Uh, so I'll play two ready sprite units.
They exist.
>> They should exist
>> somewhere.
>> Surely.
We have to check the back of the tokens.
>> I got two.
>> There's one.
>> I got one.
>> I've literally won. Haven't we had this
card played on stream already?
>> Here we go. I've got two. It's a mech.
It's a mech.
>> It's a mech.
>> Um, but Jin says I played this again.
So,
>> yep.
>> All right. So, I've got my two sprites.
>> Yep.
>> Um, did I score my point? I don't even
remember.
>> Uh, yeah, you did for this.
>> Five. Um, this works again cuz I used
the thing. I don't need this.
>> That's not good for me.
>> Yes. I will
>> Yes.
>> move the sprite into here.
>> And I'll go to six.
>> Yep.
Um, and then I will go ahead and play
this.
>> Yep.
>> And I would like to recycle. Uh, 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10. I don't think I can do it.
>> No, I wanted to.
>> Oh. Oh,
I see what's happening here.
>> I wanted to do it.
>> I know that's bad.
Uh,
>> I'll reinforce here.
>> Okay.
>> And I'll just hide
a card.
>> I don't like what's happening over here.
>> Show your thing.
>> And then you've got that over there.
>> Yep. My little guy.
>> And I think I'll hide an additional
card.
>> Okay.
>> I'll pass.
>> Just just to be safe.
>> Yeah,
>> just to be safe.
Draw a card. Oh, goodness. See, I didn't
generate enough gold.
>> No,
>> because then I could do a 10.
>> Yeah, then you could have some extra
power left over perhaps.
>> Yeah,
>> maybe four. Even
>> just showed my hand a little too.
>> Well, I don't know if I can do anything
about that.
>> Guess we'll find out.
Thinking. Thinking. All of my units feel
very slow.
>> I'll look for a Sprite while you um
while you cook. while I cook.
All right. Going to equip airloom to my
gem hand hunter.
>> Yes. I'm try and run in here and see if
you fancy a trade.
>> Four to four.
>> Four to four. Pass to you.
>> Um, sure. I'll react first with this to
draw two. Yep.
>> And
I will fancy a trade.
>> Okay. Not dead yet.
Maybe dead soon. Not dead yet. Oh, that
is so awkward.
Wow, I hate that.
I really don't like that at all.
Boo.
All right. Well, got to do what you got
to do, I guess. Mixologist go.
Okay, you're up.
notably a missing uh order power.
>> So, these will temporarily leave. I'm
not going to bother using this cuz it
doesn't do anything. Um, but it was in
case you wanted to swing.
>> Very nice to hear what these two players
are here thinking and saying to each
other. Barrett and Pastry Time, they
have been having such a wonderful time.
Of course, backstage, on stage, and of
course with Riftbound in general.
>> We do love stages here. backstage, front
stage, the arena main stage. But right
now, pastry time and Barrett on that
feature table as you were saying, just
showcasing some of the the tech with
baited hook here that you can get with
the Poppy going as well. And also Jin
Virtuoso, that new legend that was
released with Unleashed, but doesn't
mean you can't use some of those classic
favorites like a nice old Kaiser
Survivor here. Icy going in on that top
battlefield. Forgotten Library has been
conquered, but that is going to be game
because both of those battlefields have
been conquered with that plundering
power claiming the bottom the southern
battlefield. And Barrett is going to win
this match up here, this shell match
between these two wonderful, wonderful
legends.
>> We even give him the victory music.
Full honors to Barrett here. takes this
best of one show match between Barrett
and Pastry Time.
>> We do get to see a little bit of the
mechanics coming through with Pastry
Times Beta to hook that gear in a base
being able to use that to possibly bring
out bigger fish in the ocean.
>> We do love big fish. We do love one of
those fish called Atacan, which is such
a powerful order unit. But speaking of
baited hook, that LeBlanc baited hook
tech that CTCG Daniel is running is
proving its worth and it's only making
Pastry Times argument for that hook that
much stronger.
>> No, I totally agree. I mean, that
Leblanc baited hook is something I'm
looking forward to seeing more of
because of, as we know, Dan is doing
pretty well so far. He's in contention
to making that top eight.
>> Yeah. Yeah, absolutely. LeBlanc always
so so strong and I say always but over
the past two days not you know for the
history of Ripbound cuz she's an
unleashed legend that's for sure. But
that's enough from us here at the caster
desk. We are going to go to a break and
we'll be right back with round 13.
My name is Melanie Bracewell and I um am
from New Zealand but I live in
Melbourne. I'm a very competitive person
and I love sport. My fiance played
Yu-Gi-Oh and I said I would never play
that game because I hate being bad at
things. And then when Riftbound came
out, everyone was bad at it because it
was new to everyone. And that's how he
got me in. The element about Riftbound I
like the most is I'm a League of Legends
player as well and so I like that a lot
of the cards match their champions in
the game. Like it makes sense. The deck
I'm running is Lilia. I think she's fun.
I have ADHD and so I like doing things.
I like being busy and an aggro deck
suits me because you're always doing
things. You're not just waiting to ramp.
You're just you're playing the game. I
run Lilia because it's it suits me
because I can just swing in things and
they die and that's fine. My last deck I
would always leave two drops on the
battlefield and my boyfriend was like,
you know, that's kind of bad. And I was
like, well, what if they just die anyway
and that's good. I don't have a ton of
experience in any other TCGs. This is my
first TCG. For the reasons I specified,
which is just I don't like being bad and
and games that have been around for a
long time. I couldn't stand the idea of
playing the game and everyone's like,
"That's not how you do it and everyone
knows that you're wrong." Um, I think
this is nice that everyone's kind of
learning together. I've gone 311. So,
three wins, one loss, one draw. So, kind
of fine. I can still make it to day two,
maybe. I think it'll be going good. I've
been loving this this Riftbound regional
qualifier. It's been awesome. I've never
been to anything like it before. I think
the closest I could think is like going
to packs in Melbourne, which is more of
like a convention, and there's there's a
competitive element, but uh the
competition isn't the main thing. The
the the main thing is just hanging out
with people. I quite like that this is
all competitive, and you go see your
friends and you're like, "How are you
doing?" And some of them are happy and
some of them are depressed. It's just it
swings and balances, you know. I will
absolutely be at the next Riftbound
event for sure. I'd love to shout out
Rengarbot. He's a friend of ours and he
was on the exhibition match before
playing the most diabolical Rengar that
anyone has ever seen and I think people
should watch that game if they get the
chance.
Welcome to Riftbound Basics featuring
runes. In the Riftbound TCG, your energy
to play cards comes automatically. Each
player brings their own rune deck
consisting of 12 cards. This consists of
runes in the domains of your legend. A
Draven deck, for example, can play chaos
and fury runes. At the start of your
turn, immediately after you have readied
all your cards and received points for
holding a battlefield, you may play the
top two cards from your rune deck. You
need runes to pay the energy and power
costs on your cards. For example, for
Victor Leader, you must pay four energy,
which means exhausting four runes of any
color and then pay a power cost. You do
this by placing a rune of the color
shown under the energy cost at the
bottom of your rune deck. This process
is also called recycling. Some cards
such as seal of insight have no energy
cost but do have a power cost. However,
to ensure your energy isn't lost, you
may float the energy. That is, exhaust
your runes, place them under your rune
deck, and later use the energy gained to
play another card. Consequently, power
costs have no effect on the current turn
in which you play the cards, but can
have a significant impact on subsequent
turns as you are constantly playing with
fewer runes. How do you like your runes
best in Riftbound? Do you prefer them
furious and chaotic, or rather calm and
orderly?
I'm Shimon. I'm actually from Poland,
located in Melbourne. I used to play
League of Legends. Uh so I knew all the
IP. Our friend who is actually standing
next to us uh invited us for a quick
play. That was when they're doing the
pre-release of set one. We are very new
to the card games. I haven't played any
card game before. So I gave it a shot
and it sucked me in and I enjoyed had a
blast playing every day of it and that
now I'm here. I just love the strategy.
I used to play a lot of strategy games.
Is it either team fight tactics or other
strategization?
And because of that, there's this
element of I have to plan forward,
prepare for everything, no matter what
the opponent is. I'm just addicted. What
can I say? Um, my champion deck is said,
the the boss. I would say he's one of
the greatest picks you can have for set
three. He's very I would say underrated
by others
and I played him since set one and I'll
keep playing him until he rotates out.
I'm currently placed 52. Uh all of the
games were very close and enjoy every
single one of them. Uh the last game
that I had was h
was so close. It was like swinging
between both of us. Every round I would
went to three rounds. Uh but I'm looking
forward to playing the last game of
today. People here are lovely. Uh I
enjoy talking to them during and outside
of the event. Glad to be part of it and
hopefully I'll come to the next
regional. It's not I would say if
someone if you're not experienced
in ribbound, you haven't heard of it or
you just heard vaguely you're not don't
have that much knowledge, it's still
worth checking it, giving it a shot.
It's insane how much thought all the
players have to put through. It's
exciting no matter again if you're
experienced or not within the game.
First of all, I'd love to shout out my
Melbourne crew, all my friends, close
friends. Uh we've been practicing
together,
had amazing time. I would like to uh say
thank you to my girlfriend who is also
playing in this event and otherwise
anyone who I uh faced. It was an honor
facing playing with you no matter if I
won or lost.
Welcome back to coverage of original
qualifier Sydney. What a heartwarming
storm from one of our competitors here
in Sydney. But we get to the point where
it's the business end. Round 13 of Swiss
is upon us.
>> Oh, right at the end. And we did get to
see a little bit of you playing just
just now. Not necessarily the uh let's
say caliber of some of the other people
that have been here perhaps.
>> I'm mad. I'm mad about it.
>> Yeah, just a little. F my deck just
wants to uh you know
>> just a little a little mad about the
fact that your baited hook is just you
know
>> look it's called big casino poppy for a
reason.
>> Got a high roll. Did not high roll and
got rolled by Jyn of all legends which
feels extra bad.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And and you should
>> at least we got Jin on stream, right?
That was the goal really at the end of
the day.
>> Absolutely. Look, I mean it was nice to
be able to see the way that you mentally
reset given that we did get to see the
push-ups before the charismat. I don't
know. I feel like maybe I can sit
somewhere in between. Maybe later. I
don't think I'll be doing either
push-ups or baited hooks. So,
>> yeah, we'll figure that out.
>> We'll see what our competitors are doing
because we don't have too many games
left for some of our players. We're
going to have the last round here in
just a moment. And I don't know where
the standings are cuz it turns out there
was actually no undefeated left after
last round.
>> As it happens, turns out now everybody
is pretty much just hoping for the best
here. And again, I am not an expert at
how tie recommen works out. So for some
players, perhaps they'll be able to draw
if they're near the top of the standings
depending on how late they lost. You
have to think that players that were
doing a lot late into the round. Ghost
driver in particular despite picking up
a loss probably looking pretty good as
far as breakers go moving into top
eight. But potentially quite a few
players will just have to play or not
know and just play anyway because you
don't want to be the one that draws and
then misses top eight because you didn't
calculate properly. Oh my gosh, after
such a long weekend as well, you would
not want to get right to the end here
and then just on a clerical error be
like, nah, it's fine.
>> So, the good news is players are much
better at figuring this out than I am.
So, they typically, you know, looking
through the standings, figuring out
their breakers, and they're generally
pretty good at doing the math and
figuring out how to get into top eight.
So, we're in round 13. And honestly,
usually when we go to pair the rounds,
you have lots of different things we
have to think about. Which legends do we
want to see? Which players do we want to
highlight? Uh, all those things that
kind of go into picking feature matches.
And this round, I have to tell you, very
easy for the last round to Swiss.
>> The person that's picking feature goes
to the top table, figures out which two
matches are actually going to play in
this round, and then puts him in the
feature match area. It's very
straightforward.
>> The easiest pick of the day,
potentially. Yes.
>> And it gets Yeah, it is definitely the
easiest pick of the day. You kind of
just auto pick until you get to the
players that are deciding they do want
to bash it out. Whether or not they
should be, again, not up to me. I don't
do the math. I simply commentate the
game. So, whatever we see on stream
probably going to be a lot of sticks in
this matchup.
>> Yes, very much so. Again, the pressure
really does ramp up and well before we
maybe had a little bit of opportunity to
manifest what we wanted. We are entirely
down to what happens at those tables.
Now, those last two
>> certainly are flying blind. Very curious
to see how the legend mix all shakes
out. But again, could come down to a lot
of different things cuz many many X1's
hanging out in this event. And perhaps
with how with no defeated players being
left, maybe some X2s might balance see
if they win and can maybe sneak in as
well. Again, not up to me to figure it
out. That's somebody else's job. I'm
just here for the fun.
>> Well, speaking of, how are you feeling
about your predictions then?
>> I feel good. I feel like Challenger
Teslong Tech is very good and I do think
it will be making top eight. So then it
could still win. All to do is make top
eight. In fact, I think all of us will
still have our predictions live. I think
they'll be one of each at least. I think
I'm feeling pretty confident actually
that the Diana pick was the right call
to make in the end. We'll see how it
unfolds, but I'm feeling good.
>> Certainly, we'll have to see. Uhism
presumably floating around those top
tables again. Has not missed original
qualifier top eight, I think, ever, but
it's a wild stat for a player.
>> I mean, look, it is a really, really
thrilling thing to be like, "Yeah,
that's me. I've not dropped it." But
also, the pressure must be immense.
>> I mean, at some point, like variance
does get you. like you should not expect
to be this consistently successful, but
maybe they know something I don't. Pris
is a very good player. So, uh, when we
have our round aligned, I don't worry,
we'll get you there as soon as possible.
We're not doing anything other than
waiting.
>> Mhm.
>> The same thing you were all waiting for
home at more matches of Riftbound.
>> More baited breath rather than baited
hook at this point. Yeah,
>> Aurelia, Diana, Vex, maybe there's an
outside
>> Vex up there.
>> I think I saw an Azir floating around
near the top.
>> Oo, that could be interesting. a lot of
potential matchups we could be getting
here. I will say kind of thinking about
the metag game more holistically and
thinking about the decks we maybe
haven't seen a lot of Aurora. I don't
know if a single Aurora deck is going to
be making top eight. So sure a lot of
very normal discourse will erupt from
that little fact. Also Master E one of
the most represented decks in the field.
Actually I believe the not the most but
certainly the best converting and one of
the most present from day one. And I
don't think despite E's recent success
in Spirit Forge, I don't think E is
going to be making top eight this go
around either. Although again, still a
lot to work out for those final eight
players.
>> Absolutely. I do believe that day one
was a Leblanc nomination anything else.
And obviously, yes, Mi did convert
really, really well. Leblanc, I think,
came down maybe a couple of spots, but I
think we'll see definitely more
representation there in the top eight
than the
>> Yeah. And thinking I mean, it's funny to
think how far we've come as well. Like
Spirit Forge was a set all about Draven
and uh Fury in general. Haven't really
seen a lot of that domain as we have a
look at the metag game on day two. Just
to kind of paint a picture of where we
might be going. So Miy, Aurelia,
Leblanc, and Diana, Vex. I actually
think those well four of those five
legends I think we likely will see in
top eight or at least very close to. I
do think Yei has not had the best run
down the stretch as a deck despite how
well it's converted. And I think Civer
is just nowhere to be seen. M I will say
though the poppies that are on there
obviously a little bit uh more unlikely
but we did technically see a Poppy from
you so that kind of counts. I
>> think there was another Poppy on stream
also that was maybe a little bit better
maybe a little bit more suited for this
metag game we can say but yes we have
now gotten Poppy on stream at least
another time again. Thank you. We're
doing the work for you all to make sure
we get lots of unleash representation
across it all. I did actually end up
checking as well and it turns out that
there was also 7 MF for the
>> Oh, yep. Same as Poppy.
>> Same as Poppy
>> down from the 43 I think it was on day
one
>> as I mean look it it can go either way.
As an MF player I can say with absolute
certainty sometimes it's your day and
sometimes oh it's not.
>> Yeah. I think one of my favorite moments
from yesterday was actually a team of
player in the last round who was talking
about matchups said well I don't really
want to play Aurora when they have the
god draw. And I'm like, yeah, that makes
sense. Most decks don't want to play
against that. It's kind of tough to beat
it when they draw. But like I said, that
is the higher end of variance. You don't
expect to see that all that often. And
even though it is a deck where you can
navigate the games that aren't
straightforward and try and ek out
percentage points to get yourself wins,
it is a deck that could certainly not
only have its own failure rate, but just
in general, like players were very
clearly prepared for that strategy. I
have to think. And we don't even have
the top eight yet. We actually have no
idea where some of these decks are
placing. Mhm. Look, yeah, it's one of
those decks that if it is your time and
you do get that god draw, oh, it feels
so satisfying. But look, there is a lot
of hate around it and I do think you are
right that people did come in in
preparation for that. There was a lot of
gear hate built into these decks,
understandably so. But yeah, look, it
was it was always going to be a a tricky
one as to whether or not it would
actually convert, whether or not those
god draws would happen consistently. And
I mean, we all know having played, you
cannot consistently draw well every
single time. It's just not going to
happen.
>> And I do think some of that main deck
gear here might actually be all right in
general. Even thinking about potential
mantles, we could have in this round and
our last three rounds as well. Aelia
certainly has some gear that players do
like to pick up. If the Leblanc deck
we've been seen running around is there,
certainly players will be happy to have
main deck gear removal for baited hook.
That's something hook players typically
have to contend with. And uh I'm trying
to think Diana I don't think plays many
gear but Vex maybe like there are some
decks where you might still want to get
one every now and then. In fact is
really the deck where people like oh I
kind of just want a little bit of gear
eight just to slow you down and take the
BF sword out make combat math a bit
easier.
>> Yeah for sure. I think realistically
you're right the Aurelia decks is where
we're going to see the most impact with
that gear hate just because it's going
to make getting in there a lot easier
getting around some of those more tricky
defense pieces.
All right, let's uh go have a look.
>> Oh, at the road map.
>> Thanks so much. Uh, so where we started
is all the way back in 2025 in December,
which is very early on in the game's
lifespan and not too far away, but that
was the first regional qualifier won by
Annie in the hands of Dwali, who we have
seen on stream at this event here in
Sydney. Spirit of Forge then came out. A
lot of Draven happened at Bolognia and
Vegas. And then some other things
happened and maybe a couple cards were
taken out of the pool and Lil and
Atlanta showed us that the metag game
was still really fun even with Draven
still being around and now we're here in
unleashed and that was only a week ago
or so and Sydney has landed and things
look very different after this set came
out.
>> Absolutely. I mean the fact that we had
this many legends at this weekend it's
crazy.
>> Of course Vancouver Utre and Hyford all
going to be continuing on the season of
Unleash. There's even more where that
came from cuz Vendetta is going to come
out and trigger the last, not even the
last season, uh, the next season in the
road map with Barcelona and Singapore.
And then Radiant set five,
>> it's going to hit in October after LA in
September, which is going to be the
third event in that Vendetta season.
>> I'm excited. Yeah, Vendetta obviously
the uh a set for a lot of people that is
uh pretty exciting only because it is
the uh the bringing together of releases
for both China and English as far as
languages go. Simultaneous release for
sets given that the game was started
only as a project for China is wild to
think that's been done in four sets
given that physically product has to be
moved around the world in boxes to be
able to get in the hands of players. but
also uh there's been some very minor
spoilers for Vendetta and uh we're going
to get some opposite colored domain
combinations for the first time ever.
>> Very intriguing. But yes, we've learned
even just from today it's hard to move
this many people around, let alone that
much product. And we've had so many
people here this weekend. We've had over
1,600. I think 1,400 actually ended up
living it out through the days. And now
we are down to getting to that top
eight. It's crazy how quickly we can go
from that many to just a few.
>> Yeah, perhaps to thin out the field even
more in this final round, but still a
lot of matches to be played. Don't
forget, there are still best of prizes
on the lines potentially in this final
round as well. Even if your record is
not glamorous enough to make top eight,
you may want to win to make sure you
secure that very precious best of medal
card.
>> Well, now then, if you were
hypothetically to be going for a best
of,
>> which one are you thinking?
>> Leona.
>> Oh, interesting. And I kind of I'm
running out of time to be honest with
you. There's only not that many events
left. Again, as a reminder, the Origins
and Proven Grounds Legends are going to
be rotating out of the rest of rotation
the end of this season when Vendetta
will usher in their own legends into the
pool. So, uh, it's fun. There's not only
the 12 from Origins, but the four from
Proven Grounds on the chopping block, as
it were.
>> Absolutely. I think although I am
typically an MF player, I think if I was
going to go after this weekend, it has
to be Vex.
>> Vex is sweet. Vex is so sweet. I
actually went out and got myself one
after uh after talking about it and
yapping about it for so long. I've
managed to go get myself a little Vex
apathetic.
>> Very nice. Well, uh you'll use it
because that deck, a lot of decks, as
we've noticed, do want to utilize that
card. Curious to see how the metag game
evolves the next few events. Vancouver,
by the way, not too far away from this
event. So, if you thought Unleashed
release to Sydney happening was a pretty
short turnaround, which it was. Uh
Vancouver, I think, is less than two
weeks away from the end of this event.
as we have a look at the prizes on
store. Some beautiful that is so many
metal cards on display for all these
players to play for. But of course, the
champion Poppy and Champion play and
alongside the top play as well. You may
have eagle-eyed viewers may have noticed
I'm a cafe cuties Poppy Enjoyer if you
caught my little exhibition against uh
Barrett on stream.
>> And you're you're still very chill about
it, right? You've calmed down. Yeah.
>> Yeah, totally
>> feeling good.
>> Good. It's so fine that you were
defeated, actually.
>> All right, here it stands for round 12.
As a reminder, the last round of Swiss
is round 13. So, we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 X
and one players. Oh my goodness, the
team's in contention.
>> Goodness me, I would not have seen that
coming, but I'm really excited to be
able to see that.
>> So, just looking at these eight players,
right? If if we cut to top eight right
now and just use these eight players,
which I don't again that we have a round
to play, that is not what's going to
happen. But if we just cut these eight
right now in the standings, we would
have seven different legends. Aurelia
would be the only repeat from this list.
And we'd have Vex and Teemo.
>> There would be two Vex.
>> Oh, that is a lot more Vex than I
expected.
>> Absolutely.
>> It's wild that we've had two different
Vex players on stream. Both looking very
good. Both winning their preacher match.
And there is a third Vex player that is
higher in the standings than both of
them. But Bolan Zang still in contention
from round four yesterday,
>> I believe. So yeah, and they had a very
interesting build for their deck which
featured Aurelia quite heavily.
>> You can see the challenger TCD down
there. Leblanc did take a loss in the
last round. So maybe has to bash the
last one there.
>> They did not get the draw and they did
not let that Beta Cook go. I don't know.
It like you said, sometimes it works,
sometimes it doesn't. We shall see.
>> Oh, interesting. Two of the players have
a draw, so it's getting Okay, again, I
do not do tiebreaker math. Uh, it is
getting interesting, but it seems like
>> ghost driver and nice bow, who we saw in
our last feature, feeling pretty good
about their chances. Looks like we may
have one Aurora player sneak through as
well, unless Orange October is also on
an Aurora build and Fiora sneaks in. I'm
pretty confident that Sold Out is on a
Civer Aurora list. So, that may be the
one that sneaks through. Again, based on
the standings right now, which again,
there's going to be some shifting around
that happens.
>> Yeah. Yeah, just a little bit. And
again, I imagine the players are doing
the math very carefully at this point.
>> Oh, yes, very, very much so. Although,
you did say we hadn't seen much. So, now
maybe
>> now is the time.
>> Now's the time. Maybe we'll see it.
Maybe we'll see a little bit of Aurora.
See if they can get those draws. Who's
to say?
>> I guess I would expect the X2s
>> to probably just play and see.
>> Mhm.
>> I don't know what the players with the
draw to. The tenner ones I feel like can
feel relatively comfy. And there was
five of them.
>> Mhm.
>> Which may means one of them will have to
play.
>> But I don't know. Yeah. I don't know if
you necessarily want two draws.
>> Look, I think I'd like to see H.
Actually, what would you like to see?
Ideal world.
>> Oh, if we get to pick from the match I
just saw there. Oh goodness.
>> I want to see the Blanc in top eight.
>> Yeah.
>> So,
I guess if they have to play, maybe
that. Uh, otherwise I'm down for some
Vex again. That's a sweet deck. And I I
do feel like Civer and the Aurora crowd
have maybe gotten uh the fairest shake
of the stick as it were. So I'm I'm okay
to to get some Civer on stream.
>> Look, as I've always said, I am an
Aurora enjoyer and defender. I would be
very down to see a little bit.
>> I think honestly just based on the
texture of our top 10 that we just saw,
I feel like all our potential matchups
are very, very good.
>> Oh yeah. I feel like at this point on
Sunday, we know that the skill level is
going to be so well and so high and the
piloting is going to be really, really
efficient. So, either way, I think we're
going to be in for a very good time over
the rest of the day. I'm really excited
to be able to uh really just dive in as
soon as we are able. Obviously, we are
still figuring out who's going to be the
lucky ones to make it into that top
eight. certainly do because again
players are even though I'm guessing the
round has started uh players maybe
having a chat figuring out where am I
what are my tie workers like can I draw
do I have to play what do I want to do
am I hungry
>> I feel like probably a few of them would
be a little bit snacky right
>> so I think so
>> yeah it's been a long day
>> certainly has and uh not even no I don't
say not even close to we're more than
halfway through
>> the rounds we have on the docket for
today but we are getting awfully close
to the final Three.
>> All right, I have two. Oh, I see
Banzang.
>> You can see the hat from a mile away.
>> Certainly can.
>> This is very exciting then. I am keen to
see that. Vex.
>> Bolan. Obviously very successful player
in China. Made a few open qualifier top
eights there. And I believe actually won
one as well on Annie,
>> I believe. if I recall correctly. And
oh, I'm guessing that's sold out because
I'm seeing Aurora cards.
>> This will be interesting.
>> So, this is an X101 versus X. This might
be two X101's actually.
>> Mhm. Yeah. Bolan Zang went undefeated in
the pre-regional on Friday. So, came in
with a very good uh kind of sense of
momentum coming into the the weekend
here. But yes, one in Nanjing during
Spirit Forged.
>> I know who's playing Annie in that event
as well. So,
lot of good stuff between these two
players. This should be quite the match
up. And again, I am not the person to
tell you whether or not this is a win
and in. But all I can tell you is that
if you don't win, your chances are
worse.
>> So, if you if you win, all I can say is
if you win, your chances to make top
eight go up.
>> Oh, well. Yeah.
Trust me, the players would not be
playing if that wasn't true.
>> That is very very fair to say.
>> Look, I uh I'm very keen to see how Zex
will match up to this Civer.
>> It's definitely Aurora. Like I I've seen
enough cards, trust me. Very convenient
shuffling angle. There is B and Zang.
We'll pull it up again cuz we haven't
seen this Vex list for quite a while. I
think close to 10 rounds have elapsed
since we last saw this man on stream.
And now his Vex deck is back in the
spotlight.
>> There we have those three Aurelia
fervents that we were talking about
earlier. Also three Evelyn. We've seen
some really cool Evelyn plays from
people across the course of the weekend.
And then you've got all of your staples
really. Charms defies on guards
disciplines you know all of the regular
stuff. The edge of night as well. Three
of those. Couple of switcheroos and the
shovel of course.
>> So again assuming the match up no Aurora
hate in sight for game one. They want to
be getting on the battlefields early and
often and trying to race until before
Aurora comes down. Uh notably though,
there are some ways to potentially
combat
>> uh the big units, although Elder Dragon
can be a bit tricky. Switcheroo, very
good
>> going to potentially come in clutch
there a little bit. I think
>> this has been kind of Bolan's build.
Lots of hidden units of different kinds.
Three Switcheroos, three edge of
knights, three, one Teemo. Lots of
different options to hide onto a
battlefield and kind of just present a
problem to your opponent. Vex wants to
hold. So Vex is going to dig on into a
battlefield and say, "Come here.
>> What do you think it is?"
>> Exactly.
>> Look, I think depending on what we see
in this Aurora deck, it could be a very,
very interesting matchup here.
>> All right. I'm going to say I saw Blade
Flurry, so I'm pretty confident. Yes, it
is Elder Dragon, but no Baron's in
sight. Just three elders and one Mind
Spplitter was the choice.
>> Oh, interesting.
Look, I think it's it's fair to see that
we've got all of the staples here again.
A lot of the mobilize flurry of blades
definitely going to be very useful when
those elder dragons come out to play. So
yeah, look, I think realistically not a
hugely surprising.
>> What do you think?
>> I think Disposal Order is the most
interesting card I've seen in a main
deck all week. And this one is a two
energy reaction from Body. I believe
it's a new card if memory serves
correctly. Uh, choose one, draw a card.
Yeah, sure. That seems all right. Or
choose up to three cards from opponent's
trashes and then recycle them.
>> They're trying to fight against some of
the things like Fizz.
>> True.
>> You can also maybe No, not really. I was
going to say it mess your opponent's
Aurora, but not really.
>> But yeah, it's a weird bit of like trash
hate basically.
>> Yeah,
>> not a card we see a lot of. And I mean,
it's not a bad thing to run one of. This
deck can see a decent amount of cards
with things like stack deck and of
course pack of wonders and treasure
trove cuz again this is just trying to
dig for mostly one card at the end of
the day.
>> Uh so the fact that you can kind of
cycle this card by playing it and
drawing a card if nothing else. But
interesting I wonder what problem
>> they were trying to solve when putting
that card in their deck. Like what card
do they keep running into like I don't
want to do this anymore?
>> I do wonder if maybe they had a run in
with a Leblanc at some point maybe cuz
there's a little bit more recursion
there. Could be could be that could be
uh just taking Star Crush away from Fizz
and Annie.
>> Yes, very very likely as well.
>> All righty, game number one.
>> Fallen of X player on the left, sold out
on the right.
>> We have an abandoned hall and we have
Sigil of the Storm to kick us off here.
>> Again, Aurora just playing uh
battlefields that kind of suck to go to
cuz Aurora does not want you to go to
battlefields.
I did spy. Not only this mobilizer has
been played on turn number one, but
there is an Aurora in Sold Out's opening
hand.
>> The dream.
>> All right, Sneaky Deck going to kick
things off, though. Pretty nice way to
break serve on the draw, if you will.
Going to the hall and getting that point
nice and early.
>> You really want to try and uh get in
there as quickly as you can when you
know that there are the threats coming.
All right. So, pass it on back.
>> Not sure what. Oh, I guess B has hidden
cards.
>> That would be something that to tank on
at this point. I'm trying to What else
is it?
>> Well, there's the Evelyn.
>> Yep, there's Evelyn. And there's lots of
hidden cards in Bol. Just deciding
deciding if it's worth it or not.
>> Not a lot you have to worry about. I
mean technically uh Solut does have
Civer from the champ zone that could uh
come in ready as long as can pay enough
power which Civiver can do on her own
but Poland decides against hiding a card
just goes ahead passes it back don't see
a catalyst that would be the best
possible but stack deck could find one I
suppose
>> again it comes down to that draw
it's not quite the ramp spell you're
looking for
one in hand very quickly must have liked
All right.
>> Looks suspiciously like another
mobilize.
>> Yes, but it is good to see that Aurora
there as we said. So,
>> we shall see.
>> Another Mobilize. Can't play Catalyst at
this point. Didn't take the mobilize by
the looks of things. Sold out very quick
looking through these stack decks, which
uh kind of makes sense given the
>> how many rounds of Rift Bound we've all
played. Well, not me, but the players
have played at this point.
And again, oh, Gust deny the extra
point. Very common tool in Aurora deck.
Seen a lot of Gust. I think it was one
of the biggest, one of the most
represented spells this go around. And
actually holds up some runes. So I'm
pretty confident Solda had to mobilize,
but did not want to use it here. Just
goes ahead and passes on back. So does
mean that uh gust number two will
happen.
>> Keep those deck hands at bay.
>> The Mouser
>> mutated Mousa. So this is not nine
runes. This is only seven. But deciding
that the uh pushing your opponent off
some points is more worthwhile than
mobilizing when it doesn't really hit
the threshold you're looking for. So,
pack of wonders hits the table. This
one's very good with treasure trove and
sometimes good with others, but solar
going to pass on back. Bowling going to
awaken. Don't forget to wake the cat up.
There we go.
>> There we go.
>> And I will say not the draw you're
looking for cuz again kind of have to
get on board early. Get those points.
Put that pressure on Aurora. And uh one
point only thanks to all those gusts.
Means that plan is not really uh working
out right now.
>> Well, potentially two then actually
>> once again looks over. Do you have gust
number three?
>> M
>> a little a little pause there.
>> I appreciate the uh panache whether or
not it's there. Thumbs up.
>> Thumbs up. There we go. All right.
>> Yeah, you really do want to make sure.
Oh, there you go. And another over
there. Unless they've got an answer, but
I I imagine they would have answered
earlier if that was the case.
>> Yep. Back up. Well, same deck handling
that got gusted earlier, so good for a
third point here.
>> Not too much of a loss as far as overall
point tempo goes, but Zack's apathetic
going to reinforce the battlefield. And
uh
>> a card as well.
>> So, I think bowling at this point just
saying, "I hope you don't have Aurora."
And uh I got bad news, buddy. Yeah,
look, as we said, you really do want to
establish a hold very, very early when
you can see how quickly the around. Oh,
>> I was like that one.
>> That was that was an interesting uh
showcase of what you have there.
>> Nine runes
make a gold thanks to Civiver. One of
the advantages Civer gets does not fall
nearly as far behind on power costs
thanks to getting a refund pretty often.
>> And we'll flip on over and likely hit an
elder, but I guess it could be the other
one. Could be the mind spplitter.
>> Well, it's an older dragon.
>> It's an elder.
>> Very pretty elder dragon, I might add.
>> Absolutely.
>> Yeah. Look, the the one thing that I
will say for Civiver is that because of
that resource generation, it does make
it a little easier if you do have to go
more with a a natural Elder Dragon at
some point.
>> All right. Well, I kind of like this
from Bolan hiding an extra unit, knowing
the Elder Dragon could only kill one
unit a piece at each location. Vex
apathetic actually being left alive.
Curiously, the Deckhand is the unit that
gets shot down by the elders flames. But
two more points, holding to five, and it
looks tough cuz again, Elder Dragon is
just so good at efficiently cleaning out
units, but Bolan is at least giving it a
go here, trying to get the points on the
board and maybe steal away a win here.
Oh.
>> Oh,
>> never mind.
>> That was a very quick decision there.
>> Well, we know the bowl doesn't have
anywhere to answer game number one.
>> Look, understandable at this point. When
you know, you know. We will have to see
what gets sideboarded in here. I have to
imagine that they had something for this
for the weekend given that as we said,
we did anticipate a pretty significant
Aurora presence.
>> Yeah, I think every player has come in
being like, how do I beat this deck?
Whether they're playing it themselves
and playing the mirror or uh needing
something from their sideboard moving
forward, but trying to remember if Bolan
talked about his matchup as much in the
interview we did on day one. And if he
did, I have a feeling wasn't that fun to
this matchup. And after that game, I can
kind of see why.
>> Yeah. Look, it's it's never fun to to
know that you don't have the answer, but
there is still opportunity.
Yeah, I think uh in games where those
gusts maybe weren't as frequent in those
early turns does feel like would have
been uh maybe a bit more manageable to
try and
>> ek out a win
>> a slightly
>> eight points, but I mean that roar
didn't even get cast that early.
>> No, it it did take a little while, but
ultimately when it works, it works.
>> All right. Well, uh, Bolan is
unintentionally
as a flash of a few cards in the
sideboard.
>> Deep in thought there.
>> Did see a mind spin. I did see a
disarming rake.
>> That would be very useful.
>> That one's really good against
>> Yes, it is. It is uh unfortunately one
that I'm acutely familiar with.
>> Well, players are going to thumb through
their boards, shuffle up, and nice thing
about scooping early in the game. plenty
of time in the round to think think
about what decisions you might want to
make, what changes you want to make.
Curious to see if SA has other units in
the board. We saw this in our other
Aurora match on feature where we had way
more units in the later games.
>> So, an option here, but very slim in
general for these Aurora decks that
we've seen at least on stream. Pretty
much been sticking to three elder
dragons and one other unit. In this
case, Mind Splitter for sold out. In our
other matchup, it was uh the Baron,
which was quite fun. I would be very
curious to see if Sold Out has another
minds spplitter maybe in that sideboard.
I would be surprised if they had a Baron
in there. I feel like it is becoming
less of a common choice now for Aurora
decks, even though it does still have
that potential to really change the
board state, giving that extra
battlefield there.
>> Guess I didn't actually do a mental
check of how many star cross Bolan has
either. That is another way to answer
Elder Dragon. In fact, that's one of the
ways that Chaos tends to deal with that
unit. And with with your Rolex going
pretty far in on Elder as their big
payoff unit.
>> Uh,
>> and understandably so, I'd say.
>> And I guess the key difference to
highlight here. So, one of the big
differences to play C versus MF cuz you
kind of saw the MF version earlier
yesterday and, uh, that looked very good
at ganking across with gigantic units
and just acrewing points at a rapid
rate. Uh C's advantage is that whenever
you pay your power cost and you do pay a
decent number of them over the course of
the game, obviously you have to pay to
to play Aurora, uh you get a little
rebate, your little gold back, uh
recycling once per turn. Uh actually, I
guess you have to exhaust Civer, you get
one and then you can sometimes get it
back, but I don't know if this deck is
going to be doing a whole lot of that.
Have to conquer, I believe, in order to
get that done. In fact, let's read Civ's
legend text while we're here, shall we?
A bit of time. Uh, when you recycle a
rune, you may exhaust me to play a gold
gear token exhausted when one or more
enemy units die. Ready me? Actually,
that happens quite frequently.
>> Yes, it does
>> thanks to Elder Dragon. So, uh, the this
really means that you kind of get like a
an investment back on your power cost
when you pay them.
>> And obviously, Aurora costs a lot of
power. Elder Dragon, if you ever have to
play, cost a lot of power.
>> It is not a fun one to play naturally.
And this is one of the advantages that
Civer Aurora has over MF Aurora is you
don't get the ganking and your champion
unit I would argue is a little bit
worse. I think MF is though they can
both ready themselves up with have
accelerate. I think MF is uh has a
little bit more flexibility as far as
how you move it
>> on your little bit uh it's pretty close.
>> It comes down to resource versus
mobility,
>> right?
>> And obviously Civ did have I believe the
boots of swiftness in there as well. So
there is that element of mobility there.
They are covering that base as well.
>> Yeah. For how few units these decks
have. They do have a lot of things like
uh bits of mobility. Some of this have
punch first like this. They do know they
have to do some, you know, unit based
things at some point. They just want
their units to be really really big. But
the the big thing I was going to say is
that because you get a bunch of gold
back
>> as we have a look at Bolan's main deck
once again. And I yes did not
successfully see any copies of Starrust
cuz one of the things is when you get
your Elder Dragon Star obviously uh the
damage gets dealt but it's not lethal
damage anymore cuz Elder is not there.
And usually the big problem is Aurora
struggles to replay that unit fairly
right to get all those runes and they
actually pay for it because the power
cost is so steep. That is not something
CV has to worry about because he gets so
much gold and actually kind of just gets
to a point where it's like yeah you can
bounce my unit. I'm just going to keep
playing and eventually you're going to
run out of bounces. I still have the
elder dragon. So that is kind of one of
the reasons to play Civer over MF as we
have a look at sold out deck again.
Again, this is the main deck,
>> not featuring the side
>> the boots. It was Bolan who had the
boots of swiftness there. So not as much
mobility here after all
>> comparatively does have a last rights.
Obviously very good at looping your
units. This kind of one of the things
that Civer has done for a while actually
as a deck. Uh no challenges in this main
de either with three sabotagers clearly
respecting the mirror. Also, flurry is a
removal spell you can use very
effectively, but only really when you
have the elder dragon, I guess, unless
you're playing Victor. But, uh, last
means that at some point, this deck can
just keep looping its units indefinitely
with Aurora. I don't know if you've ever
been mindsplitted every single turn of
the game, but it's really tough to win
that game.
>> Mhm. I've not been mindslitted every
turn of the game,
>> but
I have been a menace at the table. So, a
little little B. Let's have a look at
what our players are doing here. Game
number two underway in just a moment. I
have to imagine. Sold out one zero up in
this best of three series. And again, we
are very close to the top eight. These
players had very good records coming in,
but winning likely gets you inning at
this point.
>> Did see that Aurelia in hand there.
>> Yeah, new card as well. So, Bewitching
Spirit actually in Bolen's hand that is
not in the main deck. So way to try and
disrupt Aurora early is fortify position
going to be up against forgotten
monument. This is not a card we see all
that often. We've seen seen a lot of
forbidding. We've seen a lot of uh
rockfall path. We have not seen
forgotten monument today.
>> So forgotten monument with players
cannot score here until their third
turn.
giving a little bit more of a uh kind of
developmental run to be able to get to
that battlefield and have a score there.
>> Seems really good going second when
you're the deck that doesn't play units
into turn four.
>> Yep.
>> And so Bolan's plan was to try and get
on Battlefield early, get some early
points, and rush away. Well, that has
been significantly slowed down thanks to
Forgotten Monument. And I know the last
battlefield in Soldout's list is
Aspirants Clan, which does a similar
thing
>> exactly.
>> Of trying to uh extend the game so
Aurora can get online. Forgotten
Monument feels like a very
>> uh very smart choice in this Battlefield
lineup.
>> Yes, absolutely. Especially knowing that
Bolan is going to try and go as hard as
possible very very early on to combat
the fact that that late game for the
Aurora if it goes off is just so
dominating.
>> All right, the mobile to start things. A
Gust was found again.
>> Not sure which unit that may have
bounced. But two scriers bloom. Another
one that Aurora players have been
enjoying. This one's pretty simple. Uh
comes in exhausted, but you can paste
some energy, kill it, and then predict
two and draw one. And again, the theme
is really just look for one specific
card in your deck.
>> It does also grant you one XP. It's not
necessarily the most uh useful in this
situation, but uh good to note as well.
>> Certainly does. I don't think anyone's
gone all the way down to playing
something like investigator cuz it is a
small unit and you tend to want big
unit. But uh maybe maybe Aurora players
will move on to use do something with
their excess XP or maybe it's just fun
thing to keep track of in the game. Hard
to say as uh this deck hand still
holding down the fort now two points to
zero. But this is very normal for
Aurora.
>> Mhm. doesn't score points for a little
while but tends to start scoring them in
it's hard to say in big chunks because
you can only score so many points a turn
of rebound but that's what it feels like
when you play against this deck.
>> Well, I think that often is the case
because a lot of Aurora decks as we said
do run Baron as well and you can get
bigger chunks when you're getting on all
three.
>> Certainly can I think that certainly
makes more sense in MF as Aelia going to
be committed here. Dan going to retreat
on out and uh hopefully that hidden card
is enough to protect this Aurelia. But
we saw the Gusts early on that was very
good at dealing with the early units
Bolan had. Aelia significantly bigger
than uh Gust is able to happen as Aurora
I believe ripped off the top
>> but not enough runes I believe. 1 2 3 4
5 6 seven. Yep. Only eight in play. So
starting to dig with the sky bloom
navigate these next few turns moving
into that first Aurora turn. H
you would be feeling okay about it so
far having Aurelia there obviously on
the fortified position battlefield when
you defend there you choose a unit that
gains shield to this combat while it is
a defender so a little bit better off
but obviously when we get those elder
dragons out here it's still going to be
very contentious
>> pretty sure one of Bolan's hidden cards
is a zaas
>> yes that I believe so
>> so that would be maybe okay for the
upcoming turn. Again, I'm thinking
ahead, right? Cuz I I know what's in
here. I think Bolan also at some point
has to be like, well, when they get to
nine runes, I expect Aurora to happen.
>> Doesn't always happen.
>> Sabotage there.
>> You do have to suspect a sabotage comes
through looking for something to take.
Notably, you cannot take disarming rate
cuz it is a unit
>> and mind splitter also very, very good
here.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> We have three units actually. So, boot's
going to go away. Ong guard going to
stay in hand alongside Aurelia Fervent,
Bewitching Spirit, and Mindsplitter. And
we've se we saw Mindsplitter do the
opposite
>> for the Aurora deck. Take the Gearhead
out of her hand. Now I feel like the
Minds is going to take the Aurora out of
someone's hand.
>> Oh, it's rough to be an Aurora player
when there's a mind spplitter on the
other side sometimes.
>> Vex draws a card, channel some runes,
get conveniently all the way up to
seven, perhaps even get another point
cuz I believe we've now had enough turns
passed where Forgotten Monument is ready
to go. Is that even true? 2 3 4 5 6 7
Actually, I don't think I can't score it
until their third turn. Okay, it is now
the third turn.
>> So, technically speaking,
>> the monument is open.
>> Monument is open for business, ready to
be scored at.
>> It is wild how much work this
battlefield has done though to kind of
curb the points at all. Granted, that
would mean B would have had to had
another unit to play and try and take
control, but this these three points
could have easily been five.
>> Oh, yeah. which still is not necessarily
enough to feel confident against Aurora.
>> No, but that's kind of what we saw last
game. Poland got to five
>> pretty easily even in the face of an
elder dragon and immediately scooped up
their gods.
>> All right, so decision decisions. Mind
split going to reinforce this
battlefield and show me what you got.
You have an Aurora. Oh no,
>> he has two full Aurora. There is rough.
>> Little nod to the head. I wonder if you
just take the shovel here ever or the
blade flurry. 3 4 5 6 7. No, it's not
exactly sold that gives a little look to
the camera. I believe uh understanding
the situation uh that has befallen his
opponent.
>> Look, if you take the flurry though, if
you do draw one of the elder dragons, it
can be
>> a little, you know, well, you never want
to have to face in to an elder dragon
coming right at you. But taking that
away, maybe ah it's
It's hard not to want to just
>> Yeah, I I don't think there's anything
other than Aurora that makes
>> a lot of sense here. At some point, you
have to work through one of them.
>> Oh, yeah. It's Yeah, it's inevitable
really that one of them at least had to
go. Having two on the board would be
rough.
>> All right. Looks like should be point
number four, I believe. Yep. Off to four
for Bolan. So, uh, feeling good as far
as points go, but those points might be,
uh, washed away in a moment
>> as the incoming Aurora and the expected
Elder Dragon.
>> It could be a mind splitter.
>> Now, it could be a mind splitter. It is
a 25% chance to be a mind splitter.
>> Well, we don't know. There could
possibly have been more units coming in
from that sideboard.
>> That's true.
>> Could also be more.
>> Could be. Uh, in fact, that I I wouldn't
be surprised to see one more mind
spplitter in the sideboard.
gear
sabotage which we saw uh played earlier.
Oh my goodness, there's the third
Aurora.
>> Oh my goodness.
Ah,
>> when it rains it pours and when it roar
it roars.
>> There we go.
>> Going to exhaust a few more runes.
>> Just a couple.
>> Uses that gold. Gets a gold back.
>> Exactly. what's coming here.
>> And uh flips it on over looking for
probably an elder, but could be
something else. Could be anything. Could
even be a
>> digging all the way through there. My
goodness.
>> Sometimes you got to flip through a
couple. You know, it's part of the fun.
Oh, it is a
>> mind.
>> Oh, we drew another one.
>> Oh,
>> so it feels bad to lose one, but feels
good to not get older dragon.
>> That is true. That is true.
>> Having the extra information of knowing
what's in hand, though, I don't know.
When I uh when I anticipate having to
come up against an Aurora in a mirror, I
I like knowing everything, but I hate
knowing that they know what I've got.
>> I'm just looking at these pumps and I'm
like, I just don't think any of them are
ever going to be enough.
>> Maybe like for the Mindsplitter, that
discipline is okay, but Aurelia can also
get pretty big. It's not really the
problem you tend to have when you're
playing up against
>> not so much. Uh the units it's more the
the big dragon that breathes fire on
your team that tends to cause more
issues.
>> So going to go all the way to six
points. Draw a card from Vex. Tunnel
some runes. Draw a card for turn.
>> There are avenues to victory here for
Bolan. Technically in position to win on
his next turn.
>> Yes, but we
>> Yes, but
>> we unfortunately have the knowledge of
what is potentially to come. Obviously
Bolan at this point kind of speculating.
You would assume
potentially that there is a good chance
of it given that we did see so much of
the deck come through for finding that
mind spplitter.
You never know. Kind of always have to
to bank around it, I suppose.
>> Yeah. I think in general the players
that have probably at this point that
have started to that have played against
AO both in in the tournament and in
testing
>> probably know that I think Elder Dragon
is kind of the unit everyone is building
around. Uh I do think there are probably
some uh other paths that are valid
>> that don't involve just jamming three
elders as your primary unit. But I think
at least for the oras we've seen succeed
in the future material and I think the
players probably suspect this as well.
Elder Dragon's kind of the unit you have
to watch out for.
For sure. There is a mind spplitter in
there. Yeah,
>> just found another one off the top. Aia
Fervent Butching Spirit Boots of
Swiftness.
>> Yeah, it is another minds splitter.
>> Got to be happy with having an extra
mind spplitter off the top there.
>> It's interesting because
Oh, I guess you know about the blade
flurry.
>> Mhm.
>> So, that actually does seem reasonable
to want to take.
>> Yep.
>> I was trying to think like you would
never suspect the third Aurora.
>> No, definitely not.
Oh, Evelyn comes out.
>> Little Evelyn backline.
>> Interesting.
>> And they're actually just going to take
the Oh, it's forbidden. Oh, never mind.
The shield. The shield means you win the
fight. Evelyn entrancing. When you play
me from face down on your turn, you may
move an enemy unit at a different
location to my battlefield
>> and has back. So, has to fight the big
monster first. Mindsplitter loses the 1v
one.
And uh fortified position surprising me
once again in the feature match area.
Yes, that plus two when you are
defending does make a big difference.
>> So, problem one dealt with.
>> Mhm. There's still a very big problem on
that board though. Well, there's
potentially going to be a lot more
problems.
>> I think only cards are in sold out's
hand. Bewitching spirit is maybe
something to consider, but I think
there's plenty of things that are at
this stage in the game things you can
reasonably throw away.
>> Mhm. as Civiver. So, I don't think
losing one card is going to feel all
that bad. So, I feel like if you're
going to play something here, given that
given that you can kind of ignore the
like combat value of the units in the
game right now
>> because I think at this point
>> if you have units to conquer with,
you're probably going to conquer with
them. If you don't have units to conquer
with, you're probably going to lose.
>> Yeah,
>> there's really no way around it.
>> But I do like the Ballins again taking
time. Scooped it up quickly in the first
game. plenty of time left in this round
to think both players playing at a more
than reasonable pace. So just trying to
think through what does the next turn
cycle look like cuz in Bolan's mind this
is a turn cycle that he makes or breaks
this game and if you lose this game you
got no hope left.
>> I do think it would be very very
tempting to get rid of that flurry given
that you know that the chances of the
next unit being an elder dragon and
given that you have got that many units
out now you kind of want to mitigate as
much as possible. So it was the third
might but only three cards enhanced for
whing spirit actually reasonably high
value but getting additional information
is Bolan Zang now seeing that there is
in fact a another Aurora in the hand
>> it does make it
frustrating sure. So,
so if you think if you think your best
chance to win is on the upcoming turn
circle, right, score these next two
battlefields, whether by holding or by
conquering.
>> I feel like you just want to protect as
many units as you can. Takes the
>> Ooh, yeah,
>> that's the Aurora.
>> Interesting.
>> So, I did count sold out and that is
eight currently. After turning two,
that's going to be 10. Obviously,
Aurora, you don't even have to pay for
it. That's already been paid for. So if
you hit an elder, you can blade flurry
as a reaction after all that happens.
>> Yeah, going to be the first one here.
>> Really hard to look past getting rid of
that second Aurora, but in this
particular circumstances when you are so
concentrated on trying to hold to get
that
>> Oh,
>> I figured it out.
>> Yeah,
>> you can't beat two elders. You can beat
one.
>> Exactly.
>> That's what it is.
>> Oh, you're right.
>> It's not even It's not even about the
flurry cuz Bolan also moved a bunch of
units back. not really staying on the
battlefield, just moving all these units
to location and saying even if you hit
the elder and you are likely to hit an
elder at this stage,
>> you can only kill one of my units in my
base and I have enough to rescore these
battlefields and take us to a third
game. I just didn't want to get pinged
twice.
>> Understandable.
>> Blade Flory does only work at
battlefields and ball on Zang one step
ahead of me unsurprisingly
in a pretty good position to win here.
Civer going to be coming on out. Might
as well. Well, you got some extra power
to spend. Got some extra stuff going on.
Might as well accelerate the civer up.
She's a six now. She's ready to go.
She's charging into the fortified
position. And uh that's enough to kill
the four might Evelyn after fortify
position goes off
>> and at least presenting some additional
might as elder dragon literal first card
flipped off the top.
>> And now you get to say, do I need to
reinforce with this elder dragon? Cuz
that will make it much harder to score a
battlefield. Very much so.
>> So, we know Bowman has answers.
Switcheroo. We already highlighted a
card that is very good
>> into these decks. You only need to take
out the Aldot once to get the damage
done, but that is 14. Sorry, 16.
>> 16 with the fortified position there.
Adding that little extra bit of shield.
>> Going to lose it. Oh, that's true. The
fortified position cuts both ways
>> betraying Paul Bol and Zang. His mind
splitter going to be shot by the elers's
breath.
>> Good enough to take out one of those
units. So 7 + 4 is 11 + 2 is 13 might
plays. What did you say again?
>> Uh 16.
>> Bearing in mind that any amount of your
damage is enough to kill enemy units
with that elder dragon.
>> Yeah, I think it's 12 plus Oh, Elder's
only 10. It cost 12. Okay, 16 the number
to beat. 13. Pretty close, but you do
have to waddle one more unit down to
that forgotten monument cuz you do need
both points to win this turn. One is not
going to be enough. How big can Aelia in
Vex really get? Perhaps we'll find the
answer very soon.
>> Well, they do have boots of swiftness
there in hand, but the costs depending
on how they want to do this. Well,
they've got the runes.
>> Yeah, I've got a decent number of runes
to play with here. No obvious out here.
No rebuke, no star, no charm,
>> no easy way to push this elder off of
this battlefield. If it was just Civer
you had to contend with, it wouldn't
feel all so bad. But having that extra
dragon there as well does make it dark.
>> I do appreciate that uh Aurora's chosen
champion like does actually do something
in a lot of cases. It seems feels like
flavor text a lot of the time in your
deck, but uh actually winning a combat
to give you this reinforce to stay alive
knowing that your opponent was two
points away from taking you to game
number three. And uh far as four to five
positions go, Elder Dragon is very good
at holding things down as discipline
going to find this Aurelia. Pump her up
three more. One for being chosen, two
for the discipline all the way up to
eight.
>> Mhm.
>> Draw a card. Boots of swiftness the
second. That copy doesn't feel nearly as
good as the first.
>> That does bring total of all of the
units, I believe, up to
16. a quick mathematics.
>> So you got to let somebody
live.
>> So the other thing is again it's it's
vex. It's not actually Aurelia. So even
if you do have ganking readying the
Aurelia to actually gank, not so easy.
>> Now you could
maybe try and set something up where
you'd play to hold the last battlefield
>> potentially.
>> Again, another elder. Oh, wait. You know
about the blade flow? You can't do that.
Yep.
>> Never mind.
>> Nope. We cannot risk that.
>> Never mind. That one really doesn't
work. Is it two? I think it's three
cards left in sold out's hand.
>> Kept the one drew on the other turn.
>> Didn't play a card from hand. Obviously
played the champion from the chosen
champion area. So ball and Zang puzzling
it out here in game number two. This
looks tough.
>> Ah. Yes. So in hand I think for sold out
is is it just the flurry?
>> Flurry last rights and I think one
mystery.
>> Oh, the last rights is gone.
>> Oh yes.
>> Trouble's in the trash. I had trouble
getting the trash.
>> It was you.
>> Uh when boots of swiftness coming out
onto Aurelia Fervent there.
>> So there's another choice. Aelia gets
bigger once again. Plus the plus two
from the boots itself. Roland Zang doing
the wrath. 5 + 4 is 9 plus two is 11.
Rolling on in to try and take out the
elder perhaps. And then the other two
will actually be big enough. Right.
>> M I think so. Trigger target fortify
position.
Hopefully didn't forget dragon now at
12.
>> That's 11.
>> That's not enough.
>> Does Bolan have another pump?
>> Let's see.
>> Yes, he has an on guard.
>> Yes, there is the on guard there.
>> I would have forgotten, but Bolan Zang
is no ordinary found player.
>> Mhm. Ahead of both of us there.
>> Unsurprising.
Oh, blade. Oh, there's left for blade
flurry.
>> Oh, I didn't realize that had a rune
available.
>> Well, that makes things a bit trickier.
>> That's rough.
>> That's rough, buddy. That's true.
>> All right. Well, uh, ignore all the math
we did because, uh, blades fixing the
issue for sold out very swiftly,
>> but now the flurry is gone.
>> Yes. So now is the other side of the
plan to try and hold the other
battlefield.
>> Mhm.
>> Cuz there's no more Civer to contest at
that battlefield.
You know, it's probably going to be an
elder dragon. That one doesn't come in
ready. C. Oh, does have ganking?
>> Well, no. No, Civer doesn't have
ganking. And we were discussing earlier,
there isn't as much mobility unless they
have sideboarded in some boots of their
own, which I wouldn't imagine they
would. They Oh, no. can get ganking if
you have uh spent
>> okay. Yeah,
>> a little bit. Yeah,
>> if you spend two power, which is
something Aurora is very easy to do. In
fact, I actually So, I know you're
allowed to recycle a rune just as a
thing. Like, you're allowed to do that
in the game. That is something you're an
action you're allowed to take, which
every now and then Civer does to make a
gold in a funny spot.
>> Civer also going to get taken out and
mines, but they're going to try and hold
down the fort.
>> Card there as well.
>> Oh, no. No need to think. Yeah, no way
to equip the boots cuz out of chaos
power, the elder dragon is going to
awaken. Scalled a second point of the
game for a sold out, but it feels like
even though it's a uh 7 to two point
game, I don't think the points are
particularly relevant here.
>> Mm-
>> So Civer, which could have gotten
ganking, is going to get dealt with. I
do like that decision.
>> I agree.
>> So now, how do you prevent your opponent
from holding?
>> Yes.
And I will say you don't exactly know,
but your suspicion should be the hidden
card at that battlefield is a unit.
>> I would imagine so. I feel like having
seen the Evelyn in that first matchup,
maybe there's a suspicion there
>> because your opponent knows an old is
coming and one unit at a single
battlefield doesn't do anything against
Elder Dragon.
>> So Mindsitter comes down, takes away
something.
>> One of these cards, not sure they're
going to matter at this stage of the
game. I think this may well be the
effectively the final turn of this game
whether literally for Bolan Zenang
taking us to game number three or
effectively for sold out
>> may indeed seal their invitation into
today's top eight
>> that Aurelia
>> Aurora time
>> Aurora time indeed
>> time to find out you got a second mind
spplitter
>> there's an Elder
>> Elder
>> unit that's a tie turner
>> Elder dragon's going to come to base and
then I'm going to use his uh
>> I would like to deal a damage to one of
your units.
>> All the damage I deal is lethal.
>> Yep.
>> I got this guy.
>> Can you deal with this?
>> I have a
>> Oh,
>> I believe I heard the fated words. I
have a response.
>> Oh, what is
>> another
>> flurry of blades? I think undoing Bolen
Zang's hopes and dreams.
>> That is rough. It is a very very cool
move though from Sold Out to have held
that one and brought it out at this
juncture. Oh my goodness. To have a
second.
>> Sometimes you just have it.
>> Yeah.
>> Mindsplitter saw it, baited out the
first one.
>> Mhm.
>> And second one just could not be
avoided.
Sold out I believe going to take this
game. Bolan still playing by the looks
of things. So puzzling a way out of this
game. M
>> but victory is looking assured. Not all
but assured but looking assured.
>> It's looking pretty good.
>> The points may be very dramatically
different.
>> Oh yeah.
>> But do not be fooled.
>> Look, I mean it depends a lot I suppose
if Bolan has some confidence that they
have any chance of finding maybe
something in as well.
>> Interesting.
>> Oh, that is
now that is hilarious.
So, we know in sold out main deck there
are only four units.
>> We know last rights is in the trash.
>> Yep.
>> That bewitching spirit there.
>> I don't know if there's enough time
>> to get something onto the battlefield
that can contend with the minds, let
alone the elder that's going to be
there.
>> Bewitching spirits there. And if you
can't hold, you have to score twice on
each battlefield. And I don't know that
double conquer is something that is
possible for Bonzang's deck right now.
>> I I can't imagine so at this point. Not
with the two elders there.
>> Treasure trove.
>> Mhm.
>> Might as well given that uh nothing else
to do.
>> Yeah, sure. Go again.
>> Little little recycle. Channel a rune.
Get it back. Get a gold.
>> Gold.
>> That's like a bonus gold there. Draw a
new card. What have we here?
>> We're going to find out cuz I don't
think Soldo wants to hold too many other
cards in hand.
>> No,
>> it's another shovel.
>> Yeah,
>> not ideal.
>> All right. Well, uh,
>> and there's the
>> trouble has begun.
>> Yeah,
>> all those units that made every run out,
they're no longer run out. Last rights
getting it done. Finding it off the top.
Equipping that mine spitter. Charging on
into the forgotten monument.
>> I you would imagine so.
>> We're rolling dice. Oh, very exciting. I
think that was to randomize the two
cards.
>> Yep.
>> That were in that uh in that recycle
from the shovel.
>> The minus going in there on to Forgotten
Monument.
>> I'm I'm genuinely like trying to find
any way out.
>> I mean, I don't know what Bolan has in
his side.
>> True. I mean, the fact that Bolan is
still kind of working things out makes
me think that maybe maybe he's thinking
there's something in there, but
>> it's a very very tricky position to be
in right now.
>> Oh, forgot about this part of the last
rights situation.
>> Uh, when you conquer a hold, you may
play a unit from your trash.
>> Another mind splitter.
>> I went on out and that does confirm
there's more than one mind splitter.
>> That is true.
>> Yes.
Two elders, two mind splitters. Ouch.
>> All right. So, I think Soldier is saying
I don't have any Oh, I don't have any
units except this one.
>> Mhm.
>> So, goes to the last two cards, plays
the odd, loses the witching spirit, does
have to reveal the rest of the deck.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah. So, it does do so cuz B says, "You
know what? You got it." Extends the
hand. Very sportsmanlike from Bow and
Zang is sold out. Two zeros his final
round to presumably
make their way into top eight. Well, we
shall see. We shall see. It is very cool
to see an Aurora this high up this late
in the day. I'm I'm feeling, you know,
gratified that we got to see one at
least. It is a very very tricky matchup.
I'm a little sad to say goodbye to this
Vex build, but not necessarily.
>> Yeah, I mean, uh I don't know what's
going to happen. I even don't even know
how many matches are still playing this
round.
>> All that information and more. Well,
we'll find out when we find out.
Hopefully we find out sooner rather than
later,
>> but at some point soon we're going to
have all the matches in round 13 done
and somebody is going to do the math and
they're going to spit out our last eight
players here in Sydney.
>> I will say though, I I'm really glad
that we did get to see another go of
that Vex with the Aurelia at the desk.
>> Yeah,
>> very cool.
>> One of the hearts and minds of people I
think here in Sydney.
>> Absolutely. I think it has definitely
been unexpected and that is one of the
reasons that I it sticks in the brain
you know
>> and I don't know what our top eight
composition is yet of course but let's
just make an assumption here let's say
solder is in the top eight
>> presume
>> I don't know what the rest is happening
but again we've seen the top 10 players
or so coming into this round we know
roughly what the possible mix of legends
could be
>> I think we've hit the right balance
based on where we where we are coming
into this round cuz we have a little bit
of Aurora but not a lot of bit of Aurora
which is what everyone was worried about
and there's so much more across the
swath of possible legends presumably in
our top eight makeup.
>> And presumably we are also seeing quite
a few unleash legends which is really
really lovely to see given that it has
only been like a week a week and a bit
since release. People have been cooking.
>> They certainly have. So when we know
don't worry we'll tell you when our top
eight is done. But I have to think there
are still matches being played.
I mean, you look, there could be two
players at X and 4 fighting out for the
best stuff.
>> You never know.
>> Gets uh gets wild out there on the final
day of play.
>> That would be to that to me would almost
be more fun than a potential top eight
win in.
>> There's two players slogging it out for
the best of Jin. Let's say
>> Jin maybe. Look,
>> had to pick someone.
>> Yeah, someone. Look, if nothing else, it
has been really, really lovely to see
the sportsmanship that everybody has
displayed here, especially up on the
desk. It is a testament to Sydney. I'm
going to claim.
>> Why not?
>> Something in the water.
>> Just encouraging good habits.
>> That's good. I like to see that.
>> Why not?
>> All right. Well, uh I don't know if we
have a backup match. If we do, try to as
soon as we have it, but other than that,
we are just going to be waiting here for
the end of round 13 because there is a
lot we still do not know. We know
roughly how many players had what
records coming into this one. We know 10
players were looking decent coming into
the final round of Swiss, but uh we only
have eight spots in our top eight. And
uh they're getting filled up rapidly, I
have to imagine.
>> You would think so. At this point, it's
only a matter of time before we do get
to find out. As we've said, we are not
in any way, shape, or form mathematic
enough be able to make those calls. But
when we have that information, you will
have that information. I have to ask
you, if you were going to ask Sold Out a
question for that match, what would you
want to ask him? Cuz as you can see,
heading over to the interviewer with
Logan for a little chitchat.
>> I think
>> I mean, look,
>> he can hear us.
>> He can
>> I think Logan not.
>> Oh, Logan can hear us. In that case, I
think the one thing that I would be very
very curious about is the decision-m
around that unit split.
>> Yes, I think that's a good one. I think
again, this is a deck where you make a
lot of different decisions before the
things start. So, you know what? Who
better than sold out himself as we go
down to the lounge for the interview
with Logan.
>> Thank you so much Pace Time and Steph
for that amazing cast of that phenomenal
game here. Sold out winning at 2. How do
you feel? You guaranteed first seed and
top eight.
>> Yes. Uh and best of civer I may add. Uh
uh I feel great. Uh my friend uh Togg
got me on this deck. I was going to
bring by initially but I played it and I
was like ah I think I maybe not. So
yeah, went with Civer. cannot believe
I've made it this far. Uh
>> yeah, 12-1 right now.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Uh my one loss was uh
I don't I just had never played ripbound
so badly in my life. It was still it was
it was awful.
>> It happens to the best of us just like
it happened to you. But walk us through
that game. Who was it into? What was the
legend?
>> Oh my my loss.
>> Yeah.
>> Um I lost to uh Diana. Okay.
>> Um I just like made bad decisions. My my
mind spplitters took the wrong cards. Uh
game two I
>> uh like frankly I just didn't channel
runes when I was supposed to. It was a
whole mess. It was a whole mess.
>> But that was great practice for this one
where you clearly played a lot better.
>> Yeah. Uh I'm very lucky. Very lucky. Uh
every single game I just draw every card
that I need and I go, "Oh, okay. That's
the card I needed and then I win." And
then I go, "Okay,
>> I really like this particular build. You
ran multiple Scriers Bloom, so you're
able to get a lot of that sort of
predict and card draw energy, giving you
the cards you needed when you needed
them."
>> Yes, Scrier's Bloom is is situationally
better than like stack deck. Even it
plays around sabotage very nicely. There
was a couple times during the tournament
where like I'll pass on the eight, go to
10, come back, uh, pop the bloom, grab
Aurora, and then they because I got it
off of the bloom, it can't be Aurora. Or
if you look at Bloom, you see Aurora in
the two, you draw one, leave the Aurora
on top. Uh, very very powerful. Uh, I I
was Yeah, I mean, the whole deck is draw
and the whole deck is drawing Aurora
basically.
>> Yeah. Fantastic. But I I did ask, how
does it feel to be in that top eight?
How does it feel to be that first seed
here at the regional ripband qualifier
Sydney right now?
>> Oh yeah, first because everyone else
everyone else threw in. So I Okay, I I
didn't even think about it till now. Now
you're completely right. And first seed
they decide first or second. So I'm
actually I'm I'm I'm doing great. I feel
fantastic.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh yeah. I mean
>> hasn't even sunk in yet.
>> I was like wow. I was I'm amazed quite
I'm just Yeah. I mean I'm speechless.
>> That's it. That's it. And have you
traveled from far to get to Sydney?
>> Yes. Yes. Um, I'm originally from the
West Coast, Oregon. Uh, my uh, my said,
my friend Tog, who got me on the deck,
he's Australian. He Yeah. Yeah. He comes
to America for um, for the regional
qualifiers there. And so last literally
the last two weeks before Sydney, I was
like, "Yeah, I'll go to Sydney. Why
not?" And uh,
>> and then I picked up Civer literally two
weeks ago and just like absolutely spent
two weeks grinding, figuring out the
matchups. Uh, it was a very hectic two
weeks, I'll tell you.
>> I doubt you had it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But then now I'm here and
we're doing we're doing great.
>> Did you have any opportunity to sample
any local cuisine or wineries and the
culture that we have here?
>> Uh abs. No, quite frankly. Uh I had some
toast yesterday.
>> Toast. Toast. Yeah. I mean
>> pretty global that one.
>> Uh but no. Uh no. I just I've been
playing and then going home and sleeping
and coming back and playing. I mean
>> absolutely deep in the tank making sure
this C Aurora deck works.
>> Being 12 and one being guaranteed locked
in for that top eight. the first seed. I
mean, surely that's made it feel worth
the trip down here as well. You've got a
real shot at winning with this Super
Aurora deck.
>> I think it's pretty likely.
>> Oh, feeling confident as well.
>> Well, you kind of you have to be like if
you're not conf like the deck only works
if you believe that it's going to work.
And one second you're like, I'm not
going to draw the Aurora or I'm not
going to hit the unit I need. You're
dead. You're done.
>> It's part of the mental game.
>> It is very mental. Uh, and I'm an I'm
I'm an unstoppable force and everybody
else are movable objects. I mean, what
else is there to say?
>> That is definitely a fantastic
perspective and I think one that we
absolutely need to roll with when we are
playing Aurora. There's obviously a lot
of conversation around Aurora decks and
how they play. But I did see on social
media before coming out here that you
have some fans out there, the the SS I
think it is the
>> uh TSS the secret sauce. Um, some of
this is my teammates. That's uh new
tagline. It's easier to like look us up.
Uh we'll probably uh do some like
content. You know, everyone likes doing
group content, so it'll be a good time.
I'm really looking forward to it.
>> Fantastic. And just one more sort of
Australia related question while we've
got you here in Sydney cuz it's not
often going to happen. Do you have any
plans to stay a few more days out?
>> No, I'm flying out tomorrow morning. I'm
going Yeah, I got to go home, get ready
for Vancouver. It's a whole deal.
>> Yeah, Vancouver is the next arcade in
Unleashed. And now, how are you feeling
about maybe taking the C Aurora there,
too? Do you think it might change
anything or keep it as it is?
um without revealing too much of course.
>> Yeah, I mean there's not really much to
reveal. I mean 99% of the deck is like
set in stone. Like you can't cut your
engine pieces, you can't cut Aurora, you
can't cut your units. Um so like maybe
like one or two slots I would move
around, but not not really. No, I I
think I really like the deck how it is.
Um it's served me really well so far
today. Uh I'm yeah, very very happy with
it.
>> Fantastic. I think every Aurora player
out there right now will also be very
happy with it and seeing you represent
it. so highly in these regional
qualifiers here in Sydney. And I mean,
we're at the tippity top of this game.
What do you expect will be a tough match
up for you tomorrow? Uh, sorry, this
afternoon.
>> This afternoon left. What do you have to
go into?
>> Uh, so I know that there's an Aurelia
that's in probably another Vex or two.
>> Uh, I don't know. It's hard to say cuz
every matchup can be tough. It just
depends on like what I draw, what they
draw. Uh, every deck has the thing about
Aurora is every deck has answers to it.
>> Yes.
>> But not every deck is going to draw
their answers as consistently as I draw
the Aurora. Yeah. And we saw in that
second game I drew all three of the
Auroras in my deck.
>> And he had the splitter two of them, but
you know, he spends almost all this time
splittering the Aurora while I'm getting
my my, you know, incremental value
effectively.
>> Yeah, absolutely. But obviously with the
mobilizers, the catalyst, the lunar
boons, the scriers, you have so much of
that card draw valuing extremely highly.
But I did actually take note on your
main board, it was three elders, one
splitter. So you sideboarded that
splitter in for that second game.
>> Yeah. So the idea behind splitter is
that it's good and you kind of want a
fourth guy just because you need a guy
to be on the field, right, to get points
to prevent your opponent from scoring.
But the splitter like hand rip isn't as
good in game one because the cards in
your opponent's hand don't matter. Yeah.
like after after post board it's like oh
they're going to side into the things
that beat me effectively right uh and
there's always some people that are like
main decking gear hate or like main
decking you know star cross or whatever
and so it's nice to take like that stuff
but it's not something you want to hit
multiple times in a row especially in
game one so
>> yeah definitely I really like to see
those sideboards and the tech that these
pro players such as yourself have here
and um I think that's actually going to
be all from us here at the regional rift
down qualifier Sydney thank you so
time. Congratulations on your 12 and one
top seed, top eight guaranteed. That's
all from us here. Back to you.
>> All right.
>> Thank you very much, Logan. And uh I
keep hearing this name around these
regional qualifiers. Some little
Australian apparently that I never met
genuinely called Togg. That is the
second time a deck designed by that
person has made the way into some sort
of feature match. Last time I heard that
name, it was actually the best of Ahri
winner from Las Vegas. Ah,
>> I don't know what's cooking down there,
but uh someone is very good at designing
decks.
>> Very very much so. Absolutely.
>> Also, shout out to the secret sauce. I
know the best of from the last uh North
American RQ is on that team as well.
>> Mhm.
>> So, fun to see them all. But, uh we have
more features. Again, we're not done and
we will not know the top eight until the
next round begins, which if you're not
aware is actually the top eight. So, we
have some things to figure out and so do
these players. You may recognize one of
them on stream. It is Dden on the right
versus ISO on the left. And this is a
Leblanc mirror, folks.
>> If you thought there was enough
reflections, there are more in every
possible way. We have is home and
obviously we have Daniel as well.
>> All right. So, uh, X and 2 certainly
cannot win, cannot make top eight if you
don't win this round.
>> I don't know if you're guaranteed top
eight if you win, but you certainly got
to get it done here and then just see
what happens. So uh but what's going to
feel like a win in even if it isn't it
could be a win and bubble which is
absolute daggers but
>> we are going to gank on over with that
ready reflection. That windswept Helix
does cut both ways.
>> I have to imagine that we're uh only
going to see one of these Leongs running
the baited hook.
>> Yeah, I think uh that's just going to be
the challenger TCD special as runes get
channel points get scored. It's two to
none right now
>> as the first early lead has gone to his
home on our left. First game though did
go to Daniels. So, uh, points on the
board in that regard as points get
scored thanks to Black Rose Dignitary.
That assault actually coming in a little
bit handy up against that soaring scout.
They both kind of do the same thing when
they death Nell. Your channel one rune
exhausted and Leblanc of course is going
to make a reflection at the helicopter
decks this weekend. Canon over does
still have assault again. It is a copy
of that unit. So easily easy combat to
win on the other side and get two more
points on the other side.
>> It is crazy how quickly that tempo can
ramp up. I
>> was going to say going to say it's crazy
how quickly the players are playing.
>> Well, that too they are rapidly here.
They know exactly what they are looking
for and hoping to achieve.
>> I'd have to I think cuz there's only 19
minutes left in this round. You got to
play maybe three games total. So Leblanc
moving on in getting her win over there.
Fragmented when she dies does draw a
card. And if it was the beginning of
your if it's the beginning phase, you
draw two instead. And oh, when would
that happen? I don't know. Maybe if
there was a copy of it, that is
temporary. And which is exactly what
happened as
>> deceiver does get exhausted to make yet
another clone.
>> So reflections abound is four points now
to two. And it does feel like if the
players are going to be trading
reflections back and forth, well, that's
going to favor the player that's already
ahead on points.
>> Mhm. That Leblanc also does have
assault, but only when attacking. So at
this point, the defensive position is
not going to get that little bit of
extra might.
>> Yeah, it's pretty comical, but the
players can kind of play the same turn
back and forth
>> right now. Again, the problem being that
uh
>> well, if this keeps happening, uh
>> one player is going to lose on points
before the other. And of course, that's
a player that I presumably went first as
Vi also in the hand I saw. But that one
doesn't work on defense for the stun.
Does work for the five might that it
adds to the board. Oh, if this is if
this is a V on the other side, it's
actually going to be such a beating.
There it is.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> Five piece makes both ways. Stuns one
moves on in and that's going to be a
very well one combat.
>> Mirror indeed.
>> Oh, smoke screen shrink it. This now
it's getting wild.
>> So, a stunned VI assume on one side,
>> but is five might a four might Leblanc
and five might total. So, which unit do
you want to take out? cuz one of them is
going to live. And unfortunately, the
attackers have to leave if the combat
doesn't resolve. You cannot have two
units occupy a battlefield at the end of
a combat. That's not allowed.
>> What have we got in hand over here on
the right though? Any responses? Not
really.
>> Yeah, I don't know how many copies of
cards like smoke screen players are
running.
>> I think that's the first time that I
have seen it on the desk this weekend.
>> Yeah, I haven't seen too many copies of
that card. was a mainstay in uh in
Kaiser back in Origins was uh somewhat
seen in Ezreal every now and then
especially out of Allen's initial build
>> before the cold shot culling
>> players just discussing uh where they
want to assign damage. So both buyers
going to hit the dust and yeah you got
to leave buddy and which means you do
not get a conquer which means you do not
score opponent which means you do not
get
>> to make your reflection or pass go and
collect 200
>> followup is going to be
>> mirror image
>> mirror image I think the first time
we've seen this card in the feature
match area actually
>> makes a copy of Leblanc fragmented much
like reflections does make it happen.
>> Mhm. If you haven't seen the text on
that card reads, choose a unit, play a
ready reflection token to your base. It
becomes a copy of that unit. Give it
temporary.
>> And uh still the unit you can make a
copy of.
>> So uh well deceiver yet to be activated.
Sacrifice discarded. Reflection made.
>> And again that assault still staying as
the ganking happens. And uh two
reflections now sitting on those
battlefields as four points now should
be
>> for Denon.
Very very rapid pace here. As we said
before, it is very impressive to see how
well both of them pilot these decks.
>> You have to wonder, do you reckon they
would have drilled much for a mirror
match?
>> I mean, if you're going to play a
matchup quite a few times coming into an
event, I think you're probably going to
play
>> Leblanc and Master and Aurora. I guess I
think those are probably the matchups
you've drilled more than any others. So,
I would suspect that
both players would have a good amount of
experience in the mirror. I don't know
how much experience is home has against
the hook version specifically. I also
don't know what version he's on.
>> True.
>> Could in theory be on a hook version
too,
>> but uh I guess I'd say that's unlikely.
Although I wouldn't say it's impossible.
>> It's not impossible. But yes, coming
into a weekend where we know that
LeBlanc was the most populous deck.
>> This is going to be a draw four, by the
way.
>> Oo. Those are remember copies of the
block fragmented and they are temporary
and they're dying in the beginning phase
which means you don't just draw one for
the death you get to draw two. So four
cards after equalizing the points and
back kind of on tempo to retake these
battlefields.
>> Got to be happy with that.
>> Yeah, I think if your opponent just
plays soaring scout as their only card
for turn, you feel pretty good.
>> Yeah,
>> about your turn.
>> That Leblanc coming right back in
>> and uh right back out as another
reflection is going to get made. The
ganking's going to happen. And we'll do
the whole dance again. Watchful sentry
hits the bin.
>> Absolutely.
>> Reflection ganking aspirin climb. As a
reminder to mostly myself,
>> it is an aspirin climb game. So, we're
playing tonight. Don't get fooled by the
even point totals we always talk about
in games of Riftbound.
>> Got to get a bonus one to win this
particular game.
>> Got that ruined Rex coming in there as
well. And I will
>> Gallio called a week. I think I saw
watchful sentry soaring scout.
>> Still trying to spy for a sacrifice.
Haven't seen a high value one for a bit.
>> Also didn't spy the hook.
>> Haven't sp I mean uh that's true. Don't
always need it as when your deck is
humming along.
>> Especially when you have all of those
death nail triggers that are going off
very very well for that four draw. Yeah,
that was uh that was quite the turn
>> that uh Zidon just had as Face Breaker
smoke screen. Saw a couple other cards
in the in the hand for his home, but
haven't remember them just yet. Soaring
Scout eats on in
>> looks a little suspicious.
>> Time to break some faces. Stun. Nope.
Time to hit some blades.
>> Drawing cards. Actually going to be
taking out that soaring scout. Channel
run exhausted and draw two cards. Not a
bad little exchange, but clearly digging
for more answers. Tactical Retreat and
Vi Peacemaker were the two cards found.
>> Sacrifice in hand as well alongside that
smoke screen
>> and that face breaker.
>> Fun little stun card you can hide every
now and then.
>> Recycle
>> Vi.
>> Yeah,
>> guess so.
>> Looks like it.
>> Vi to base.
>> V go. Not always what you want to see,
especially with ruined Rex surviving the
turn cycle. point for holding on one
side of the battlefield going to seven.
Two cards drawn for Leblanc Fragmented
being uh whisked away by the rules of
the game at the beginning phase.
>> And one more point to come. You have to
think gank on over to the aspirants
climb. Maybe park the watchful sentry
there. Doesn't really matter how you
want to do it. You're going to get
yourself to point number eight.
>> Got that ruined Rex coming over to do it
there for you.
>> Shout out to the overlay. Little quick
change there for the aspirants climb
game. Should be eight points to four. My
memory serves.
>> The points reflecting that it is going
to nine because of that aspirin climb.
>> Ruin Rex.
>> That's a six
>> five peacekeeper going to struggle to
bust through that battlefield. And
again, we've seen this a lot. Oh no,
>> the hard cast harness dragon.
>> Going to force the sacrifice. No, it's
tactical retreats.
>> Interesting.
>> Heals that unit, exhausts it, recalls
it. I believe that saves it. So, a very
timely retreat from base to base. A
little bit or sometimes looks silly, but
enough to keep Vi into the game and I
think keep the game in reach for his
home.
>> Again though, paying for that cost is
rough anytime there's a dragon in store.
>> Well, the other problem is you only have
>> one unit. Yeah,
>> there's two battlefields. Okay, ganking.
That's going to be solution to all our
problems.
>> Take out the one, draw a card thanks to
the death nail, but five piece keeper
grabs a point. most importantly gets the
trigger deceiver. Discard a card.
Goodbye, Honest Broker. You've served us
well, but it's time to make a
reflection. And we got to keep the piece
over on the other side of the rift.
>> I think that's enough. Glancing at the
hand. It's 12 might currently the five
of this VI, but you can stun one of the
units.
You can smoke screen another. Although
Face Breaker pulled the text real
quickly because I think that has to
target two different units and
unfortunately I think one of the units
does have to be yours. Indeed, it is
stun a friendly unit and an enemy unit
at the same battlefield. So sacrifice
will be made. Peacekeeper
>> going to be put to the trash.
>> Two cards drawn. Any answers
forthcoming? Another face breaker
>> and
>> smoke screen a six. That's ruined Rex
and it is a three. That is Karthus I
believe.
>> Yep.
That does not feel like enough to break
through that battlefield.
If you can take out the real Rex though,
obviously temporary units can't score
from holding,
but you still have to deal with the hunt
dragon and the watchful sentry in the
base.
>> Yeah, look, ordinarily drawing Carus
wouldn't be so bad if you were earlier
on in the game so that you can get that
doubling of all of those triggers, but
at this point you have to wonder whether
it is going to be just that little bit
too late.
Suppose I'll do some math. So V's going
to stun. Vi is going to win almost any
combat on her own here. So I you can
roll in, stun the temporary one, shrink
the other one, take out the real one,
and at least keep yourself in the game.
But that does not make that much
progress.
>> No. And as we all know, the next turn
can definitely make it almost
impossible.
>> Oh, stun's the real one,
>> especially when that dragon is there in
base. Smoke screen. The real one.
>> All right. Go to damage.
>> Clean it up. Choose that.
>> The temporary Rex is going to take out
the temporary VI.
>> Yeah. This is
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So I think I think
>> I think a little bit of I think not the
play maybe uh Daniel expected I think
expected to well I guess it's kind of
all's the same at the end of the day cuz
the unit would have been kicked out.
It's temporary anyway so like it doesn't
really matter
>> I suppose
>> you have no units. Oh no.
>> Tried to reinforce at the helic.
>> Is that it?
>> It seemed like it was almost there.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. Little error.
>> Unfortunately, nothing left to do.
Nowhere to get through even with the
hold. There's two units there to capture
those battlefields. And that is going to
be Daniel potentially moving into our
top eight. Did all he could. won as many
rounds as possible.
>> We didn't expect to see a Leblanc mirror
at the end here for this one, but very,
very exciting to see how this went.
Unfortunate for his home to have gotten
to that point, but ultimately only one
person can win and only one person can
potentially make it through.
>> Okay, let me do some reading.
>> Okay,
>> one deceiver. When you conquer or hold,
you may discard one and exhaust me to
play a ready reflection token there. It
becomes a copy of another unit there.
give it temporary. So,
>> you have to have the unit at the
battlefield that you score at when you
activate Leblanc.
>> And you can only put that unit there.
So, I'm I'm trying to figure out what
line he wanted to take.
>> Yeah. Look, I feel like
I can't really see what options were.
Obviously, we didn't got used already
the entire deck as well cuz we came into
it as that.
>> Oh, okay. I think I see. I think the
hope is that when you reinforce there,
>> you at least make it so your opponent
can't score both battlefields cuz when
you don't have anything like
>> your opponent's just going to waltz on
in for free. So that reinforce was
designed
>> to try and
>> prevent you from losing on that turn.
The position wasn't great, but at least
you try and hold on for another turn.
>> But unfortunately, you had to sacrifice
your VI earlier, I think, to get to that
point and draw those cards. There was
just no way to reinforce, so it didn't
matter.
>> It's rough. It's rough. And the result
is very clear. Danielle just happened to
make the uh the stronger plays there on
that one. Got the the four draw at that
point.
>> Oh, that was nasty.
>> That's great.
>> This tech is sweet. I certainly hope
it's in top air. We're going to find out
in just a moment. We have questions and
after the break, we'll have some
answers. Don't go too far away.
I'm Chris. I'm from Melbourne, so I'm
pretty local. Used to live in Sydney, so
this is really local for me. I got into
ripbound because I recently moved to
Melbourne. I was looking for a quick
hobby to play. Timing was perfect for
Ripbound, so I just started playing some
Riftbound. Thing I like about Ripbound
is that I played quite a lot of TCGs
before, and I think the fundamentals for
this game is like really interesting,
and there's a lot of decision- making.
most recently was probably One Piece,
but outside of that, the the array of
online TCGs, Rune Terror, Hearthstone,
Grant, you know, all the online one
stuff free to play. The champion I'm
playing today is actually Teemo. How do
I think Teemo matches me as a TCG
player? Honestly, one of my favorite
things about it is how uh the hidden
cars you can like really mind game the
opponent. And uh it really is funny
watching watching somebody on the
opposite side have their hands next to
their face being like is that
switcheroo? Is that tie turner? Is that
another Teemo? And then it's consult the
past. I think there's a lot of head
games when it comes to playing a
competitive TCG. Ripbound especially. Um
I mean I was just talking about hidden
cards and there is so many decision-m
points in this kind of game. It's